TODAY'S HEARING WILL EXPLORE THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE V..
SIX SEVENTEEN I DON'T HAVE TO
ANSWER THE QUESTION --
QUESTION VIDAK WITH THE AIR
RESOURCES BOARD HAD LOCAL
AIRSTRIKES ARE ON TRACK TO
DELIVER ISSUE REDUCTIONS.
CALIFORNIA'S MOST POLLUTION BIRD.
FEDERAL --
HAVE FOSTERED WANT TO SHARE WITH
US AND ONE OF THE PRIMARY
REASONS WE'RE HERE TODAY.
WE HAVE IDEAL CONDITIONS FOR
LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT RIGHT NOW
WE HAVE THE JEEP AUTHOR OF THE
BILL ASSEMBLY MEMBER CRISTINA
GARCIA JOIN US IN A FEW MOMENTS --
AND BUT WE'RE ALSO HEARING
TESTIMONY TODAY THE COMMITTEE
WOULD BILLS FOR A HOUSE WHERE
MEMBERS INSISTED.
CAP CALIFORNIA'S ENVIRONMENTAL
POLICIES WAS NOT.
GLOBAL CLIMATE LEADERSHIP FOR
REAL PROGRESS ON LOCAL.
ALSO FORTUNATE TO BE JOINED
TODAY BY MANY OF THE KEY FIGURES
RESPONSIBLE FOR DELIVERING ON
THE PROMISE OF EIGHTY SIX
SEVENTEEN THE AIR RESOURCES
BOARD LOCAL YOUR DISTRICTS AND
LEADERS.
AND COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE STATE
SELECTED FOR YOUR WIFE REALLY
EMISSION REDUCTION PROGRAMS. FOR
SOME THIS MAY BE THE FIRST
OPPORTUNITY TO LEARN FIRSTHAND
WHAT EIGHTY SIX SEVENTEEN BE
DOING TO IMPROVE. TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN I WAS SIGNED IN DAHLE
GARDENS BY GOVERNOR BROWN JUST
NINE DAYS LATER.
AIRBNB --
DISTRICTS BEGAN WORKING WITH
PATIENTS FROM THE ONE THE
LEGISLATURE ALL UP WITH NEARLY
THREE HUNDRED MILLION FUNDING
TWO MONTHS [inaudible]
RIGHT.
OKAY HOPEFULLY YOU CAN HEAR ME
BETTER NOW.
NO VOTE IF YOU WANT ME TO REPEAT
ALL THAT.
I THOUGHT IT SOUNDED STRANGE
OKAY -- AIR
BE COMPLETED THE FIRST MAJOR
IMPLEMENTATION MILESTONES LAST
SEPTEMBER INCLUDING SELECTION OF
THE FIRST TEN COMMUNITIES AFTER
REVIEWING NOMINATIONS FROM AIR
DISTRICTS AND DIRECTLY FROM
COMMUNITIES.
WE'RE NOW ABOUT SIX MONTHS INTO
COMMUNITY BASED PROCESSES WITH
ABOUT SIX MONTHS LEFT BEFORE
EACH OF THE AIR DISTRICTS MUST
ADOPT AND SUBMIT TO A R. B. FOR
REVIEW.
AND EMISSIONS REDUCTIONS PROGRAM
FOR EACH COMMUNITY INCLUDING
EMISSIONS REDUCTION TARGETS
SPECIFIC REDUCTION MEASURES AND
IMPLEMENTATION SCHEDULE AND
ENFORCEMENT PLAN.
SO ENOUGH TIME HAS PASSED TO
LEARN HOW THE PROCESSES ARE
GOING AND WE HAVE ENOUGH TIME
LEFT TO MAKE COURSE CORRECTIONS
OF NECESSARY.
IT IS ALSO A GOOD TIME TO REMIND
OURSELVES OF THE FUNDAMENTAL
OBJECTIVE OF AB SIX SEVENTEEN IS
NOT MERELY TO IDENTIFY WHERE
PEOPLE ARE SUFFERING THE WORST
EFFECTS OF AIR POLLUTION.
WE ALREADY KNOW THAT CITIES IN
THE SOUTH COAST IN SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY HAVE THE MOST OF YOUR
REGIONAL AIR POLLUTION IN THE
NATION.
AND WE KNOW THAT COMMUNITIES ALL
AROUND THE STATE NEAR PORTS REAL
ROADS FREEWAYS BORDER TRAFFIC IN
CLUSTERS OF INDUSTRY THEIR
DISPROPORTIONATE BURDEN OF BOTH
REGIONAL POLLUTANTS LIKE SMOG IN
PARTICULAR MATTER.
AS WELL AS AIR TOXINS.
THESE COMMUNITIES SUFFER FROM A
RANGE OF HEALTH EFFECTS
INCLUDING INCREASED RESPIRATORY
AILMENTS HEART DISEASE CANCER
RISK AND EVEN DAMAGING CHILD
BRAIN DEVELOPMENT.
AMONG POCKET POPULATIONS THAT
HAVE LITTLE CHOICE BUT TO LIVE
WORK AND PLAY AN UNHEALTHY AIR.
THE OBJECTIVE OF AB SIX
SEVENTEEN IS TO DO SOMETHING
ABOUT THAT.
IN ADDITION TO OUR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS WE HAVE INVITED MEMBERS
REPRESENTING EACH OF THE TEN
COMMUNITIES TO JOIN US TODAY.
FINALLY AT THE CONCLUSION OF THE
COMMUNITY FOCUS PANELS WE WILL
INVITE OTHERS TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE ON OTHER SPECIFIC
ISSUES RELATED TO AB SIX
SEVENTEEN IMPLEMENTATION.
IF YOU WISH TO OFFER COMMENTS
PLEASE SIGN IN AT THE SERGEANTS
TABLE.
WE WILL BE KEEPING TIME BECAUSE
WE HAVE A LOT OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
GOING TO SPEAK TODAY AND WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE CAN HEAR
EVERYONE AND THAT WE STILL HAVE
MEMBERS LEFT IN THE BUILDING --
TO HEAR THE TESTIMONY --
WE'D LIKE TO ADJOURN BEFORE SIX
PM AND WE'RE GOING TO ASK YOUR
PATIENCE WE WILL BE TIMING THE
PANELISTS SO PANELISTS.
BE CONCISE GET EVERYTHING OUT
BUT SAY IT ONCE --
NOW BEFORE THE WITNESSES FROM A
RB BEGIN THEIR PRESENTATIONS I'D
LIKE TO INVITE.
WELL OUR PRICE YOUR IS NOT HERE
YET BUT I WOULD INVITE US
ASSEMBLYMEMBER AL MURATSUCHI TO
SEE IF HE HAS ANY COMMENTS.
SURE THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
TO MADAM CHAIR JUST BRIEFLY I
APPRECIATE TO THE HEARING TODAY
BECAUSE I I I KNOW THAT --
IN OUR LINE OF WORK --
WILL JUST SPEAKING FOR MYSELF I
I KNOW THAT OFTEN.
I I HEAR FROM --
A WIDE RANGE OF CONSTITUENTS --
THAT ARE CONCERNED.
ABOUT --
ENVIRONMENTAL ISSUES BUT I I I
DO WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
THERE ARE A GOOD NUMBER OF
PEOPLE THAT I HEAR FROM.
WHO SAY THAT YOU KNOW I I DON'T
CARE AS MUCH ABOUT YOU KNOW
CLIMATE CHANGE ARE ALL THESE YOU
KNOW THESE THESE GLOBAL ISSUES
WHAT I CARE ABOUT IS WHETHER MY
CHILDREN --
BRETT BREEDING CLEAN AIR AND AND
DRINKING CLEAN WATER AND SO I
THINK --
TODAY'S SUBJECT MATTER REALLY
GOES.
TO THAT --
CORE CONCERN THAT I HEAR ACROSS
THE BOARD FROM ALL OF MY
CONSTITUENTS ALL OF OUR
CONSTITUENTS AND SO I I
APPRECIATE THIS A HEARING.
THANK YOU AND THANKS FOR JOINING
US TODAY SO I'M GONNA CALL THE
PANELS UP ONE BY ONE AND WHAT
I'LL DO IS I'LL ASK THE
PANELISTS IF YOU WANT TO MAKE
ANY INTRODUCTIONS.
I'M JUST TO EXPLAIN YOUR
BACKGROUND OR HOW TO FIT INTO A
BRIEFLY AND DO IT --
FROM -- YOU
KNOW BEFORE YOU MAKE YOUR
REMARKS WE HAVE ALL ASK THE
MEMBERS TO HOLD THEM UNTIL EACH
PANELIST FINISHED WITH JUST BEEN
JOINED BY OUR VICE CHAIR --
SEVEN MEMBER HEATH FLORA MISTER
FLOOR WOULD YOU LIKE TO MAKE ANY
COMMENTS BEFORE WE BEGIN OKAY
THANK YOU.
SO WITHOUT A FOR AN OVERVIEW OF
AB SIX SEVENTEEN FROM THE AIR
RESOURCES BOARD I'M GOING TO
INVITE OF RICHARD CORY THE
EXECUTIVE OFFICER PRODUCT EDT
ASSISTANT EXECUTIVE OFFER
OFFICER.
AND KAREN VALLEY ON OF THE
DIRECTOR OF THE OFFICE OF
COMMUNITY --
PROTECTION WELCOME AND THANK YOU
I WANT TO THANK EVERYONE WHO
CAME TO JOIN US TODAY ESPECIALLY
THOSE OF YOU WHO TRAVELED FROM
OUT OF THE AREA.
WHILE THEY'RE SITTING UP WE'VE
JUST BEEN JOINED BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBERCRISTINA GARCIA THE
AUTHOR OF SIX SEVENTEEN AND I
WILL ASK HER --
IF SHE WOULD LIKE TO MAKE ANY
COMMENTS BEFORE THE PANEL BEGINS
AND THANK YOU FOR JOINING US.
THANK YOU JUST WANNA WELCOME AND
THANK EVERYONE WHO IS HERE BUT
ALSO THINK EVERYONE ON THE
GROUND WHO'S DOING THE WORK. TO
TRY TO TAKE THIS FROM A BILL TO
A REALITY THAT HOPEFULLY GIVES
OF CLEANER COMMUNITIES AND
HEALTHIER CONSTITUENTS OUT THERE --
IT'S A IT'S A WORK IN PROGRESS
AND I DO APPRECIATE EVERYONE'S
WORK AND I LOOK FORWARD TO THE
INSIDE OF WHERE WE'RE AT AND
WHERE WE STILL NEED TO GO.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OKAY.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU THANK YOU
CHAIR FRIEDMAN I'M RICHARD CORE
AB JACKET OF OFFICER OF THE
CALIFORNIA RESOURCES BOARD THANK
YOU MEMBERS AS WELL.
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PROVIDE AN UPDATE ON THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF SIX SEVENTEEN
AND THE COMMUNITY PROTECTION
PROGRAM.
I'LL BE SHARING THIS OVERVIEW
PRESENTATION TODAY WITH TWO
MEMBERS MY TEAM WERE RESPONSIBLE
FOR IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
PROGRAM VERONICA ET.
OUR SYSTEM EXECUTIVE OFFICER FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE TO MY LEFT.
AND CARE ABOUT THE AUTO THE
DIRECTOR OF THE COMMUNITY HERE
PROTECTION PROGRAM WHICH IS
REALLY FORMED ESTABLISH
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE EFFORT.
JB SIX SEVENTEEN SHE NOTED
SPONSORED BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CRISTINA GARCIA REPRESENTS THE
MOST COMPREHENSIVE.
AIR QUALITY PROGRAM IN OVER
THIRTY YEARS.
CALIFORNIA'S AIR QUALITY
PROGRAMS HAVE HISTORICALLY
FOCUSED ON IMPROVING AIR QUALITY
AT THE REGIONAL LEVEL AS WELL AS
REDUCING TOXICS RISK.
FROM INDIVIDUAL SOURCES.
THESE PROGRAMS HAVE RESULTED IN
SIGNIFICANT PRUDENCE OZONE
LEVELS HAVE DROPPED OVER 40% THE
SOUTH COAST SINCE.
NINETEEN NINETY LEVELS OF LETTER
NOW 90% LOWER AND DIESEL
PARTICULATE MATTER.
WHICH ACCOUNTS FOR OVER TWO
THIRDS TWO THIRDS OF THE TOTAL
KNOWN CANCER RISK IN THE STATE
FROM AIR QUALITY STANDPOINT IS
DROPPED NEARLY 70%.
HOWEVER HOWEVER. TOO MANY
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITIES ARE STILL
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED BY
POOR AIR QUALITY.
SB SIX SEVENTEEN PLACES A
RENEWED EMPHASIS ON THE NEED FOR
FOCUSED ACTION. TO CLEAN THE AIR
IN THESE COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE
STATE.
A GREAT DEAL GOES IN A MINUTE A
GREAT DEAL PROGRESS HAS OCCURRED
OVER THE LAST YEAR AND A HALF
AND THERE'S ALSO A LOT OF WORK.
AHEAD OF US IS ALREADY NOTED IN
THIS NEW PROGRAM.
CALIFORNIA LOCAL AIR DISTRICTS
IN PARTNERSHIP WITH COMMUNITY
MEMBERS ARE KEY. TO ITS ULTIMATE
SUCCESS.
MAYBE YOU CAN SEE IF YOU CAN
ADVANCING AND KEEP GOING
[inaudible] SIX SEVENTEEN
SYSTEM MULTIPLE ELEMENTS THAT
ARE DESIGNED TO WORK TOGETHER TO
SUPPORT COMMUNITY FOCUSED ACTION
THIS INCLUDES BETTER DATA ON A
MISSION SOURCES IN THE IMPACTS
THE SOURCES HAVE.
ON AIR RESIDENTS ON THE REST AIR
RESIDENTS ARE BRICK BRIEF
BREEDING.
AND MAKING THIS DATA MORE
AVAILABLE AND UNDERSTANDABLE.
THE MOST CRITICALLY.
IT'S USING THIS INFORMATION TO
INFORM AND NEW STATE AN AIR
DISTRICT ACTIONS TO REDUCE
EMISSIONS.
AND EXPOSURE THIS WILL INCLUDE A
BROAD SET OF APPROACHES FROM NEW
REGULATIONS TO ENHANCED
ENFORCEMENT. TO TARGETED
INCENTIVE FUNDING.
WE'RE ALSO LOOKING TO ENHANCE
PARTNERSHIPS WITH LOCAL LAND USE
AND TRANSPORTATION PLANNING
AGENCIES AND OTHER STATE
AGENCIES.
AS WE ALL HAVE A ROLE IN
DEVELOPING SOLUTIONS TO REDUCE
AIR POLLUTION IN THESE
COMMUNITIES.
DEVELOPING AND IMPLEMENTING AB
SIX SEVENTEEN IS A JOINT EFFORT
CHAIRED BY CARP THE LOCAL YOU'RE
DISTRICTS AND AS I NOTED MOST
IMPORTANTLY THE COMMUNITY
STAKEHOLDERS.
THIS EMPHASIS ON COMMUNITY
PARTICIPATION EVEN THE GOALS OF
AB.
SIX SEVENTEEN AND THOSE OF THE
COMMUNITY.
THEIR PROTECTION PROGRAM AND NOW
I'D LIKE TO TURN THE
PRESENTATION OVER TO CARE AND TO
PROVIDE AN OVERVIEW OF THE WORK
TODAY.
AND PROVIDE A LITTLE MORE DETAIL
ABOUT THE DIFFERENT ELEMENTS OF
THE PROGRAM.
OKAY THANK YOU RICHARD.
SO AS YOU HEARD ONE OF THE FIRST
STEPS IN IMPLEMENTING SB SIX
SEVENTEEN IN SEPTEMBER OF LAST
YEAR OUR BOARD APPROVED THE
COMMUNITY AIR PROTECTION
BLUEPRINT.
WHICH ESSENTIALLY OUTLINES THE
OVERALL REQUIREMENTS FOR THE
PROGRAM --
AND THE OPERATING INSTRUCTIONS
FOR HOW WE CONTINUE TO MOVE
FORWARD WITH IMPLEMENTATION.
SO THE BLUEPRINT DESCRIBES BROAD
STATEWIDE STRATEGIES THAT WILL
BE PURSUING AS WELL AS
INDIVIDUAL COMMUNITY FOCUSED
ELEMENTS AND THROUGHOUT THE
BLUEPRINT YOU'LL SEE A VERY
STRONG EMPHASIS ON COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT AND COMMUNITY
PARTNERSHIPS.
THESE VARIOUS ELEMENTS INCLUDE
FACTORS IN THE PROCESS FOR
SELECTING COMMUNITIES FOR
ADDITIONAL FOCUSED ACTION.
AND THEN IN THESE COMMUNITIES
THE BLUEPRINT LAYS OUT THE
CRITERIA FOR DEVELOPING AND
IMPLEMENTING COMMUNITY ARE
MONITORING PROGRAMS SO THAT
THEY'RE DESIGNED TO INFORM
SUBSEQUENT ACTION.
AND THEN THE SCOPE AND PROCESS
FOR DEVELOPING AND IMPLEMENTING
COMMUNITY EMISSION REDUCTION
PROGRAMS.
INCLUDING METRICS FOR TRACKING
PROGRESS SO THAT WE MAKE SURE
THAT WE'RE MAKING PROGRESS AND
ARE SEEING TANGIBLE IMPROVEMENTS
IN THESE COMMUNITIES.
AND THEN AT THE SAME TIME.
GO.
OUR BOARD ALSO SELECTED TEN
INITIAL COMMUNITIES TO LAUNCH
THE PROGRAM AND THE ORANGE DOTS
ON THE SLIDE SHOW THOSE TEN
COMMUNITIES AND THE
CORRESPONDING AIR DISTRICTS ARE
SHOWN IN BLUE.
THIS INITIAL SAT ARE ALL HIGHLY
BURDENS THEY HAVE A MIX OF URBAN
AND RURAL COMMUNITIES DIFFERENT
KINDS OF AIR POLLUTION SOURCES
AND DIFFERENT COMMUNITY SIZES
BECAUSE WHAT WE ARE WHAT WE GET
IS GIVE REFLECTION AND THE
DIVERSITY OF POLLUTION
CHALLENGES THAT WE SEE
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
AND THEN THE GOAL IS THAT
STRATEGIES DEVELOPED IN THESE
INITIAL SET OF COMMUNITIES
PROVIDE MODELS FOR ACTION IN
OTHER COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE
SIMILAR CHALLENGES.
AND TO SUPPORT THAT WILL BE
WORKING WITH THE ARE DISTRICTS
TO IDENTIFY THOSE STRATEGIES
THAT ARE WORKING AND THEN
LOOKING FOR OPPORTUNITIES ON HOW
THOSE CAN BE TRANSFERRED TO A
BROADER SET OF COMMUNITIES.
THIS IS THE START OF A LARGER
EFFORT AND WE DO EXPECT THAT THE
NUMBER OF COMMUNITIES WILL GROW
AS WE GROW THE PROGRAM OVER TIME.
SO THEY ARE DISTRICTS ARE NOW
WORKING WITH THE LOCAL
COMMUNITIES THROUGH COMMUNITY
STEERING COMMITTEES AND THIS IS
TO DEVELOP AND IMPLEMENT THE ARE
MONITORING AS WELL AS THE
EMISSION REDUCTION PROGRAMS.
AND AS YOU CAN SEE HERE ON THE
SLIDE THE AIR MONITORING IS
EXPECTED TO BEGIN IN JULY OF
THIS YEAR.
AND THEN AIR DISTRICTS NEED TO
BRING THE COMMUNITY EMISSION
REDUCTION PROGRAMS TO THEIR
BOARDS BY OCTOBER OF THIS YEAR.
THERE'S A LOT OF WORK IT'S
ALREADY HAPPENED OVER THE PAST
SIX MONTHS BUT A LOT OF WORK
STILL AHEAD AND YOU'LL BE
HEARING MORE FROM THE INDIVIDUAL
AIR DISTRICTS AND THE COMMUNITY
LEADERS.
ABOUT THE WORK THAT IS UNDER WAY.
SO WHAT I WANTED TO DO IN THE
NEXT FEW IS HIGHLIGHT WHAT CARDS
ON GOING ROLE IS --
AND MANY OF THE STATE WIDE
EFFORTS THAT WE ARE WORKING ON
SO CLEANING THE AIR IN THESE
COMMUNITIES IS A SHARED
RESPONSIBILITY OF BOTH CAR AND
THE LOCAL AIRDISTRICTS AND EACH
ELEMENT OF AB SIX SEVENTEEN
REALLY REFLECTS THIS JOINT
EFFORT.
SO OUR ON GOING ROLE AS WE MOVE
FORWARD INCLUDES A NUMBER OF
CORE ACTIVITIES THERE SHOWN HERE
ON THE SLIDE.
AND THAT BEGINS WITH DEVELOPING
AND IMPLEMENTING NEW STATEWIDE
STRATEGIES FOR MOBILE SOURCES AS
WELL AS WORKING WITH OTHER STATE
AGENCIES SO WE CAN LEVERAGE
THEIR RESOURCES AND INVESTMENTS
IN THESE COMMUNITIES.
AND THIS WORK SUPPORTS NOT ONLY
THE TARGETED ACTION IN THE
INITIAL TEN COMMUNITIES.
BUT REALLY IMPORTANTLY REDUCING
POLLUTION IN SIMILARLY BURDEN
COMMUNITIES STATEWIDE.
WE'RE ALSO DEVELOPING A NUMBER
OF NEW TOOLS AND RESOURCES TO
PROVIDE THE MORE DETAILED
INFORMATION THAT'S REALLY NEEDED
AT THE COMMUNITY LEVEL.
AND THAT INCLUDES SITTING DOWN
WITH COMMUNITY MEMBERS AND OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS --
TO UNDERSTAND WHAT THOSE NEEDS
ARE AND HOW THEY WANT TO BETTER
ACCESS AND USE THIS INFORMATION.
WE ALSO WORK WITH THE LOCAL AIR
DISTRICTS ON ADMINISTRATION OF
THE INCENTIVE FUNDING.
AND IF YOU'LL BE HEARING MORE
FROM VERONICA IMPLEMENTING A
BRAND NEW COMMUNITY AIR GRANT
PROGRAM THAT FACILITATES
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
PARTICIPATION IN AB.
SIX SEVENTEEN AND THEN FINALLY
OUR BOARD HAS AN ONGOING ROLE
INCLUDING APPROVAL OF THE
COMMUNITY EMISSION REDUCTION
PROGRAMS AND ANNUAL PROCESS FOR
CONSIDERING ADDITIONAL
COMMUNITIES.
LOOKING AT ANNUAL PROGRESS
REPORTS AND MAKING ADJUSTMENTS
AS NEEDED.
SO STARTING WITH STATEWIDE
STRATEGIES ARE REGULATORY
EFFORTS REALLY PROVIDE THE
FOUNDATION FOR COMMUNITY LEVEL
ACTION.
AND MANY MEASURES OF ALREADY
BEEN IDENTIFIED THROUGH OUR
TRADITIONAL CRITERIA POLLUTANT
TOXICS AND GREENHOUSE GAS
PROGRAMS.
AND THEN THE BLUEPRINT
IDENTIFIES FURTHER ACTION SO
THAT TOGETHER WE HAVE A LARGE
PORTFOLIO OF REGULATIONS THAT
ARE GOING TO BE COMING TO OUR
BOARD OVER THE CUP THE NEXT FEW
YEARS.
MANY OF THESE MEASURES WILL
FOCUS ON ZERO EMISSION
TECHNOLOGIES IN THE FREIGHT
SECTOR.
AND IN RECOGNITION OF THE NEED
FOR CONTINUING TO REDUCE
LOCALIZED EXPOSURE UNDER AB.
SIX SEVENTEEN IN MARCH OF LAST
YEAR OUR BOARD IDENTIFIED
RELATED ACTIONS INCLUDING THE
REGULATIONS FOR SOURCES SUCH AS
CLEAN OR CARGO HANDLING
EQUIPMENT HARBOR CRAFTED
DRAINAGE TRUCKS.
ANOTHER ALSO OTHER MEASURES
UNDER WAY TO REDUCE POLLUTION
FROM VEHICLES LIKE THE CLEAN
TRANSIT MEASURE THAT OUR BOARD
ADOPTED LAST DECEMBER WHICH IS
TRANSITIONING TRANSIT FLEETS TWO
ZERO EMISSION TECHNOLOGIES.
AND THEN FOR OTHER INDUSTRIAL
SOURCES LIKE REFINERIES OR
CEMENT PLANTS OIL AND GAS
OPERATIONS.
AIR DISTRICTS WILL BE UPDATING
THE RULES TO REFLECT THE BEST
AVAILABLE RETROFIT CONTROL
TECHNOLOGIES ARE MARKED AS SHOWN
ON THIS SLIDE.
THE DISTRICTS OF RECENTLY
ADOPTED SCHEDULES FOR THAT RULE
MAKING AND MANY OF THOSE WILL
MAKING EFFORTS ARE ALREADY UNDER
WAY.
THE LEGISLATURE IS ALSO STRONGLY
SUPPORTED AB SIX SEVENTEEN BY
PROVIDING NEARLY HALF A BILLION
DOLLARS TO JUMP START EARLY
REDUCTIONS IN THESE COMMUNITIES
THROUGH TARGETED INCENTIVE
FUNDING THAT COMPLEMENTS THE
REGULATORY EFFORTS.
THIS INCLUDED TWO HUNDRED AND
FIFTEEN TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MILLION IN THE SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN STATE BUDGET.
AND THE MAP ON THE RIGHT HAND
SIDE OF THE SLIDE SHOWS THE
ALLOCATION TO THE INDIVIDUAL AIR
DISTRICTS WHICH IS SPECIFIED IN
THE BUDGET BILL.
AIR DISTRICTS HAVE BEGAN
DISTRIBUTING THIS FUNDING FOR
CLEANER TRUCKS BUSES OTHER
MOBILE EQUIPMENT.
AND EXAMPLE PROJECTS INCLUDE
HYBRID GANTRY CRANES AT THE PORT
OF OAKLAND ZERO EMISSION TRACKS
IN THE SOUTH COAST IN ZERO
MISSION SCHOOL BUSES IN THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY AMONGST OTHERS.
THEN THE SECOND HALF OF THE
FUNDS WAS PROVIDED IN THE
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN BUDGET WHICH
HAS NOW EXPANDED TO INCLUDE
STATIONARY SOURCE TYPE PROJECTS.
WERE IN THE PROCESS OF
DEVELOPING GUIDELINES FOR THOSE
NEW TYPES OF PROJECTS AND THAT
INCLUDES DISCUSSIONS WITH
COMMUNITY RESIDENTS ABOUT WHAT
THEY WOULD LIKE TO SEE HAPPEN IN
THEIR COMMUNITIES.
AND THESE GUIDELINES WILL BE
CONSIDERED BY OUR BOARD NEXT
MONTH.
MOVING ON TO SOME OF THE OTHER
TOOLS ARE WORKING ON EMISSIONS
DATA IS VERY MUCH THE FOUNDATION
FOR OUR STATE PROGRAMS.
INCLUDING INFORMING EMISSION
REDUCTION STRATEGIES AS WELL AS
TRACKING PROGRESS OVER TIME.
AB SIX SEVENTEEN AND AB --
ONE NINETY SEVEN THAT CAME
BEFORE IT CALLED FOR ENHANCED
EMISSIONS DATA REPORTING ALONG
WITH GREATER ACCESS TO THE STATE
OF BY COMMUNITY RESIDENTS.
SO WE'RE WORKING WITH THEIR
DISTRICTS ON NEW EMISSION
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS PROVIDE
MORE INFORMATION TO COMMUNITY
MEMBERS AND HEALTH SCIENTISTS ON
THE SOURCE OF THE CRITERIA
POLLUTANTS AND ESPECIALLY AIR
TOXICS WITHIN THESE COMMUNITIES.
AS WELL AS DEVELOPMENT OF MORE
UNIFORM EMISSIONS REPORTING
METHODOLOGIES.
OUR STAFF BEGAN THIS PUBLIC
PROCESS FOR THE REGULATION LAST
SPRING AND WAS ADOPTED BY OUR
BOARD IN DECEMBER.
BUT AT THE DECEMBER BOARD
MEETING OUR BOARD ALSO DIRECTED
STAFF TO TAKE A BROADER FOCUS
AND BETTER SUPPORT COMMUNITY
LEVEL DATA THAT WE NEED FOR THE
PROGRAM STATEWIDE.
A FEW WEEKS AGO WE RELEASED
DRAFT CHANGES THAT RESPONDED TO
THAT DIRECTION.
WE'VE ALSO JUST COMPLETED
WORKSHOPS IN SACRAMENTO OAKLAND
LA SAN DIEGO IN FRESNO TO GO
OVER THE PROPOSED MODIFICATIONS
AND TALK ABOUT WHAT THE NEXT
STEPS ARE.
OVER THE NEXT FEW MONTHS WILL BE
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH THEIR
DISTRICTS COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS AND OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS. TO FINALIZE THE
REGULATION AND THAT WILL INCLUDE
A FORMAL PROCESS FOR COMMENT ON
THE PROPOSED CHANGES.
SO ALONG WITH ENHANCED EMISSIONS
DATA WE'RE ALSO WORKING ON A
NUMBER OF EFFORTS TO BETTER
SUPPORT COMMUNITY LEVEL AIR
MONITORING.
THERE ARE A VARIETY OF METHODS
THAT CAN BE USED TO IMPROVE OUR
UNDERSTANDING MANY OF WHICH ARE
HIGHLIGHTED HERE ON THIS SLIDE
FROM SMALLER SENSORS TO MOBILE
PLATFORMS TO SATELLITE DATA.
THIS IS REALLY AN AN AREA OF
RAPID EXPANSION AND INNOVATION
AND COMMUNITY LED EFFORTS HAVE
REALLY PLAYED A KEY ROLE IN THIS.
SO AS PART OF AB SIX SEVENTEEN
WE ARE ASSESSING THE
CAPABILITIES OF MANY OF THESE
DIFFERENT TECHNOLOGIES ALSO IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE SOUTH COAST
WHICH HAS THEIR AQ SPEC PROGRAM.
AND AS YOU'VE HEARD THROUGHOUT
THE PRESENTATION WE NEED TO MAKE
IT EASIER FOR PEOPLE TO ACCESS
AND USE THIS INFORMATION ABOUT
AIR QUALITY IN THEIR COMMUNITY.
SO THIS SUMMER WE'RE GOING TO BE
LAUNCHING A NEW WEBSITE IT'S
CALLED H. Q. VIEW.
AND THEN FINALLY AS I MENTIONED
EARLIER THE BLUEPRINT ALSO
PROVIDES GUIDANCE FOR HOW TO
DESIGN EFFECTIVE COMMUNITY ARE
MONITORING NETWORK SO THEY
REALLY CAN SUPPORT.
A VARIETY OF ACTIONS FROM
PROVIDING BETTER INFORMATION
ABOUT WHAT PEOPLE ARE BREATHING
ON A REAL TIME BASIS AND THEIR
COMMUNITIES.
THE BETTER UNDERSTANDING THE
IMPACTS OF DIFFERENT SOURCES SO
WE CAN BETTER TARGET UNDERSTAND
HOW WE NEED TO REDUCE EMISSIONS.
AND THEN TO HOUSE ALL THIS
INFORMATION WE'VE LAUNCHED AN
ONLINE RESOURCE CENTER WHICH
PROVIDES ONE LOCATION FOR AIR
DISTRICTS COMMUNITY MEMBERS TO
ACCESS THE MULTIPLE TOOLS AND
RESOURCES THAT ARE AVAILABLE.
THIS ALSO INCLUDES DEVELOPMENT
OF A TECHNOLOGY CLEARING HOUSE
WHICH PROVIDES INFORMATION ON
CONTROL APPROACHES THAT ARE IN
PRACTICE TODAY.
BUT ALSO FORWARD LOOKING NEXT
GENERATION KINDS OF TECHNOLOGIES
WHERE THERE MAY BE BENEFITS OF
PROVIDING SOME ADDITIONAL
INCENTIVE FUNDING.
THIS IS A FREE RESOURCE FOR BOTH
AIR DISTRICTS AND COMMUNITY
MEMBERS AS THEIR DISTRICTS BEGIN
DEVELOPING THEIR PARKING OF THE
RULES.
WILL BE CONTINUING TO UPDATE
THIS RESOURCE CENTER AS MORE
INFORMATION BECOMES AVAILABLE --
AND ALSO INCLUDING RESOURCES FAR
COLLABORATING WITH LAND USE AND
TRANSPORTATION AGENCIES BEST
PRACTICES AND INFORMATION ABOUT
HEALTH IMPACTS AND HEALTH
STUDIES THAT ARE ONGOING.
AND WITH THAT I WILL TURN IT
OVER.
TO VERONICA TO CLOSE THE
PRESENTATION.
SO IF YOU'RE HURT AS YOU'VE
HEARD BY NAMES FOR ANNIKA EDM
THE ASSISTANT EXECUTIVE OFFICER
FOR ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE KAREN
AND I HAVE WORKED REALLY CLOSELY
AND IMPLEMENTING --
EIGHTY SIX ONE SEVEN INVOLVEMENT
HAVE BEEN AT THE HEART OF THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS PROGRAM.
MANY COMMUNITY MEMBERS AS WE
ROLLED OUT THE PROGRAM --
AT PROVIDED SUGGESTIONS FOR
IMPROVING OUR OUTREACH --
IT WAS CLEAR IN FACT THAT
ENGAGING.
WITH THESE COMMUNITIES REQUIRED
NEW APPROACHES AND NOT JUST OUR
TRADITIONAL DAYTIME WORKSHOPS.
SO SOME OF THE NEW APPROACHES
INCLUDED --
CREATING AT A NEW CONSULTATION
GROUP WHICH IS A BROAD RANGE OF
STAKEHOLDERS AND IS CHAIRED BY
ONE OF OUR BOARD MEMBERS --
WE PARTICIPATED IN LEGISLATIVE
TOWN HALLS AND OF COURSE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MARTUCCI --
WAS ONE OF THE LEGISLATORS WHO
OPENED THE DOORS FOR US TO MEET
WITH HIS CONSTITUENTS.
AND THEN A NUMBER OF EVENING
MEETINGS AS WELL.
BUT IT ISN'T ABOUT ONLY ABOUT
FINDING NEW WAYS TO BRING PEOPLE
TOGETHER IT WAS ABOUT HAVING
REAL CONVERSATION SOME OF THEM
DIFFICULT CONVERSATIONS --
WITH RESIDENTS TO SHARE THEIR
KNOWLEDGE AND EXPERIENCES --
MANY OF THE LOCAL GROUPS INVITED
US ON TOWARDS OF THEIR
NEIGHBORHOOD AND IT WAS REALLY
IMPOSSIBLE FOR US --
TO BE ABLE TO EXT THE
NEIGHBORHOODS WHERE PEOPLE LIVE
AS THEY SEE THEIR NEIGHBORHOODS
AND WE WERE REALLY.
FORTUNATE TO HAVE RICHARD ON A
NUMBER OF THOSE STORIES WITH US --
MANY OF THE LOCAL GROUPS --
AS I SAID --
EXPLAIN TO THEIR FIRST HAND
PROBLEMS AND WE'RE CONTINUING TO
HAVE THESE CONVERSATIONS --
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT THAT WE
CONTINUE TO DO THIS PARTICULARLY
AS WE NOT JUST --
SELECT NEW COMMUNITIES IDENTIFY
NEW COMMUNITIES THAT WILL BE A
BE SIX ONE SEVEN COMMUNITIES.
BUT ALSO.
THE THROUGHOUT THE
IMPLEMENTATION IN THESE FIRST
YEARS IN THE COMMUNITIES THAT
THE BOARD DESIGNATED --
SAU.
WE'RE ALSO SUPPORTING COMMUNITY
INVOLVEMENT THROUGH FUNDING --
PROVIDED BY THE LEGISLATURE FOR
GRANTS PROGRAM FOR COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS WE CALL THAT
THAT COMMUNITY AIR GRANTS.
THIS MAP SHOWS THE FIRST TEN
MILLION DOLLARS THAT WE AWARDED
TO TWENTY FIVE COMMUNITY GROUPS
ACROSS THE STATE --
AS WELL AS THREE NATIVE AMERICAN
TRIBES.
THE GRANTS PROVIDE FUNDING FOR
GROUPS TO PARTICIPATE IN A LOCAL
COMMUNITY ARE PROTECTION PROCESS
SO IN SOME CASES IT'S SHARING
INFORMATION AND BUILDING CASES
IT'S A BUILDING CAPACITY WITHIN
THE COMMUNITIES USING A NUMBER
OF APPROACHES.
SO FOR EXAMPLE WE'VE HIGHLIGHTED
HERE IN --
VENTURE A DEAR ACTION TEAMS LED
BY COMMUNITY MEMBERS TO HELP
DOCUMENT AIR POLLUTION SOURCES --
ALL ABOUT WILL HELP US IN THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF AB --
SIX ONE SEVEN IN FRESNO THERE
ARE SCHOOL STUDENTS WHO WILL
LEARN HOW TO IDENTIFY UNHEALTHY
AIR QUALITY ISSUES.
AND IN EAST LA RESIDENTS WILL
LEARN ABOUT THE LONG TERM PUBLIC
HEALTH IMPACTS OF AIR POLLUTION
EXPOSURE AND AIR POLLUTION
REDUCTION --
IN.
HI EAST LA THIS IS A
PARTICULARLY --
IMPLEMENTED OUT OF PUBLIC
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT --
WE ARE EXPECTING TO HAVE A TO
ALLOCATE THE ADDITIONAL FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS THAT WE HAVE
LEFT.
DURING AS SECOND SOLICITATION
THAT WILL ROLL OUT IN THE COMING
MONTHS --
AND ANNOUNCING THE WORD AT THE
GRANT SOMETIME THIS SUMMER.
ANOTHER KEY PART OF THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF AB SIX ONE
SEVEN ANOTHER CORE PIECE OF IT
IS THAT COMMUNITY STEERING
COMMITTEES --
THIS IS A CRITICAL STEP IN
CONTINUING ENGAGEMENT AND
COMMUNITY PARTNERSHIPS THAT ARE
FUNDAMENTAL TO THIS PROGRAM.
THE AIR DISTRICTS HAVE CAN BE
AND COMMUNITY STEERING
COMMITTEES TO GUIDE THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THE MONITORING
PLANS.
AND THAT INCLUDES --
DETERMINING WHERE THE MONEY --
LOCATED IN THAT OF COURSE IN
PUTTING TOGETHER THE COMMUNITY
EMISSION REDUCTION PROGRAMS.
THESE COMMITTEES BRING TOGETHER
A BROAD GROUP TO THE TABLE.
DRAWN FROM EACH SELECTED
COMMUNITY WITH PEOPLE THAT LIVE
THERE --
WITH PEOPLE THAT BUSINESSES AND
THE COMMUNITY AND THE
PUBLICATION SEES THAT GOVERN
LOCAL POLICIES --
AND IT'S PRETTY IMPORTANT TO
HAVE THE LOCAL AGENCIES SO THAT
WERE ABLE --
TO ADOPT PROGRAMS THAT ALSO.
MIGHT INCLUDE LOCAL LAND USES
AND OTHER THINGS --
OTHER TOOLS THAT AREN'T
NECESSARILY WITHIN OUR AUTHORITY
OR THE FORTY THE AIR DISTRICT.
THE STEERING COMMITTEE
MEMBERSHIP --
IS PRIMARILY COMMUNITY RESIDENTS
SO A MAJORITY OF COMMUNITY
RESIDENTS THAT REPRESENT VOICES
FROM ACROSS THE COMMUNITY.
THESE COMMITTEES ARE WORKING
WITH THE AIR DISTRICTS
THROUGHOUT THE PROCESS FROM
DISCUSSING --
MONITORING NEEDS IDENTIFYING
STRATEGIES THAT REDUCE POLLUTION
AND ALSO TRACKING PROGRESS IN
MAKING SURE THAT WE HAVE METRICS
AS WE MOVE FORWARD.
WE'LL BE HEARING MORE ABOUT THE
EXTENT OF WORK GOING ON WITH
THESE COMMITTEES OF COURSE FOR
BOTH FROM THE AIR DISTRICTS WHO
ARE HERE TODAY AND AS WELL AS
STEERING COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
SO LOOKING FORWARD --
AS WE LOOK AHEAD THERE ARE MANY
IMPACTED COMMUNITIES AND WILL
CONTINUE WORKING WITH OUR
PARTNERS --
IN COMMUNITIES IN THE AIR
DISTRICTS.
TO ACTIONS THAT WILL REDUCE
EMISSIONS AND EXPOSURES.
WILL ALSO WORK WITH COMMUNITIES
TO DEVELOP THE TOOLS NEEDED TO
BETTER UNDERSTAND POLLUTION
SOURCES.
AND DOCUMENT AIR QUALITY IMPACTS.
THIS WILL BE AN ONGOING EFFORT
THAT WILL INVOLVE AS WE LEARN
ADJUSTED.
BASED ON THE INITIAL YEARS OF
THE PROGRAM.
OUR BOARD HAS AN ONGOING ROLE OF
COURSE INCLUDING CONSIDERATION
OF ADDITIONAL COMMUNITIES AND
THE PROPOSAL OF THE COMMUNITY
READ EMISSION REDUCTION PROGRAM
SUBMITTED BY THE AIR DISTRICTS.
LATER ON THIS YEAR WE ALSO LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO WORK
WITH THE LEGISLATURE --
BOTH THROUGH LEGISLATIVE
COMMITTEE REPORTS AND
DISCUSSIONS WITH INDIVIDUAL
LEGISLATORS OUGHT TO ADDRESS
CONCERNS IN THEIR COMMUNITIES
ALL OF THESE EFFORTS WILL
CONTINUE TO SHAPE THE PROGRAM
AND PROVIDE.
THE CRITICAL PUBLIC HEALTH
PROTECTION THAT IS NEEDED.
THANK YOU AND WE'D BE HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU
MIGHT HAVE.
THANK YOU AND A CONGRATULATIONS
ON STAYING WITHIN THE ALLOTTED
TIMEFRAME I THINK YOU WERE AN
EXEMPLARY GROUP SETTING REALLY
EXAMPLE.
INTO GROUPS YET TO COME SO THANK
YOU --
BEFORE I ASK MY QUESTIONS I WILL
MOVE TO THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS TO
SEE IF ANYBODY HAS ANY.
QUESTIONS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CRISTINA GARCIA FIVE THAT USE
ANY TALK ABOUT CARBS ONGOING
ROLES AND YOU.
I MIGHT HAVE [inaudible]
IT'S OKAY.
I'M SORRY.
IN A EASE AT THAT THERE'S CARBS
ONGOING ROLAND.
YOU OUTLINED FIVE ROLLS AND THAT
THE WHAT I DIDN'T SEE ON THAT
WAS YOUR ROLE AND HELPING THE
AREA THE LOCAL OR DISTRICTS ARE
HOLDING THEM ACCOUNTABLE.
THE IDEA IS THAT HOT SPOTS HER
THEIR FRIENDS IN THE COMMUNITY
TOOLS THE NEEDS WE HAVE ARE
GOING TO BE DIFFERENT AND WE
WANT THEM TO BE TAILORED TO THE
INDIVIDUAL THANKS AND SO WE
DON'T EXPECT TO SEE.
A REPLICA OF A SYSTEM ACROSS THE
BOARD BUT WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
IT'S EQUITABLE SPECIALLY IN THE
COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT PIECE THAT
EVER REALLY FULLY IT EXEMPLIFIES
WHAT WE WANTED AND THAT WE ARE
NOT JUST DOING.
MONITORING THAT WE'RE GOING WELL
BEYOND THAT AND THAT --
THE COMMUNITY HAS TO SAY AND
IT'S A PARTNERSHIP AND NOT JUST
BEING TOLD AND SO HOW DO YOU SEE
YOUR ROLE IN IN THIS PROCESS AND
AND FOR ME THIS WAS REALLY
IMPORTANT BECAUSE THESE FIRST
TEN COMMUNITIES ARE WHO ARE
LEARNING FROM WHEN WILL BE THE
BLUEPRINT MOVING FORWARD.
YES ASSEMBLYMEMBER GARCIA.
THE ONGOING IMPLEMENTATION AS
YOU NOTED IS KEY TO THE ULTIMATE
SUCCESS OF THE PROGRAM IS IT ARE
THE REAL REDUCTIONS BE REALIZED.
AND REDUCED EXPOSURE.
THE COMMUNITY OF EMISSION
REDUCTION PLAN THE BOARDS ARE
BOARDS CONSIDERATION OF THE PLAN
IS REALLY A TOUCH POINT A START.
THE AMPLE WILL REQUIRE ONGOING
WORK THAT WE WILL BE DOING WITH
THE DISTRICTS WITH THE
COMMUNITIES IN TERMS OF BECAUSE
THERE'S M<c.cyan> FOR MOBILE AND</c>
STATIONARY MEASURES AND
INCENTIVES THAT ARE EMBEDDED IN
IN THOSE ELEMENTS.
IN AN ELEMENT IN THE BURKE
BLUEPRINT THAT YOU TOUCHED ON
WAYS IN ANNUAL UPDATE IN TERMS
OF STATUS OF IMPLEMENTATION SO A
KEY ELEMENT OF THE COMMUNITY
EMISSION REDUCTION PROGRAM.
IS NOT ONLY THE INVENTORY WHERE
THE EMISSIONS COMING FROM IS ONE
OF THE COMMITMENTS.
WHAT IS THE TIME FRAME FOR THOSE
COMMITMENTS AND AN ANNUAL?
STATUS REPORT ON PROGRESS
RELATIVE THE PLAN IN A PUBLIC
POSTING OF THAT.
THE ANNUAL UPDATE AN ONGOING
WORK WITH DISTRICTS AND
COMMUNITIES THERE'S GOING TO BE.
IT REALLY IS A KEY ELEMENT TO
THE ALTIMA EFFECTIVENESS OF THE
PROGRAM.
IS THERE A ROLE FOR YOU AS THE
IT'S THAT THE AS A STEERING
COMMITTEES ARE MEETING --
IS THERE A ROLE FOR YOU IN ANY
OF THIS PROCESS.
NOW I KNOW THAT THEIR MEETING AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL BUT IS THERE A
ROLE FOR YOU NOW WHAT DO YOU SEE
THAT ROLE FOR YOURSELF.
IF THERE IS.
ONE SO WE'VE BEEN --
STAFFING THOSE DURING COMMITTEES
SO -- KAREN
IS AT HER STOP THEIR WE'VE HAD
STAFF FOR MONITORING LABORATORY
DIVISION AND A MARBLE JUSTICE
STAFF IN THERE --
THAT WE HEAR IGGY AGING IN
BETWEEN STEERING COMMITTEE
MEETINGS WITH --
AJ GROUPS AND COMMUNITY
RESIDENTS WHO WANT TO ENGAGE
WITH US SO IN SOME OF THE
DISTRICTS WE'VE HAD QUITE A BIT
OF CONTACT EVEN JUST TODAY WE
HAD A MEETING WITH --
CALIFORNIA VITAL JUSTICE
ALLIANCE SO WE'RE KEEPING THE
LINES OF COMMUNICATION OPEN AND
WE'RE MAKING ADJUSTMENTS AS WE
NEED [inaudible]
TO IF -- I
HAVE SOME MORE QUESTIONS BUT YOU
GUYS ARE GONNA STICK AROUND FOR
THE FIRST THE PRESENTATION I
THINK I'LL LET.
SO I THINK IT'LL BE BASED ON
WHAT I HEAR FROM THE GROUPS WILL
WILL BE HERE --
BUT I I'VE BEEN I HAVE BEEN
SPEAKING TO FOLKS AND AS
EXPECTED DIFFERENCE DURING
COMMITTEES ARE IN DIFFERENT
PROCESS THIS AND AND I COULD
HAVE SOME PATIENCE FOR FOR THAT
DIFFERENCE.
BUT THERE IS FRUSTRATION OF
LOCALLY.
FROM COMMUNITY MEMBERS WHERE
THIS AND PHYLLIS COLLABORATIVE
AN EXPECTATION OF FOOD THEN
STEPPED IN TO HELP THEM BE MORE
COLLABORATIVE IS THAT YOUR ROLE.
AND AT THAT I MEAN IN MY EYES
IT'S YOUR OWN BUT A IT'S NOT
CLEAR WHOSE ROLE IS TO HELP MAKE
THE SWITCH IS A LITTLE BIT
BETTER WE BELIEVE WE HAVE A KEY
ROLE IN TERMS OF NOT ONLY THE
WORK WITH THE DISTRICTS.
THE WORK WITH THE COMMUNITIES
AND TO VERONICA'S POINT IT'S ONE
OF THE REASONS WE'VE ATTENDED
AND WILL CONTINUE TO ATTEND THE
STEERING COMMITTEE SO WE ARE
ENGAGED.
AWARE HOW THINGS ARE PROCEED WE
ALL OF US COLLECTIVELY WANT TO
BE CONFIDENT.
THAT THE COMMUNITY THAT THE
MISSION REDUCTION PLAN THAT THE
BOARD ULTIMATELY CONSIDERS.
IS EFFECTIVE AND WORKS IN A
SOLID AND FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE
THE WAY TO DO THAT IS BEING
GAUGE FROM THE GET GO.
AND NOT A ONLY FOR BOARDS
CONSIDERATION OF PLAN REALLY
THROUGHOUT ITS IMPLEMENTATION.
AND IF I COULD JUST ADD --
SO AS YOU CAN IMAGINE EACH --
STEERING COMMITTEE ACROSS THE
REGION AND IS A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENT BASED ON THEIR
COMPOSITION AND THEIR CULTURE
AND AND SO KAREN AND I HAVE BEEN --
AS I SAID MEETING WITH PEOPLE
BUT ALSO PAYING ATTENTION TO
WHAT THE NEEDS OF THOSE STEERING
COMMITTEES ARE --
SO FOR EXAMPLE YOU KNOW --
AS YOU CAN IMAGINE PEOPLE ARE UP
AGAINST A FOR A REALLY TIGHT
CLOCK.
AND I'VE EXPERIENCED A
DIFFERENCE OF THE US DURING
COMMITTEES WHERE --
SOME OF THAT MEMBERS OF THE
STEERING COMMITTEE FEEL LIKE
THEY DON'T HAVE A DEPTH OF UNDER
SO.
WE'RE CONTINUING TO HAVE
INTERNAL CONVERSATIONS ABOUT HOW
WE CAN PROVIDE THE TOOLS THAT
THE STEERING COMMITTEE NEEDS TO
BE ABLE TO BE EFFECTIVE AT THEIR
JOBS AND SO OVER THE COURSE OF
THE NEXT YEAR AND ESPECIALLY AS
WE SEE MORE COMMUNITIES COMING
ONLINE.
I THINK WE WILL BE DOING SOME
COURSE ADJUSTMENTS SO THAT WE
CAN BE --
SUPPORT FOR THEM.
THANK YOU.
OTHER QUESTIONS ASSEMBLYMEMBER
CHAO THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND AND
CHECK OFFICE WELL THANK YOU ALL
FOR BEING HERE I HE WALKED IN.
A COUPLE MINUTES LATE SO I'M NOT
SURE IF YOU ALREADY ADDRESSED
ISSUES --
BUT LOOKING AT THE STATUE THE
STATUTE BE SOCIALLY BECAUSE FOR
SOME ARMED BASICALLY HIGH LEVEL
KIND OF ALL COMPLAINTS --
THE DIAL IS ACTUALLY SO COOL
FIRST QUESTION IS ARE A WE
BASICALLY ON TRACK AS FAR AS THE
TIME LINES ARE ARE CONCERNED AS
FAR AS IMPLEMENTING EACH STEP OF
THE OF THE GAME PLAN.
WE ARE ON TRACK BUT I WANNA MAKE
SURE WHEN I SAY THAT THIS
PROGRAMS VERY COMPREHENSIVE VERY
AMBITIOUS AND ALL THOSE OLD SAID
THIS TABLE BEHIND ME.
YOU ARE COMMITTED TO PAYING
ATTENTION TO HELP PLACE OUT BUT
JUST TO DIRECTLY ANSWER YOUR
QUESTION.
THERE ARE A NUMBER DATES THAT
WERE CALLED OUT FOR THE FIRST
YEAR IN TERMS OF A COMMUNITY A
PLAN THAT THE TEMPLATE FOR
DEVELOPING COMMUNITY BE SURE
REDUCTION PLANTS.
A PLAN FOR AIR QUALITY
MONITORING THE DISTRICT'S
SCHEDULE FOR BARKED.
ALL THOSE THINGS HAVE HAPPENED
AND THEY'VE HAPPEN ACCORDING TO
THE SCHEDULE BUT I WANT TO SAY
THAT REALIZING.
THERE'S MUCH MUCH WORK AHEAD OF
US BUT WE ARE ALL THE STATUTORY
DATES AT RECALL THAT WE MET
THOSE CUTS I NOTICED THAT THE
TEN REGIONS HAVE BEEN SELECTED
AND ALSO YOU MENTION JUST
MENTIONED ABOUT THE MONITORING
PLAN.
BUT WHAT ABOUT THE CLEARING
HOUSE THAT BASICALLY IDENTIFIES
THE VARIOUS ALL PATERNITY OF SO
TECHNOLOGY ALTERNATIVES --
TO COMBAT THE SITUATION HAS NOT
ALSO BEEN IMPLEMENTED OR AT
LEAST DESIGNED YES SO --
LAST SEPTEMBER WE ACTUALLY
LAUNCHED AN INITIAL VERSION OF
THE CLEARING HOUSE SO IT CAN
SUPPORT THE EFFORTS THAT ARE
GOING ON RIGHT NOW.
BUT WE CONTINUE TO HAVE
DISCUSSIONS WITH COMMUNITY
MEMBERS AS WELL AS AIR DISTRICTS
ON HOW WE CAN FURTHER ENHANCE
THAT AND ACTUALLY HAVE A
CONTRACT UNDER WAY --
TO FURTHER ENHANCE THAT --
AND MAKE IT THE INFORMATION EVEN
MORE USER FRIENDLY AND
ACCESSIBLE AND THAT WILL BE
COMING OUT PROBABLY IN THE NEXT
SIX MONTHS TO A YEAR.
SO THAT'S WHEN WE WOULD EXPECT
TO SEE A WRITTEN REPORT OF SORTS
IT WOULD ANA.
WE CAN CERTAINLY PROVIDE ONGOING
REPORTS ABOUT THE STATUS OF THAT
IN THE INFORMATION THAT'S
AVAILABLE WITHIN THE CLEARING
HOUSE WE WANT TO CONTINUE TO
EXPAND IT OVER TIME YEAH I'M
JUST WONDERING WHETHER THERE'S A
WRITTEN REPORT ON THE OVERALL --
PROGRESS OF THE OF THE THE
IMPLEMENTATION THEY'RE NOT WHEN
WE GONNA GET TO SEE THAT IF AT
ALL IN THE NEXT FUTURE --
IN THE NEAR FUTURE.
THE A KEY POINT WILL BE LATE
THIS YEAR I WILL BE AFTER THE
DISTRICTS BRING BEFORE THEIR
BOARDS.
THE INITIAL COMMUNITY EMISSION
REDUCTION PROGRAM SO THEIR
BOARDS BY A OCTOBER ONE WILL BE
CONSIDERING THOSE PLANS.
AFTER THAT THEY'LL BE
TRANSMITTING THOSE PLANS TO CALL
OUR FOR WITHIN A SIXTY DAY
PERIOD FOR CONSIDERATION REVIEW
APPROVAL.
THAT WOULD BE ANOTHER GOOD TOUCH
POINT WILL BE BRIEFING OUR BOARD
IN TERMS OF A TOUCH POINT IN
TERMS THE STATUS OF THE PROGRAM.
THAT BE AN EXCELLENT OPPORTUNITY
TO BRIEF YOU AS WELL.
THANKS VERY MUCH [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANY OF THE OTHER COMMITTEE
MEMBERS HAVE QUESTIONS.
I HAVE A FEW QUESTIONS --
FIRST YOU KNOW GIVEN THAT MOBILE
SOURCES AND PARTICULARLY DIESEL
ARE A MAJOR CONTRIBUTOR TO A LOT
OF THESE COMMUNITIES --
HOW HOW WAS CARP GOING TO USE
ITS AUTHORITY --
TO REDUCE THE POLLUTION FROM THE
SOURCES AND IS IT ALL THROUGH
THE GRANT PROGRAM OR DO YOU HAVE
OTHER --
STRATEGIES THAT YOU'RE
CONSIDERING EMPLOYING AND THEN
THE SECOND PART OF THE QUESTION
IS ARE THERE OTHER STRATEGIES
THAT WE AS A LEGISLATURE SHOULD
BE CONSIDERING IN YOUR VIEW.
WE HAVE FROM A CONTROL
STANDPOINT SHEESH THE INITIAL
RESPONSE IS NOT ON SENATE'S
IMPACT IT'S HEAVILY FOCUSED ON
REGULATION.
WE ARE THE MOST.
THE MOST COMPREHENSIVE PACKAGE
OF MOBILE SOURCE HEAVY DUTY
REGULATIONS THEY WERE WORKING ON
THAT WE COMMITTED TO IN THE
HISTORY OF THE ORGANIZATION.
AND REALLY THOSE REGULATIONS BE
THEY HEAVY TRUCKS BE THE
DELIVERY TRUCKS TRANSIT BUSES.
SCHOOL BUSES T. R. USE A
REFRIGERATED TRAILERS THAT RUN
ON DIESEL.
THESE ARE TRANSITIONING EACH OF
THOSE TWO ELECTRIFICATION SO THE
COMPREHENSIVE REGULATION SOME OF
WHICH WE ALREADY BROUGHT TO THE
BOARD SOME WILL GO TO THE BOARD
THIS YEAR.
AND SOME IN THE NEXT YEAR TWO OR
TWO THREE YEARS.
VERY COMPREHENSIVE REALLY PHASE
OUT OF COMBUSTION.
AND REGULATIONS IN OUR MIND AND
FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE ARE A KEY
ELEMENT IN GETTING THEIR
INCENTIVE TO HELP MOVE THINGS
FORWARD.
THE BIGGER CHALLENGE AND THIS IS
JUST A ONE THAT WE ARE GRAPPLING
WITH THIS AN ORGANIZATION.
IS ONE WERE ONE EFFORT IS THE
TIGHTER STANDARDS MOVING THIS
YEAR THAT I TALKED ABOUT.
THE OTHER ISSUE IS. ZERO THE
DIESEL EQUIPMENT THAT'S ON THE
ROAD TODAY.
THE LAST FOR DECADES.
AND WE HAVE A TRUCK AND BUS READ
BUT WE HAVE A MANY OTHER --
IT HEAVY DUTY PIECES OF
EQUIPMENT THAT COULD LAST FOR
THE NEXT FEW DECADES THE
CHALLENGES.
I DO WHAT WORLD INCENTIVES PLAY
AND INCENTIVES HAVE BEEN HELPFUL
ABOUT MOVING THAT DIRTY QUITMAN
OUT AND REPLACING.
IT WITH THE CLEANEST ZERO
MISSION TECHNOLOGY THAT'S BEEN A
CHALLENGE AND IN SOME OF THAT
EQUIPMENT IS OWNED BY.
SINGLE OWNER OPERATORS LOWER
INCOME FOLKS.
THAT'S BEEN A CHALLENGE HOW DO
YOU EXPEDITE THE TURNOVER OF THE
EXISTING DIRTY FLEET AT THE SAME
TIME YOUR TIGHTENING STANDARDS
FOR THE NEW TECHNOLOGIES.
AND TRYING TO EXPEDITE THE
TURNOVER WITH INCENTIVES BUT
INCENTIVES WILL NEVER COVER ALL
THAT.
THAT THAT'S A YOU ISSUE OUR
BOARD AND WE ARE GRAPPLING WITH
STAKEHOLDERS ON RIGHT NOW TRYING
TO WORK THROUGH.
THANKS FOR DIFFERENT TYPES OF
EMISSIONS ARE THERE IS THERE A
CENTRAL LISTING OF ALTERNATIVES.
FOR JUST FOUR DIFFERENT TYPES OF
OF EMISSION SOURCES
ON THE ON THE MOBILE SIDE WHAT
WE'VE DONE BECAUSE MOBILE SOURCE
ON HEAVY DUTY.
IT'S EXCEEDINGLY COMPLEX IN
TERMS OF THE SCOPE OF SOURCES.
OF A FORKLIFT IS DIFFERENT THAN
A PIECE OF CARGO HIM THE
EQUIPMENT IS DIFFERENT THAN A
CLASS SIX ROCKETS DIFFERENT THAN
A CLASS EIGHT WHAT WE'VE DONE IS
PREPARE TECHNICAL ASSESSMENTS.
FOR EACH OF THESE CATEGORIES OF
HEAVY DUTY AND IN TERMS OF
WHAT'S AVAILABLE IS ZERO
AVAILABLE TODAY ONE OF THE
EMISSIONS SO THIS IS SOMETHING
WE POSTED AND IT REALLY IS A
PREAMBLE.
THAT WORK TO THE REGULATORY WORK
THAT WE'RE CURRENTLY DOING SO
THAT IS ON OUR WEBSITE --
I I'M NOT SAYING IT'S ALWAYS IS
USER FRIENDLY THESE ARE DETAILED
TECHNICAL DOCUMENTS.
AND THEN --
IN TERMS OF THE REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS WHAT WAS THE
CRITERIA AND HOW IT HOW DID YOU
BASE THAT YOU KNOW WHAT WITH THE
THRESHOLDS BASED ON AND HOW WERE
YOU ABLE TO IMPACT THAT.
TO JUDGE THE IMPACTS ON
COMMUNITY HEALTH --
WITH A LACK OF SORT OF PRIOR
DATA.
SO IN AND I THINK THE EMISSIONS
REPORTING YEAH REGULATION SO
WE'VE TAKEN SORT OF A TIERED
APPROACH --
IN TERMS OF THE REQUIREMENTS --
IN THE REGULATION AND IT'S
REALLY BASED ON THE PRIOR WORK --
THAT IS BEING DONE LOOKING --
FIVE EIGHTY EIGHT AND THE
SCIENCE AND THE HEALTH
INFORMATION ASSOCIATED WITH THAT.
SO FOR EXAMPLE WHEN WE'RE
LOOKING AT CRITERIA POLLUTANTS
PM KNOCKS --
WE ARE NOW PROPOSING UP A
THRESHOLD FOR PERMITTED SOURCES
THAT EMIT MORE THAN TEN TONS PER
YEAR AND THAT'S A A PRETTY
CONSISTENT THRESHOLD WHEN YOU
GET TO TALK SIX OF COURSE IT
BECOMES MORE DIFFICULT BECAUSE
THE HEALTH IMPACTS ARE MUCH MORE
SIGNIFICANT.
SO FOR A NUMBER OF KEY AIR
TOXICS WE'RE REALLY LOOKING AT
REPORTING OF ALL SOURCES FOR
THOSE WHEN YOU'RE LOOKING AT
THINGS LIKE HEX CHROM COMING
FROM FROM PLAYERS ETCETERA.
AND THEN FOR OTHER KINDS OF
SOURCES --
IT'S STARTING TO LOOK AT
ADDITIONAL THRESHOLDS FOR THIS
AND THEN PART OF THIS IS ALSO
LOOKING AT RECOGNIZING THIS IS A
A LOT OF DATA THAT WILL NEED TO
BE COLLECTING OVERTIME.
WORKING TO PHASE THE
REQUIREMENTS FOR THE REPORTING
REGULATION IN OVER A PERIOD OF
TIME AS WELL.
THANK YOU AND LAST MY LAST
QUESTION FOR NOW IS WHAT
PROGRESS HAS BEEN MADE ON THE
BEST AVAILABLE RETROFIT CONTROL
TECHNOLOGY DATABASE.
SO -- THAT'S
THE TERMINOLOGY I WAS USING FOR
THE TECHNOLOGY CLEARING HOUSE SO
THAT WAS WHAT WE LAUNCHED AS AN
INTERIM VERSION AND THEN WE'RE
CONTINUING TO WORK TO ENHANCE
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL DATA INTO
THAT AND EVENTUALLY ALSO
INCORPORATE NOT ONLY STATIONARY
SOURCE BUT MOBILE SOURCE
TECHNOLOGIES AS WELL.
RIGHT THANK YOU THAT IS FINE --
SAY THAT WE'VE JUST BEEN JOINED
BY SOME MEMBERS WHOSE EGGMAN
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE --
Là IS ANYBODY HAVE ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS ASSEMBLYMEMBER GARCIA.
I HAVE ONE MORE QUESTION WE WE
HAVE STE AND ACTION PLANS THAT
WILL BE COMING DOWN EVENTUALLY --
AND THE AIR BE.
WILL BE LOOKING AT THOSE ACTION
PLANS AND DECIDING THIS IS GOOD
THIS IS BAD I JUST MISS HOW ARE
YOU GUYS PREPARING TO REVIEW
THOSE AND GIVE THEM PUT AND MAKE
SURE THAT THE STEERING.
PLANTS.
LOOK GOOD.
RIGHT AND BRANKA MAY WANT TO ADD
TO THIS BUT GETS TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER A POINT I MADE EARLIER
WHICH IS.
THE OCTOBER ONE DEADLINE IS THE
DATE BY WHICH THE DISTRICT WOULD
ACT ON THE COMMUNITY'S MISSION
REDUCTION PROGRAM.
IF EVEN THE HEAD OF THAT LAST
YEAR WAS THE BILL WHAT WE'RE
REFERRING IS THE BLUEPRINT WHICH
WAS WHAT IS THE BENCHMARK TO
ASSESS INEFFECTIVE COMMITTEE WHO
JOSH REDUCTION PLAN SO IT LAID
OUT [inaudible]
SUBSTANTIAL CRITERIA THAT WOULD
BE USED TO JUDGE THE
EFFECTIVENESS AND COMPREHENSIVE
NATURE OF A COMMUNITY REDUCTION
PLAN.
WE COULD PROMOTE CONSISTENCY AND
QUALITY THE OTHER ELEMENT.
WAS ENGAGEMENT THAT VERONICA
MENTION AT THE STEERING
COMMITTEE SO THAT WE'RE NOT
WAITING TO SEE A AL SOLVE THE
PLAN IS THAT WE CAN FALL WITH A
LONG AND ENGAGE IN THE PROCESS
OF THE REALLY --
PARTS PRICES WE HAVE DESCRIBED
MUCH MORE TO ADD BUT THE
STEERING COMMITTEES HAVE BEEN I
MEAN I AM AND ALL OF THEM BUT
I'VE BEEN.
TO QUITE A NUMBER OF THEM AND
IT'S BEEN A REALLY HELPFUL TO
EXPERIENCE THE PROGRESS AS IT
UNFOLDS --
YOU'LL HEAR OF COURSE FROM --
WEST OAKLAND REBEL INDEED
INDICATORS PROJECT MISS MARGARET
GORDON -- AS
WELL AS IN THE AIR DISTRICT
THERE REALLY FARTHER ALONG THAN
ANYBODY ELSE IS IN THE PROCESS.
SO THERE ARE A LOT OF LESSONS TO
BE LEARNED I THINK FROM WEST
OAKLAND AS THE OTHER.
COMMUNITIES BEGIN TO COME ALONG.
SO DO YOU EXPECT THAT.
NOW THAT YOU'RE ON THE GROUND IN
YOUR AT TEN THE IN THE STEERING
COMMITTEES THAT YOUR BLUE PRATT
MIGHT CHANGE [inaudible] FORTY
SO THE THE STATUTE SAYS THAT YOU
KNOW AT A MINIMUM WE WOULD NEED
TO UPDATE THE BLUEPRINT WITHIN
FIVE YEARS.
I THINK CERTAINLY AS YOU'VE
HEARD BECAUSE THIS IS SUCH A
BRAND NEW PROGRAM AND WE'RE ALL
LEARNING AND GROWING THAT WE
WOULD EXPECT TO MAKE ADJUSTMENTS
TO THE BLUEPRINT MUCH EARLIER
THAN THE FIVE YEAR TIME FRAME
SINCE WE'RE LEARNING SO MUCH
THIS YEAR.
THANK YOU ACTUALLY I DO HAVE ONE
MORE QUESTION BEFORE I MOVED TO
MY COLLEAGUES --
ON YOUR SLIDE NINE YOU SHOULD AN
AIR TOXICS MONITOR AND I'M
WONDERING IF A OR B. OR ANY
OTHER THEY ARE DISTRICT US
DEPLOYED ANY.
THEIR TOXIC MONITORS PURSUANT TO
AB SIX SEVENTEEN AND IF SO IF
THAT A MISSION ST IS AVAILABLE
TO THE PUBLIC AND WHERE THAT
WOULD BE.
SO THERE IS A A ROUTINE.
AIR TOXICS NETWORK ACROSS
CALIFORNIA THAT WE IN THE LOCAL
AIR DISTRICTS HAVE HISTORICALLY --
OPERATED WHAT TAP IS THROUGH THE
COMMUNITY STEERING COMMITTEES --
THE AIR DISTRICTS ARE WORKING
WITH THOSE COMMITTEES TO
IDENTIFY WHAT KIND OF THINGS WE
WANT TO MONITOR FOR AND THE MOST
APPROPRIATE TECHNOLOGIES.
AND I THINK YOU'LL BE HEARING
FROM SOME OF THE AIR DISTRICTS
TODAY WHAT THEY'RE LOOKING AT
BUT WE DO KNOW THAT AIR TOXICS
IS ONE OF THE KEY ELEMENTS OF
THAT AND SO THEY'RE LOOKING AT
WHICH KINDS OF APPROACHES
THEY'LL BE USING --
AND HOW TO MAKE THAT INFORMATION
AVAILABLE AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE
TO THE COMMUNITY MEMBERS
[inaudible]
SEPTEMBER.
I HAVE ONE MORE QUESTION ON IT'S
MY UNDERSTANDING THAT THE
STATIONARY SOURCES ARE WITHIN
THE JURISDICTION OF BOTH THE
COUNTY AS WELL AS THE A. R. B. --
STILL IS IT CORRECT TO SAY THAT --%
STATIONARY SOURCES IS REALLY
NOTHING NEW AS FAR AS COLLECTING
DATA ABOUT STATIONARY SOURCES.
FROM -- FROM
THE A ARBY'S PERSPECTIVE WOULD
THAT BE A CORRECT STATEMENT.
FROM AN OVERALL AFFORD THESE AIR
QUALITY AUTHORITY STANDPOINT
IT'S THE LOCAL AIR DISTRICTS
THAT HAVE PERMITTING AND
ENFORCEMENT AUTHORITY.
OVER STATIONARY SOURCES
STATUTORY SEVENTEEN IS THE FIRST
TIME THAT THE A A RP IS KIND OF
DOING A STATIONARY SOURCES OR
WELL FOR LACK OF BETTER TERM.
SIX SEVENTEEN RECOGNIZED THE KEY
ROLE OF BOTH THE STATE CARB ANY
ARE DISTRICTS AND REALIZE THAT
YOU COULD AND CLEARLY THE
COMMUNITIES IN REAL RECOGNIZE
THAT.
YOU COULD EFFECTIVELY LEAD TO A
EFFECTIVE EMISSION REDUCTION
PROGRAM WITHOUT CLOSE
COLLABORATION BETWEEN BOTH THOSE
PLAYERS.
THANK YOU SOME OF OUR FLOOR.
THANK YOU FOR A JOINT US IT'S
GOING TO BE GREAT TO SAY HERE
LISTEN TO THE TESTIMONY FROM.
FROM EVERYBODY BUT I THERE IS A
COUPLE WORDS I'VE HEARD --
THROUGHOUT THIS IS PARTNERSHIP.
YEAH WE HEAR THAT A LOT RIGHT
NOW AND I'M ACTUALLY ENCOURAGED
BY THIS --
BECAUSE AS WAS STATED YOU KNOW
FROM OUR MY COLLEAGUES.
WE START PAINTING IN BROAD
BRUSHES IN THE STATE.
IT DOESN'T WORK AT TIMES BECAUSE
ALL OF OUR INDIVIDUAL OR
DISTRICTS HAVE UNIQUE CHALLENGES
WITHIN THE COMMUNITIES THAT THEY
SERVE.
I REPRESENT THE CENTRAL VALLEY
AND SO WE HAVE A LARGE AG REGION.
AS I'M JUST CURIOUS --
IN IN INTO THE BECAUSE I'M A BIG
FAN OF THE CARROT VERSES A STICK
APPROACH.
I THINK --
THE COMMUNITIES THEY RESPOND TO
INCENTIVES AND IT'S CERTAINLY
COMING FROM AN AG BACKGROUND.
OR THESE INCENTIVE PROGRAMS
WORKING.
AND IF NOT WHAT CAN WE DO TO
BOLSTER THOSE TO GET MORE OF
THESE --
TRACTORS --
UTILITY VEHICLES SEMIS THAT WERE
THAT WERE DESPERATELY TRYING TO
REMOVE.
HOW CAN WE BOTH BOTH OF THOSE
PROGRAMS AND IF THEY'RE NOT
WORKING WHAT CAN WE DO TO MAKE
THOSE BETTER AND SOLIDIFY THEIR
SUCCESS?
YEAH I'LL I'LL BRIEFLY SPEAK TO
THIS IS REALLY A BROADER
RESPONSE IN THE VALLEY THE
INCENTIVE PROGRAMS THAT HAD
PROGRAM FOR INSTANCE FARMER
WHICH IS.
AS WELL AS MORE YEAR HISTORICAL
TRACTOR REPLACEMENTS THIRTY
TRUCK REPLACEMENTS FROM A KEY
METRIC IN TERMS OF DIESEL
EMISSION REDUCTIONS.
COST EFFECTIVENESS A TRACK
RECORD OF EFFECTIVE
IMPLEMENTATION IS A SET OF
PROGRAMS MANY OF WHICH BEEN
IMPLEMENTED FOR MANY MANY YEARS
THE DECADE DECADES IN SOME CASES.
DEPENDING EXCEEDINGLY AFFECTED
THE ISSUE IS THEIR SUBSTANTIALLY
OVERSUBSCRIBED.
THERE'S NEVER ENOUGH FUNDING BUT
FOR THE FUNDING HAS BEEN
APPROPRIATE IN AVAILABLE THEY
WORK IN THERE'S ESTABLISHED
TRACK RECORD THAT THEY DO JUST
THAT.
THAT'S AWESOME I MEAN I KNOW
JUST LIKE IN THE FORMER PROGRAM
YOU KNOW AS I KNOW WHAT THE
BOARD RECOMMENDED WHICH I'M
INCREDIBLY --
EXCITED ABOUT YOU KNOW YOUR
PROPOSAL YOU WITHIN THE BUDGET
IT GOT WHACKED YOU KNOW PRETTY
SUBSTANTIAL AND YOU WILL HAVE
THESE CONVERSATIONS I THINK IT'S
CERTAINLY SOMETHING THAT WE CAN
TALK OFF LINE.
BUT I AM EXCITED ABOUT THAT THE
DISTRICT THIS TO WORK WITH ALL
OF OUR COMMUNITIES YOU KNOW AND
CERTAINLY FROM MY OFFICE IN THE
AREA THAT WE REPRESENT HOWEVER
WE CAN BE.
HELPFUL IN THAT REGARD BECAUSE I
DO BELIEVE THAT THE THE AG
INDUSTRY IS READY AND WILLING --
WITH THE PROPER AMOUNT
INCENTIVES AND I KNOW THAT
MOVING FORWARD.
JUSTIN THIS YEAR ALONE WE GOT
LIKE TWENTY SIX HUNDRED TRACTORS
IN THE QUEUE.
AND THAT FUNDING NUMBER IS NOT
THERE AND IT IS A BIG NUMBER AS
WE GET INTO THESE THESE CLEANER
ADMISSIONS ARMIES CLEANER
ENGINES.
THAT PRICE GOES THROUGH THE ROOF
PER UNIT.
AND SO THIS FUNDING SOURCES A
HUGE CONCERN OF ALL OF OUR
SEPARATE FUTURE TIME THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER CITY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I WONDER
MAKE SURE I DIDN'T.
TO MESS --
ANY OF YOUR EXPLANATION AS TO
HOW THE THE TEN INITIAL
COMMUNITIES --
WERE WERE SELECTED --
I I SEE AND SOME OF THE
MATERIALS THAT WERE.
DISTRIBUTED BY THE COMMITTEE
THAT -- ONE
OF THE CORE CRITERIA WAS POVERTY
LEVELS --
BUT I I WANT TO KNOW.
YOU KNOW IN MY DISTRICT I I
REPRESENT --
THE CITY OF TORRANCE WHICH HAS A
A LARGE REFINERY --
THE THAT IS --
SURROUNDED BY A DENSE ID --
SUBURBAN MIDDLE CLASS LARGELY
MIDDLE CLASS COMMUNITIES AND SO --
HOW HOW WOULD?
TO YOU KNOW --
COMMUNITIES LIKE TORRANCE --
BE BE COVERED BY --
THE PROVISIONS AB [inaudible]
SIX SEVENTEEN SO WE SET OUT --
IN THE BEGINNING SOME BROAD
CRITERIA THAT WE ASKED THEM
LOCAL AIR DISTRICTS WORKING WITH
COMMUNITY MEMBERS AND COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS IN THEIR
REGION. TO LOOK AT IN THAT IN
COLLUDED OF COURSE JUST
UNDERSTANDING WHAT YOU'RE
POLLUTION LEVELS WERE IN THE
COMMUNITY --
BUT ALSO LOOKING AT THINGS LIKE
SOCIO ECONOMIC FACTORS THAT
INCREASE VULNERABILITY TO AIR
POLLUTION SUCH AS POVERTY AT
CETERA --
AND THEN ALSO LOOKING AT HEALTH
IMPACTS THAT WE KNOW ARE OFTEN
VERY CLOSELY RELATED TO AIR
POLLUTION HEART ATTACKS
PREMATURE BIRTH RESPIRATORY
DISEASE --
AND THEN THEY WORK THROUGH A
PUBLIC PROCESS TO WEIGH ALL OF
THOSE AND PROVIDE
RECOMMENDATIONS TO US FOR
COMMUNITIES THAT THEY THOUGHT
WOULD REALLY BE SUCCESSFUL IN
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE FIRST YEAR
OF THE PROGRAM ITSELF.
OF AND FROM THAT SET WE THEN
RECOMMENDED TO OUR BOARD THAT
TEN COMMUNITIES THAT YOU SEE
HERE --
TODAY TO BEGIN THE PROGRAM
RECOGNIZING THAT THERE ARE
HUNDREDS OF OTHER COMMUNITIES --
THAT REALLY HAVE SIMILAR
CHALLENGES AND THAT'S WHY IT'S
SO IMPORTANT ONE THAT WE HAVE
THESE BROUGHT STATEWIDE
STRATEGIES THAT ARE ADDRESSING
THE PROBLEMS AND THEN TO AS I
MENTIONED.
THAT AS WE IDENTIFY THINGS THAT
ARE WORKING IN THESE COMMUNITIES
REALLY LOOK AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE TO SEE HOW THEY CAN BE
IMPLEMENTED ELSEWHERE.
SO IT WHEN YOU WHEN YOU SAY THAT
TO YOU YOU LOOKED AT THE
COMMUNITIES THAT WERE YOU WOULD
HAVE THE THE GREATEST IMPACT I
MEAN IS IS IT FAIR TO SAY THAT --
THAT -- BE
CLEAR THAT THE COMMUNITIES THE
THAT YOU WERE SELECTED WITH THE
HIGHEST.
POVERTY LEVELS ALSO HAVE THE
HIGHEST LEVELS OF AIR POLLUTION.
AND GENERAL IF YOU LOOK ACROSS
THESE THEY ALL HAVE SOME OF THE
HIGHEST LEVELS OF AIR POLLUTION
IN THE REGION THEY ARE ALL --
HEAVILY BURDENED IN TERMS OF THE
SOCIO AND ECONOMIC FACTORS AS
WELL AS THE KIND OF HEALTH
IMPACTS THAT WE SEE.
IN THOSE COMMUNITIES. ONE POINT
I'D LIKE TO ADD TO THIS RESPONSE
I THINK IT'S AN IMPORTANT.
THAT IS MANY OF THE PROVISIONS
OF SIX SEVENTEEN GO BEYOND JUST
THOSE COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
SELECTED THE BARK PROVISIONS
WOULD CERTAINLY PICK UP THE
REFINERY.
THE INVENTORY PROVISIONS THE
INCENTIVES.
THAT WERE PROVIDED SO AS WELL AS
IN THIS CARE MENTION THE RAGS
THAT WE'RE WORKING ON AND
DEVELOPING SO.
ALTHOUGH THERE CLERK CLEARLY FOR
THOSE COMMUNITIES WERE SELECTED
THERE NEEDS TO BE A FOCUSED
EFFORT FROM IMPLEMENTATION
LESSONS LEARNED WE CAN MULTIPLY
APPLY TO OTHERS.
BUT THE INTERNET WILL BE ACTIONS%
ACROSS THE STATE AND MANY MANY
OTHER AREAS BY VIRTUE OF THE
POINTS I JUST MADE ON BARKED
EMISSIONS INVENTORY AND
REGULATIONS AND AND RULES.
THAT WILL COVER THOSE
COMMUNITIES BR VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE IT.
I'M MOVING TO OUR NEXT PANEL
WHAT'S SO CUENTA RICHMOND.
WE'RE GOING TO GET --
A CALL OF JACK BROADBAND AREA
AIR QUALITY MANAGEMENT DISTRICT.
MS MARGARET GORDON WEST OAKLAND
ENVIRONMENTAL INDICATORS PROJECT.
AND WILLIE ROBINSON RICHMAN
NAACP.
WELCOME TO ALL OF YOU AND THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR JOINING US.
AND I BELIEVE THAT MISTER
BROADBENT WILL BE SPEAKING FIRST.
IT DIDN'T FEEL RIGHT HERE MISS
PARKER.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
MY NAME IS JACK BROADBENT ON THE
EXECUTIVE OFFICER FOR THE BAY
AREA AIR QUALITY MANAGEMENT
DISTRICT.
I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE TALKING
ABOUT OUR EFFORTS IN
IMPLEMENTING.
SB SIX ONE SEVEN THE COMMUNITY
PROTECTION PROGRAM.
I THINK THE SHORT ANSWER TO THE
QUESTION IS THAT WE ARE ON TRACK.
TO DELIVER EMISSION REDUCTIONS
TO CALIFORNIA'S MOST POLLUTION
BURDEN COMMUNITIES IN THE BAY
AREA.
AS YOU KNOW --
FOR THE BAY AREA WE HAVE TO YEAR
ONE COMMUNITIES WEST OAKLAND
WHICH IS --
HOME OF COURSE TO THE PORT OF
OAKLAND.
BUT ALSO HAS A STATIONARY
SOURCES IN IT --
BUT ALSO THREE FREEWAY IN
RICHMOND WHICH HAS.
ALSO A PORT.
THE HOME TO THE LARGEST OF
CERTAINLY ONE OF THE LARGEST
REFINERS IN CALIFORNIA.
AS WELL AS A NUMBER OF MOBILE
SOURCES --
AND FREEWAYS IN THAT COMMUNITY.
AT THE BAY AREA AIR QUALITY
MANAGEMENT DISTRICT WE'RE PROUD
OF OUR EFFORTS IN IMPLEMENTING.
SIX SEVENTEEN IN WORKING WITH
OUR COMMUNITY PARTNERS TO NOT
ONLY IDENTIFY AND UNDERSTAND THE
LOCAL.
CONDITIONS AND SOURCES IN THOSE
COMMUNITIES BUT TO ESTABLISH
KERR MONITORING PLANS AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY.
I CAN'T OVER EMPHASIZE THIS BUT
TO ESTABLISH EMISSION REDUCTION
PLANS THAT'S REALLY THE KEY HERE
IS TO BE ABLE TO TAKE ACTIONS.
TO IMPROVE PUBLIC HEALTH IN
THESE COMMUNITIES.
A COUPLE OF KEY POINTS MANAGER
BEFORE HANDED OVER A IS REALLY
THAT WE BELIEVE IN THE BAY AREA
WERE EQUAL PARTNERS WITH OUR
COMMUNITY LEADERS --
AND THAT COMES DOWN TO NOT ONLY
HOW WE CONDUCT OURSELVES IN
TERMS OF FORMING THE STEERING
COMMITTEE WITH OUR COMMUNITY
PARTNERS BUT CONDUCTING THOSE
MEETINGS --
MEMBERSHIPS OF THOSE COMMUNITIES
BUT HOW THE MEETINGS THEMSELVES
HER --
CONDUCTED BUT THEN ALSO THAT IS
REALLY CRITICAL AND PARAMOUNT AS
TO HOW WE ESTABLISH WHAT GOES
INTO THE MISSION REDUCTION PLAN
AS WELL.
THE OTHER KEY POINT ONE LEVY
WITH BEFORE HAND IT OVER TO MR
NOTED MY DEPUTY IN CHARGE OF
THIS EFFORT.
HE IS THAT REALLY ALL EMISSION
REDUCTION OPPORTUNITIES AND AND
SOLUTIONS ARE ON THE TABLE.
WE HAVE THE DISTRICT OF COURSE
ARE A PROUD OF ESTABLISHING THE
MOST STRINGENT AIR TOXICS
MISSION STANDARD IN THE STATE
FOR A STATIONARY SOURCES.
BUT WE KNOW THAT TIME MOBILE OF
CREATING THE RISK IN THESE
COMMUNITIES AS WELL.
AND SO -- WE
REMAIN OPEN TO BE ABLE TO
IDENTIFY AND IMPLEMENT ANY OR
ALL MEASURES NECESSARY.
TO PROTECT PUBLIC HEALTH IN
THESE COMMUNITIES TAKE IT VERY
SERIOUSLY.
SO LET ME --
DO THIS AND HANDED OVER TO MR
NODE AND ALL.
I THINK COME BACK ON OUR LAST
SLIDE AND IF YOU CAN.
NOTICE OF IT AS WELL.
GREAT MY NAME IS GREG NOW DIE
AND DEPUTY EXECUTIVE OFFICER FOR
POLICY AT SAID BEAR AIR DISTRICT.
AND WALK YOU THROUGH KIND OF OUR
APPROACH TO EIGHTY SIX SEVENTEEN
IN THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY AREA --
IN REFERENCE TO THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS RECENT IN THE BAY LOOKED
AT THOSE COMMUNITIES THAT HAD
HIGH VULNERABILITY TO AIR
POLLUTION.
AND THERE ARE A LOT OF SOCIO
ECONOMIC FACTORS THAT FEED INTO
THAT BUT ONE OF THE KEY
PARAMETERS THAT WE LOOKED AT WAS.
LIFE EXPECTANCY AT BIRTH AND
ACROSS ALAMEDA COUNTY FOR
EXAMPLE YOU CAN SEE AT TEN TO
FIFTEEN YEAR DIFFERENCE IN LIFE
EXPECTANCY AT BIRTH BETWEEN.
WEST OAKLAND FOR EXAMPLE AND
SOME OF THE WEALTHIER
COMMUNITIES UP IN THE HILLS.
SO WE LOOKED AT THAT PARAMETER
WE ALSO LOOKED AT EXPOSURE TO
AIR POLLUTION.
AND THE INTERSECTION OF THOSE
TWO SETS IS WHERE WE CAME UP
WITH OUR HIGH PRIORITY
COMMUNITIES.
AND WE SELECTED WEST OAKLAND FOR
AN ACTION PLAN IN YOUR ONE
BECAUSE QUITE A BIT OF
MONITORING HAD ALREADY BEEN DONE
IN WEST OAKLAND.
OVER THE PAST SEVERAL YEARS
THANKS LARGELY IN PART TO THE
EFFORTS OF MS BARBARA GORDON AND
HER ASSOCIATES AT THE WEST
OAKLAND BY MIDDLE INDICATORS
PROJECT.
AND ALSO RICHMOND BECAUSE WE HAD
SOME QUESTIONS ABOUT RICHMOND
WANTED TO USE MORE MONITORING
THEIR AND I'LL GET TO THAT ONE
BY ONE HERE.
SO WHY WEST OAKLAND AS I'VE
MENTIONED BEFORE MADE A VERY
STRONG PARTNER THERE IN THE WEST
OAKLAND ENVIRONMENTAL INDICATORS
PROJECT.
AND I I MEAN PARTNER IN REALLY
THE THE LITERAL SENSE.
THAT -- IT'S
IMPORTANT TO THE SUCCESS OF
THESE EFFORTS TO HAVE A STRONG
COMMUNITY LEADER.
IN THE MEETING TO GUIDE HOW YOU
PUT THE AGENDAS TOGETHER AND TO
GIVE SOME CREDIBILITY TO THE
OVERALL PROCESS.
THE OTHER ASPECT IN WEST OAKLAND
AS JACK MENTIONED IT HAS A LARGE
PORT -- AND
A LOT OF OTHER SOURCES OF MOBILE
SOURCE RISK A COUPLE OF LARGE
AIR TOXICS FACILITIES THAT ARE
WITHIN OUR REGULATORY AUTHORITY
AS WELL.
I'LL TALK ABOUT THAT AS MINUTES
IN A MINUTE AND THEN OF COURSE
THE HIGH HEALTH BURDENS --
ASSOCIATED WITH THAT COMMUNITY.
SO WE HAVE BEEN IN WEST OAKLAND
FOR OVER TWELVE YEARS --
WORKING WITH --
WEST OAKLAND THE I. P..
AND THROUGH THE PROCESS OF
PUTTING TOGETHER THE THE
STEERING COMMITTEE AND
IMPLEMENTING SB SIX SEVENTEEN IN
WEST OAKLAND.
WE'VE BEEN MEETING WEEKLY WITH
OUR PARTNERS IN THE WEST OF
LUMBER MILL INDICATORS PROJECT.
AND TO HAVING MONTHLY TECHNICAL
MEETINGS TO GO OVER THE DETAILS
OF THE TECHNICAL WORK THAT WE'RE
DOING.
OKAY INTRODUCTION TO THAT
TECHNICAL WORK.
EXPOSURE TO AIR POLLUTION IN A
COMMUNITY IS A COMBINATION OF
REGIONAL SOURCES AND LOCAL
SOURCES.
AND SO WE DID AN EXTENSIVE
ANALYSIS TO DETERMINE WHAT THAT
PERCENTAGE WAS SENT ON FOCUSING
ON CANCER RISK RIGHT HERE.
BUT IT ALSO APPLIES TO THINGS
LIKE PARTICULAR MATTER AND
DIESEL PM AND THAT SORT OF THING.
SO IN WEST OAKLAND A'S BIRD 30%
OF THE BURDEN IS DUE TO LOCAL
SOURCES --
FOR CANCER AND THIS CANCER RISK
NUMBER THE FOUR HUNDRED NINETY
SIX PER MILLION IT'S A TOOL THAT
THE IN OUR OFFICE AND ARE MENTAL
HEALTH HAZARD ASSESSMENT
DEVELOPED. TO GIVE US ONE
MEASURE OF COMBINATION OF RISKS
FROM MULTIPLE POLLUTANTS SO.
ANYBODY BREATHE IN THE AIR AND
AND AND WEST OAKLAND RIGHT NOW.
HAS THE SIX HUNDRED IN A MILLION
CHANCE OF DEVELOPING CANCER OVER
THIRTY YEAR PERIOD DO THE
EXPOSURE TO THAT POLLUTION.
OF THAT SIX HUNDRED MILLION A
HUNDRED EIGHTY SIX PER MILLION
IS DUE TO THESE LOCAL SOURCES.
AND THE LOCAL SOURCES VARY
DEPENDING ON WHERE YOU ARE.
MISS PARKER TALKS A LOT ABOUT
PROXIMITY AND EXPOSURE.
AND NOT JUST FOCUSING ON
EMISSIONS AND THAT LAYS OUT IN
THIS MAP HERE AND WHAT THIS MAP
SHOWS IS HOW CANCER RISK VARIES
DEPENDING ON WHERE YOU ARE IN
WEST OAKLAND.
AND FOR ANY SPOT ON THIS MAP WE
CAN TELL YOU WHAT THE PERCENTAGE
CONTRIBUTION IS.
AT THAT PARTICULAR LOCATION A
COUPLE OF THINGS TO NOTE HERE
KIND OF IN THE IN THE LOWER
MIDDLE SECTION OF THE CHART AND
IN THE UPPER.
LEFT YOU SEE A COUPLE OF
STATIONARY SOURCES THAT ARE
SIGNIFICANTLY CONTRIBUTING TO
RESCUE.
THOSE SOURCES ARE SUBJECT TO THE
RULE THE JACK MENTIONED OUR RULE
ELEVEN EIGHTEEN AND THEY'RE
GONNA BE REQUIRED TO GET THEIR
CANCER RISK DOWN TO TEN IN A
MILLION OR LESS UNDER THAT RULE --
THOSE ARE SIGNIFICANT SOURCES
BUT YOU CAN SEE HOW THEY BLEND
IN WITH THE OTHER SOURCES OF
RISK IN THE COMMUNITY --
AND OVERALL THE TO TRUCKS AT
ABOUT 33% AND MARINE VESSELS AT
31% --
PERMITTED FACILITIES THE ONES
THAT WITH AND WITHIN OUR
JURISDICTION.
ACCOUNT 410% OF THE RISK BUT
THAT'S KIND OF AVERAGED OUT OVER
THE WHOLE COMMUNITY ANY
PARTICULAR POINT IN THE
COMMUNITY YOU'RE GONNA SEE A
DIFFERENT SOURCE APPORTIONMENT.
SON I'M GONNA HANDED OFF TO IT
AT TO CARLO.
THE ACTING MANAGER OF OUR
PLANNING GROUP AND WHO'S THE
LEAD PROJECT MANAGER FOR THEIR
DISTRICT ON THE WEST OAKLAND
PROCESS.
THANK YOU GREG.
SO SINCE THE WEST OAKLAND ACTION
PLAN IS AN EMISSION REDUCTION
PROGRAM AS COMPARED TO ONE MONTH.
COMPARED TO A MONITORING PROGRAM
THE PLAN FOCUSES ON STRATEGIES
THAT BOTH DIRECTLY REDUCE
EMISSIONS AS WELL AS REDUCING
THE COMMUNITY'S EXPOSURE TO
EMISSIONS.
SO FOR THE LAST FEW MONTHS THEIR
NEXT NEW POLL THE MIKE A LITTLE
CLOSER TO YOU --
I'M SORRY YEP AND THAT'S FOR FOR
EVERYONE PEOPLE CAN HEAR OKAY.
AND USE MY OUTDOOR.
SO FOR THE LAST FEW MONTHS OF
THE YEAR DISTRICT OF THE
STEERING COMMITTEE HAVE BEEN
WORKING TOGETHER ON A BROAD
RANGE OF STRATEGIES THAT ARE
REPRESENTED ON THE SLIDE.
SO STARTING AT THE TOP ONE OF
THE MOST IMPORTANT ISSUES TO THE
COMMUNITY IS INCOMPATIBLE LAND
USES.
SO THE WEATHER INDUSTRIALIZED
COMMITTEES WHETHER THEIR
PERMANENT OR NOT --
OFTENTIMES DIRECTLY NEXT TO
PEOPLE'S HOMES SCHOOLS AND OTHER
SENSITIVE RECEPTORS.
AND THE NEXT RELATED TO LAND USE
ISSUES OUR TRUCK RELATED
BUSINESSES THAT ARE IN OR NEAR
NEIGHBORHOODS.
THE CITY OF OAKLAND CURRENTLY
HAS A DRAFT TRUCK MANAGEMENT
PLAN THAT ADDRESSES SOME OF
THESE CONCERNS HOWEVER ARE AB
SIX SEVENTEEN PLAN --
SEEKS TO ADD TO THOSE MEASURES
AS WELL ZHU'S IN THAT DRAFT PLAN.
ALSO THERE STRATEGIES THAT HAVE
TO DO A FUNDING --
CERTAINLY FOR FUNDING CLEANER
EQUIPMENT BUT ALSO TO ENSURE
THAT AGENCIES IN THE COMMUNITY
HAVE THE RESOURCES TO
SUCCESSFULLY IMPLEMENTED THE NEW
PROGRAMS.
AS WELL AS TO IMPLEMENT EXISTING
PLANTS THAT HAVE ALREADY BEEN
ADOPTED.
STRATEGIES THAT WOULD HELP
REDUCE EXPOSURE TO POLLUTION AND
CREWS INCLUDE GREEN
INFRASTRUCTURE.
SO FOR EXAMPLE VEGETATIVE WALLS
CAN MITIGATE POLLUTION COMING
FROM FREEWAYS BUT ALSO TREES CAN
BE PLANTED AROUND SCHOOLS AND
OTHER SENSITIVE RECEPTORS FROM
STREET TRAFFIC --
THAT GENERATES POLLUTION.
BUT AS MANY OF OUR STRENGTH MANY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS HAVE POINTED
OUT IT'S NOT JUST PLANTING THE
TREES THERE NEEDS TO BE A
COMPREHENSIVE PROGRAM THAT
ENSURES THAT THE TREES ARE
MAINTAINED AND WATER IT'S THAT
THEIR SUSTAINABLE.
AT ONE OF OUR RECENT STEERING
COMMITTEE MEETINGS THAT REALLY
SEEM TO BE ONE OF THE MOST
POPULAR WAS WE INVITED THE
OAKLAND.
CITY VOCALS PLANNING DIRECTOR
AND THE ALAMEDA COUNTY PUBLIC
HEALTH DEPARTMENT TO COME AND
PRESENT ON THEIR DIFFERENT
AGENCIES ROLES RESPONSIBILITIES.
AND IT REALLY DEMONSTRATED HOW
INTERTWINED PLANNING POLICIES
ARE. TO TO HEALTH OUTCOMES.
SO THAT THAT MEETING GENERATED A
NUMBER OF DIFFERENT STRATEGIES
THAT IDENTIFIED DIFFERENT WAYS
THAT WE CAN COORDINATE AMONG
LOCAL REGIONAL AND STATE
AGENCIES.
AND THEN LASTLY BROAD GROUP OF
CATEGORIES INCLUDES IMPLEMENTING
AND TRACKING PROGRESS OF THESE
EXISTING PLAN.
PLANS WHICH INCLUDE ENFORCEMENT
MEASURES.
JUST LAST LAST WEEK WE HAD OUR
MOST RECENT STEERING COMMITTEE
MEETING.
AND WE HAD CONSENSUS FROM THE
STEERING COMMITTEE ON A HUNDRED
AND TWENTY NINE DISTINCT
MEASURES SO THAT WAS I THINK
EVERYONE CLAPPED AT THE END OF
THAT MEETING.
VERY EXCITING MEANING TO COME TO
THAT CONCLUSION AND HAVE THAT
THAT CONSENSUS STAR NEXT UP IS
GOING TO BE PRIORITIZING THOSE.
THOSE DIFFERENT MEASURES WHAT
WOULD BE DONE IMMEDIATELY AND
THEN MID TERM AND THEN SLIGHTLY
LONGER TERM --
NEXT SLIDE [inaudible]
THANKS.
SO THERE CERTAINLY ARE SOME
CHALLENGES ALONG THE WAY --
RESPONSIBLE AGENCIES ARE NOT
ALWAYS REQUIRED TO CHANGE
POLICIES THAT CREATE AIR
POLLUTION IMPACTS AND THAT'S
ESPECIALLY TRUE FOR LAND USE
POLICIES THAT CAN INADVERTENTLY
CAUSE NEGATIVE HEALTH OUTCOMES.
IN TERMS OF AUTHORITY THE
DISTRICT --
CAN PROVIDE INCENTIVES WE DO
ENFORCE MOBILE SOURCE
REGULATIONS WITH THROUGH AMMO
USE WITH CARMEN --
BUT IT MADE US BUT WE CAN'T SET
REGULATIONS FOR THEM.
ON THIS MAY NOT BE AS CRITICAL
FOR OTHER A BUT IN WEST OAKLAND
MOBILE SOURCES TO ACCOUNT FOR A
LARGE PORTION OF THE POLLUTION.
AND SO WE ARE GOING TO BE
EXPLORING ANY NEW WAYS THAT WE
CAN ADDRESS EMISSIONS FROM THESE
SOURCES.
ALSO ENFORCEMENT REMAINS A
CHALLENGE FOR THE STEERING
COMMITTEE MEMBERS SOME
ACTIVITIES DON'T NECESSARILY
NEED A THRESHOLD FOR NEEDING
THEIR DISTRICT PERMIT BUT THEY
STILL ARE NUISANCES OR AIR
QUALITY NUISANCES TO THE
COMMUNITY.
AND THAT MIGHT INCLUDE THINGS
LIKE TRASH BURNING A RESTAURANT
SMOKING WOOD BURNING.
IN TERMS OF THE LAST CHALLENGE
WHICH HAS BEEN TALKED ABOUT A
BIT ARE THE TIGHT TIME ONCE OF
THIS --
PROCESS THERE ARE LEGAL
REQUIREMENTS OF COMPLYING WITH
SEQUEL THAT MEANS WE HAVE TO
IDENTIFY STRATEGIES EARLY SO
THAT WE CAN HAVE SEVERAL PUBLIC
COMMENT PERIODS ON IT.
THERE IS ALSO THE NEED FOR THE
AIR DISTRICT TO DEVELOP THE
RELATIONSHIP ITH OUR NEW
COMMUNITY PARTNERS AND TO FIGURE
OUT HOW WE WOULD WORK TOGETHER
THROUGH THIS PROCESS.
WE ALSO NEEDED TO CREATE THE
STEERING COMMITTEE AS WELL AS
BUILD THEIR KNOWLEDGE SO THEY
COULD PROVIDE MEANINGFUL INPUT
INTO THE PROCESS.
AND THEN ALSO WE TYPICALLY USE A
REGIONAL LANDS FOR ADDRESSING
AIR POLLUTION BUT AB SIX
SEVENTEEN REQUIRED A NEW
APPROACH TO ITS TECHNICAL
ASSESSMENT WORK.
BY CREATING A COMMUNITY LEVEL
INVENTORY AND MODELING AT THE
NEIGHBORHOOD LEVEL.
AND THERE'S BEEN A TREMENDOUS
AMOUNT OF EXTERNAL AND INTERNAL
COORDINATION I THINK MISS
MARKETS GOING TO TALK A LITTLE
BIT MORE ABOUT THAT.
SO I'M GONNA FOLLOW UP AND AND
START TALKING ABOUT RICHMOND.
RICHMOND IS A COMPLICATED
SITUATION AS YOU CAN SEE FROM
THIS MAP WE'VE GOT A VERY LARGE
REFINERY THERE.
A PORT.
SEVERAL FREEWAYS MANY --
RAILROAD LINES AND ALSO A VERY
VALUABLE POPULATION.
WHAT ONE OF THE THE THINGS HAVE
BEEN PUZZLING US ABOUT RICHMOND
IS WITH ALL THE SOURCES?
AND THE KIND OF HEALTH OUTCOMES
WERE SEEING THEIR IT DOESN'T
REALLY MATCH WITH THAT
MONITORING DATA SO FAR.
SO WE'RE CONCERNED THAT WERE
EITHER NOT MONITOR --
TRYING FOR THE RIGHT THINGS AND
SO THAT'S WHAT WE WANT TO START
OUT WITH A MONITORING PLAN IN
RICHMOND.
NOW RICHMOND WILL ALSO BENEFIT
QUITE A BIT FROM THE BEST
AVAILABLE RETROFIT CONTROL
TECHNOLOGY WORK THAT WE'RE DOING.
A LOT OF THOSE ARE GOING TO
FOCUS ON REFINERY EFFORTS AND
THEN --
REGULATION ELEVEN EIGHTEEN AIR
TOXICS RULE WILL ALSO HAVE A
SUBSTANTIAL IMPACT IN RICHMOND
IS GONNA BE A NUMBER OF
FACILITIES THERE SUBJECT TO THAT
RULE.
SO WHILE WE'RE PUTTING THE
MONITORING PLAN TOGETHER FOR
RICHMOND WE'RE GONNA
SIMULTANEOUSLY BE REDUCING
EMISSIONS THROUGH A REGULATORY
AUTHORITY AND OUR INCENTIVE
PROGRAM.
SO AS JACK ALLUDED TO BEFORE THE
THE COMMUNITY GETTING THE
COMMUNITY PROCESS RIGHT IS
REALLY OUR NUMBER ONE PRIORITY
IN EACH OF THESE COMMUNITIES.
AND SOMETIMES IT MAKES IT TOUGH
TO MEET THE TIME LINES THAT ARE
IN THE STATUTE THE TIME LINES
THAT ARE IN CARBS BLUEPRINTS.
BUT WE DON'T WANT TO SHORT
CIRCUIT THE COMMUNITY PROCESS.
AND SO IN RICHMOND WE DIDN'T
HAVE A READY PARTNER LIKE WE HAD
IN WEST OAKLAND THERE ARE A LOT
OF WONDERFUL VERY IMPACTFUL
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS IN
RICHMOND.
BUT THOSE THAT ARE FOCUSED ON
ENVIRONMENTAL ISSUES IN
PARTICULAR WERE NOT ABLE OR NOT --
COULD NOT HAVE THE CAPACITY TO
TAKE ON THAT LEADERSHIP ROLE
THAT WE HAD IN WEST OAKLAND.
SO THROUGH A SERIES OF MANY
MEETINGS AND MANY COMMUNITY
MEETINGS WE CAME UP WITH A
DESIGN TEAM AND THAT DESIGN TEAM.
DESIGNED A COMMUNITY SUMMIT AND
THE COMMUNITY SUMMIT LAID OUT
THE STRUCTURE FOR HOW THE
COMMUNITY STEERING COMMITTEE
WOULD BE.
WOULD BE NAMED AND SO --
THE STEERING COMMITTEE AND
MISTER ROBINSON FOR RICHMOND
WE'LL TALK A LITTLE BIT MORE
ABOUT THAT --
IN A FEW MINUTES.
SO THIS TO GIVE YOU KIND OF A
PICTURE OF THE COMPLEXITY OF
IMPLEMENTING AB SIX SEVENTEEN
WITH TO COMMUNITIES.
YOU CAN SEE THAT FOR EACH
QUARTER WE HAVE A LOT OF
ACTIVITIES GOING ON BOTH IN THE
WEST OAKLAND SIDE AND ON THE
RICHMOND SIDE.
AND THE IN ONE OF THE STRUGGLES
THAT WE'VE HAD AS I MENTIONED
BEFORE IS.
IT'S CRITICAL TO GET THE
COMMUNITY PROCESS RIGHT IT'S
CRITICAL TO GET COME TO THAT
UNDERSTANDING THAT LEVEL OF
TRUST.
AND TO HAVE THAT TRUE
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE COMMUNITY.
AND IN ORDER TO DO THAT AND MEET
THE TIME LINES HAS BEEN A
CHALLENGE EVEN IN WEST OAKLAND
AND IT'S GOOD PARTICULAR GOING
TO BE A CHALLENGE IN RICHMOND.
AND JET WHEN JACKETS HIS
CONCLUDING REMARKS FOR A TALK
ABOUT A PROPOSAL WE'D LIKE TO
MAKE TO IMPROVE THE STRUCTURE OF
AB. SIX SEVENTEEN TO TO ALLOW
MORE TIME FOR THOSE COMMUNITY
PROCESSES.
SO MADAM CHAIR JUST.
THE MEMBERS THE COMMUNITY JUST
LAST COUPLE OF KEY POINTS IS --
COURSE -- IN
ADDITION --
THE TIME AND THE CHALLENGES THAT
WE'VE TALKED ABOUT HERE THIS
AFTERNOON FUNDING OF COURSE IS
ALSO A CHALLENGE --
THIS CHART HERE IS REALLY JUST
FOR INFORMATION SAKE IT'S TO
KIND OF INFORM YOU OF WHAT OUR
CURRENT COSTS ARE WITH REGARD TO
THESE TWO COMMUNITIES AND AND
REALLY PROJECTING THAT OUT WHAT
WE ARE BUT WE'RE SEEING AS WE
BEGIN TO THAN.
A POTENTIALLY LIST OTHER
COMMUNITIES AS WELL.
AND I MY LAST POINT MADAM CHAIR
IS REALLY AT THE POINT THAT MR
NOT IN OTHERS HAVE RAISED.
IS THAT A STRONG SUGGESTION THAT
WE HAVE FOR EIGHTY SIX SEVENTEEN
MOVING FORWARD.
IS.
TO SEEK TO BE ABLE TO BUILD IN A
PROCESS WHERE IN THAT WE COULD --
BILL CAPACITY IN THE LOCAL
COMMUNITY --
ONE OF OUR MOST IMPORTANT
LESSONS LEARNED TO DATE IS WE
REALLY NEED --
THAT PARTNERSHIP OAKLAND INTO A
VITAL INDICATORS PROJECT WE'RE
VERY PROUD OF THAT PARTNERSHIP
WERE ALSO BUILDING IT WITH
MISTER.
ROBINSON AS WELL AND THEN THAT
STEERING COMMITTEE BUT ALL RIGHT
NOW.
THAT'S WHAT'S REALLY LED TO THE
SUCCESS SO FAR IN WEST OAKLAND
IS THAT PARTNERSHIP AND WE AND
IT'S TIME. TO TO BE BUILT AND WE
WOULD SUGGEST THAT AS WE WORK
WITH CARP ON TERMS OF THE TIME
FRAME OF IDENTIFYING AND AND
COMMUNITIES AND IN MOVING
FORWARD AND ESTABLISHING
MONITORING COMMITTEES.
MONITORING PLANS ANIMUS
REDUCTION PLANS THAT THAT GETS
BUILT IN TO THE THE
IMPLEMENTATION PROCESS.
WITH THAT MANAGER THAT'S GOING
TO CONCLUDE OUR PARTS REMARKS.
ARE REMARKS AT LIKE TO HAND OVER
TO MS MARGARET CORDON.
WELL GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYONE OP
WHAT I'M GOING GOING --
TO GET MORE TAKE DETAILS OF
IMPACTS WITH LOCAL.
FIRMS SAW WE HAVE THREE
RECYCLERS.
WE HAVE ANYWHERE FROM SIX THIRTY
AM.
BESIDES THE THREE FREEWAYS WE
HAVE A POST OP OF THIS IS JUST
SEVEN WE HAVE A PORT OF OAKLAND
AND IS EXPANDING BASED ON AFFECT
THE GOT.
THE FORMAL ARMY BASE LAYER OF
RETURNS THE FIVE ACRES AND IT
LANDS WITH SPLIT BETWEEN.
THE PORT IN THE CITY SO WOULD
SENATE LOCAL WILL OUT TO PORTS.
IN THE FUTURE SO THAT'S NOT SO
THAT'S NOT INCLUDING THE OF THE
TRUCK WITH A BUSINESS OF A
REPAIR SERVICES FOOD SERVICES.
AND CUSTOMS OF ANY KIND OF THE
DISTRIBUTION OF MATERIALS LEVEL
THAT THEY NEED FOR IN THAT AREA
SO WEST OAKLAND IS STILL A MIXED
USE COMMUNITY OF INDUSTRIAL.
AND WHAT PEOPLE LIVE AT SO I
JUST WANNA MAKE CLARIFICATION TO
THAT THEN ALSO I WOULD LIKE
COUNSEL STATE THAT.
OUR DATA THAT WE HAVE COLLECTED.
AN IN THE LAST. THREE YEARS HAS
BEEN MORE PACIFIC AND MORE WE
FIND THAT WE HAVE EVER HEAD
BASED ON THE FACT THAT WE WENT
OUT ON ALL THE WAY. TO DO A
PROJECT WITH A VIRAL DEFENSE ON
A GOOGLE.
USE THE GOOGLE CAR AND AQABA.
AND THE UNIVERSITY OF TEXAS SO
WE WERE ABLE TO GET MORE REFINED
DATA THAT WE HAVE EVER HEAD.
BOOK ON THE BLOCK.
BLOCK BY BLOCK AND ALSO A
DEMOCRAT THOSE BLOCKS WILL BILLS
FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE BARS SINCE
THE I HAVE SINCE THE RECEPTOR SO
ALSO PEOPLE SYSTEMS OF THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE ELDERLY.
WHO ARE NOT GOING TO FIVE YEARS
OF AGE WHO ARE EITHER HAVE A
FROM OUT OF DISABILITY?
SO WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO REFINE OUR
DAVID TO SUCH A PLACE I THINK.
THE I HAD MORE DEFIANT A RE FINE
OF LOCATIONS THAT WE HAVE EVER
HAD BEFORE NEXT SLIDE.
SO THAT'S THE GOAL OF OUR BOB
ARE MAPPING OF OUR PROJECT.
NEXT LAST.
SO AS I SAY THESE ARE WE HAVE
ALL THESE ATTRACT THE BUSINESSES
WITHIN THAT COMMUNITY --
CONNECTS FLAT.
THOSE ARE SOME ARE.
MEDIUM ABOVE MID MEDIA AT HIGH
LEVELS OF PEOPLE WHAT.
IMPACTED BY OF KERR BLACK CARBON
[inaudible]
NEXT LAST.
BY HAVING BILLS PART OF A STARRY
MAP.
WITH WITH WITH THE THE BACK AND
LOOKS LIKE THE STORY MATT.
WE CAN REFINE --
WHERE TRUCKS THOUGH WHEN THEY
DON'T KNOW?
HOW AND WHERE ARE OUT THERE --
THE BUSINESSES THAT I IMPACT IN
THE COMMUNITY ARE BEING
[inaudible]
NEXT LAST.
THIS IS BOTH ALSO FELL OF WHERE
THE BUSINESSES ARE.
ALL THOSE WILL LIVE TRUCKS
PROBABLY CONSUME.
ALL OF THE TRUCKS THAT ARE ON
THAT MAP SHOWS OF THE EXACT WORK
THE BIZARRE AND WE HAD NEVER HAD.
THE THAT EITHER FROM NO WHERE
NOBODY FROM CITY FROM THE COUNTY
BAY AREA QUALITY THIS IS THE
FIRST TIME WE HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
HAVE.
THIS KIND OF DATA.
OUR AIM FOR ABOUT WITH OPEN
[inaudible]
NEXT.
FIVE SO THIS IS.
SO BEAUTIFUL ARE THE THE US
CIRCLE ARE.
AS LONG AREAS WE IDENTIFIED
THOSE LONG AREAS WHERE LIKE I
SAID IT BOB MEDIUM ABOVE MOVIE
BUT NOT ON BOB UP OUR CARBON
BLACK CARBON.
TO SO THESE ARE REALLY WE REALLY
HOLDEN IN BY THE BLOCK.
ISLAND WHERE ARE YOU IMPACTS ON
THE FLAT.
SO THIS IS WHY I LOVE IT.
THIS IS A LOT OF AB ONE RIGHT AT
THE FREEWAY.
I WANT A BOSTON FOR THE POST OF
THIS RESISTANCE.
I HAVE A BART.
OVER OVER IT AND I'M OUT AS FOR
THE EXCELLENT AND JUST TO AND
I'LL REPORT.
ON SEVENTH STREET.
NEXT.
FIVE SO YOU CAN SEE HOW THOSE
RED BLUFF WHILE UP.
THAT IS THAT IS SHOWN OF THE
HIGHEST LEVEL OF A BLACK CARBON.
OUR OF OUR THESE LITTLE IT NOT
COMMUNITY [inaudible]
NEXT LIVE.
SO WE HAVE DEVELOPED YOU SEE THE
LONG ONES OWN TO OPEN.
YOU COULD SAY THAT.
AS WE GO DOWN CERTAIN AREAS ON A
FAR IAN HERE OF WHERE THE BLUE
THE FINE IS THAT WE HAVE.
THE HOW THE INTEREST AND EXITS
TO THE FREEWAY ARE AFFECTED THAT
PART OF THE COMMUNITY
[inaudible]
NEXT LAST.
THIS IS THIS MORE DETAILED WHAT
HOW WE HAVE BEEN ABLE WHERE THE
HIVE LEVEL OF CHILDREN WITH THAT.
BASED.
BET THOSE UP.
A VOTE ON AND I NEIGHBORHOOD
[inaudible]
LET'S FLAT.
SO YOU THE STATE FROM WHAT AND
WHAT'S OPEN TO OTHER.
IN WHAT'S CALLED A WEB FOCUS YOU
HAVE A DIFFERENT LEVELS.
OF MAKES ALMOST S
RBON -- IN --
AN EMAIL.
TO AND YOU ALSO COULD SEE WE
HAVE A BIT OF A REFINED PICTURE
OF WHERE THE HOT SPOTS ARE.
WITH THIS TYPE OF MODELING THAT
WE HAVE ALSO [inaudible]
LET'S NOT.
SO THAT'S ALSO WHY ARE SENIOR
FACILITIES ARE.
WHERE WE HAVE --
ELEVATED OF BLACK CARBON.
IN --
ALRIGHT THAT'S IT I'M I'M NOT
GOING FOR THE YOU CAN SEE FROM
OUR SEEING FAR.
WE HAVE GOT REALLY REVIVING DATA
THAT WE HAVE NEVER HAD BEFORE
BASED ON NOT JUST DYLAN. ONE
TYPE OF A ONE OF MY MONITORING
WE HAVE HAD THREE DIFFERENT
TYPES OF MONITORING IT WAS
OAKLAND AND THE LAST THREE YEARS.
WE EVEN THE POOR THE HUNDRED
SMALL SENSE OF TO THE
NEIGHBORHOOD WOULD UC BERKELEY
WE DID LIKE A FOR THE PROJECT
WITH.
GOAL WILL UNLOCK AMMAN.
AND THEN WE ALSO HAVE OUR OWN
EQUIPMENT WE HAVE THREE DOES
TRACKERS THAT WE HAVE GO THROUGH
THE NEIGHBORHOOD AND TRAIN
RESIDENTS HOW TO USE.
THAT AS A BACK BACK.
THE BACKPACK WITH INSTRUMENTS I
LOVE IT.
WITH THE GPS ONLY CAN IDENTIFY
ANY DAY IN TIME WHERE WE ARE AS
WE CAN.
AS YOU.
VOTE FOR USE THAT EQUIPMENT DO A
ROUTE.
SO I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE THE
OTHER THING IS WHEN THEY FOR I'M
TELLING AFFECTS EVIDENCE AND AND
THE UP OVER THE LAST. THREE TO
FIVE YEARS OF DOING THIS WORK.
AND BUT I DO HAVE.
A COUPLE OF THINGS I WOULD LIKE.
TO ADD TO THE CONVERSATION IS
THAT I WOULD NOT A WILL PUT
FORTH THE REQUEST THAT WE WE ARE
PARTNER.
A BAY AREA QUALITY.
MAKE A FORMAL REQUEST TO
CALTRANS TO SIT DOWN WITH US AND
TALK ABOUT COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT.
MITIGATION SB SIX ONE SEVEN
BECAUSE THEY WANT TO CHANGE THE
FIVE EIGHTY MAYES MCCARTY BAGS
DO SOME CONSTRUCTION WITH AND
THEY HAVE NOT BEEN ON A FULL
LEVEL INVEST THE FULL LEVEL.
INFORMATIONAL OR TOLD US THAT
THEY HAVE DONE A ENVIRONMENTAL
EVEN THANK BASED ON AFFECT THOSE
TRUCKS US OPEN.
I'M I'M GOING TO PUBLICLY AND
I'M ALSO WON'T SAY THE BLUEPRINT
THE BOOK AND DOES NOT HAVE NO
TEETH INTO IT.
THAT'S WHEN TALK ABOUT LAND USE.
I DO NOT.
AND I SEVERAL CONSULTATION
COMMITTEE I DO NOT REMEMBER.
THAT THE THAT.
THE ISSUE OF DEVELOPING THAT
MOVEMENT WAS INITIATED BY US WHO
ARE SITTING ON THAT CONSULTATION
COMMITTEE WITH CAR. TO DEVELOP
IT.
SO SOME OF THE STUFF THE DAY
THERE'S WELFARE.
WITH HIM OUT.
WE WE GET THE FEEDBACK.
WE GOT SOME FEEDBACK.
BUT I DON'T LIKE THE WAY I WOULD
MAKE A DECISION.
I WANT TO FIND SOMETHING I WON'T
STOP MAKING SOMETHING IS MORE
PROGRESSIVE BEYOND DEATH.
OF SOME UP BEYOND JUST.
WHAT MORE OF THE COMING THAT
IMPACT THE COMMUNITIES --
THROUGHOUT THE STATE HAVE IN A
THE VOICE IN FLAB CONTACTING
FILL INSIDE A BROOKLYN WHERE
ANYTHING I SEE IT.
OUR ABOUT MY COMMUNITY IS BEING
PRINTED OUR OUR THAT IS BEING
JUSTIFIED FOR THEM TO DO WHAT
THEY'RE DOING.
SO THE BOOK NEEDS TO BE UPDATED.
THANK YOU.
A GOOD AFTERNOON WILLIE ROBINSON
I AM PRESIDENT OF THE RICHMOND
BRANCH IN A C. P. AND I'LL
INTEREST IN THIS IS BECAUSE THE
NAACP HAVE A COMMITTEE.
AND THAT COMMITTEE IS CLIMATE AN
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE SO I CAME
TO THIS COMMUNITY MEDIAN TO SEE
HOW WE COULD IMPLEMENT THAT
COMMITTEE AND START TO LOOK AT
THE IMPACTS OF AIR QUALITY IN
OUR COMMUNITY ALONG WITH OTHER
ENVIRONMENTAL ISSUES --
I'D THE PROCESS SO FOR HAS BEEN
VERY --
REWARDING TO ME IN AS MUCH AS IT
LOOKS LIKE IS NOT JUST STATING
COMMUNITY INVOLVEMENT BUT IT IS
THE TO ME OF COMMUNITY
INVOLVEMENT.
BECAUSE THE COMMUNITY HAS COME
TOGETHER HAVE A DISCUSSION AND
FROM THAT DISCUSSION THAT WAS
THE DESIGN TEAM DEVELOP MODELING
WHAT YOU'VE HEARD EARLIER.
AND FROM THAT TEAM WE'VE MET OF
FOUR MORE TIMES PRIDE TO A
SUMMIT AND FROM THAT SUMMIT THE
FEEDBACK THEY CAME IN AND THE
SUGGESTIONS I WAS PUT IN PLACE
USING MODELS THAT WE HAD FROM
WEST OAKLAND. TO DEFINE THE
EASTERN COMMITTEE AND HOW IT'S
GOING TO OPERATE AND PUT IN
PLACE THE OBJECTIVE THAT WE WANT
TO MOVE TO WHAT --
WE HAVE TO DATE COMPLETED.
THAT PROCESS HAVE SELECTED A
STEERING COMMITTEE THAT IS QUITE
LARGE THIRTY FIVE MEMBERS AND
DECIDES RICH AT THE END. TO
ATTEST TO THAT RICHMOND AND SENT
OUT WAS A VERY LARGE AREA AND WE
HAVE A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT
THINGS THAT ARE THEY ALSO OUR
CONCERN WAS TO MAKE SURE.
THAT WE HAD RESIDENTIAL INVOLVED
THIS INVOLVEMENT ALONG WITH
PARTNERING WITH THE MUNICIPAL
GOVERNMENTS THEY'RE BOTH CITY OF
SAN PABLO AND RICHMOND ALONG
WITH THOSE AGENCIES AS OPERATING
WITHIN THAT COMMUNITY.
AND WE'RE IN THE PROCESS NON OF
SETTING DATES AND TIME OF
MEETING SO WE LOOK FORWARD TO
MOVING FALL WITHOUT PROCESS
UNDER THE GUIDANCE AND
DIRECTIONS ALL THE BEER QUALITY
MANAGEMENT.
ALONG WITH THE ADVISEMENT WE GET
FROM PERSON SUCH AS MS MARGARET
AND I BELIEVE SHE'S BEEN QUITE
AN ASSET TO US UNDERSTAND IN
THIS PROCESS SO THAT WE CAN HIT
THE GROUND RUNNING [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU --
I HAVE A QUESTION --
BEFORE I GO.
TO MY COLLEAGUE --
MISS MARGARET BROUGHT UP --
LAND USE AND THAT'S THE FIRST
TIME WE'VE HEARD THAT BROUGHT UP
SO FAR IN TODAY'S HEARING AND I
REALLY APPRECIATE YOU BRINGING
THAT UP SO MY QUESTION. FOR YOU
AND I YOU KNOW I'M SORRY THAT I
DIDN'T THINK OF IT TO ASK CARP
WHEN.
THEY WERE TALKING ABOUT HOW THEY
IMPLEMENT THIS IS WHAT WHAT HOW
DO YOU WORK ON LAND USE IN THESE
IN THIS PLANNING DOCUMENT AND
WHAT IMPACT I MEAN I I'VE COME
FROM LOCAL GOVERNMENTS SO I KNOW
THATLOCAL GOVERNMENT HAS YOU
KNOW THE CONTROL OVER LAND USE
BUT HOW.
DO YOU INTERSECTED AND WITH
LOCAL GOVERNMENT AND HOW DO YOU
INTERCEPTED THE COMMUNITIES.
AND DO YOU LOOK AT LAND USE THE
PRINCE AND IF SO YOU KNOW HOW DO
YOU IMPLEMENT THAT BECAUSE SHE'S
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT THAT THAT'S A
HUGE.
A HUGE --
WAY OF MITIGATING --
SOME OF THIS AIR QUALITY AND
REALLY MOVING --
VULNERABLE PEOPLE OUT OF THE
PATH OF OF THE POLLUTION.
SO MANAGER THAT'S A GREAT
QUESTION ALL ALL START BUT I
WANNA HANDED OVER TO MISS
MARGARET CORDON.
UP SO LAND USE STRATEGIES IN THE
MISSION REDUCTION PLAN ARE GOING
TO BE CRITICAL FOR WEST OAKLAND
I SUSPECT IT'LL ALSO BE WHEN WE
GET THERE FOR RICHMOND AS WELL.
WHAT WE'RE GONNA NEED WE WE
ALREADY KNOW THAT WHAT WE NEED
TO DO IS GET THE CITY OF OAKLAND
TO REROUTE TRUCKING EVEN FURTHER?
AND INDEED --
BOB BEGIN TO START TO PUT IN
PLACE A SET OF LAND USE
DECISIONS THAT MAY INVOLVE
FRANKLY MOVING SOME OF THESE
SOURCES.
HOW FROM THE COMMUNITY AND PUT
THEM IN A WAY FROM THE COMMUNITY
BECAUSE INSIDE WEST OAKLAND?
THE UNFORTUNATE THING IS OVER
TIME YOU HAD A LOT OF REALLY BAD
LAND USE DECISIONS TO TAKE
SOURCES.
OR AND ALLOW HOMES TO BE RIGHT
UP BUILT UP RIGHT UP NEXT TO
EACH OTHER.
AND SO.
I THINK WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO IS
GOING TO RELY ON IN AND FRANKLY
PRESSURE SO THAT THE CITY OF
OAKLAND.
IN THEIR LEADERSHIP COMES
THROUGH INCLUDING THE MAYOR SO
WE CAN MOVE SOME OF THOSE
SOURCES OUT OF THE WEST OAKLAND
COMMUNITY THAT'S THAT'S LARGELY
A BIG STRATEGY WE'RE GOING TO BE
RELYING ON INDIVIDUAL ACTION
PLANS SO IS MARGARET.
YEAH OR DO YOU.
THOSE MAPS HE'S GIVING PEOPLE OF
ONE ABOUT WHAT'S OPEN.
THIS DOES ANYONE OWN.
MARK STONE OKAY.
OKAY REAL QUICK THERE'S ONE BACK.
ANY ANY MAP RESERVES WAS OPEN.
OKAY. TO YOUR RIGHT.
THEN BUT MADRE.
BIG MONEY RIGHT HERE
[inaudible]
THERE ARE.
AND IF I'M NOT A PROBLEM I'LL
HOUSES.
BUILT UP ON THE FRONTAGE ROAD
NONE OF THAT HOUSING.
HAVE IF INTO INDOOR FILTRATION.
AND THE CITY IS ALLOWING.
NEW PEOPLE GET SICK.
THAT'S SOMETHING OUT THAT'S WHY
I'M THAT'S WHAT THEY ABOUT LAND
USE.
AND THEN THE ALLOW.
THOSE THREE FOUR FIVE ABOUT
ABOUT HOUSE OF THE BILL BUILT ON
ONE SIDE IS THE FREEWAY ONE SIDE
OF THE BORDER AND THEN AS A
REFLECTING.
SEVEN RIGHT NEXT OF IT.
LOOKS LIKE WITH A RIGHT NEXT TO
IT.
THE BRINK TRUCKS IN MAY THEN THE
ALL NEW TRUCKS BUT STILL GOT
TRUCKS.
SO I'M JUST SAYING THAT'S HOW.
THE FOOD IS STILL.
NOT PROTECTED WITH ANYBODY.
BROWN LAND USE BY ALLOWING
[inaudible]
HOUSING. TO BE ABLE.
AFFORDABLE MARK READ ALL OF THE
BE BUILT RIGHT A FIELD NEXT TO
BELIEVE.
THESE BUSINESSES THAT WILL I
MEAN I I THINK.
YOU'RE YOU'RE HIGHLIGHTING THE
IMPORTANCE OF RESPONSIBLE A LAND
USE PLANNING AYE.
I GOT A I KNOW THAT --
GO WE'RE WE'RE GONNA HAVE SOME
MORE BILLS --
THEY'D BE PROPOSING GAIN ON THE
ONE HAND AS YOU TRY TO ADDRESS
THE THE HOUSING SHORTAGE AND IN
IN IN OAKLAND IN THE BAY AREA
BUT ON THE OTHER HAND.
YOU KNOW MAKING SURE THAT WE
HAVE WHERE WHERE WE'RE NOT SURE
CUTTING GO.
INTO PROCEDURES. TO TO TO MAKE
SURE THAT WERE.
PUTTING HOMES --
YOU KNOW AND AND AND PLACES THAT
ARE NOT THREATENING THE THE THE
THE HEALTH OF OF OF THE
RESIDENTS THAT ARE BEING --
SO -- MS
GORDON THANK YOU I I REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR YOUR PASSION AND
YOUR YOUR YOUR YOUR EFFORTS INTO.
ADDRESSING THESE ISSUES --
I I I JUST I WANTED FOCUSING --
YOU KNOW THIS PAGE --
IN YOUR PRESENTATION ON THE
CHALLENGES AND IN PARTICULAR THE
THE THE THE POINTS THAT YOU
IDENTIFIED IN TERMS OF LIMITED
AUTHORITY LIMITED ENFORCEMENT OF
EXISTING ORDINANCES.
I MEAN GOING TO MS BUT WHAT I'M
HERE MS GORDON SAYING IS THAT
YOU KNOW.
YOU KNOW I JUST --
BE -- THE
PROVIDING FEEDBACK YOU WANT YOU
MAKING A DIFFERENCE TAKING THAT
INFORMATION --
AND AND MAKING THINGS BETTER
THAT AND IN THE NEIGHBORHOOD BUT
IF YOU DON'T HAVE THE THE THE
THE THE THE AUTHORITY OR OR IF
THE EXISTING ORDINANCES ARE NOT
BEING ENFORCED THEN.
YOU KNOW WHAT'S THE POINT OF
HAVING ALL THE ALL THE FEEDBACK --
AND AND AND SO [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
YEAH.
I GOT THE TREES I'VE BEEN LIVING
THINGS LIKE THE TWENTY FIVE
YEARS.
THE CITY DONALD STREETSCAPE
PROJECT CUT DOWN THE TREES ON
WHAT TO CUT DOWN THE TREES
BECAUSE IT WILL GIVE A SEVENTY
MORE. SEVENTY MORE WOULD CHOOSE
THE BUT NEVER TWENTY FIVE YEARS.
AT THE MICRO SINCE IT AND ALL
SHOULD KNOW ABOUT THE AIR
QUALITY ISSUES OF WHAT'S OPEN.
I'D STILL TODAY I'M STILL TRYING
TO I'M LOSING IT WOW.
THE CITY PUT SEVEN PUBLIC WORKS
DEPARTMENT ALLOWABLE STRINGS TO
BE.
TOWARD OUT METAL NOW.
SO.
YEAH THAT WAS THAT WE HAVE TO
DEAL WITH THE LA YOU YEAH YOU
KNOW IT IS IT'S A LOT OF STUPID
STUFF THE HAVE YOU CAN HAVE.
TO BRING A SOUNDS LIKE YOU HAVE
TO FOCUS ON THE CITY OF OAKLAND
DUE TO MAKE SURE THAT TO THE
THAT THAT THEY THEY ADDRESSES
ISSUES BUT YOU DON'T HAVE BEFORE
US AT THAT AT THE STATE.
YOU KNOW AS AS AS THE STATE
LEGISLATURE HAVE RECOMMENDATIONS
IN TERMS OF HOW TO ADDRESS THESE --
THESE ISSUES OF THE LIMITED
AUTHORITY --
YOU KNOW IN IN IN ORDER TO
ENFORCE ACCOUNTABILITY.
WELL AT THE RISK OF UPSETTING
SOME OF MY COLLEAGUES THAT ARE
STILL TO STILL TO TESTIFY I
WOULD SAY THAT THERE ARE SOME --
AUTHORITY QUESTIONS THAT --
PROBABLY OUGHT TO BE.
LOOKED AT WITH REGARD TO LOCAL
DISTRICTS.
AND SPECIFICALLY WHAT COMES TO
MIND IS --
INDIRECT SOURCE AUTHORITY THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT --
I THINK THAT WHAT THAT HAS TO DO
WITH IS IT MAY NOT NECESSARILY
BE A STATIONARY SOURCE.
IN TERMS OF STACKS BUT IT IT
ATTRACTS A LOT OF TRIPS.
AND THIS IS SOMETHING THAT --
THE LAW IS A LITTLE BIT WITH
REGARD TO THE BARE.
THE LAW COULD BE STRENGTHENED.
IN TERMS OF PROVIDING
AUTHORITIES BECAUSE IN THE WEST
OAKLAND COMMUNITY WE DO HAVE
THESE INDIRECT SOURCES THE POST
OFFICE COMES TO MIND WHICH IS
RIGHT SMACK DAB IN THE MIDDLE OF
THE COMMUNITY.
IT IT IS TRACKS A LOT OF TRIPS
AND INDEED IS HAVING A BIG
IMPACT IN THE COMMUNITY SO AS AN
EXAMPLE THAT IS.
ONE WHERE --
FRANKLY WE OUGHT TO EXPLORE IN
TERMS OF ADDITIONAL AUTHORITY --
FOR THE AIR DISTRICTS AUTHORITY
TO RELOCATE THOSE THOSE TYPE
THEY WOULD PLAN YOU.
ESSENTIALLY AUTHORITY.
RICK.
PROVIDED TO THE OUR DISTRICT TO
REQUIRE FOR EXAMPLE IN THIS CASE
THE THE POST OFFICE. TO PUT
TOGETHER A PLAN WHEREBY THEY
COULD --
DEPLOYED ZERO EMISSION
TECHNOLOGY --
KEEP IN MIND WE TALK ABOUT THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT SO THEY MAY
OR MAY NOT NECESSARILY --
TAKES STEPS ALONG THESE LINES OF
LESS THEY'RE REQUIRED TO DO SO.
SO USE THAT AS AN EXAMPLE OF
SOME OF THE AUTHORITY THAT THE
COULD BE SO STRICT.
BUT THIS PLAN IS BEING PUT
TOGETHER WITH OUR PARTNERS AND
ELOPED ULTIMATELY COME BEFORE MY
BOARD.
WHICH WILL --
CONSIDER ADOPTING IT IN THE FALL
OF THIS YEAR AND THEN --
BEFORE IT ONTO A CAR AND DURING
THAT ENTIRE PROCESS WE'RE GOING
TO BE LOOKING TO CARVE TO ALSO
COME TO THE TABLE.
AND BE --
SEEKING.
TO STEP UP TO THEIR COMMITMENTS
IN TERMS OF THEIR REGULATORY
AUTHORITY AND WHAT THEY WILL DO
AS WELL --
TO RELATIVE TO THE MOBILE
SOURCES.
SO WE HAVE TO TAKE A LOOK AND
SEE IF INDEED --
SOMEONE IS WHETHER --
WHAT'S ALREADY BEING COMMITTED
TO BY CAR ISN'T GOING TO BE
SUFFICIENT AND IF NECESSARY WILL
THEN COME BACK WITH THEM.
SOME ADDITIONAL AUTHORITY --
SICK SICK SOME ADDITIONAL
AUTHORITY.
HI I KNOW THAT PART OF AB SIX
SEVENTEEN WAS AND SAID FIT IN.
IN IN WEST OAKLAND.
IN WEST OAKLAND WE DO HAVE --
THE BIG GUYS SOURCE NEARBY.
SO STILL SHREDDING FACILITY AND
IT SHOWS UP ON OUR MAPS BUT
FRANKLY --
THAT WAS A VERY WELCOME STEP AS
PART OF SIX SEVENTEEN BECAUSE
THE OF THE TIMOTHY AUTHORITIES
HADN'T BEEN TOUCHED IN PROBABLY
TEN PLUS YEARS.
AND THEY NEEDED TO BE
STRENGTHENED SO THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT WE VERY MUCH WELCOMED.
AT THE DISTRICTS SO ARE INCREASE
PENALTIES BEING IMPOSED THEY'RE
ALREADY A PART OF HOW WE IMPOSE
OUR FINES AND PENALTIES ON THE
SOURCES YES.
SO THEY'VE BEEN LEVIED ON THAT
THAT PART TO SEE IF THERE'S BEEN
ANY --
VIOLATIONS OKAY.
THANK YOU --
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
THAT IS THE DARKEST SOURCE IN
THE BOTTOM IS THAT YOUR STEEL
SHREDDING.
FACILITY.
BEFORE RIGHT.
SOMETHING FAR LESS.
OKAY SO WHAT THE DARKEST SOURCE
ON THE BOTTOM RIGHT IT'S STILL A
QUART.
THAT'S THE PORT OKAY YEAH THAT'S
A COMBINATION OF FORTY MISSIONS
AND SCHNITZER STAY OKAY.
YEAH RIGHT.
THANK YOU ALL VERY MUCH REALLY
APPRECIATE THE TESTIMONY
[inaudible]
YEAH RIGHT.
OKAY OUR NEXT PANEL IS MATT
DESERT FROM THE IMPERIAL COUNTY
AIR POLLUTION CONTROL DISTRICT
AND LOUIS ALL METAL.
COMMITTEES CIVIC GO DOWN BALLOT
.
I HAVE NO NINE EGGS [inaudible]
WELCOME.
THANK YOU --
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR IN
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS IT'S A PLEASURE
TO BE HERE REPRESENTING IMPERIAL
COUNTY.
AND REPRESENTING THE COMMUNITIES
HAVE BEEN AWARDED THE SIX
SEVENTEEN DESIGNATION OF
CALEXICO AT OUR INTERNATIONAL
BORDER WITH MEXICO.
A SMALLER COMMUNITY IF YOU WERE
JUST NORTH OF THERE AND THEN THE
ANOTHER LARGE CITY FOR IMPERIAL
VALLEY -- EL
CENTRO -- MY
NAME'S MATT DESERT AND I AM THE
AIR POLLUTION CONTROL OFFICER
FOR IMPERIAL COUNTY.
NEXT SLIDE PLEASE.
OUR DISTRICT RECEIVED OVER SIXTY
APPLICATIONS --
FROM THE COMMUNITY FOR
MEMBERSHIP ON TO THE STEERING
COMMITTEE --
THE CO CHAIRS --
THEIR POLLUTION CONTROL OFFICER
MYSELF --
MISTRAL METAL WITH THE
COMMITTEES DIFFICULT DIVIDE A
REVIEWED ALL APPLICATIONS AND
SELECTED THE PRIMARY MEMBERS --
WITH THEM HAVING THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SELECT THEIR ALTERNATES FROM
THE POOL OF APPLICANTS THAT IS
WE HAVE LIKE MINDED ALTERNATES
THAT WORK AND COMMUNICATE WELL
WITH THE PRIMARY MEMBERS --
TO MAKE SURE IF THERE'S ANY
SUBSTITUTION A REPLACEMENT THAT
EVERYONE IS AS PLUGGED IN AS
POSSIBLE.
WE ARE ONE OF TWO AB SIX
SEVENTEEN COMMUNITIES WHO SHARE
OUR CHAIRMANSHIP WITH A LOCALLY
J. GROUP.
A NEXT SLIDE PLEASE --
NOVEMBER FOURTEENTH WAS OUR
FIRST --
COMMITTEE STEERING COMMITTEE
MEETING --
FOR SIX SEVENTEEN THERE WE
DISCUSS THE BROWN ACT AND A. B.
SIX SEVENTEEN INCENTIVES.
ON NOVEMBER FOURTEENTH OF WE
ALSO SET UP INTO IT UP
ADDITIONAL AGENDAS ITEMS TO COME.
ON DECEMBER SEVENTEENTH THE
COMMITTEE STEERING COMMITTEE
TOOK ACTION ON THE ROSTER AS
WELL AS WERE GIVEN PRESENTATIONS
ON BARK.
INCENTIVE FUNDING I HAVE AN AIR
MONITORING AND SOURCE
ATTRIBUTIONS.
ANALYSIS.
ON JANUARY SIXTEENTH THE
COMMITTEE STRENGTH MAKES AT THE
REGULAR MEETING DATES WHICH IT
WOULD MEET WHICH BE THE SECOND
WEDNESDAY OF EACH MONTH.
PRESENTATIONS INCLUDE REGULATORY
MONITORING.
AT THE REJECT VERSUS NON THAT
THE PROJECT SOURCES AND
AGRICULTURAL BURNING AND
IMPERIAL COUNTY.
ON JANUARY THIRTIETH TO SEE A
SEEK --
STEERING COMMITTEE ADDRESSED OF
THE FIRST FIVE ELEMENTS.
AS WELL AS COMMUNITY MONITORING --
FEBRUARY THIRTEENTH OF TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN SAW THE
COMMITTEES DURING MAY TAKE
ACTION IN ADOPT THE CHARTER.
WELL WHICH WILL GO BEFORE THE
AIR DISTRICT BOARD OUR LOCAL
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS TOMORROW
MARCH NINETEENTH.
PRESERVATION IS FOR THAT MEETING
INCLUDE CONTROL STRATEGIES --
FOR COMMUNITY EMISSIONS
REDUCTION PROGRAM AND ACT
BURNISHING POLICY --
ONE THIRTY FOUR AT OUR MARCH
FOURTEENTH MEETING OF THE
COMMITTEE STEERING COMMITTEE AND
THAT UNANIMOUSLY APPROVED THE
FILE CORD OR BOUNDARIES.
AND THE COMMITTEES CODE OF
CONDUCT AT THAT MEETING.
EACH BEING HAS BEEN FILLED WITH
GREAT DIALOGUE IN OUR NEW
MEETINGS VENUE OPERATED BY THE
ELCENTRO REGIONAL MEDICAL
CENTER.
HAS BEEN EXTREMELY CONDUCIVE TO
FACILITATE DISCUSSION AMONGST
VARIOUS COMMUNITY MEMBERS.
OF THIS NEW FACILITY IS IS VERY
MODERN NEW IT'S AN INSIDE A
LARGE SHOPPING MALL --
WITH THE ROOT DOWNTURN OF RETAIL
SALES --
THIS KIND OF AN OPPORTUNITY HAS
POPPED UP IN ITS HAS SERVED WELL
AS A A MEETING LOCATION --
WE'RE BEING ABLE TO BRING A
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FROM DIVERSE
BACKGROUNDS TO THE SAME TABLE
AND DISCUSS ACTIONS AND IDEAS TO
BETTER OUR AIR QUALITY IMPROVE
THE HEALTH OF OUR RESIDENTS.
IS WHAT MAKES SIX SEVENTEEN SO
EXCITING TO WORK.
THE NEXT SLIDE PLEASE.
WITH THE ASSISTANCE OF A
COMMITTEES DIFFICULT DIVIDE OUR
JANUARY THIRTIETH MEETING SAW
OUR STEERING GROUP BREAK OFF
INTO THREE GROUPS TO DISCUSS.
AND BE SURVEYED ON CONCERNS
REGARDING AIR QUALITY AND A. B.
SIX SEVENTEEN CORRIDOR AND THEIR
INPUT ON ELEMENTS.
TO THREE FOUR OF THE COMMUNITY
MONITORING PLAN.
THAT WILL BE FINALIZED BY JUNE.
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN QUESTIONS
THERE INCLUDED WHAT WHAT DO YOU
THINK HAS CONTRIBUTED TO A
WORSENING AIR QUALITY IN THE
CORNER THE CORNER BEING AGAIN
THE CITIES OF CALEXICO UBER.
AND ALL CENTRO.
WHAT POLLUTANTS SHOULD WE
MONITOR?
WHERE IN THE QUARTER SHOULD WE
MONITOR --
AND USING A Q. V. CODE VERY
MODERN DEVICE COMMITTEE SAID
WITH GOALS A STAFF BROUGHT THIS.
TO THE MEETING --
THAT'S THE BOTTOM LEFTHAND
CIRCLE THERE.
WE ARE ABLE TO DO SURVEYS IN
REAL TIME WITH THE GROUP AND GET
CONSENSUS ON SUBJECT MATTERS AND
QUESTIONS.
AFTER THE SERVICE WE CAME
TOGETHER TO CONTINUE THE
DISCUSSION --
FROM OUR TABLES AND GROUPS.
NEXT SLIDE PLEASE.
WE SUBMITTED OUR DRAFT PLAN BY
THE FEBRUARY TWENTY EIGHTH
DEADLINE WE INCLUDED THE
COMMITTEE STEERING COMMITTEE AND
PUT WHICH CAME FROM THE MEETING
DISCUSSION ON THE JANUARY
THIRTIETH ROUND TABLE
DISCUSSIONS.
THE STEERING COMMITTEE COMMUNITY
[inaudible]
COMMITTEE.
ATTRIBUTES THE WORST THING AIR
QUALITY IN THE QUARTER TO MOBILE
EMISSIONS FOR TRAFFIC.
FUGITIVE DUST EMISSIONS FROM
ATHEROGENIC SOURCES THAT IS
PAVED AND UNPAVED ROADS.
NOT AT THE PROJECT SOURCES.
OF THAT IS UNDISTURBED OPEN
DESERT AREAS.
AG BURNING IN INDUSTRIAL
FACILITIES.
THEY ALSO IDENTIFIED PM TWO
POINT FIVE PM TEN AND GREENHOUSE
GASES AS MAIN POLLUTANTS OF
CONCERN.
THE COMMUNITY STEERING COMMITTEE
INDICATED THAT THE INTERNATIONAL
BORDER.
WAS THE AREA OF HIGHEST INTEREST
ON THE POTENTIAL MODERN LOCATION.
AT THE INTERNATIONAL BORDER WITH
THE US CITY BEING CALEXICO
MEXICAN CITY BEING MEXICALI.
THE DRAFT COMMUNITY ARE MARKING
PLAN ALSO ADDRESS THE FORMING OF
A COMMUNITY PARTNERSHIP.
OUR WEBSITE DEDICATED TO AB
[inaudible]
SIX SEVENTY ACTIVELY.
WITH A DEDICATED PARA COUNTY OR
POLLUTION CONTROL DISTRICT STAFF
PERSON HAS CONTACT WILL BE
BUILDING COMMUNITY PARTNERSHIPS.
EFFORTS AND ACTIONS WILL BE
TAKEN ON BETTER INTERPRETING AIR
QUALITY DATA AND HELPING THE
PUBLIC UNDERSTAND THE IMPACTS OF
POOR AIR QUALITY.
AIR MONITORING WILL BE DONE IN
COORDINATION WITH COMMITTEES
COMMITTEE CIVIC OF THEIR BY ON
EXPANDING ENHANCING THE I'VE AN
AIR MONITORING NETWORK.
THAT MANY OF YOU IF NOT ALL OF
YOU HAVE HEARD SO MUCH ABOUT.
THE SUCCESS OF THE DEVELOPING
THIS PLAN HAS BEEN A
COLLABORATIVE EFFORT.
WITH MANY DIFFERENT PARTIES
INVOLVING.
INVOLVING THE COMMITTEE STEERING
COMMITTEE ANSI C. V..
THE COMMITTEE STEERING COMMITTEE
IS THE SUPPORT ACT OF COMMUNITY
INVOLVEMENT COLLABORATION THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THE PROGRAM FOR
PROVIDINGA FORUM FOR
IDENTIFYING COMMUNITY ISSUES AND
POTENTIAL SOLUTIONS.
WITH ALL RELEVANT PARTIES.
THE BILL COUNTY AIR POLLUTION
CONTROL DISTRICT IS THE
AUTHORITY FOR AIR QUALITY
MATTERS IN APRIL COUNTY.
IT WILL BE THE RESPONSIBILITY OF
THE IMPERIAL COUNTY OR PUSH
CONTROL DISTRICT TO SUPPORT
COMMITTEE CIVICO DIVIDE.
AND THE SIX SEVENTEEN COMMITTEE
STEERING COMMITTEE WITH THEIR
KNOWLEDGE FOR THE SUCCESSFUL
EXECUTION OF THIS PLAN.
COMMUNITIES DIVIDE WILL PLAY AN
INTEGRAL ROLE IN THE PLAN
IMPLEMENTATION.
PARTICULARLY REGARDING COMMUNITY
ARE MONITORING.
THE CONNECTIONS THAT COMMITTEE
CERVICAL THEREBY HAS MADE WITHIN
THE COMMUNITY WILL BE INVALUABLE.
AND CONDUCTING OUTREACH IN
GALVANIZING INVOLVEMENT BY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
COMMUNITY BASED ACTION IS A
CENTRAL TENET OF AB SIX
SEVENTEEN THE COMMITTEE STEERING
COMMITTEE MEMBERS WERE SELECTED.
WITH THE EXPECTATION THAT THEY
WOULD COMMUNICATE WITH AND
VOICED THE SENTIMENTS OF THEIR
FELLOW COMMUNITY MEMBERS.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ARE INVITED TO
ATTEND EACH COMMITTEE STEERING
COMMITTEE AND THE COURAGE TO
VOICE THEIR OPINIONS DURING THE
PUBLIC COMMENT DAVID IS.
AS STATED WE HAVE A WEBSITE
DEDICATED TO A. B..
SIX SEVENTEEN WHICH INCLUDES
BACKGROUND INFO.
OF OUR COMMUNITY STEERING
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ROSTERS AND
BIOS ON GOING.
MEETING SCHEDULES MEETING
INFORMATION.
MEETING RECORDINGS.
CONTACT LINKS FOR THE APRIL CON
AIR POLLUTION CONTROL DISTRICT.
CCV.
COUNTY OF IMPERIAL.
AND THE CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES
BOARD.
THE BILL COUNTY AIR POLLUTION
CONTROL DISTRICT ALSO CREATED
SOCIAL MEDIA PAGES WHICH
PUBLICIZES OUR MEETINGS VIA.
EVENT CREATIONS FLYERS VIDEOS
AND OTHER VARIOUS POSTINGS.
THE PROCUREMENT YOU CONTROL
DISTRICT AND COMMITTEE CERVICAL
DIVIDE A ARE CURRENTLY
DEVELOPING SURVEYS TO KEEP OUR
STEERING COMMITTEE MEMBERS
ENGAGE IN DOLLAR BILL OF AIR
QUALITY INFORMATION ESPECIALLY
DURING THE LAPSES IN BETWEEN
MEETINGS.
SOMETIMES WERE HAVING MEETINGS
EVERY TWO WEEKS SOMETHING THAT A
MINIMUM WE'RE HAVING THEM EVERY
MONTH.
THE PORTLY OUR CODE OF CONDUCT
WAS DEVELOPED ALONGSIDE WITH CC
THE COMMITTEE CERVICAL DIVIDE.
ACTUALLY WAS DEVELOPED PRIMARILY
BY COMMITTEES TYPICAL DIVIDE TO
ENSURE THE INTEGRITY AND FREE
FLOWING DISCUSSION OF OUR A. B.
SIX SEVENTEEN MEETINGS
[inaudible]
CONTINUOUS.
NEXT SLIDE PLEASE [inaudible]
NEXT SLIDE.
THE BILL CAN AIR POLLUTION
CONTROL DISTRICT IS COMMITTED TO
SUBMITTING THE COMPLETE DRAFT
COMMITTEE MARKING PLANNED BY MAY.
AND FINAL VERSION BY JUNE.
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN WE'RE
COMMITTED TO ADOPTING THE
COMMUNITY EMISSIONS REDUCTION
PROGRAM BY OCTOBER OF TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN WE'RE
COMMITTED TO CONTINUING OUR
COLLABORATIVE WORK WITH
COMMITTEE CYNICAL THE BY AND THE
A. B. SIX SEVENTEEN COMMUNITY
STEERING COMMITTEE.
IN A PORTLY HERE WE'VE BEEN THIS
DISCUSSION AND HAD AYE IDEAS
COME UP THAT HAVE ALREADY BEEN
ADDRESSED IN MOVING FORWARD. TO
MAKE THINGS BETTER.
WE'VE BEEN AB REVIEW IN OUR AG
BURN POLICY WITH THE REVIEW AND
UPDATE.
AND WE'RE ALSO LOOKING AT
UTILIZING SOME OF THE MONIES ARE
MONITORING TO HELP BETTER PLAN
AND ESTABLISH.
ROOMS ENGAGEMENT ROOMS
MONITORING ROOMS THAT COULD BE
OPEN TO THE PUBLIC AT THE LOCAL
AIR POLLUTION CONTROL DISTRICT
THAT IS.
A SEPARATE ROOM FROM OUR
MONITORING EQUIPMENT.
THAT THE PUBLIC OUR INDUSTRY
COULD COME IN AND TEST NEW
EQUIPMENT.
OR EXISTING EQUIPMENT CALIBRATED.
AND ALSO TESTED AGAINST OUR
EXTREME HEAT AND ENVIRONMENTAL
CONCERNS THAT WE HAVE IN THE
IMPERIAL VALLEY.
AS STATED THE INTERNATIONAL
BORDER WAS THE AREA OF HIGHEST
INTEREST ON POTENTIAL MONTEREY
LOCATIONS FAR SIX SEVENTEEN
STEERING COMMITTEE.
THERE POLLUTION CONTROL DISTRICT
HAS DEVOTED TIME AND RESOURCES
TO CREATING A BETTER WORKING
RELATIONSHIP WITH MEXICO
OFFICIALS.
WHICH IS A DIRECT BENEFIT FROM
THE CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES
BOARD AN ASSEMBLYMEMBER RD
GARCIA'S EFFORTS AND SUPPORT IN
OUR BORDER AREA WITH MEXICO.
OR THE FRONT DATA.
A FAVORITE WORD OF MINE LE FOR
DATA.
THE CONTINUATION AN ENHANCEMENT
OF PM TWO POINT FIVE MONITORING
IN MEXICALI AS WELL AS THE
COORDINATION AND TRAINING OF LOW
COST MARK COMMITTEE MONITORS.
HAS IN REAL TIME SEEN SUCCESS
FROM THE COLLABORATIVE WORK
BETWEEN KERR PANI IMPERIAL
COUNTY OR POLLUTION CONTROL
DISTRICT.
THE CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES
BOARD COMMITTEE CYNICAL TO BUY
AN AGENCIES FROM MEXICALI AND
MEXICO.
WE ARE CONFIDENT THAT WE WILL
ACCOMPLISH ALL SHORT AND LONG
TERM GOALS AS STATED IN THE
IMPERIAL COUNTY MEXICALI AIR
QUALITY WORK PLAN.
AS WELL AS ALL SHORT LONG TERM
GOALS OF THE SIX SEVENTEEN AND
ARE DESIGNATED QUARTER. SIX
SEVENTEEN LEADERSHIP AND
MOMENTUM NEEDS TO BE CARRIED ON
THROUGHOUT IMPERIAL VALLEY.
AS WELL AS INTO OUR BORDER AREA
WITH MEXICO.
NOW ON THIS LAST SLIDE.
THE RED LINE GOING ACROSS THE
PAGE IS THE US MEXICAN BORDER.
THOSE THREE COMMITTEE CIRCLE IN
YELLOW.
THE TOP ONE BEING EL CENTRO HAS
A POPULATION OF APPROXIMATELY.
FIFTY THOUSAND THE MIDDLE ONE
SMALLER ONE HAS A POPULATION OF
APPROXIMATELY.
TWELVE THOUSAND AND THEN THE
LOWER ONE YELLOW ONE HAS ANOTHER
POPULATION OF PRODUCTS WE FIFTY
THOUSAND THAT'S CALEXICO.
THE PREDICTED PROPORTION THAT
REPRESENTS OF APPROXIMATELY TWO
THIRDS OF THE IMPERIAL VALLEY
POPULATION.
THE AREA BELOW THE BORDER AS
MEXICALI.
YOU SEE THE SIZE DIFFERENCE AND
THE IMPACT DIFFERENCE.
BUT WHAT YOU DON'T SEE THE DANCE
OF THIS OF THAT POPULATION OR
THE INDUSTRY THAT HAPPENS DOWN
THERE.
OR THE UNPAVED ROADS.
OF THE POWER PLANTS THAT ARE
EXISTING DOWN THEIR SHIPPING
POWER ACROSS THE BORDER TO THE
US.
THAT AREA IN RED MEXICALI IS A
POPULATION BASE OF A MINIMUM OF
A MILLION AND A HALF PEOPLE.
AND THAT'S WHY IT'S SO IMPORTANT
TO THE SUCCESS OF SIX SEVENTEEN
THE SPIRIT IN THE ENERGY OF SIX
SEVENTEEN WHICH IS CARRIED OVER
TO THESE PM TWO POINT FIVE
WORKSHOPS THAT CARP HAS BEEN
PUTTING ON INTO THE AREA --
IT'S JUST INCREDIBLE THE ENERGY
IN THE ALIGNMENT THAT'S
HAPPENING --
THE BUZZ IT'S IN THE COMMUNITY --
NOT ONLY IN OUR COMMUNITY BUT
ALSO IN OUR COMMITTEE MEMBERS
AND MEXICALI.
OF WHICH MANY OF OUR LOCAL
RESIDENTS AT ALL.
IN MORE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME TODAY.
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MADAM CHAIR.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PROVIDE TESTIMONY.
MY NAME'S LISA METAL I'M THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF CALL ME TO
SEE BECAUSE THE RIGHT WERE A
COMMUNITY BASED ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE ORGANIZATION.
COMMITTEE GOODBYE IS FULLY
COMMITTED TO THE SUCCESSFUL
IMPLEMENTATION OF AB.
SIX SEVENTEEN AND IMPROVING
THEIR QUALITY IN CALIFORNIA DRUG
CAM UNITIES INVOLVEMENT AND
PARTICIPATION.
INFORM PEOPLE BUILD HEALTHY
COMMUNITIES.
CALL ME THEY SAY GOODBYE IT WAS
FOUNDED ON THIS PRINCIPLE AND
CONTINUES TO INCORPORATE.
THIS MISSION AND ALL
PARTNERSHIPS RESEARCH STUDIES
CIVIC ENGAGEMENT.
INITIATED OR COMPRISED OF OUR
ORGANIZATION.
AS OUTLINING CARDS COMMUNITY A
PROTECTION PROGRAM.
LOOK AT THE BLUEPRINT.
AND AS WE HAVE BEEN EXECUTING TO
THE BEST OF OUR ABILITY IN THE
IMPERIAL VALLEY. FOR ME THIS
CYNICAL STRONGLY BELIEVES THE
PATH TO FULFILLING THE SPIRIT OF
AB.
SIX SEVENTEEN WILL BE
ACCOMPLISHED A COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT IN PARTNERSHIP.
WITH LOCAL EDITION.
IN CONTINUING TO INTERPRET CARBS.
BLUEPRINT AND CONFORMING.
CALIFORNIA TO BEST SUIT OUR
REGION. FOR ME THIS CYNICAL PRO
ACT IS PROACTIVE IN INVOLVED IN
INTO THE IMPAIR VALLEY'S
WORSENING AIR QUALITY.
CRISIS.
HAS RESULT IN THE IMMEDIATE
URGENCY OF ESTABLISHING AND
DEVELOPING A STATEWIDE.
STRATEGIC AIR MONITORING NETWORK
TO COMBAT AIR QUALITY LOCALLY.
WHILE SIMULTANEOUSLY
COORDINATING OUR ON SITE OTHER
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
ORGANIZATION.
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
IDENTIFY VIOLATIONS AFFECTING
NEIGHBORHOODS.
OR AS WE CALL I'VE BEEN THERE.
HAS BEEN INSTRUMENTAL IN THE
FORMATION OF A STATEWIDE
COLLABORATION THAT WE CALL OUR
ALLIES IN REDUCING EMISSIONS
OTHERWISE IT.
HEY WE WILL CONTINUE TO PLAY AN
INTEGRAL ROLE.
IN THE EXPANSION OF THIS
COMMUNITY ARE MUNCHING NETWORK
MOVING FORWARD.
ALTHOUGH WE ARE CONTINUOUSLY
STRIVING TO DEVELOP A UNIFORM
COMMUNITY ARE MONITORING NETWORK
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA'S MORE
DISPROPORTIONATE MOST IS
PROPORTIONALLY EXPOSED
COMMUNITIES FOR ME THIS VEHICLE
REALIZES HE SEPARATES REQUIRED
COMMUNITY PARTICIPATION.
AIR DISTRICT ENGAGEMENT AND
ENFORCEMENT AND STATEWIDE
COORDINATION.
WE ALMOST TO OUR PART IN
ENSURING THE SUCCESS OF AB SIX
SEVENTEEN IMPLEMENTATION.
AND THIS IS ONLY THE BEGINNING
[inaudible]
IN EXECUTING.
AB SIX SEVENTEEN OBJECTIVES IN
OUR COMMUNITIES WITH MONTHS ALSO
BEGAN TO LOOK AHEAD AND ALIGN
OUR LOCAL EFFORT STRATEGICALLY.
WITH OTHER CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITIES EXPERIENCING THE
SAME DISPARITIES IN THE REGIONS.
CALL ME THE CIVIC ANOTHER
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
ORGANIZATIONS ARE CURRENTLY
FOCUSING ON THIS.
BY FORMING IT.
ALLIES IN REDUCE EMISSIONS
COLLABORATIVE IN CALIFORNIA.
WE ARE PARTNERING OUR EFFORTS
WITH THOSE WE SHARE THE SAME
CONCERNS INVASION AND EXECUTING
THE SUCCESS.
OF THE COMMUNITY A PROJECTION
PROGRAM.
AMONG THEM IS CLASSIFIED MEDIA
IN SUNNY.
ZERO CENTRUM OUR CENTRAL
CALIFORNIA MEMO JUSTICE NETWORK
IN SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY.
VALLEY LEAP INSTITUTING KINGS
COUNTY.
COMMUNITIES FOR SAFE ENVIRONMENT.
IN WILMINGTON CALIFORNIA WEST
OAKLAND MARMION ORINDA CASE
PROJECT.
IN OAKLAND AND TRACKING
CALIFORNIA.
TOGETHER I'D IS MISSION IS TO
DEVELOP A STATEWIDE STRATEGY IN
FULFILLING THE SPIRIT OF EIGHTY
SIX SEVENTEEN BY COORDINATING
OUR COMMUNITY ARE WANTING
EFFORTS AND EMISSIONS REDUCTIONS
PRODUCT PROJECTS.
BY COMMUNICATING CHAIRING
TEACHING AND LEARNING THE BEST
PRACTICES AND LESSONS LEARNED.
TO MAXIMIZE THE RESULTS OF THE
WORK BEING DONE COLLECTIVELY.
I'D IS PICKING UP WHERE THE
BLUEPRINT LEAVES OFF.
AND BY DOING SO.
AS WAS STATED BEFORE.
THIS IS JUST THE BEGINNING.
AND THERE'S PLENTY OF WORK AHEAD.
WE DECEIVE ICAL AND THE IMPERIAL
COUNTY AIR POLLUTION CONTROL
DISTRICT ARE PROVIDING THIS
METHODOLOGY TO BE.
THE WORKING MODEL. FOR OTHER
JURISDICTIONS THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIANS TO IMPLEMENT.
OUR FIRST RUN A COMMUNITY
QUARTER DESIGNATED.
COMMUNITY INCLUDES CALEXICO HE
WERE EL CENTRO.
BORDER COMMUNITIES AS STATED BY.
MY DESERVE THE IMPAIR GONNA PUSH
AN OFFICER A JOB GRAPHIC AREAS
LOCATED BETWEEN THE SONG SEE TO
THE NORTH.
AND THE INTERNATIONAL BORDER
PROXIMITY.
WHICH IS UNDER REGULATED
MEXICALI AND THE SOUTH.
THIS PRODUCES AN AGRICULTURE
NEXUS WHICH ALSO CONTRIBUTES TO
MAKE IN THE REGION. ONE OF THE
MOST DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
SUFFERING FROM THE ADVERSE
AFFECTS ASSOCIATED.
WITH OVER EXPOSURE TO BETTER
QUALITY.
COMING THIS YEAR BECAUSE BEEN
MONITORING OUR REGION'S AIR
ANKLE ACTING OPEN SOURCE DATA.
FOR OVER FIVE YEARS TO LIVE IN A
MODEL CONSISTING OF OR FORTY AIR
MONITORS.
THAT MEASURE PM TEN PM TO
PROVIDE THAT WERE DEPLOYED
THROUGHOUT THE COMMUNITIES OF
THE IMPERIAL VALLEY.
WE ARE CURRENTLY IN THE PROCESS
OF EXPANDING OUR AIR I'VE BEEN A
MONITORING NETWORK TO INCLUDE
EASTERN PATELLA VALLEY.
BATTING AN ADDITIONAL FIFTEEN
MONITORS.
WITH THE HELP OF LOCAL RESIDENTS.
THE PASSAGE OF AB SIX SEVENTEEN
LEGISLATION.
AND THE AWAY UNWAVERING
LEADERSHIP OF PUSHED OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CRISTINA GARCIA.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DARLA GARCIA.
AND I AM I REMEMBER JUST
COMMUNITY PARTNERSHIP WITH OUR
LOCAL AIR DISTRICT PROVIDING THE
SUCCESSFUL IN THE IMPLEMENTATION
BEGINS AT THE GROUND LEVEL.
AS IMPERIAL COUNTY A POLLUTION
CONTROL OFFICER MATT DOES
REPRESENT.
CALL ME TO SEAQUEST PARTNERED
WITH THE OUR DISTRICT TO BRING
THE SPIRIT OF AB. SIX SEVENTEEN
TO FRUITION. FOR THE BETTERMENT
OF HEALTH AND WELL BEING OF OUR
COMMUNITY.
WE ARE SHARING A CO CHAIR IN OUR
AB SIX SEVENTEEN COMMITTEE.
STEERING COMMITTEE ALONGSIDE THE
AIR POLLUTION CONTROL DISTRICT
TO BRIDGE THE DISCONNECT BETWEEN
GOVERNMENT AGENCIES AND PEOPLE
THEY SERVE.
AB SIX SEVENTEEN IS MAKING THIS
PARTNERSHIP.
A RARE A REALITY.
PRIOR TO AB SIX SEVENTEEN SUCH A
PARTNER CHEN UPS PART SUCH A
PARTNERSHIP WAS UNHEARD OF LET
ALONE NON EXISTENT.
TODAY WE ARE DEVISING THEIR
MUNCHING PLANS EMISSIONS
REDUCTION STRATEGIES.
TOGETHER WITH THE HELP OF PEOPLE
WHO.
WHO KNOW THEIR ENVIRONMENT
BETTER THAN ANYONE ELSE THE
COMMUNITY?
IMPAIR VALLEY'S COMMUNITY CORD
OR EVERY EVERY PROTECTION
PROGRAM.
IS A DIRECT RESULT OF WHAT CARP
OUTLINED IN AMBITION IN THE
DRAFT.
THE COMMUNITY A PROTECTION
PROGRAM TO PRINT.
HOWEVER IN ORDER TO SUCCESSFULLY
IMPLEMENT THE MANDATES AS
OUTLINED WITHIN THE BLUEPRINT.
NOPE WHERE DISTRICTS MUST BE
WILLING TO ADAPT ACCORDINGLY.
THERE DISTRICTS MUST BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE IN ENSURING THEY ARE
FULFILLING THE COMMUNITY A
PROTECTION PROGRAMS DIRECTORS.
BY ACCEPTING COMMUNITY
INVOLVEMENT AND PARTICIPATION.
AS IN THE CASE OF OUR DISTRICT
THE BEST WAY TO ACHIEVE THAT IS
THROWN BY OUR MIDDLE JUSTICE
ORGANIZATIONAL PARTNERSHIP.
AND NOT SOLELY REPRESENTATION OR
INCLUSION.
WE BELIEVE THAT THAT IS A MAJOR
KEY TO SUCCESS AND THE PROGRAM.
AS WE CONTINUE TO WORK TOGETHER.
THROUGH AB SIX SEVENTEEN PROCESS.
FAILURE TO RECOGNIZE OR ACCEPT
THIS REALITY IS
COUNTERPRODUCTIVE.
AND SIMPLY CONTRADICTS THE
PROGRAM'S MISSION.
IT'S TIME TO CHANGE THE WAY
CALIFORNIA AGENCY SERVE AND WORK
FOR THAT REPRESENT RESPECTIVE
COMMUNITIES.
IN CONCLUSION AB.
SIX SEVENTEEN IMPLEMENTATION
REQUIRES A COMMITTED CONCERTED
EFFORT.
FROM THE LOCAL LEVEL.
OF EVERY KIND THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE IN THE STATE CAPITAL.
AIR DISTRICT ENGAGEMENT AND
COMMUNITY PARTICIPATION ARE AT
THE CORE OF THE COMMUNITY OF
PROTECTION PROGRAM.
AND MUST BE RECOGNIZED IN ORDER
TO ENSURE THE PROGRAM'S SUCCESS.
CARP SHOULD BE OVERSEEN AIR
DISTRICTS AND MEDIATING THE
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE COMMUNITY
PARTNERSHIPS IN ORDER TO
REINFORCE.
THEIR WORKING RELATIONSHIPS
FINALLY STATEWIDE COORDINATION
AND RESOURCE AVAILABILITY WILL
BE FUNDAMENTAL AND FULFILLING.
THE SPIRIT OF AB.
SIX SEVENTEEN IN PROMOTING AND
REALIZING THE ENVIRONMENTALLY.
SAFER AND HEALTHIER CALIFORNIA
FOR ALL RESIDENTS.
AND NEIGHBORING COMMUNITIES.
THANK YOU FOR A TIME AND THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE TESTIMONY.
YOU VERY MUCH.
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
JUST A FEW COMMENTS MA'AM CHAIR
ONE X. KNOWLEDGE TO WORK IS
BEING DONE BY BOTH.
SIR MIDDLE AND MISTER DESERT
BRINGING COMMUNITY GATHER.
TOOK NEARLY THE PARTNERSHIP THAT --
IS UNDER WAY WITH THE OUR
DISTRICT AND MICKEY KILEY --
WHICH AS YOU SAW IN THIS SLIDE
TO REALLY.
ISN'T A A BORDER AND MANY OF YOU
HAVE HEARD ME SAY THIS BEFORE
PORTER TALL ENOUGH BIG ENOUGH.
THICK ENOUGH TO KEEP. THIRTY
YEAR ON ONE SIDE --
FROM MOVING TO THE OTHER AND
THAT'S TAKEN A LOT OF WORK --
TO COME TOGETHER OF COURSE OF
KNOWLEDGE IN THE WORK OF THE AIR
RESOURCES BOARD AND LEADERSHIP
OF MISS CORY IN.
FRONT BRINGING THIS TOGETHER I
THINK IT'S GOING TO HAVE A
SIGNIFICANT IMPACT TO THE REGION.
A REGION THAT --
UNFORTUNATELY STATISTIC THAT
PART TOO LONG HAS TO BE
MENTIONED THAT. SEVEN OUT OF TEN
CHILDREN SUFFER FROM RESPIRATORY
DISEASE PROBLEMS ALL OF THESE
EFFORTS.
ARE UNDERWAY OURS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT TO THE PUBLIC.
AND WELL BEING OF OF THE FOLKS
OUT THERE I DO HAVE A QUESTION
FOR MR DESERT NEED.
MENTIONED.
THIS IN PASSING.
THE REVIEW OF THE AG BURNING
POLICY FOR THE AIR DISTRICT I'M
I'M INTERESTED IN HEARING MORE
ABOUT THAT IF YOU IF YOU HAVE A
FEW MINUTES TO JUST KIND OF GIVE
US A AN OVERVIEW FOR FOLKS TO
UNDERSTAND BOTH LOCALLY AS WELL
AS THE WHITE.
THAT THIS IS A PRACTICE THAT
CONTINUES --
IN THIS REGION AND SOMETHING
THAT ALWAYS IS BROUGHT UP BY
MANY CONSTITUENTS --
IN FACT TO THE EXTENT THAT IT'S
WIDE [inaudible]
OR WHY THERE ARE MORE --
EFFORTS TO REDUCE IT AND I THINK
PART OF IT IS PEOPLE NOT KNOWING
WHAT EXACTLY IS HAPPENING AT THE
DISTRICTS OF PERHAPS YOU CAN
KIND OF SHARE WITH US WHAT IS
THAT.
REVIEW OF THE POLICY LOOK LIKE
IT WILL OF THE LEGISLATION
EXISTS THAT THAT ALLOWS THE AG
COMMITTEE THE FARMING COMMUNITY
TO DO THIS AS A AS A PRACTICE OF
CULTURAL PRACTICE --
AND WE WE WE ORGANIZED WE WE
MONITOR IT WE WE WE RUN THE
PROGRAM --
WE LOOK FOR THE RIGHT TYPE OF
WEATHER ON THOSE DAYS SO TO MAKE
SURE THE SMOKE.
RISES TO A CERTAIN LEVEL AND
DISPERSES --
WITH DOING THE THE THE LEAST
DAMAGE OF THE LEAST PROBLEMS AS
POSSIBLE --
IT'S NOT AN EXACT SCIENCE
WORKING WITH THE WEATHER --
BUT WE DO OUR BEST AND WE'VE HAD
SOME SUCCESSES THERE --
WE'RE ALL HOPING THAT THE
LEADERSHIP THAT WE SHOW.
ON OUR SIDE OF THE BORDER WITH
OUR RULES AND REGULATIONS IN
THIS NEW RELATIONSHIPS WITH
MEXICO.
THAT MEXICO GETS AN APPETITE FOR
SOME OF THAT AND THE FIRST STEP
FOR MEXICO WOULD BE A BABY STEP
WOULD BE AN ACT BURN PROGRAM.
AND THAT FIRST BABY STEP WITHIN
pSTOP BURNING THEIR FIELDS AT
NIGHT SO THE INVERSION LAYER
DOESN'T HOLD THAT SMOKE.
IN THE MORNING.
OR SPECIFICALLY BACK TO THE
POLICY SO IT'S A MINISTRY TO
POLICY WE'VE BROKEN THE IN
PROVIDING TO FOUR DIFFERENT
QUADRANTS WITH A MAXIMUM OF
THOUSAND TWO THOUSAND ACRES A
DAY THAT CAN BE BURNED FIVE
HUNDRED ACRES PER QUADRANT --
WORD LOWER THAT TO FOUR HUNDRED
ACRESPER QUADRANT OR TOTAL OF
SIXTEEN HUNDRED ACRES TODAY.
WE'RE TAKING A LOOK AT MAKING
THE BURN SMALLER.
BOTH THE RESIDENTIAL BURNS WHICH
ARE THE PRIMARY SOURCE OF OUR
VIOLATIONS BAG BURN --
FOLKS ARE DOING A PRETTY GOOD
JOB A VERY GOOD JOB.
SO IF THE FIELDS ARE SMALLER.
AND THE SEQUENTIALLY THEY CAN BE
BURNED --
THERE OF LIST IMPACT LESS VISUAL
IMPACT.
AND LESS CUMULATIVE IMPACT --
WE'RE ALSO LOOKING AT OUR
SPECIAL BURN AREAS AROUND ARE
SENSITIVE RECEPTORS ARE CITIES.
A RIGHT NOW THAT WE SPECIAL
BURNED REQUIRES A INSPECTOR TO
BE ON SITE.
IT'S BEST BETTER HIGHER STANDARD
WHETHER CONDITION SO THOSE BIRDS
CAN TAKE PLACE.
THERE'S A MILE AND A HALF BUFFER
AROUND THESE COMMITTEES
COMMUNITIES AND CITIES VERY
SIMILAR TO THE BUFFER THAT
SURROUND THEM FOR PESTICIDE
APPLICATIONS --
WE'RE LOOKING AT MOVING THAT
BUFFER OUT AN ADDITIONAL HALF
MILE -- WE
ARE BERNIE CHRIS HAVE COME DOWN
IN TIME SO THAT BE A TWO MILE
RADIUS.
HAVE COME DOWN WE HAVE AN
INCENTIVE PROGRAM EMISSION
REDUCTION RED CREDIT PROGRAM.
THAT HAS IT IS WORKING AND I
BIRDS HAVE COME DOWN IN A GREAT
SIZE.
HOWEVER IT'S JUST IN THIS DAY
AND AGE I EVEN THOUGH IT'S LEGAL
OF THE AVAILABLE AND IT'S RIGHT.
IT'S THE IT'S HARD TO PUBLICLY
DEFEND AG BURNING --
OUT OUT THERE WHEN THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS ARE.
CALLING IT OUT. FOR ASTHMA
PURPOSES FOR HEALTH PURPOSES
SOMETIMES IT'S SIMPLY VISUAL
PURPOSES.
AND WE DO HAVE PEOPLE THAT ABUSE
THE COMPLAINTS SOMETIMES THEY
EVEN CIRCUMVENT OUR LOCAL.
OFFICE AND CALL STRAIGHT TO THE
CARDBOARD AND WE'VE BEEN.
ON IT TO TO MAKE RESPONSES TO
EACH AND EVERYONE OF THOSE AND
THE LAST TWO YEARS.
QUESTION IF YOU HAD A A
PERCENTAGE THAT YOU COULD TO PUT
FORWARD TO SAY.
DURING THE EXT PERIOD OF TIME TO
PRESS REDUCTION IN NEXT PERCENT
OF THE LEGAL BURNS AND EVEN FOR
THAT MATTER THE NEED.
FOR LEGAL BURNS WOULD YOU HAVE A
NUMBER THAT YOU COULD.
PUT FORWARD OR IS THAT SOMETHING
MAYBE THAT WE HAVE A GRAPH PUT
TOGETHER AT THE DEPARTMENT THAT
SHOWS THE BURNS OVER THE LAST
TEN YEARS THE NUMBER OF ACRES OF
BURNED WE HAVE TWO DIFFERENT
CROPS THAT ARE SEASONALLY BURNED
BERMUDA GRASS AND AND WHEAT
STRAW.
AND THOSE HAVE SIGNIFICANTLY
COME DOWN IN NUMBERS AS A
CULTURAL PRACTICES IN THE
TRADITIONS OF THOSE FARMERS.
AND FAMILIES A NEW GENERATIONS
OF COME ALONG OR PERHAPS THE
MARKET PRICE OUR DEMAND FOR
WHEAT HAS.
HAS HAS GONE DOWN BUT IT DOES
SPIKE PERIODICALLY I DON'T HAVE
THOSE NUMBERS OFF HAND BUT I
WILL SEND YOU THAT CRAFTED AT
THE TELEGRAPH IT'S ON OUR
WEBSITE. TO YOU --
EDWARD.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I THANK YOU BOTH VERY
MUCH FOR BEING HERE SAY SOME.
REMARKS AT THE EVENT WERE WERE
WERE DONE WITH THAT TESTIMONY
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR COMING.
OKAY NEXT FOR BRINGING UP --
THE SOUTH COAST AIR QUALITY
MANAGEMENT DISTRICT --
AND WE'RE GOING TO BE HEARING
FROM REPRESENTATIVES FROM
WILMINGTON WEST LONG BEACH
CARSON IN EAST LOS ANGELES BOYLE
HEIGHTS COMMERCE AND SAND.
PORTANTINO AND WITH SQUARE --
SO FROM SOUTH THREE THE
EXECUTIVE OFFICER PHILLIP FINE
DEPUTY EXECUTIVE OFFICER.
JOE OKAY GOSH HEALTH EFFECTS
OFFICER.
AND THEN WE HAVE FROM SEAL CV --
CALIFORNIA VOICES PROGRAM FROM
SAM READY NO MATTER OUR BROCK
MACIAS --
MARC LOPEZ IS HERE FROM EAST
YORK COMMUNITIES FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE FROM
COMMERCE AND JESSE MARK HAS FROM
THE COALITION FOR SAFER
ENVIRONMENT FROM WILMINGTON.
THANK YOU ALL FOR BEING HERE
WE'RE GOING TO BE HEARING FROM.
A SOUTH COAST UP.
FIRST BEFORE THE COMMUNITY
REPRESENTATIVES.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
WAYNE ASTRI I'M THE EXECUTIVE
OFFICER. FOR THE SOUTH COAST AIR
QUALITY MANAGEMENT DISTRICT.
WE'RE HERE TODAY TO REPORT ON
THE STATUS.
OF AB SIX SEVENTEEN
IMPLEMENTATION IN THE SOUTH
COAST REGION.
AND LIKE MY COLLEAGUE JACK
BROADBAND.
ECHO IN THE FACT THAT --
WE BELIEVE THAT WE ARE MAKING UP
ARE ALREADY ACHIEVING EMISSION
REDUCTIONS IN THE COMMUNITY.
AND THAT WE WERE ABLE TO BRING.
EARLY --
EMISSION REDUCTIONS THROUGH
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE INCENTIVE
PROJECTS.
I'D LIKE TO NOTE THAT SOUTH
COAST AIR QUALITY MANAGEMENT
DISTRICT.
ACTUALLY HAS EXTENSIVE
EXPERIENCE WORKING IN
COMMUNITIES.
OF BOTH THROUGH OUR CLEAN
COMMUNITIES PROGRAM WORKING ALSO
WITH THE TARGET ERROR SHOULD
GRANTS FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT --
IN AREAS INCLUDING.
BOYLE HEIGHTS AND SAN BERNADINO.
THE FOCUS OF THE INCENTIVE
PROJECT HAS BEEN ON ACHIEVING
THE EMISSION REDUCTIONS THROUGH
PRIMARILY REPLACEMENT OF HEAVY
DUTY TRUCK ENGINES.
AND SO WE UTILIZE THE FUNDS THAT
ARE AVAILABLE THROUGH THE CAR
LAWYER PROGRAM.
AS WELL AS YOU AB ONE THIRTY
FOUR IN ADDITION TO THE HEAVY
DUTY TRUCK ENGINES.
WE ALSO LOOK AT OFF ROAD ENGINES
A MARINE ENGINES.
AND OTHERS.
I WOULD SAY THAT ASA RESULT OF
AB SIX SEVENTEEN BE REALLY TRIED
TO ENHANCE.
THE AWARENESS THROUGH CARL MOYER
AND I WOULD SAY THAT AS A DIRECT
RESULT OF AB SIX SEVENTEEN WE'VE
ALREADY SEEN A THREE FOLD
RESPONSE. TO SOLICITATIONS
THROUGH THE CAR MORE PROGRAM.
WE'VE ALSO EMBARKED ON AN
EXTENSIVE REVIEW OF COMMUNITIES
AS A RB DESCRIBE --
WE LOOKED AT ALMOST A HUNDRED
DIFFERENT COMMUNITIES LOOKED AT
A VARIETY OF DIFFERENT FACTORS.
INCLUDING PROXIMITY OF SOURCES
TO UTILIZING CAL ENVIRO SCREEN
LOOKING AT THE RELATIONSHIP OF
SOURCES TO A SPECIAL.
OF POPULATIONS.
AND SO THERE WAS A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT ACTIONS THAT WE DID
AND FINALLY ON THE PARK RULES
UPDATE.
REMOVING VERY AGGRESSIVELY TO OF
PHASE OUT REKLAME AND INSTITUTE
A NUMBER OF THE BAR CONTROLS.
SO WITH THAT --
AS I MENTIONED WE'VE ALREADY
ALLOCATED OVER ONE HUNDRED AND
ONE MILLION DOLLARS IN PROJECTS.
TO REDUCE DIESEL EMISSIONS
PRIMARILY.
AND AS WE KNOW IT NEARLY 90% OF
THOSE FUNDS HAVE BEEN AND
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES.
AND THIRTY MILLION OF THOSE
FUNDS HAVE BEEN IN AB SIX
SEVENTEEN COMMUNITIES.
AND THIS IS IMPORTANT TO NOTE
BECAUSE THE FIRST YEAR OF
FUNDING WAS REALLY DONE BEFORE
THE IDENTIFICATION OF THE SIX
SEVENTEEN COMMUNITIES.
AND THAT GETS TO THE ABILITY OF
THE SOUTH COAST AIR QUALITY
MANAGEMENT DISTRICT.
BECAUSE IT HAS BEEN IN NON
ATTAINMENT STATUS FOR SO LONG
IT'S DEVELOPED AIR QUALITY
MANAGEMENT PLANS AND THOSE AIR
QUALITY MANAGEMENT PLANS.
OR THE BLUEPRINT FOR HOW WE HOPE
TO COME INTO ATTAINMENT.
ANNA DESCRIBES IN A WAY THAT.
THE FACT THAT WE NOW KNOW WE
HAVE THE TECHNOLOGY WE KNOW THAT
WE CAN REDUCE CRITERIA
POLLUTANTS AND WE KNOW THAT IT'S
EXPENSIVE.
AND SO THE CHALLENGE IS HOW DO
WE HAVE THE FUNDS AVAILABLE AND
MAXIMIZE THE EMISSION REDUCTIONS.
IN THOSE COMMUNITIES ESPECIALLY
THOSE COMMUNITIES WHERE THEY
HAVEN'T TO PERHAPS ENJOYED THE
BENEFITS OF THAT WE'VE SEEN
THROUGH.
A GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSION
REDUCTIONS IN CLIMATE
INVESTMENTS.
AND SO WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE CAN ADDRESS THOSE PARTICULAR
ASPECTS.
AS HAS BEEN MENTIONED WITHIN THE
SOUTH COAST AIR QUALITY
MANAGEMENT DISTRICT WE HAVE
THREE COMMUNITIES.
WE HAVE ROAMING TEN CARS IN WEST
LONG BEACH.
WE ALSO HAVE SAN BERNADINO AND
MY SCHOOL LIKE.
AND THEN WE HAVE THE BOYLE
HEIGHTS IS LOS ANGELES WEST
COMMERCE.
THIS IS UNIQUE IN THE SENSE THAT
IT'S REALLY MUCH MORE THAN JUST
ONE COMMUNITY IT'S A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT COMMUNITIES.
AND WE FELT THAT FROM A REGIONAL
PERSPECTIVE.
OF THAT NATURE OF THE SOURCES OF
THE GOODS MOVEMENT ASPECT.
THAT IT WAS MUCH PREFERABLE FOR
US TO SORT OF TAKE A LARGER.
VIEW IF YOU WILL OF THESE
COMMUNITIES AND WE WANT TO TRY
TO MAXIMIZE THE RESULTS WITHIN
THOSE COMMUNITIES.
SO THAT'S WHY YOU SORT OF SEE
THAT IT'S NOT JUST ONE
PARTICULAR COMMUNITY.
BUT RATHER A SIMULATION OF A
MULTIPLE COMMUNITIES CITIES
LOCALITIES AROUND THAT AREA
[inaudible]
AND SO.
I'M GOING TO TURN IT OVER TO DR
GOSH -- TO
DESCRIBE ABOUT THE ACTUAL
EFFORTS THAT WE'VE BEEN LEADING
ON THE GROUND.
THANK YOU --
SO LATE LAST YEAR AFTER THE
CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES BOARD
DESIGNATED THAT THE THREE A YEAR
ONE EIGHTY SIX SEVENTEEN
COMMUNITIES IN OUR DISTRICT WE
FORMED A COMMUNITY STEERING
COMMITTEES FOR EACH OF THESE
COMMUNITIES.
THE PURPOSE OF THESE COMMITTEES --
WAS TO HELP US IDENTIFY AND
PRIORITIZE THE LOCAL AIR
POLLUTION ISSUES AND HELP GUIDE
THE STRATEGIES THAT WILL BE
WRITTEN INTO THE COMMUNITY PLANS.
OF THE MEMBERS RAP VERY OF A
VERY DIVERSE --
SET OF OF AFFILIATIONS --
THEY ARE ALL --
MAJORITY RESIDENTS --
COMMITTEES BUT ALSO INCLUDES --
COMMUNITY ORGANIZATION LOCAL
BUSINESSES AND LABOR UNIONS
UNIONS REPRESENTING LOCAL
WORKERS --
WE ACTUALLY WORKED REALLY HARD
TO ENGAGE LAND USE AGENCIES AND
WE DO HAVE A LAND USE H.
AGENCIES REPRESENTED ON ALL
THREE OF OUR STEERING COMMITTEES --
WE HAVE A AND WE HAVE OTHER --
REPRESENTATIVES AS AS WELL.
THIS IS A ROUGHLY THE TIMELINE
THAT THE STEERING COMMITTEES I
HAVE BEEN FOLLOWING SO WE FIRST
STARTED BY IDENTIFYING THE
COMMUNITY AIR QUALITY CONCERNS
ARE NOT JUST WITH THE COMMUNITY
STEERING COMMITTEE MEMBERS --
THEMSELVES BUT ALSO WITH MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC WHO ATTENDED WHO
ATTEND OUR MEETINGS --
WE THEN WENT THROUGH A
PRIORITIZATION PROCESS WITH ALL
THREE OF OUR COMMUNITIES TO HELP --
IDENTIFY WHICH OF THESE --
AIR QUALITY CONCERNS REALLY ROSE
TO THE TOP IN TERMS OF WHAT --
THESE COMMUNITIES WANTED TO
ADDRESS THREE A AND FINALLY WE
ARE BEGINNING THE PROCESS TO
DEVELOP THE MEASURES AND THE
SPECIFIC ACTIONS THAT WILL BE
WRITING INTO --
INTO THESE PLANS.
I WANTED TO SHARE WITH YOU A FEW
OF THE NUMBERS SO --
ACROSS THE THREE COMMITTEES WE
HAVE APPROXIMATELY A HUNDRED
FORTY A STEERING COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AND ALTERNATES US SO FAR
WE'VE HELPED THIRTEEN COMMUNITY
MEETINGS.
ALL THE MEETINGS HAVE BEEN TO A
VERY VERY WELL ATTENDED --
BOTH BY THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS AS
WELL AS BY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
EYE AND ALL MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC ARE CERTAINLY WELCOME --
TO TO ATTEND AND PARTICIPATE IN
OUR MEETINGS --
WE HAVE TWENTY THREE MORE
MEETING SCHEDULED A ON THE
COMMUNITIES IDENTIFIED OVER TWO
HUNDRED AIR QUALITY CONCERNS.
I WANTED TO GIVE YOU A TASTE OF
WHAT OUR COMMUNITY MEETINGS LOOK
LIKE AND WHAT THE WHAT THEY WHAT
WHAT THEY FEEL LIKE SO --
THE FIRST WE WE TRY --
TO HAVE A AN INTERACTIVE FORMAT
WHENEVER POSSIBLE THE PHOTO IN
THE TOP LEFT SHOWS --
ONE OF OUR SMALL GROUP
DISCUSSIONS WHERE WE HAVE THE
AIR QUALITY ISSUES THAT WERE
IDENTIFIED PRINTED ON THOSE BLUE
CARDS OR DID DIFFERENT CARDS ARE
ON THE TABLE AND THEY'RE SORTING
OUT.
SORTING OUT THE CARDS IN THIS
PRIORITIZATION CONSENSUS
BUILDING ACTIVITY OF THE GRAPHIC
ON THE TOP RIGHT IS ACTUALLY ONE
OF OUR SOCIAL MEDIA POSTS
WHENEVER POSSIBLE WE ACTUALLY
TRY TO WE TRY TO INCLUDE ENGLISH
AND SPANISH ON THE SAME GRAPHIC --
SO THAT THEY ARE INTEGRATED.
BOB WE STEERING COMMITTEE
MEMBERS TO BROADCAST OUR
MEETINGS ON FACEBOOK LIFE TO
HELP ENGAGE A YOUNGER AUDIENCE
PARTICULARLY YOUNGER AUDIENCES
THAT MAY NOT BE ABLE TO ATTEND
OUR MEETINGS IN PERSON.
SO WE'VE BROADCAST ALL OUR
MEETINGS ON FACEBOOK LIFE --
AND FINALLY I JUST JUST WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT THAT ALL MATERIALS ARE
PROVIDED IN ENGLISH AND SPANISH
WE DO PROVIDE SPANISH LANGUAGE
INTERPRETATION AND HAVE ALSO
PROVIDED OTHER LANGUAGES AS WELL --
AND WE DO TRY TO ALSO PROVIDE
REFRESHMENTS WHICH IS ONE OTHER
ONE OF THE I REQUEST --
FROM FROM THESE COMMUNITIES AND
WHEREVER POSSIBLE TRYING --
TO PATRONIZE LOCAL BUSINESSES
THERE.
BUT WE HAVE RECEIVED SOME
POSITIVE FEEDBACK FROM OUR ABOUT
OUR STEERING COMMITTEE MEETINGS --
EIGHT IN PARTICULAR I WANTED TO
HIGHLIGHT THAT.
WE ARE USING A A CO HOST --
AND ALSO AN OUTSIDE FACILITATOR
TO HELP A RUN THESE MEETINGS SO
THE CO HOST IS ACTUALLY ONE OF
THE STEERING COMMITTEE MET UP.
IS ACTUALLY A STEERING COMMITTEE
MEMBER WHO LIVES IN THAT
COMMUNITY WHO SERVES AS THE CO
HOST AND HELPS US RUN THOSE
MEETINGS --
WE TRY VERY HARD TO PRESENT ALL
THE MATERIALS IN PLAIN LANGUAGE
WE'VE ACTUALLY BEEN COMPLIMENTED
ON THIS WHICH IS GREAT --
AND AGAIN YOU KNOW THE THE
SPANISH LANGUAGE MATERIALS WE
ACTUALLY DO HAVE.
A FEW STEERING COMMITTEE MEMBERS
WHO SPEAK ARE PRIMARILY SPANNER
WHO PRIMARILY SPEAK SPANISH AND
SO -- BUT
THEY'VE EXPRESSED --
THAT IN SPANISH.
BUT NOW CERTAINLY A PROGRAM OF
THIS COMPLEXITY.
X. IT CAN COME WITH MANY
CHALLENGES AND AND WE'VE WE'VE
CERTAINLY COME ACROSS A A NUMBER
OF CHALLENGES I WANTED TO
HIGHLIGHT SOME OF THE WAYS THAT
WE'VE WE'VE TRIED TO ADDRESS
THOSE ISSUES THAT HAVE BEEN
BROUGHT UP --
IS SO --
FIRST I THINK TOWARD THE
BEGINNING OF THIS PROCESS THAT
WE HAD A NUMBER OF QUESTIONS
ABOUT THE PURPOSE OF THE
STEERING COMMITTEES AND WHAT
AUTHORITY THEY HAVE --
WHAT FORTY THE COMMITTEES HAD I
DO WANT TO NOTE THAT WE DO HAVE
A COMMITTEE CHARTER US IT THE
CHARTER FOR EACH OF THE CAN A
CHARTER FOR EACH OF THOSE
COMMITTEES --
AT THAT REALLY --
EMPHASIZED WHAT WHAT WHAT IS THE
THE THE KEY ROLE OF OF THE
COMMUNITY STEERING COMMITTEES --
AND HOW THEY WILL PLAY A ROLE IN
HOW THESE PLANS ARE SHAPED BUT
THAT ON EIGHT AS HE CAN DO AND
CARPORTS WILL RETAIN THEIR
AUTHORITY.
WE HAD A COUPLE A STEERING
COMMITTEE MEMBERS RAISE CONCERNS
ABOUT POTENTIAL CONFLICTS OF
INTEREST AMONG MEMBERS OF OF THE
STEERING COMMITTEE AND SO --
I HEY WE EMPHASIZE THE REALLY
THE IMPORTANCE OF OF THAT
TRANSPARENCY AND WE HAVE --
AT THE HAVE ASKED ALL THIS --
FEES ALL ON OUR WEB PAGE AS WELL.
UGH THE COMMUNITY BOUNDARIES WAS
OF IT WAS A BIG TOPIC OF
DISCUSSION AT OUR FIRST COUPLE --
STEERING COMMITTEE MEETINGS FOR
EACH OF THESE COMMUNITIES AND WE
CERTAINLY GOT A LOT OF INPUT AND
WE REALLY WANTED TO DIG INTO THE
THE THE REASONS FOR FOR THAT
THAT SPECIFIC INPUT FOR THAT
SPECIFIC TASK OF CHANGING THE
BOUNDARY IN A CERTAIN AREA TO A
CERTAIN.
A CERTAIN LOCATION AND SO WE WE
WORKED VERY CLOSELY WITH ALL
OVER STEERING COMMITTEE MEMBERS
WHO HAD MADE THIS REQUEST AND
CAME TO A CONSENSUS AGREEMENT
ALL THREE OF THE COMMUNITY
BOUNDARIES HAVE BEEN FINALIZED.
SO -- I
THINK PART OF THE CHARGE OF THIS
PROGRAM WAS TO USE BOTH
TECHNICAL DATA AS WELL AS
COMMUNITY INPUT AND DEVELOPING
THESE PLANS.
AND SO REALLY PART OF THE
CHALLENGE IT IS REALLY TRYING TO
PRESENT A LOT OF THIS TECHNICAL
DATA IN AN ACCESSIBLE WAY THAT
IS UNDERSTANDABLE TO THE PUBLIC --
ONE OF THE TOOLS THAT WE'VE USED --
IS THE THE INTERACTIVE STORY
MAPS WHERE WE PRESENTED
INFORMATION ABOUT THE COMMUNITY
INCLUDING WHAT FACILITIES ARE
LOCATED WHAT TYPES OF FACILITIES
AYE THEY ARE.
LAND USE INFORMATION --
AND WITH LOCATIONS SCHOOLS AND
HOSPITALS AND OTHER A SENSE THE
RECEPTORS --
WE ALSO --
DIGITIZED ALL THE AIR.
AT THAT --
THAT WERE PROVIDED TO US --
SO THE MAP ON THE BOTTOM RIGHT
SHOWS THE EAST LA BOYLE HEIGHTS
THE WEST COMMERCE A COMMUNITY --
WITH THE EACH DOT REPRESENTING A
UNIQUE AIR QUALITY CONCERN --
THAT WAS THAT WAS RAISED BY THE
COMMITTEE OR MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC.
AND A FINAL --
AFTER AFTER THE CONCERNS OR AIR
QUALITY CONCERNS WERE IDENTIFIED
WE DID GO THROUGH A
PRIORITIZATION ACTIVITY WITH ALL
THREE OF OUR COMMUNITY STEERING
COMMITTEES AND I WANTED TO
PRESENT --
THE SOME OF THE HIGHEST PRIORITY
ISSUES THAT WERE IDENTIFIED FOR
EACH OF THESE COMMUNITIES AGAIN
HIGHLIGHTING THAT EACH COMMUNITY
IS UNIQUE AND THEY THAT WE ARE
WORKING HARD TO TAILOR THE PLANS.
TO MEET THE NEEDS OF THESE
COMMUNITIES SO FIRST WHETHER
WILL MEET IN CARSON AND WEST
LONG BEACH COMMUNITIES AGAIN OF
COURSE OUR PORTS JERRY COMMUNITY.
THE THREE HIGHEST PRIORITY
ISSUES THAT WERE IDENTIFIED WERE
REFINERY ADMISSIONS PARTICULARLY
EMISSIONS ARE RELATED TO FLARING
LEAKS AND UP AND SPECIFIC TYPES
OF EQUIPMENT SUCH AS HEATERS AND
BOILERS --
THE PORTS --
PORTS RELATED AND LIKE --
VERTICALLY CONCERT A LOT OF
CONCERNS AROUND I DIESEL
EMISSIONS --
IDLING TRUCKS AND ALSO SHIP
BUT SOME ADDITIONAL HIGH
PRIORITY ISSUES THAT WERE --
THAT THAT WERE RAISED THROUGH
THE PRIORITIZATION PROCESS
INCLUDING OIL AT YOUR INCLUDED
OIL DRILLING AND PRODUCTION RAIL
EMISSIONS AND ALSO --
CONCERNS AROUND SCHOOLS NOT AS A
POLLUTION SOURCE OF COURSE BUT
AS A AS A PLACE WHERE A KID
SPENT A LOT OF TIME.
I NEXT OUR STANDARD YOU KNOW IN
MY SCHOOL --
THIS IS OF COURSE ARE INLAND
EMPIRE COMMUNITY.
AND IN THIS COMMUNITY THERE IS A
MAJOR RAIL YARD --
THE BNSF RAILYARD WHICH WAS
IDENTIFIED AS ONE OF THE HIGHEST
PRIORITY ISSUES BUT IN
PARTICULAR THE NUMBER ONE ISSUE
THE I WOULD SAY THAT REALLY ROSE
TO THE TOP VERY CLEARLY IN THIS
COMMUNITY WAS NEIGHBORHOOD TRUCK
TRAFFIC.
AND PARTICULARLY TRUCK TRAFFIC
RELATED TO WEAR HOUSING --
BUT ALSO RELATED TO THE WHERE TO
THE A RAIL YARD AS WELL --
ADDITIONAL HIGH PRIORITY
CONCERNS INCLUDE THE ON THE
TRANS -- BUS
YARD FACILITY THERE'S ALSO
LOCATED WITHIN THAT COMMUNITY
AND ALSO A COUPLE OF CEMENT
FACILITIES --
IN THAT AREA --
FINALLY OUR EAST LA BOYLE
HEIGHTS IN WEST COMMERCE AGAIN
OF COURSE THIS IS THIS IS --
FAMOUSLY THE THE WHERE THE EAST
LA INTERCHANGE IS LOCATE ALL
SORTS CONCERNS --
BUT NOT SURPRISINGLY THE HIGHS
PRETTY ISSUES INCLUDED NEIGHBOR
TRUCK TRAFFIC --
INCLUDING A TRUCK TRAFFIC ON
FREE WITH THAT ALSO MAJOR
ROADWAYS AND ALSO A TRUCK
TRAFFIC THAT WAS LOCATED VERY
CLOSE TO WHERE PEOPLE LIVE OR
WHERE PEOPLE GO TO SCHOOL --
THERE ARE A THERE WERE CONCERNS
AROUND WAREHOUSES PARTICULARLY
AGAIN TRUCK TRAFFIC RELATED TO
WAREHOUSES AND ALSO CONCERNS ARE
REGARDING --
RAIL YARD EMISSIONS BOTH FROM
LOCOMOTIVES OTHER EQUIPMENT AS
WELL AS THE TRACKS THAT THE THAT
THE RAIL YARD --
SOME ADDITIONAL HIGH PRIORITY
CONCERNS INCLUDED --
THE SCHOOLS IN THE AREA AND ALSO --
MIDDLE FACILITIES AND TOXIC
WASTE FACILITIES.
I WE PRESENTED.
A SUITE OF POTENTIAL STRATEGIES --
THAT WE CAN --
USE IN THE COMMUNITY IN WRITING
THE COMMUNITY PLANS VERTICALLY
FOR THE EMISSION REDUCTION PLANS
BUT I ALSO THE AIR MONITORING
PLANS SO THIS INCLUDES --
DEVELOPING REGULATIONS.
IT OF DIFFERENT INCENTIVE
PROGRAMS USING A MONITORING --
IN A VERY TARGETED FASHION TO
HELP ADDRESS THESE A COMMUNITY
CONCERNS AND IN PARTICULAR --
YOU KNOW WHERE IT WHERE IT MAKES
WORK TO ATTRIBUTE TO TO FOLLOW
UP ON ANY THAT FOLLOW UP ON THE
RESULTS OF MONITORING WITH
ENHANCED ENFORCEMENT --
WE'VE ALSO DISCUSSED THE
DIFFERENT TYPES OF OUTREACH
PROGRAMS THAT CAN BE INTEGRATED
AS PART OF THESE PLANS --
A WE ARE TRYING TO ACTIVELY
COLLABORATE WITH A VARIETY OF
OTHER AGENCIES INCLUDING PUBLIC
HEALTH AGENCIES AND LAND USE
AGENCIES AND FINALLY WERE
CERTAINLY ALSO CONSIDERING --
EXPOSURE REDUCTION STRATEGIES AS
WELL.
WHAT ARE THE THINGS THAT WE'RE
DISCUSSING IN OUR US DURING
COMMITTEE MEETINGS IS REALLY HOW
TO INTEGRATE THESE DIFFERENT
TYPES OF STRATEGIES SO JUST AS
AN EXAMPLE OUT OF THE DIESEL
TRUCK EMISSIONS CAME UP AS A
HIGH PRIORITY IN ALL THREE OF
OUR COMMUNITIES?
AND ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE
CAN DO IS USE MONITORING OR
OTHER DATA TO IDENTIFY WHICH
TRUCKS ARE THE FREQUENT FLYERS
IN THAT IN THAT COMMUNITY.
AND FROM THERE WE CAN ACTUALLY
HELP TARGET OUR INCENTIVE SO
THAT WE GET THE MORE GET MORE
BANG FOR OUR BUCK.
WE'VE ALSO --
HEARD A LOT ABOUT UP A TRUCK
IDLING TRUCK IDLING LOCATIONS
AND WE CAN.
WE CAN USE OUR TARGET
ENFORCEMENT SWEEPS TO HELP
ADDRESS THOSE ISSUES AND ALSO
WE'VE REACHED OUT TO OUR LAND
USE AGENCIES TO SEE WHAT WE CAN
DO A COLLABORATIVELY WITH REGARD
TO TRUCK ROUTES AND TRAFFIC
SIGNAL TIMING.
I WITHOUT GOING TO HEAD OFF TO
DR PHIL FIND TO TALK ABOUT OUR
PARK REAL DEVELOPMENT.
THANK YOU DOCTOR GOSH --
PHILIP FIND UP THE EXECUTIVE
OFFICER AT SOUTH COAST FOR
PLANNING AND WILL DEVELOPMENT
AND IF I TALK VERY BRIEFLY ABOUT
THE A. B. SIX SEVENTEEN
REQUIREMENT FOR THE BEST
AVAILABLE RETROFIT CONTROL
TECHNOLOGY --
FOR THE SOUTH COAST THAT
REQUIREMENT TOOK ON NEW MEANING
BECAUSE FOR MANY YEARS WE HAD
OUR RECLAIM PROGRAM.
WHICH WAS A CAP AND TRADE
PROGRAM --
FOR NOT NITROGEN OXIDE IN A SELF
RESOURCES.
ARE BOARD HAD ALREADY.
ADOPTED A PLAN TO A SENSE THAT
THAT PROGRAM BUT WHAT AB SIX
SEVENTEEN DID IS REALLY LIGHT A
FIRE UNDER OUR EFFORTS WITH THE
DEADLINE --
AT THE END OF TWENTY TWENTY
THREE TO IMPLEMENT PARKED --
IN OUR REGION SO WHAT TYPICALLY
WE WOULD --
AMEND WE CLAIM EVERY FIVE YEARS
OR WORK ON PARK TOOLS FOR NON WE
CLAIM SOURCES MAYBE ONE OR TWO A
YEAR AS YOU CAN SEE HERE.
WE HAVE REALLY GONE INTO
OVERDRIVE AND ARE WORKING ON A A
ABOUT A DOZEN RULES IN PARALLEL
TO IMPLEMENT BARKING EXCEPT ARE
EX WE CLAIM FACILITIES AS A
COMMODITY CLAIM.
IT'S A COMPLEX PROCESS IT'S A
COMPLEX PROGRAM --
WE'VE ALREADY ADOPTED A SERIES
OF THREE RULES ACTUALLY ONE WAS
ACTUALLY THREE RULES.
SO -- THREE
WILL TO ADOPTED ALREADY AND THEN
COMING UP THIS YEAR WE HAVE A
WHOLE SERIES OF RULES THAT WE
THINK WE CAN GET TO IN.
TWENTY NINETEEN AND THEN A FEW
MORE IN TWENTY TWENTY TO REALLY.
TO REALLY REQUIRE --
BARKED AT THESE FACILITIES THE
CAP.
BARKED EQUIPMENT REDUCTIONS BUT
IT DIDN'T ENSURE THAT PARTICULAR
PIECE OF EQUIPMENT IN A
PARTICULAR COMMUNITY WAS GOING
TO HAVE --
THE BEST AVAILABLE CONTROLS AND
GOING FORWARD UNDER THIS COMMAND
CONTROL STRUCTURE THAT WILL BE
THE CASE.
I'LL TURN IT BACK OVER --
TO MISTER NASTY FOR THE FINAL
SLIDE.
THANKS TALK TO FIND.
SO AS WE MOVE FORWARD --
I CERTAINLY WANT TO ECHO THE
COMMENTS THAT BAY AREA MADE WITH
REGARDS TO THE LIMITED AUTHORITY --
WITH REGARDS TO AS YOU KNOW
DISTRICTS HAVE PRIMARY AUTHORITY
OVER STATIONARY SOURCES.
WELL WE CAN UTILIZE SOME OF
CARBS ENFORCEMENT AUTHORITY
PARTICULARLY WHEN IT COMES.
TO A TRUCK ANTI IDLING EFFORTS.
YOU KNOW WE CERTAINLY WOULD LIKE
TO DO MORE AND WE'RE CERTAINLY
IN DISCUSSIONS WE WANT TO
EXPLORE.
HOW WE COULD SEE MORE ENHANCED
ON ROAD TESTING WE WANT TO SEE
HOW WE CAN LOOK AT SOME OF THE
OTHER LARGER SOURCES?
WHICH AS WE KNOW OF WITH THE
PORT COMPLEX.
WE HAVE THE LARGEST
CONTAINERIZED PART COMP AND IT'S
THE ONLY SOURCE OF KNOCKS IT'S
GOING TO BE GROWING OVER THE
NEXT SEVERAL YEARS.
SO WE HAVE TO IDENTIFY WAYS TO
REDUCE.
THOSE OCEAN GOING VESSELS IN
ORDER.
TO REDUCE EMISSIONS IN THE PORT
AREA AND MORE IMPORTANTLY TO
REDUCE EMISSIONS TO ACHIEVE.
ATTAINMENT.
WE ALSO FACE WITH THAT PERSONNEL
CHALLENGES MANY OF THE DISTRICTS --
AND AGENCIES ARE FACED WITH THE
LARGE NUMBER OF RETIREMENTS AND
SO WE'RE ALL COMPETING FOR THE
SAME PERSONNEL PULL TO HIRE
PEOPLE SO THAT WE CAN MOVE MORE
QUICKLY.
THE OTHER ASPECT IS THE NEW
TECHNOLOGY THAT'S OFTEN
NECESSARY. TO DISPLACE THE OLDER
TECHNOLOGY IS FAIRLY EXPENSIVE.
AND THE CHALLENGE THAT WE HAVE
BEEN ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE
HEAR.
A QUITE OFTEN IS THAT WE WANT TO
PURSUE ZERO EMISSION TECHNOLOGY.
YET HOW CAN WE GO FOUR ZERO
EMISSION TECHNOLOGY IF WE DON'T
NECESSARILY HAVE THE FUNDS AND
IS THE TECHNOLOGY ITSELF READY
THESE ARE QUESTIONS THAT.
WE ASK OURSELVES WE CERTAINLY
AGREE WITH THE TECHNOLOGY IS
READY CAN BE DEPLOYED IN CAN BE
SUPPORTED IT SHOULD BE.
WORD ISN'T CAN WE GET EMISSION
REDUCTIONS THROUGH OTHER MEANS I
THINK THOSE ARE PART OF THE
CHALLENGES THAT WE HAVE COMING A
HEAD.
AS WELL AS THE OVERALL TIMING.
MOVING FOR A IN A WAY THAT ALSO
HAS EXTENSIVE PUBLIC PROCESS
SOMETIMES THE TWO AREN'T --
COMPATIBLE AND IN ORDER TO HAVE
A BETTER.
PUBLIC DISCOURSE WE MAY NEED A
LITTLE BIT MORE TIME.
AND WE'VE ALSO HEARD THAT THAT
IN SOME OF THE DISTRICTS THEY
ACTUALLY ADVOCATE FOR INCREASED
TIME.
WE CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND AND
APPRECIATE THAT DESIRE BUT WE
ALSO UNDERSTAND THE DESIRE THAT.
TIME IS OF THE ESSENCE FOR FAR
TOO LONG COMMUNITIES HAVE BEEN
SUFFERING AND WE NEED TO MOVE AS
QUICKLY AS WE CAN.
THESE ARE SOME OF THE CHALLENGES
THAT WE SEE MOVING HAD AND WITH
THAT I'LL CONCLUDE MY COMMENTS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HELLO I'M NOT A BLACKSMITH C. S.
AND I AM JUST HELPING THE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS EDUCATION
FUND COVER WHAT'S PROGRAM HERE
TODAY REPRESENTING THE SAN
MEDINA AND MISS KHïI
COMMUNITIES ANY FIGHT BEGAN
OFFICIALLY MY STATEMENT.
I DO WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
ALTHOUGH THE THREE OF US ARE MEN
IN MY COMEY TO SPECIFIC
SPECIFICALLY IT'S A LOT OF WOMEN
AND THOSE WHO IDENTIFY OTHER
THAN SAYS MEN ARE REALLY HOLDING
IT DOWN.
AND LEADING ORGANIZING EFFORTS I
DO WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE THEM IN A
STATEMENT TODAY IS IN
COLLABORATION WITH THEM.
ROM SO THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR FOR
HAVING HEARING TODAY.
AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER RACE WHO
INVITED ME TO COME ON BEHALF OF
OUR COMMUNITY --
SO TODAY WE'RE HERE TO HELP
ANSWER THE QUESTION BERMAN
TATIAN OF A. B. SIX SEVENTEEN
OUR AIR BE AND THE AIR DISTRICTS
ON TRACK TO DELIVER EMISSIONS
REDUCTIONS TO CALIFORNIA'S MOST
POLLUTION BURN COMMUNITIES.
AB SIX SEVENTEEN IMPLEMENTATIONS
ON TRACK I HAVE AN ANSWER FOR
THAT.
BUT FIRST I FEEL WE MUST ASK
BEFORE ASKING THE RIGHT
QUESTIONS.
I KNOW FIRST TACKLE THE QUESTION
BY REMOVING THE AB SIX SEVENTEEN
LEAD.
WHAT I WANNA KNOW?
IS WHERE IS THE HEARING.
ON IS CALIFORNIA STATE
LEGISLATURE ON TRACK TO DELIVER
EMISSIONS REDUCTIONS
CALIFORNIA'S MOST POLLUTION
BRING COMMUNITIES.
I'D LOVE TO COME BACK FOR THAT
HEARING.
BUT ON A SERIOUS NOW.
WE ARE ASKING US TO DO TODAY IS
TO TELL YOU ABOUT A PROGRAM THAT
EXIST.
AND CERTAINLY SINCE IT DOES
EXIST THE COMMITMENT THAT THE
STATE HAS MADE MUST BE FULFILLED.
BUT THAT DOESN'T REALLY TRULY
GETS THROUGH THE ISSUE RIGHT AND
I THINK WE NEED TO REMEMBER AB
SIX SEVENTEEN HAS A CONTEXT IN
WHICH IT EXIST --
BECAME ABOUT AS AT COMPROMISED.
AND AB THREE NINETY IS THE CAP
AND TRADE EXTENSION ARE
MECHANISM IN THE STATE TO REDUCE
EMISSIONS BUT IT'S PROVEN OVER
AND OVER AGAIN.
NOT TO WORK TO REDUCE EMISSIONS
IN OUR COMMUNITIES.
AND NOR THE STATE NOW OUR RATE
OF REDUCTIONS HAD INVERTED.
AND WE'RE NOT ON TRACK TO MEET
TARGETS.
ALSO WE KNOW WILD FIRES ARE
GOING TO CONTINUE TO JEOPARDIZE
NOT ONLY OUR LIVES.
BUT OUR ABILITY TO MEET
EMISSIONS REDUCTIONS EVERYTHING
WE'VE MITIGATED I RACED BY
WILDFIRES THEN THERE WAS THE
LITTLE NOT SO LITTLE REPORT THAT
CAME OUT LAST FALL WHICH
REMINDED US.
OUR TIMELINE TO SOLVE THIS
PROBLEM IS MUCH CLOSER THAN IT
APPEARED.
KIND OF LIKE A REAR VIEW MIRROR
IN A CAR.
BUT UNLIKE REVIEW MEARS WE CAN'T
LOOK BACKWARDS EVER GOING TO GET
THE REDUCTIONS IN OUR
COMMUNITIES AND STATE.
THE POINT WE NEED MORE
AGGRESSIVE NOT ACTION NOW.
I KNOW THIS IS NOT NEWS TO ANY
OF YOU ARE COMMUNITIES AND ARE
YOU TO ADVOCATES HAVE BEEN
BEATING THIS TRAUMA ALL ALONG.
AND EVEN TO THE MEMBERS IN THIS
COMMITTEE ALTHOUGH THEY'RE NOT
PRESENT TODAY.
DO NOT SUPPORT THE FALSE PREMISE
THAT WITHOUT CAP AND TRADE WE
HAVE NO PROGRAM FOR THE STATE
THAT'S SUPPOSED TO BE THE
NATIONAL MAY BE EVEN GLOBAL
LEADER ON CLIMATE SOLUTIONS THAT
ALSO ENCOURAGES ECONOMIC GROWTH --
I WAS GOING TO REACH OF THEIR
STATEMENTS TO NOT SUPPORT AB --
THREE NINETY EIGHT BECAUSE THEY
KNEW THAT IT WAS NOT IT SAYS BUT
I'LL JUST SUMMARIZE WITH --
ONE THERE WERE SOME MEMBER MARK
STONE AND SOMEWHERE MONIQUE
LIMON FOR REFERENCE --
OUTSTRIP I'LL JUST READ THEIR
WANT ONE SENTENCE FROM ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LEGAL STATEMENT HE SAID.
I LOOK FOR EVIDENCE OF THE CAP
AND TRADE MECHANISM WHAT
IMPLEMENTATION MONITORING AND
REGULATORY POLICIES IN PLACE TO
ACHIEVE SIGNIFICANT
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPROVEMENT.
BUT THE BILL FELL SHORT OF
PROVIDING SUCH EVIDENCE.
AND TO THE OTHER COMMITTEE
MEMBERS I UNDERSTAND THE
PREDICAMENT YOU WERE IN AT THE
TIME -- AND
I WORK FOR AN ORGANIZATION THAT
ALSO AT THE TIME UNFORTUNATELY
MADE THE SAME DECISION TO
SUPPORT THIS PACKAGE OF BILLS AT
THIS.
AND I KNOW VERY MUCH THAT YOU
ALL AGREE WITH ME WITH WHAT I'M
SAYING RIGHT NOW AND ARE LOOKING
FOR THE RIGHT AND BEST THING TO
DO.
AND ARE READY TO TAKE BOLD
ACTION TO MEET THE CHALLENGE OF
RADICAL REDUCTION OF THE
MISSIONS IN THE NEXT DECADE TO
KEEP THEM WARMING BELOW TWO
DEGREES CELSIUS AND WHO BELIEVE
IN THE INGENUITY OF CALIFORNIANS
TO SOLVE THIS CRISIS.
AN INTERSECTIONAL WAY.
THAT CREATES EQUITABLE OUTCOMES
FOR ALL IN CHANGES WHAT IS
POSSIBLE FOR OUR STATE.
WHAT I CAN SAY ABOUT HOW THEY
RELEASED AB SIX SEVENTEEN IS
THIS AT THE POLICY WITH THE
COMPROMISE IT'S ONE THAT I DON'T
BELIEVE WILL MAKE A REAL OR
SIGNIFICANT DIFFERENCE FOR
DELIVER IN EMISSIONS REDUCTIONS?
CRITERIA POLLUTANT REDUCTIONS OR
TOXIC AIR CONTAMINANT REDUCTION
AND I'LL GET MORE INTO WHITE
SHORTLY.
I DO THINK HOWEVER YOU AT THE
BODY.
HAVE THE ABILITY TO CORRECT THAT
[inaudible] FOR ONE BEAR THAT
NO LONGER IS IN PLACE.
GOVERNOR JERRY BROWN.
AND WHILE I'M STILL WAITING TO
SEE WHAT GOVERNOR GAVIN NEWSOM'S
POLICY POSITION IDEAS ON CLIMATE
WILL LOOK LIKE BECAUSE I PERSON
TALKING SUPPORT BUT NO CLEAR
AGENDA YET ALTHOUGH I SHOULD
NOTE A BRIGHT SPOT THE NEW HELP
THE P. H. CHIEF STATED THAT
CRITTER POLLUTANTS.
WILL --
BECOME A PRIORITY --
I THINK WE CAN AGREE THAT MAYBE
PEOPLE THOUGHT THAT THAT WAS THE
BEST DECISION AT THE TIME.
BUT WE NOW NO LONGER IS NOW.
NOW TO ANSWER TO THE SPIRIT OF
THE QUESTION AROUND.
EIGHTY SIX SEVENTEEN WHICH IS
NOW A REALITY.
BY ALL MEANS IT WAS IMPAIRED
IT'S IMPERATIVE WE DIRECT EIGHTY
SIX SEVENTEEN TO A TANGIBLE
SUCCESS FAR COMMUNITIES.
BECAUSE IT STANDS AS THE ONLY
REAL STATEWIDE EMISSIONS
REDUCTION STUDY THAT ATTEMPTS TO
ADDRESS POLLUTANTS AND SOURCES
IN COMMUNITIES LIKE SALMON
ENORMOUS KHïI. TO TELL YOU A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT FAMILY DRAMA
SCHOOL WAY.
IT'S ONE TOP BY CENSUS TRACT
COMMUNITIES FROM CALAVERAS
SCREEN.
IT'S LOW INCOME.
IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES OF COLOR.
WE HAVE KIDS GOING TO SCHOOL
BETWEEN THE B. NSL FELL YARDS
HIGH TRAFFIC TRUCK ROUTES GOING
TO AND FROM WHERE HOUSING.
AND NATURAL GAS PIPES AND TANKS
THAT HAVE LEAKED.
AND LIKE WHAT JUST HAPPENED OVER
THE WEEKEND WICKS BUT 40% OF ALL
GETS THE REST OF THE UNITED
STATES COMES TO OUR BACKYARDS.
IMAGINE ALL THAT TRUCK TRAFFIC
JUST TAKE A SECOND TO IMAGINE
ONE HUNDRED DIESEL TRUCKS PER
HOUR COMING DOWN YOUR STREET.
HOW THAT BILL?
UNDOUBTEDLY THE NEED TO ADDRESS
GREAT HERE POLLUTANTS IN
EMISSIONS IN OUR COMMUNITY IS SO --
DE OVER THE YEARS THEY HAVE BEEN
SO MANY PLANS BUT VERY LITTLE
CHANGE.
SOME OF THE MOST COMMON
CHALLENGES THESE PLANS HAVE FACE
ARE ALSO TRIP AB.
SEVEN SIX SEVENTEEN FIRST WE
MUST DISCUSS ENFORCEMENT.
MANY PEOPLE IN OUR COMMUNITY
HAVE EXPRESSED CONCERN THAT WE
ARE ASKING FOR COMMUNITIES TO
GET THEIR HOPES UP FOR ANOTHER
PROGRAM PROMISING IMPROVEMENT.
ONE OF THE REASONS OUR COMMUNITY
REMAINS IN NON ATTAINMENT
COMMUNITY FOR CRITERIA
POLLUTANTS IS BECAUSE WE'RE NOT
ENFORCING WHAT'S ALREADY IN
PLACE.
ALSO THERE'S NO LANGUAGE IN THE
BILL THAT I COULD IDENTIFY THAT
DISCUSSES REPERCUSSIONS TO CARP
HM DE FOR NOT REACHING THE GOALS
OF THE PROGRAM.
SHARE AN ORGANIZATION CAN GO
THROUGH A LEGAL PROCESS TO
ENFORCE THE PLAN BUT NOT PUTS
ADDITIONAL BURDEN ON OUR
COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS ARE
ALREADY PUTTING OUT FIRES IN OUR
COMMUNITIES.
LITERALLY TO APPARENTLY.
THE STATE NEEDS TO FIND BETTER
MEANS TO ENFORCE IMPLEMENTATION
OF THE REDUCTION PLANS.
WHERE FREIGHT WILL COME UP WITH
THE PLAN BUT THERE WILL BE A
LACK OF ACCOUNTABILITY TO
ENFORCE THE PLAN AND ENFORCE
COMPLIANCE FROM THE SOURCES? ONE
WAY THE SENTIMENT HAVE ALREADY
ARISEN HAS BEEN FROM THE TYPE OF
MONITORING THE DISTRICT IS
LOOKING TO USE.
AIR MONITORS THAT ARE PLANNED TO
BE YOU IT ENOUGH TO DETERMINE
COMPLIANCE SO THEREFORE SOURCES
OF POLLUTANTS CAN'T BE SUBJECTED
TO ENFORCEMENT BASED ON MOST OF
THE MONITORING BEING FUNDED IN
THE PROGRAM.
THAT DOESN'T SEEM RIGHT TO ME.
BECAUSE IF WE'RE GOING TO SPEND
MONEY ON THE PROGRAM THAT WE
SHOULD DO IT RIGHT AND MAKE SURE
WE HAVE THE BEST AVAILABLE
MONITORING.
THAT WILL ALSO ALLOW ENFORCEMENT
OF SOURCES.
OF FORT UNFORTUNATELY THAT LEADS
TO THE SECOND CHALLENGE.
THE FUNDING COMMITTED IS NOT
SUFFICIENT TO IMPLEMENT THE
PROGRAM AS BEST AS POSSIBLE.
I DO WISH TO RECOMMEND EIGHTY
SIX SEVENTEEN FOR INCREASED
FUNDING IN THE PROPOSED BUDGET --
I THINK THE STATE HAS MADE MANY
COMMITMENTS TO DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE ON TO FILL
PROMISES.
DON'T MAKE THIS ANOTHER.
ONE BEFORE WE CAN EVEN BEGIN TO
THINK ABOUT YOUR TO COMMUNITIES
WE NEED A PROGRAM THAT'S PROVEN
EFFECTIVE I THINK THE
LEGISLATURE TO THE BUDGET NEEDS
TO MAINTAIN COMMITMENT TO YOUR
ONE COMMUNITIES.
ALSO THE NEED FOR DRESSING
POLLUTANTS IN EMISSIONS IS SO
VAST WE SHOULD CONTINUE TO
EXPAND THE PROGRAM TO MORE
COMMUNITIES.
BUT WHAT WE DON'T NEED IS THE
STATE TO THROW MONEY AND FINDING
A WAY TO A PROGRAM THAT DOESN'T
ACTUALLY ACHIEVE ENFORCEABLE
REDUCTIONS.
WE NEED TO GET SET COMPLIANCE
WE'VE BEEN OUT OF A COMPLAINT
SINCE NINETEEN SEVENTY THROWING
MORE MONEY AND SUBSIDIZING
BRIDGE TECHNOLOGIES HAVE BEEN
WHAT WE'VE BEEN DOING AND WE
HAVEN'T GOTTEN THERE.
WE NEED TO KIND OF GET OUT OKAY
BECAUSE I GOT LIKE A LOT GO
AHEAD GO BUT YOU KNOW WHAT --
YOU CAN THE NUMBER I SAID
BECAUSE YOU'RE YOU'RE EVERYONE
IS SUPPOSED TO BE EIGHT MINUTES
IN YOUR LIFE MYSELF IS ALSO MADE
IN WRITING.
THERE WE GO --
BUT ULTIMATELY WHAT I THINK THE
BIGGEST CáC OF AB SIX SEVENTEEN
IS IS IF YOU WANT TO DELIVER
CRITERIA POLLUTANT.
DELIVER --
CURTIRPOLLUTANTS IN AT AN AIR
TOXIC REDUCTIONS WE NEED TO TAKE
ACTION ON DIESEL TRUCKS --
WE DON'T MEAN ON ENFORCEABLE
STATES AND PLANS ON A WE DON'T
NEED THE NEXT AVAILABLE
TECHNOLOGY THAT LEASES
SUSCEPTIBLE TO EXPLOSIONS NEXT
TARGET SCHOOLS AND WE DON'T NEED
PUBLIC DOLLARS SUBSIDIZING
BILLION DOLLAR PROFIT INDUSTRIES
BECAUSE THEY TEND TO TAKE JOBS
AWAY.
ON I KNOW IT'S A IN THIS KIND OF
CLIMB IT SOMETIMES IT'S SEEN AS
WE NEED COURAGE SHOULD REALLY
TAKE ACTION ON TRUCKING --
AND I KNOW THE SENSITIVITY TO
WORKERS AND ALSO FEDERAL
CHALLENGES.
A FEDERAL CHALLENGES GETTING US
THE SUPPORT INFRASTRUCTURE FOR
ZERO MISSION TECH --
TRUCKING --
BUT I DON'T THINK THERE'S ENOUGH
SAYS AND SENSITIVITY FOUR SEVEN
EIGHT YOU KNOW MY SCHOOL I AND
OTHER COMMUNITIES BURDEN CANCER
RESPIRATORY DISEASES AND DEATH --
BUT I'M SENSITIVE TO THOSE
WORKERS I HAVE FEELS WHO ARE
FORMER TRUCK WORKERS --
AND I UNDERSTAND HOW IT HELPS
pA HUNDRED BUT THAT'S WHAT THAT'S
RECENTLY STATED STAT.
LIKE WORKING IN A RESPONSE IT
BEGIN ABOUT AUTOMATION HOW THIS.
AND THE REASON WE'RE NOT EXCITED
IS BECAUSE WE LIVE IN A SOCIETY
WHERE IF YOU DON'T HAVE A JOB
YOUR LEFT TO DIE AND THAT IS AT
ITS CORE OUR PROBLEM.
AND IT'S SOMETHING OUR CLINIC
POLICIES HAVE BEEN ADDRESSED
[inaudible]
THANKS [inaudible]
HELLO.
THANK YOU MATT THAT WAS THAT WAS
AWESOME.
I I REALLY APPRECIATE THAT --
HI MY NAME IS MARK --
I'M WITH YOU START COMMUNITIES
FOR ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE AND
ALSO SIT.
ON THE COMMITTEE FOR BOYLE
HEIGHTS EAST LA AND AND COMMERCE
AND I'M A RESIDENT WITHIN THE
THE TARGETED AREA FOR EMISSIONS
REDUCTIONS [inaudible]
AND WHEN AB SIX ONE SEVEN CAME
UP.
WE SAID NO.
WE SAID THIS IS NOT SOMETHING WE
WANT --
PROCESS IS IN PROGRESS WHEN IT'S
A DISTRACTION TO POLICY THAT
WE'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT AND
WORKING ON FOR YEARS --
I WILL GIVE A A LOT OF PROPS TO
ASSEMBLY WOMAN GARCIA --
BECAUSE I THINK.
A RESPONSE TO OUR CRITIQUES WAS
THIS ISN'T JUST ABOUT MONITORING
THIS IS ABOUT EMISSIONS
REDUCTIONS.
AND IF WITH THAT THAT WE ENGAGE
IN THIS PROCESS --
WE'RE WE'RE DEFINITELY NOT HERE
TO SAY WE TOLD YOU SO WE'RE HERE
TO MAKE IT WORK.
RIGHT --
BECAUSE IF WE DON'T MAKE IT WORK
THEM WHAT ARE WHAT ARE OUR
OPTIONS.
AND SO --
WE'VE BEEN HERE TO MAKE IT WORK
WE'VE BEEN AT A Q. M. D. TO MAKE
IT WORK.
I CAN POINT TO TOO MANY THINGS
BUT I'LL POINT TO THE PORT
BACKSTOP RULE IN PARTICULAR.
WHICH WAS SUPPOSED TO ENSURE
THAT -- THE
PORTS.
OF ALLEY IN LONG BEACH REACHED
EMISSIONS REDUCTIONS TARGETS.
AND THAT.
IT WOULD BE ENFORCEABLE.
UNFORTUNATELY THERE WERE SOME
CHANGES IN IN THE BOARD MAKE UP
AND STAFF DIDN'T BRING IT TO THE
BOARD.
AND SO WHEN QUESTIONED.
PUBLICLY WHAT WAS STATED --
OR YOU KNOW LEGALLY IS KNOWLEDGE
HE SAYS IS NOT AVAILABLE YET.
BUT WHAT STAFF TOLD US DIRECTLY
WAS IT WASN'T POLITICALLY
FEASIBLE ANYMORE BECAUSE OF THE
NEW PORT MAKE [inaudible]
WHICH IS THE WORST POSSIBLE
REASON TO NOT DO THE RIGHT THING
RIGHT.
AND SO --
ALSO POINT TO INDIRECT SOURCE
RULES WHICH WE'VE BEEN TRYING TO
WORK -- WORK
AT WITH.
WITH THE DISTRICT AND
UNFORTUNATELY --
PORTS ARE NOT NOT REALLY PART OF
THE CONVERSATION --
RAIL IS IS REALLY ABSENT IN AND
WHEN IT COMES TO WAREHOUSES --
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT IMHO USE AND
THAT'S DEFINITELY NOT SOMETHING
THAT THAT WE'RE INTERESTED IN WE
WANT SOMETHING THAT'S
ENFORCEABLE.
AND SO PRIOR TO A. B. SIX ONE
SEVEN WE REALLY GOT A POINT BACK
TO SB ONE RIGHT IF WE'RE GONNA
GET THE THE THE LARGER CONTEXT.
AND SO --
OUR OUR ASSEMBLY WOMAN WAS ABLE
TO GET THE GOVERNOR TO COME DOWN
AND VISIT WITH US AND AND THAT
WAS A GREAT SESSION AND TING HE
HEARD FROM FROM MANY
STAKEHOLDERS.
AND EXPRESSED INTEREST IN IN --
INDIRECT SOURCE WAS HE ACTUALLY --
EXPRESS A LITTLE BIT ARE SHOCKED
THAT WE DIDN'T ALREADY HAVE THAT
IN HOW ARE WE CALIFORNIA WE
DON'T HAVE INTERREX SOURCE RULES --
UNFORTUNATELY.
WHAT WE GOT BACK WAS WAS A BE --
SIX ONE SEVEN AND AGAIN WE'RE
WE'RE HERE TO MAKE IT WORK RIGHT.
SO WHEN WE ATTEND.
THE A. B. SIX ONE SEVEN MEETINGS
IN OUR COMMUNITIES UNFORTUNATELY
WHAT WE'VE SEEN IS IS KIND OF A
COOKIE CUTTER APPROACH FROM THE
DISTRICT --
AND I THINK WHAT WHAT.
WHAT I'VE NOTICED FROM
THROUGHOUT THIS PROCESS OF
HEARING EVERYONE BUT ALSO FROM
FOLKS THAT WE WORK WITH
CONSISTENTLY AS ALL OF OUR
COMMUNITIES ARE DIFFERENT RIGHT?
EVEN WHEN WE'RE LOOKING AT THE
ISSUES THAT ARE AFFECTING US
IT'S LITERALLY THE SAME GOODS
MOVEMENT FOR STRUCTURE --
BUT YOU HAVE TO WORK WITH THE
COMMUNITIES THAT THAT ARE IN
FRONT OF YOU YOU HAVE TO CENTER
THE THE THE COMMUNITIES AND
NEEDS TO BE COMMUNITY LEAD AND
THEY THINK.
I DESCRIBED EARLIER TODAY IS
THIS PROCESS FEELS LIKE IT'S
BEEN POSTED LEAD.
RIGHT VERY VERY SURFACE
ENGAGEMENT --
FEELING KIND OF LIKE CHECKING A
BOX LIKE THEY'VE ALREADY SET UP
A PLAN FOR HOW THIS PROCESS IS
GOING TO ROLL OUT.
AND AND THE REALITY IS WE'RE
READY TO GO WE WERE READY TO GO
MONTHS AGO WE ARE READY TO GO
YEARS AGO RIGHT.
AND SO I THINK --
THE ENGAGEMENT WITH THOSE OF US
WHO ARE PARTICIPATING IN THIS
PROCESS NEEDS TO BE A REFLECTIVE
OF WHERE WE'RE AT WE NEED TO BE
MET.
WHERE WHERE --
WE DON'T NEED TO GO THROUGH
MONTHS OF A PROCESS --
TO TO TRY --
TO ESSENTIALLY GET TO A PLACE
WHERE WE'VE BEEN AT RIGHT THAT
THAT'S NOT WHAT WE WANT --
BECAUSE AT LEAST FROM MY
EXPERIENCE IT THEY REALLY FELT
LIKE AN EIGHT Q. M. D. --
PUBLIC RELATIONS ROLL OUT.
THOUGH THE WAY THE SOME OF THE
MEETINGS WERE WERE HANDLING --
AND AND I UNDERSTAND FOR FOR FOR
FOLKS WHO MAY BE ARE FAMILIAR
WITH THE DISTRICT MAYBE IT'S
IT'S SOMETHING THAT THAT THAT
MAY BE NEEDED BUT FOR THOSE OF
US WHO ARE ENGAGING IN THIS
PROCESS --
WE KNOW WHAT A KIM DE IS WE'VE
WE'VE KNOWN WHAT THEY'VE DONE --
AND WE KNOW WHAT THEY HAVE INTO.
RIGHT.
AND SO --
YOU KNOW WHAT ONE OF THE BIG
ISSUES AGAIN TWENTY BACK TO
MONITORING [inaudible]
AND AND THIS IS SOMETHING WE'VE
CALLED OUT CONSISTENTLY IS
ESPECIALLY IF IF FUNDS ARE BEING
INVESTED IN MONITORS THAT ARE
NOT PROVIDING ADEQUATE
INFORMATION THAT IS PROVIDING
INFORMATION THAT.
THAT CAN BE IN.
IN FLEET TO ENFORCEMENT --
IT'S REALLY NEEDING TO NOTHING --
WE'VE WE'VE DONE LOW COST
MONITORING.
WE'VE DONE THAT IN OUR
COMMUNITIES FOR FOR TWO DECADES
RIGHT TO THINK WE'VE BEEN DOING
THIS RIGHT --
AND WE'VE DONE IT BECAUSE THE
BOARDS THE AIRPORTS HAVE BEEN
DONE THEIR JOBS.
THAT'S WHY WE'VE DONE IT.
WE DID LOW COST MONITORING
BECAUSE WE DIDN'T HAVE RESOURCES.
SO WHEN THE DISTRICT COMES BACK
IN AND IS TALKING ABOUT THIS
BEING ONE OF THEIR STRATEGIES --
IT'S SHOCKING THAT THEY'RE
TRYING TO REPLICATE WHAT WE'VE
DONE. FOR US THE RESPONSES ACT
LIKE AN INSTITUTION YOU ARE AN
INSTITUTION YOU ARE AN AUTHORITY
YOUR GRANTED CERTAIN POWERS.
ACT WITH THAT RIGHT --
SHOWS YOU CAN TAKE ACTION SHOWS
YOU CAN IN FORCES --
AND SO WE'RE HERE WE'RE READY TO
GO AND AND A LOT OF CASES WE ACT
AS A BRIDGE.
RIGHT YOU HEARD FROM FOLKS
EARLIER TODAY THAT WERE PUT INTO
OTHER AGENCIES AND YOU TO ENGAGE
IN THE PROCESS WE NEED TO ENGAGE
WITH THOSE AS WELL --
NOW I'LL I'LL CALL BACK TO ONE
OF OUR OUR OUR MEMBERS IN THE
COMMITTEE --
RAFA WHO WAS ON THE VERGE OF
DISRUPTING THE MEAL KEPT COMING
OUT WHY ARE WE GOING THROUGH
THROUGH THIS DE CHARETTE RIDER
OR CHARADES WHEN WE KNOW WHAT
THE ISSUES ARE.
RIGHT AND SO WE TOOK A FORTY
FIVE MINUTE PROCESS TO GET TO
THE POINT THAT HE WAS MAKING
THAT.
ARE THOSE PRIORITIES THERE AND
YOU SAID WE'VE DONE IN THE LAST
MANY WE TALK ABOUT IN THE LAST
MINUTE EVERY MEETING WE KEEP
BRINGING UP THE SAME ISSUES.
WE DON'T NEED TO GO THROUGH
THESE PROCESSES BECAUSE WE KNOW
WHAT THE ISSUES ARE LET'S TALK
ABOUT SOLUTIONS I GUESS THAT'S
NOT ON THE VERGE OF WHERE WE'RE
AT RIGHT NOW.
AND SO AGAIN WE'RE HERE TO MAKE
TO MAKE IT WORK --
AND AND THE REALITY IS WE WE
LIVE IN A IN A POLITICAL ECOLOGY.
RIGHT AND SO MY FEAR IS THAT
WHERE WE'RE HEADED IN THIS
PROCESS AND I KIND OF THOUGHT IN
THE POWER POINT A LITTLE BIT
PRESENTED EARLIER.
IS THAT WE'RE GONNA BE.
GUIDED UP TO TO PUT IT NICELY
WE'RE GONNA BE GUIDED --
TO SUPPORT A BALLOT MEASURE TO
CREATE A FUNDING STREAM --
THAT IS ESSENTIALLY GOING TO OUR
TOWARDS FALL SOLUTIONS IT'S A
THAT THE DISTRICT IS IS
INTERESTED IN.
AND AND REALLY IS HEADING
TOWARDS YES --
WE'VE ALREADY SEEN --
CONSULTANTS AND AND NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS IN LOS ANGELES
PUMPING UP THE THE FUTURE OF
THIS THIS MEASURE --
AND TALKING ABOUT FUNDING WHAT
WHAT'S AVAILABLE NOW WHICH IS
NATURAL GAS AND THEN IN TEN
YEARS WE CAN CONSIDER --
ZERO EMISSIONS --
WHICH OF COURSE IS IS NOT AT ALL
WHAT WHAT WE'RE INTERESTED IN
WHERE WE'RE NOT INTERESTED IN
ANY PUBLIC FUNDS GOING. TO A
TECHNOLOGY THAT'S BEEN AROUND
FOR A LONG TIME --
WE'RE ON THE OTHER SIDE OF THE
OF THAT BREACH AND SO --
WE KNOW THAT THAT THESE
CONVERSATIONS ARE ALL TIED
TOGETHER AND SO --
THIS ISN'T TO SAY FREE POLLUTION
IS IS OUR ONLY ISSUE AN INDIRECT
SOURCE RULES --
ARE DEFINITELY NOT OUR ONLY
SOLUTION --
BUT IF IF WE CAN'T MOVE TOWARDS
THESE REGULATORY SOLUTIONS WITH
ALL THE DATA ALL THE FUN DEAN
AND ALL THE COMMUNITY DIRECTION
THAT HAS ALREADY EXISTED.
THEN WHAT CAN WE EXPECT FROM
THESE AGENCIES MOVING FORWARD
RIGHT -- WE
NEED ACTION FROM THE LOCAL.
AND REGIONAL AUTHORITIES AND WE
NEED ACTION AT THE STATE LEVEL --
FROM THE AGENCIES AND ALSO FROM
OUR ELECTED OFFICIALS --
AND IT NEEDS TO BE COMMUNITY
CENTER BECAUSE RIGHT --
SO.
I THINK AT THE HEART OF THIS IS
WE NEED TO DE INCENTIVIZE
COMBUSTION WE NEED TO WE NEED TO
AS A FORM OF INCENTIVIZING --
ZERO EMISSIONS.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
OF THE SIMPLY AND STAFF IN THE
PUBLIC.
MY NAME IS JESSE MARQUEZ I WAS
RAISED ON MY LIFE IN THE
COMMITTEE WILMINGTON.
I FIRST WANT TO CLARIFY A FEW
THINGS WE HAVE A CLEAR
UNDERSTANDING.
WE SEE A. B. SIX ONE SEVEN AS
THE MOST SIGNIFICANT AND
HISTORICAL.
COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT OF A RB AND
THE SOUTH COAST A KENNEDY WITH
OUR COMMUNITY.
NOTHING IN THE MICROPHONE A
LITTLE BIT CLOSER THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THESE.
TWO THESE TWO HAVE BEEN THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT.
PROGRAMS COMING INTO OUR LIVES.
AND WHY DO I TAKE IT SO
SERIOUSLY.
BECAUSE I'VE BEEN AN ACTIVIST
SINCE I WAS SIXTEEN YEARS OLD.
WHEN I WAS SIXTEEN YEARS OLD THE
FLETCHER OR REFINERY IN THE CITY
OF CARSON ACROSS THE STREET FROM
WOMAN CANNELLA SANDERS BLEW UP?
SEVEN MEMBERS OF MY FAMILY WERE
BURNED FROM FIRST TO THIRD
DEGREES OVER TWO HUNDRED PEOPLE
WERE BURDEN INJURED.
MY MOTHER'S GOING THROUGH
CHEMOTHERAPY RIGHT NOW BECAUSE
SHE WAS DIAGNOSED WITH CANCER
AND IT RETURNED.
MY FATHER WAS DIAGNOSED WITH
CANCER.
MY SISTER WAS DIAGNOSED WITH
CANCER MY SEVENTEEN YEAR OLD
NEPHEW LYMPHOMA DIAGNOSED WITH
CANCER AND EVER BROTHER GOING
THROUGH CHEMOTHERAPY RIGHT NOW.
I TAKE THIS SERIOUS FOR MY
FAMILY AND FOR MY COMMUNITIES
AND FROM OTHER COMMITTEES I HAVE.
BEEN FORTUNATE TO GO MEET THEM.
ARE THE SOLUTIONS YES.
I WANT AB SIX ONE SEVEN TO BE AN
ABSOLUTE SUCCESS AND I WILL DO
EVERYTHING I CAN TO CONTRIBUTE
TO THAT SUCCESS.
TAKES MY TWENTY YEARS EXPERIENCE
IN ALSO TAKE ME BEING A CRITIC
TO POINT OUT WHAT NEEDS TO BE
FIXED.
FIRST THOUGHT LET'S START OFF
WITH THE BASIC LAW.
READ THE CLEAN AIR ACT.
BASICALLY THE FIRST PAGE I'VE
GIVEN YOU SOME DOCUMENTS YOU
COULD READ IT BUT IN THE CLEAN
AIR ACT.
NO WERE IN IT DOES THAT STATE
ANYWHERE THAT INDUSTRIES ANY
INDUSTRY OR ANY BUSINESS.
HAVE ANY RIGHTS THAT SUPERSEDE
THE PUBLIC.
THEY HAVE NO RIGHTS BUT
SUPERSEDE US YET GOVERNMENT
AGENCIES HAVE DELEGATED
AUTHORITY TO THEMSELVES. TO MAKE
DECISIONS THAT THEY HAVE NO
RIGHT TO DO AND WE WANT THAT
STOPPED WE WANT LEGISLATURE TO
MAKE SURE THAT STOPS.
OTHER QUESTIONS THAT'LL COME OUT
ABOUT EIGHTY SIX SEVEN SIX ONE
SEVEN FROM INDUSTRY --
IT'S ONLY STATIONARY.
SO IN ONE OF THE PAGES I QUOTE
TO SECTION OF AB SIX ONE SEVEN
THAT STATE MOLD FORCES ARE
INCLUDED.
I ALSO INCLUDE SOME PAGES WHAT
TOOK ONE EXAMPLE OF CONICAL
PHILLIPS OR REFINERY SO ONE PAGE
SHOWS YOU.
FROM THE YEAR 200-022-00017 ALL
THE CRITERIA POLLUTANTS ALL THE
TOXIC POLLUTANTS.
AND GUESS WHAT YOU DISCOVER.
THERE'S BEEN NO SIGNIFICANT
REDUCTION WHAT SO EVER.
AND I CAN TELL YOU WHY.
THE GUYS SO BECAUSE THEY CAN BE
ADOPTED THE REKLAME PROGRAM AND
A RB ADOPTED THE CAP AND TRADE
PROGRAM THAT ALLOWED HIM TO BUY
CREDITS.
EVERYWHERE ELSE AND NEVER REDUCE
POLLUTION.
SO YOU CAN LOOK AT THE DATA I'VE
TAKEN BUT THEN THEY CAN DEFINE
SITE AND I WANT TO THANK YOU A
COMMITTEE BECAUSE THE UPDATE IT
AND MADE IT MORE USER FRIENDLY
SO NOW I HAVE MORE ACCESS TO
MORE INFORMATION.
BUT THE DATA SHOWS.
BUT IF YOU LOOK AT SEVENTEEN
YEARS WORTH OF DATA.
SEVERAL CATEGORIES A TRACTOR
PULLS HAVE GONE UP IN MANY
CATEGORIES OF TOXIC POLLUTANTS
HAVE GONE UP.
WE NEED TO STOP THAT SO WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT REDUCING THE
FORTUNATELY.
I'VE TAKEN THE TIME TO LEARN
WHAT OTHER MEMBERS OF OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS AND WE HAVE OUR
UNIVERSITY SCIENTISTS AND EVEN
NEW EMERGING COMPANIES THAT HAVE
COME TO US THE SHOW WAS THEIR
TECHNOLOGIES.
AND WHAT I LEARNED.
REFINERY TECHNOLOGIES COULD BE
REDUCED AND LET ME TELL YOU THAT.
WE CAME UP WITH OUR OWN LITTLE
GOALS.
IF YOU LOOK AT A CANDY GOALS
THEY DO NOT INCLUDE OUR GOALS
ARE GOALS IS TO REDUCE AIR
POLLUTION FROM ALL STATIONARY
AND MOST BALL FORCES TWO ZERO
EMISSIONS.
THAT'S OUR GOAL.
OUR SECOND GOAL REDUCE AIR
POLLUTION FROM STATION STORIES
STATIONARY SOURCES BY 90% IN
FIVE YEARS.
REDUCE AIR POLLUTION FROM MOBILE
FORCES 90% IN SEVEN YEARS.
IMPROVE PUBLIC HEALTH BY 90%
WITHIN TEN YEARS.
IS THAT ACHIEVABLE ABSOLUTELY
YES.
BECAUSE TECHNOLOGIES EXIST THEY
ARE BE MENTIONED TO YOU ABOUT
THE STATUS OF THEIR TECHNOLOGY
CLEARING HOUSE.
I'VE TALKED AT LEAST THIRTY
MEMBER DROP THE OF THE
TECHNOLOGY CLEARING HOUSE.
BUT I CAN TELL YOU ONE THING IN
THE DOCUMENT I GAVE YOU.
ARE A LITTLE ORGANIZATION IS
DOING SOMETHING.
THAT NO ONE ELSE IS DOING IN LA
NO ONE ELSE IS DOING IN
CALIFORNIA NO ONE ELSE IS DOING
UNITED STATES AND NOWHERE ELSE
ON PLANET EARTH WE ARE PROVIDING
A MONTHLY SURVEY.
OF ALL ZERO EMISSIONS VEHICLES
AND ZERO EMISSIONS EQUIPMENT.
BY MANUFACTURER AND MODEL NUMBER.
NOW THAT DOESN'T INCLUDE OTHER
EQUIPMENT LIKE FOR REFINERIES.
VAPOR RECOVERY SYSTEMS HAVE
EXISTED AND APPROVED BY EPA FOR
TWENTY FIVE YEARS ARE OFF THE
SHELF.
BUT NOT ONE TITLE FIGHT PERMIT
FROM ANY COMMITTEE MAKES IT
MANDATORY FOR EVERY STORAGE TANK
SAYS RESULT WE HAVE.
HUNDREDS OF TONS OF VOCS COMING
OUT.
FLARING OUR MAJOR EVENTS.
BUT YOU KNOW WHAT.
WE HAVE ALL THESE FIVE SIX POWER
OUTAGES.
AND THE WORST DAYS ARE THE
FLARING DAYS WHEN THE POWER GOES
OUT FOR ONE TO ONE AND HALF DAYS.
WHAT'S THE SOLUTION.
WELL WE KNOW THEY HAD A LIQUID
MET BREAK DOWN.
BUT IF THEY HAD A BACKUP POWER
SYSTEM THERE WE WANT TO HAVE
THAT.
DO YOU HAVE A GOOD EXAMPLE YES
B. B. R. GOING CARSON HAS TO
COACH AND PLANTS THAT THEY NEVER
GO OUT [inaudible]
BUT WHERE IS REQUIREMENTS FOR
EVERYBODY ELSE TO HAVE A BACKUP
POWER IT'S NOT THERE.
AND THEY SAY OH FLARING IT'S A
FOR SAFETY YOUR WANTED EXPLODING
YOU KNOW YOU WANT TO HURT
ANYBODY.
YOU KNOW WE'RE LOSING PROFITS
BURNING OUR FUEL [inaudible]
WELL SIMPLE.
YOU HAVE THE VAPOR RECOVERY
SYSTEM WHICH IS A PIPE SO IN
YOUR GAS IS GO UP THEY GO DIVERT
TO PIPE TO AN EMPTY TANK.
AND YOU'RE ABLE TO USE IT AGAIN
AND YOU DON'T LOSE PROFITS.
SO WE KNOW TECHNOLOGIES.
AND WE ARE AT THAT LEVEL NOW
WHAT WE COULD CONTRIBUTE. TO THE
AWARENESS OF WHAT TECHNOLOGIES
ARE APPLICABLE WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT EMISSIONS REDUCTIONS I CAN
TELL YOU ONE THING IN OUR PLAN
WE'RE GONNA DATA FIVE SPECIFIC
EQUIPMENT.
LAST MONTH I SUBMIT A PUBLIC
COMMENTS ON SIX OR REFINERIES IN
LA THEIR DRAFT FENCE LINE
MONITORING PLAN.
AND I REJECTED ALL SIX OF THEM.
NONE OF THEM WERE A 100% 90% 80%
THEY'RE ABOUT 6270% OKAY.
WHERE THEY FAILED THE MOST WAS
AN PUBLIC NOTIFICATION TO ANYONE
PUT IN ANYTHING IN THAT CATEGORY
FOR PUBLIC NOTIFICATION?
THAT'S NOT ACCEPTABLE THE
GUIDANCE THAT YOU'RE SUPPOSED TO
THEY DIDN'T AND THEN WERE USING
TECHNOLOGY YES I'M BECOMING VERY
AWARE.
OF AIR MONITORING EQUIPMENT AND
TECHNOLOGIES ONE COMPANY
CONTACTED ME AND I CONTACTED
THEM.
THEY HAVE AN FTIR.
THE BEST ONE I CAN READ RIGHT
NOW ON PLANET EARTH NOW WHY IS
THAT IMPORTANT BECAUSE THEY CAN
DETECT THE CHEMICAL AND LESS
THAN A MINUTE.
THEY CAN QUEUE A VALIDATE THAT
DATA IN LESS THAN A MINUTE AND
THEY CAN REPORT IT IN LESS THAN
ONE MINUTE.
THEY STAND FIVE TIMES VERSUS
FOUR TIMES.
BUT WHY IS THAT IMPORTANT
BECAUSE SEE [inaudible]
IN TORRANCE.
AT THE TORRANCE REFINERY THEY
HAVE A CHEMICAL CALLED HYDROGEN
FLUORIDE IN WILMINGTON AT THE
ALTAR MARVOLO WE HAVE A CHEMICAL
CALLED.
HYDROGEN FLUORIDE AND IF THAT
TANK BREAKS LOOSE.
IT KILLS EVERYBODY WITHIN
MINUTES.
WITHIN TWO MILES.
SO HAVING A FIVE TEN MINUTE OR
QUARTERLY.
NOTIFICATION AS TO WHAT HAPPENED
IS NOT ACCEPTABLE.
IF THAT BREAKS LOOSE EVERYONE
DIES.
FIRST THE FOR FIRST RESPONDERS
SHOWING UP WILL DIE I
INTERVIEWED AND SPOKE A FIVE
FIRST RESPONDERS FROM LA COUNTY
FIRE DEPARTMENT.
AVAST EVERYONE OF THEM PRIOR TO
THREE YEARS AGO OF THAT
EXXONMOBIL REFINERY DID THEY
KNOW THAT HOW DO IN FLORIDA WAS
THERE THEY ALL SAID NO.
AND THAT WAS A FIRST RESPONDER.
SO WHAT WE HAVE LEARNED THAT
OVER THE YEARS.
HM THE STAFF.
LIKE YOU HEARD MARK MENTIONED
ARE PROPOSING MO USE.
NEVER AS ONE E. J. ORGANIZATION
AND THE HISTORY OF OUR
CALIFORNIA EVER SUPPORTED AND
AMMO YOU ARE RECOMMENDED AN AMMO
YOU.
THESE ARE THEIR STAFFS.
POLLUTING WITH INDUSTRY TO GET
AWAY WITH THE MINIMUM WE WANT
RULES WE WANT REGULATIONS AND WE
WANT NEW LAWS THAT ARE
ENFORCEABLE.
CAN YOU FOR SENATE MILIEU YES
SOMETIMES YOU CAN'T WE DON'T
WANT TO GO THAT ROUTE BEING
CHALLENGED.
WE WANT A ROLE WE WANNA
REGULATION DO WE ARE PROBLEMS
WITH YOU KNOW LAND USE YES.
I ASKED AT LEAST THIRTY TO FORTY
PLANNERS OVER THE LAST TEN YEARS
THEY LOOK AT YOUR A. R. B..
LAND USE BOOK DID YOU LOOK AT
THE A COMMITTEE THAT HIS BOOK.
AND THEY SAID NO MAYBE EVEN KNOW
IT EXISTED.
SO WE NEED.
LOS FROM THE LEGISLATORS SAY YES
WE NEED TO DO THIS DID YOU KNOW
IN RUSSIA FOR REFINERIES THEY
HAVE A LAW YOU CAN'T LIVE WITHIN
FIVE KILOMETERS AND THEY
RELOCATE YOU OUT [inaudible]
IT WORKS.
AND CAN YOU.
OF SOME SOME UP IN.
YOU'RE ALSO AT ABOUT TEN MINUTES
OKAY SORRY OKAY AND THEN WE ASK
TO SEE THE BUDGET WE SAW THE
BUDGET TWENTY SEVEN MILLION.
SEVEN MILLION WAS BEING
ALLOCATED TOWARDS RECLAIM.
OUR CSE NEVER DISCUSSED SEVEN
MILLION GOING TOWARDS RECLAIM.
WE NEVER VOTED OR PROVE DEBT OR
EVEN RECOMMENDED IT.
IF YOU'RE GOING TO TAKE IT.
THAT WAS IN YOUR BUDGET FROM A
COMMITTEE BACK IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN WHEN THEY VOTED TO
PHASE IT OUT DON'T TAKE MONEY
FROM OUR FUNDS [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ALL --
AND WITH THAT NOW I'LL GO
THROUGH THE COMMITTEE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GARCIA.
THANK YOU --
ON THE START WITH THE WINGS I
WANT.
TO BEFORE I ASK MY QUESTION WANT
TO MAKE SURE I HEARD YOU COULD
KING ABOUT.
THE SCOPE OF WHAT THE SOUTH
CLOSE DOES.
DD SAVE THAT YOU'RE LIMITED TO
STATIONARY SOURCES.
I HEAR YOU RIGHT OR I SAID WE
HAVE PRIMARY AUTHORITY FOR
STATIONARY SOURCES.
WE HAVE LIMITED AUTHORITY ON
MOBILE SOURCES.
WE CAN UTILIZE SOME OF CARBS
EXISTING AUTHORITY FOR SOME OF
THE ENFORCEMENT PURPOSES.
WE ALSO HAVE LIMITED AUTHORITY
WHEN IT COMES TO MOBILE SOURCES
THROUGH OUR FLEET RULES.
OUR FLEET RULES ARE NOT TAILPIPE
STANDARDS WHICH WE ARE NOT.
ALLOWED TO ESTABLISH UNDER US
LAW THAT IS THE DOMAIN OF
CALIFORNIA AT LEAST FOR NOW IN
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
BUT WE CAN REQUIRE PURCHASING
REQUIREMENT FOR GOVERNMENT
AGENCIES OR PRIVATE FACILITIES
THAT ARE CONTRACTED PRIMARILY BY
GOVERNMENT AGENCIES.
SO THAT'S ABOUT THE EXTENT OF
OUR MOBILE SOURCE THE THIRTY AND
WE ALSO HAVE --
INDIRECT SOURCE REAL AUTHORITY
THAT IS ACTUALLY.
PROBABLY MOST CLEAR WITH REGARDS
TO SOUTH COAST AND A BAY AREA
MENTIONED THAT.
IT WASN'T CLEAR WITH REGARD TO
SOME OF THE OTHER BUT SOUTH
COAST DOES HAVE --
I WOULD SAY LIMITED AUTHORITY
WHEN IT COMES.
TO OF PORTS AIRPORTS A
WAREHOUSING OF RAIL YARDS AND
NEW DEVELOPMENT REAL ESTATE.
SO I MEAN I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT.
TO RECOGNIZE [inaudible]
OUR WHAT ARE THIRTY DOESN'T
DOESN'T ALLOW US TO DO AND THEN
NOT HAVE THAT BE WE CAN DO
CERTAIN THINGS SO WE CAN FOCUS
ON SOMETHING WE HAVE TO THE
COMMUNITIES THAT THAT YOU
PRESENTED AND THEY ALL I
IDENTIFIED.
MOBILE SOURCES AS THE BIG ISSUE
RIGHT AND SO.
INDIRECT SOURCES MIGHT BE A
SOLUTION THEN THAT WE HAVE ABOUT
THIRTY WITHIN THEIR AND SO I
JUST WANNA MAKE SURE AS REMOVING
FORD.
THAT IS THE COMMUNITY HAS
IDENTIFIED AND IN THIS --
DISTRICT.
pTHE TOP ISSUE THEN THAT WE GET
CREATIVE --
AND DECIDING PART OF THE PURPOSE
OF AB SIX SEVENTEEN IS LET'S
LET'S NOT LIMIT OURSELVES THAT'S
GET CREATIVE AND THEN THE SECOND
PIECE WITHOUT THAT I WANT TO
**** HE TALKED ABOUT CHARTERS
FOR EACH OF THIS COMMITTEES TO
DEVELOP THESE CHARTER FOR THESE
COMMITTEE SAYS IS.
DEVELOPING CONJUNCTION WITH.
COMMUNITY GROUPS IS A SOMETHING
THAT --
EIGHT HIM HE CAME IN WITH
ALREADY --
SO STAFF DRAFTED THE CHARTERS
AND THE PRESENTED THEM AS DRAFT
TO AND SOUGHT --
FEEDBACK AND INPUT TO YOU SEE
VERY LITTLE FEEDBACK AND INPUT
ON THE CHARTERS.
MASS YEARS ABOUT THAT CHARTER
PROCESS [inaudible]
YEAH -- MY
ENGAGEMENT WITH THE CHARTER WITH --
RECEIVING IT.
AND AND BEING ASKED TO SIGN IN I
DID MISS THE FIRST MEETING --
SO I'M NOT SURE IF THERE WAS A
PRESENTATION THERE BUT AT THE
SECOND MEETING WHICH WAS THE
FIRST MEETING I ATTENDED THAT'S
WHERE I RECEIVED THE CHARTER AND
AND WAS ASKED TO SIGN.
THEY'RE ASKING US JUST SIGN A
CHARTER.
BUT WE WANT THE SAME RECIPROCAL
TRANSPARENCY BACK [inaudible]
THAT.
I AM I'M AT THIS TABLE BECAUSE I
REPRESENT MY COMMUNITY MY
COMMUNITY SUPPORTS THE WORK THAT
I DO AND I REPORT BACK TO THEM.
AND I'M RESPONSIBLE TO THEM.
BECAUSE MY FAMILY IS PART OF
THAT COMMUNITY AND SO WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT YOU KNOW YES I'M
A LEADER AND YES UP THE TABLE.
EVERYTHING IS TO BE DISCUSSED AT
THE TABLE.
I WANT TO BE A CO WRITER OF THAT
CHARTER.
WE SUBMITTED A DOCUMENT.
FOR DISCLOSURE OF CONFLICT OF
INTEREST SO WE HAVE TO DRAFT IN
THE FORM THAT IT WILL COULD FILL
OUT THERE WAS NOTHING PARTICULAR
DANGEROUS ABOUT IT.
AND THEY DIDN'T WANT TO DO IT --
WELL SOME OF THE WORK FOR
INDUSTRY WELL YES BUT THEY'RE
GONNA BE VOTING AGAINST US.
THE ONES THAT ARE CONCERNED
BECAUSE THEY WANT TO PROTECT
THEIR JOBS.
SO YES YOU KNOW WE WERE DISCUSS
EVERYTHING GOLDEN APRIL DISCUSS
GETTING UP PURCHASING EQUIPMENT
FOR AIR QUALITY MONITORING.
WE HAVE A DISCUSS OUR COMMITTEE
MONITORING NEEDS YET AND WHAT
EQUIPMENT WE WANT YET.
WE MAY WANT TO INPUT ON THAT.
YEAH -- MY
EXPENSES CHARTER IS PRESENTED AT
THE FIRST --
COMMITTEE MEETING WE'RE ASKED TO
PROVIDE FEEDBACK BY THE NEXT
COMMUNITY MEETING I BELIEVE SOME
OF OUR COMMITTEE MEMBERS DID
PROVIDE SOME FEEDBACK ALTHOUGH I
THINK IT JUST SPEAKS TO A HIGHER
ISSUE.
IN THAT A LOT OF THIS IS BEING
DISTRICT DRIVEN AND NOT
COMMUNITY DRIVEN.
ON THE AND THANK YOU FOR THAT
MATTER I MEAN I'M TRYING TO GET
AT THAT POINT I I HAVE TO I
APOLOGIZE I DIDN'T GET TO HEAR
THE PRESENTATIONS EARLIER
BECAUSE MY OTHER PASSION --
TALKING ABOUT MY PRE TO THE
SOUTH UP IN ANOTHER COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU --
BUT I I I I APPRECIATE SOME OF
YOU WERE ABLE TO COME TALK TO ME
A LITTLE BIT AHEAD OF TIME.
ABOUT WHAT'S GOING ON AND I I
DON'T EXPECT EVERY DISTRICT TO
BE THE SAME AND AND I EXPECTED
TO BE GROWING PAINS ACROSS THE
BOARD.
BUT IN SOME DISTRICTS THAT THERE
SEEMS TO BE A MUCH MORE
COLLABORATIVE --
TEAM EFFORT AND FROM THE THIRTY
COMMUNITY GROUPS HERE THAT THERE
SEEMS TO BE A DISCONNECT AND SO
I I PICKED ON THE CHARTER
SPECIFICALLY BECAUSE IT WAS
MEANT.
TWO OF OF THE LIST EVEN THAT A
COLLABORATIVE PROCESS OF HOW WE
WORK TOWARDS BUILDING THAT TRUST
I THINK AND MY COMMUNITY I'VE
SEEN OTHER LACK OF TRUST.
AND SO EVERY STEP IS GOING TO BE
PAINFUL AND EVERYTHING'S GONNA
REQUIRED A LOT OF EXTRA WORK BUT
I THINK EVERY STEP THIS
OPPORTUNITY. TO BUILD THAT TRUST
AND GETTING THE CHARTER GOING
MIGHT BE PART OF AND I THINK I
SENATE-DISTRICT YOU HAVE A
DEADLINE THEY HAVE TO MEETING
YOUR SEEN THAT SO YOU'RE TRYING
TO BE LIKE LET ME MAKE SURE I DO
WHAT I CAN NOW TO HELP.
MEET THAT DEADLINE AND MAYBE
THERE'S WERE GREAT COULD DO AT A
TIME.
BUT SOMETIMES THAT BEEN WORKS
AGAINST US IN IN THE LONG HAUL
AND IN THE COMMITMENT FROM THE
COMMUNITY MEMBERS I DISAGREE A
LITTLE BIT WITH MATT --
ABOUT THE POWER OF AB SIX
SEVENTEEN YEAR READ OF HOW IT
WAS IT WAS --
VOTED ON AND WHAT I HAD TO
LEVERAGE --
BUT BUT IT'S IT'S ONLY GOING TO
BE SUCCESSFUL IF I HAVE BY IN
FROM MY COMMUNITY MEMBERS.
AND IT WORRIES ME THAT ARE HAVE
BY IN IN IN ULTIMATELY IS LIKE
WHAT DO I NEED TO DO WHAT WE
NEED TO REFINE THIS PROCESS. TO
GET THAT BY IN AND HOW DO WE
MAKE SURE THAT THAT MORE OF WHAT
THEY WANT IS IS BEING INCLUDED
IN I TELL MY COMMUNITY MEMBERS
ARE NOT GOING TO GET IT ALL.
RIGHT AND IT'S A DOWN PAYMENT IT
WILL KEEP FIGHTING FOR FOR A
BETTER BUT IT DOES WORRY ME THAT
IN SOME [inaudible]
AND I I HAVE HOPE IT'S NOT
PERFECT IN THIS IS WHAT I WANT
TO SEE AND THEN I'M HEARING HERE
IN THE SOUTH COAST REGION.
I WOULD ENACTED THIS IS ALL
SIXTEEN AND I DON'T HEAR A LOT
OF HOPE HERE ABOUT WHERE WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE --
AND SO THAT'S WHY I PICKED ON
THE CHARTER I DON'T KNOW THERE'S
MORE PIECES OUT THERE BUT I
THINK EVERY STEP IS A STEP. TO
BEST BUILD THAT TRUST AND WHILE
WE HAVE A REAL DEADLINE.
SOMETIMES WE CAN'T WE SHOULD BE
GETTING AHEAD OF OURSELVES.
AND IN THAT PROCESS --
AND ARE WORTH MATTER AND SO I
THINK WE NEED TO BE CAREFUL I
ALSO WANT TO ASK ABOUT THE
MONETARY --
BECAUSE IT'S BEEN AN ISSUE
THAT'S BEEN EQUITY FOR QUITE
AWHILE FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
ACROSS THE STATE NOT JUST IN
THIS REGION ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT
LEASE PRO PURPLE MONITORS OR
WHETHER OR NOT WE SEE MONITORS
THAT ARE.
CERTIFIED AND APPROVED BY THE
FED TO WE HAVE THAT ENFORCEMENT
DOWN THE ROAD --
AND WHY ARE WE NOT DOING I AND I
GET THE COST ISSUE THAT'S NOT
THAT'S NOT THAT'S NOT LOST ON ME.
BUT IF IF I INVEST WHATEVER MONO
PROBLEM MONITORS AND IT'S NOT
THE END OF THAT IS GOING TO MEAN
ANYTHING FOR ENFORCEMENT.
WHY AREN'T WE DOING A LITTLE BIT
MORE OF THE DATA THAT THAT WILL
MEAN SOMETHING FOR ENFORCEMENT?
THANK YOU SOMEONE EVER GARCIA OF
PHILIP FINE SO --
WE WE ARE NOT ONLY RELYING ON
THE LOW COST SENSORS IT'S AN ALL
OF THE ABOVE APPROACH SO WENT
AND DID THE THE WE HAVEN'T
FINISHED IS MONITORING PLANS YET
TIME IS SHORT WE HAVE TO START
PURCHASING SOME EQUIPMENT THAT
WE WE DO THINK IT'S GOING TO BE
USEFUL.
LOW COST MONITORING VERSES
REGULATORY MONITORING IT IS BOTH
THEY BOTH SERVE DIFFERENT
PURPOSES IT IS NOT POSSIBLE TO
PUT A THOUSAND REGULATORY
MONITORS OUT IN ONE COMMUNITY.
THERE'S NO AMOUNT OF MONEY
YOU'RE RESOURCES IT'S GOING TO
DO THAT BUT YOU CAN PUT FIVE OR
SIX OR MAYBE MORE THAN THAT BUT
THE FILL OUT THAT GAP.
YOU PUT IN LOW COST MONITORS IF
THEY SHOW A PROBLEM YOU COULDN'T
MOVE THE REGULATORY MONITOR
THEIR SO IT'S IT'S THEIR
DIFFERENT TOOLS FOR DIFFERENT
REASONS DIFFERENT OBJECTIVES
DIFFERENT THINGS WE'RE TRYING TO
ACHIEVE.
WITH MONITORING.
SO HOW MANY JUST THEN AND THAT'S
FAIR -- LIKE
LET'S SAY IN THE LIMITING IN
WILMINGTON WAS LONG BEACH CARSON.
AREA COMMUNITY OR WE HAVE A
STEERING GROUP HOW MANY OF THE
OF THESE FEDERALLY.
REGULATED MONITORS ARE WE
PUTTING THERE.
ARE DO WE HAVE A TO DO WE HAVE
FIVE DO WE HAVE NINE YET SO AS I
SAID THE MODERN PLANTS AREN'T
COMPLETE YET BECAUSE WE'RESTILL
TAKING INPUT AND TRYING TO MATCH
THE MONITORING PROGRAM WITH THE
EMISSIONS REDUCTION PROGRAM.
SUCH THAT WE CAN TRACK PROGRESS
AND MAKE AND SO AT AND WE HAVE
MET MONITORING AND OTHER SO.
TIME IS SHORT WAS SUPPOSED TO
START MONITORING ON JULY FIRST --
THAT'S WHAT'S IN THE THAT'S
WITHIN THE STATUTE AND AGAIN
IT'S A SURE THE FRUSTRATION WITH --
ALL THE ALL THE MEMBERS OF THE
STEERING COMMITTEE THAT WERE
READY TO GO ON DAY ONE WITH WITH
MEASURES AND ACTIONS BECAUSE WE
WERE.
TOO IT IS WE HAVE A LOT OF NEW
PEOPLE IT'S VERY CHALLENGING TO
BRING EVERYONE UP --
TO THAT CONSENSUS.
CONSENSUS ABOUT HOW WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE FORWARD --
AND AGAIN THAT THE TIME LINES
ARE TIGHT ON MONITORING THE TIME
LINES EVEN TIGHTER.
SO -- IT IS
A CHALLENGE BUT WE'RE GONNA TRY
TO GET A BASIC LEVEL OF
MONITORING OUT THERE.
AND WAS WORKING WITH THE
COMMUNITIES TO DEVELOP THOSE
MONITORING PLANS.
IN AND IF I HAD TO YOU KNOW VICE
FOR EXAMPLE.
MAYBE THERE WAS WORK THAT COULD
HAVE BEEN DONE EARLIER ON THE
MONITORING SITE THAT WAS YOU
KNOW WHAT THE WHAT THE COMMUNITY
HAS BEEN SAYING. FOR TOO MANY
YEARS I'VE BEEN AROUND AND
THEY'VE BEEN AROUND LONGER THAN
I HAVE ISSUING DISCUSSING THIS
ISSUE BUT I WILL SAY THAT THESE
MONITORS IN THE TYPE OF MINERS
THAT WERE YOU SEEN EVEN BEFORE
AB.
SIX SEVENTEEN WAS TALKED ABOUT
WITH AN ISSUE THAT'S BEEN OUT
THERE AND A FRUSTRATION AMONG
THE COMMUNITY AND IT COULD HAVE
BEEN A PLACE WHERE MAYBE WE CAN
ABOUT AND I HAD.
ON THAT PIECE --
A LITTLE BIT AND SO I'M NOT
SAYING THAT WE WE A CENTER
DISTRICT YOU HAVE A SKILL SET
AND SOMETIMES IT'S GOOD TO GET
AHEAD AND SOMETHING'S BUT THAT
MIGHT HAVE BEEN.
A BETTER PLACE TO TO GET AHEAD.
ON A SOME OF THE MONETARY IN OUT
THERE I I WILL SAY TO THE
COMMUNITY I DO THINK WE NEED A
PLAN.
I DO THINK YOU KNOW THERE'S A
PLACE FOR THOSE PURPLE MONITORS --
BUT THERE'S ALSO I WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT IF I HAD DATA THAT I
COULD GET ENFORCEMENT WENT THAT
AND I REALIZE THAT THE REALITY
SETTLES FOR PER MONITOR DATA
DOESN'T GIVE ME ENFORCEMENT SO.
I I DO AGREE THAT WE NEED A
PLANNED AND A BALANCE AND AND
SEND THAT PART.
I ALSO WANT TO TALK ABOUT --
THESE HEARINGS AND THAT BRING IN
AND OTHER ISSUES WHETHER IT'S AB
THREE NINETY EIGHT AND CAP AND
TRADE EVEN IF IT'S NOT GERMANE
EVEN THOUGH THE HISTORY IS TIED.
OR A TAX --
FOR THE DISTRICT --
AND SO I WILL TAKE A MOMENT ON
THAT TAX FOR THEIR WHEN WE'RE
STILL TRYING TO FIGURE OUT THIS
PIECE.
OF THE PIE IN THIS PIECE OF OF
THE EQUATION --
AND WHEN THERE'S ALSO THE
ABILITY --
TO AND FROM FOURTH AND IMPOSE
OTHER FEES THAT THEY'LL HAVE TO
BE TAXES ON POLLUTERS OUT THERE --
IN SOME OUT I'LL TAKE THAT
SOAPBOX FOR A MOMENT THANK YOU.
SOME MEMBERS TO CHECK THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I APOLOGIZE THAT STEP
OUT. TO TAKE ANOTHER MEETING --
ON THE MOST --
TO DIRECTLY RELEVANT TO THE
PORTION OF TODAY'S AGENDA --
TO TO TO MY DISTRICT BUT I HOPE
BY -- PLEASE --
EXCUSE ME IF I ASK SOMETHING
THAT AND THAT WAS COVERED --
DURING MY ABSENCE --
MY PRIMARY CONCERN OUR
REFINERIES --
YOU HAVE THE THE PRIMARY
AUTHORITY FOR STATIONARY SOURCES
INCLUDING REFINERIES --
I SAW GREAT PROMISE WITH THE
THAT THE BARK PROVISIONS OF
REDUCING --
I AIR AIR POLLUTION AND I GUY
HEARD YOUR PRESENTATION ON THE
ROLE DEVELOPMENT --
PROCESS AS IT RELATES TO
REFINERIES BUT IT WOULD BE A A
MY IN MY UNDERSTANDING CORRECTLY
THAT YOU --
THAT THE FINAL ROLE AS TO
ADOPTING BART.
TECHNOLOGIES --
AS IT RELATES TO A REFINERY
BEING WORKED ON YEAH WE HOPE BY
THE END OF THIS YEAR TO HAVE --
LET'S SPECIFIC WILL FOR BARKED
KNOCKS EMISSIONS AT REFINERIES
IN PLACE --
TO REQUIRE THE BEST AVAILABLE
CONTROLS OBVIOUSLY WON'T HAPPEN
OVERNIGHT THERE'S HAS BEEN
IMPLEMENTATION SCHEDULE --
DOING THE BEST WE CAN HIT THE
DEADLINE IN STATUTE AT THE FOR
THE END OF TWENTY TWENTY THREE
THAT'S NOT THE ONLY WILL WE'RE
WORKING ON FOR REFINERIES --
WE AS PART OF THE STEERING
COMMITTEE --
WE WANT TO DISCUSS BRINGING OUR
RULE ELEVEN EIGHTEEN BACK WHICH
IS OUR RULE THAT IS INTENDED TO
REDUCE FLARING EMERGENCY FIRINGS
ALREADY PROHIBITED I MEAN THAT.
WE CAN CLEARING SAUDI PROHIBITED
BUT HOW CAN WE REDUCE EMERGENCY
AND NON ROUTINE FLARING.
SO THERE'S ANOTHER ROLE --
COMING BACK THERE AND THERE'S
THERE'S A COUPLE OTHER RULES
WERE LOOKING AT OBVIOUSLY
FOURTEEN TEN FOUR REFINERIES.
SO OTHERS THAT THERE'S A WHOLE
REGULATORY PROGRAM COMING
FORWARD ON REFINERIES ALL RIGHT
SO AS TO THE WITH THE MAIN ROLE
ON REFINERIES THAT'S THAT YOUR
YOUR YOUR GOAL RIGHT NOW IS TO
HAVE SOMETHING IN PLACE BY THE
END OF THIS YEAR.
UP FOR THE BARK REQUIREMENTS YES
FOR THE BARK REQUIREMENTS OKAY.
SO -- I I I
I KNOW THAT WHEN WE WERE
DEBATING --
THIS BILL AS WELL AS THE BUDGET
BILL LAST YEAR THAT ONE OF THE
THE CONCERNS WAS NOT HAVING A
ADEQUATE RESOURCES TO ENFORCE
THE PROVISIONS OF THIS BILL BUT
AT HOW IS THAT GOING.
WELL I YOU KNOW I I THINK.
WE WERE CONCERNED JUST ABOUT
IMPLEMENTATION WELL THE BILL WAS
FIRST COMING FORWARD ABOUT ALL
THAT YOU KNOW WE'VE HAD TO HIRE
AT LEAST FIFTY OR TWO HUNDRED
NEW STAFF TO IMPLEMENT THIS
PROGRAM PART OF THAT IS
ENFORCEMENT.
PART OF THAT IS NEW INSPECTORS
TO DO ENHANCED ENFORCEMENT IN
THESE COMMUNITIES THAT'S
EXPECTED TO COME OUT OF THE
PROCESS --
SO FOR AT LEAST YOU'RE WANTING
YOUR TO A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF
MONEY WITH THAT ENOUGH.
WHEN COULD SPEAK TO THAT BUT IT
WASN'T QUITE ENOUGH TO COVER
EVERYTHING WE NEED THAT LEVEL OF
FUNDING GOING FORWARD WE THINK
IT'S ABOUT A THIRTY MILLION
DOLLAR A YEAR PROGRAM JUST IN
SOUTH COAST? TO MOVE FORWARD TO
BRING NEW COMMUNITIES IN AND
HAVE THAT THAT.
DADDY MARCH FORWARD TO BRING NEW
COMMUNITIES IN AN AND OF
IMPLEMENTING PLANS AND PREVIOUS
COMMUNITIES --
TO WE'RE GRATEFUL THAT THE
LEGISLATURE HAS PROVIDED FUNDING
FOR TWO YEARS AND HOPEFULLY IN
THE COMING YEAR AS WELL.
ALL RIGHT SO SO ENTER IN TERMS
OF A LIKE.
FOCUSING ON THE TORCH REFINERY
MY DISTRICT I MEAN WHAT WHEN CAN
WE EXPECT TO SEE.
THE THIS AIR POLLUTION REDUCING
TECHNOLOGY BEING --
INSTALLED AND AND PUT TO USE --
IT SO AS SOON AS POSSIBLE IS
ALWAYS THE ANSWER BUT REFINERIES
ARE COMPLEX --
ORGANISMS AND YOU KNOW THEY THEY
HAVE TURN AROUND SCHEDULES HAVE
DIFFERENT SCHEDULES SO THE
THINGS THEY CAN DO FOR IT
QUICKLY WE WON'T REQUIRE THEM TO
DO QUICKLY AND THE THINGS THAT
NEED MORE TIME WILL TAKE MORE
TIME.
OUR GOALS AND MAXIMIZING THE
EARLY REDUCTIONS SO WHATEVER WE
CAN.
REQUIRE THEM TO DO EARLY WE WANT
TO FOCUS ON THE LARGEST EMITTING
EQUIPMENT --
AND MAKE SURE WE GET THOSE
BENEFITS AS EARLY AS POSSIBLE --
TO BE TO BE MONITORED YEAH A OR
D. FOOT FOR THE CONTROLS TO GO
ON SURE OKAY --
IT.
AM I CORRECT IN UNDERSTANDING
THAT.
THAT THE FLARING --
INCIDENTS --
GO.
BECAUSE THE SPIKES IN IN IN THE
THE THE THE AIR POLLUTION --
THAT -- THAT
AB SIX SEVENTEEN IS IS TRYING TO
TARGET.
THEY CAN --
SO AGAIN ROUTINE FLARING IS NOT
ALLOWED IT ONLY HAPPENS EITHER.
FOR EMERGENCY REASONS WHICH ARE
USUALLY THOSE BIG FLARES THAT
EVERYONE SEES ON THE NEWS AND
AND AND JESSE IS TALKING ABOUT --
ALSO THERE IS SOME WHAT'S KNOWN
AS NANA.
NANA TEEN FLARING WHEN THEY WERE
DOING CERTAIN ACTIVITIES AND
DOING TURNAROUNDS IN MAINTAINING
EQUIPMENT --
IT IT'S FOR THE NON ROUTINE
FLARING I THINK THERE'S SOME
THINGS THAT COULD BE DONE AND
JESSE MENTIONED SOME OF THEM
ENHANCING THE VAPOR RECOVERY
SYSTEMS TO HAVE MORE CAPACITY --
FOR THE EMERGENCY FLARING
SOMETIMES THAT'S TOUGH BUT I
THINK WE CAN WE CAN DO A LOT OF
WORK ABOUT.
A PUBLIC NOTIFICATION AND VAPOR
RECOVERY IS ONE THING BUT AT
SOME POINT THAT MAY RUN OUT SO
THEY MIGHT HAVE TO BE A FLARE
BUT WHAT CAN WE DO WITH
MONITORING AND ENFORCEMENT AND
AND MAKING SURE THE PUBLIC KNOWS.
WITH WHAT WITH YOU BEING EXPOSED --
TO SO IN SOME CASES YES THAT WE
HAVE SEEN --
SHORT TERM INCREASES WITH
ESPECIALLY DURING THOSE LARGER
FLYING OF AND THINGS BUT IT.
YEAH ON THAT AND THEN AGAIN.
DUE.
TO YOUR BILL ASSEMBLY MAN --
AB --
SIXTEEN FORTY SEVEN THERE'S
GONNA BE FENCE LINE MONITORING
AT ALL OUR REFINERIES --
WE WE PASSED INTO OUR WILL
ELEVEN EIGHTY BY THE ENDOF THIS
YEAR AS WELL AS COMMUNITY
MONITORING --
IN THE COMMUNITIES AROUND
REFINERIES WHICH OVERLAPS.
WITH THE A. B. SIX SEVENTEEN
COMMUNITIES IN MANY PLACES --
SO THAT IS ALL HAPPENING IN
PARALLEL EMPLOYMENT AB SIX
SEVENTEEN OR SO WHEN TO EXPECT
THOSE MONITORS TO BE UP AND
RUNNING.
THE DEADLINE IN THE BILL WHICH
IS THE END OF THIS YEAR.
OKAY -- SO.
I I I GUESS I I I I SHARE MY THE
THE THE FRUSTRATION THAT WAS EXT
EXPRESSED EARLIER IN THIS
HEARING BY.
MS GORDAN FROM WEST OAKLAND THAT --
YOU KNOW WE WE WE WE GET THESE
REPORTS FROM THE H. M. D. AS TO
YOU KNOW --
WENT WHEN THE THE FLARING IS
GOING TO HAPPEN AND AND AND WE
GET THESE REPORTS ON HOW MUCH
KNOCKS AND AND AND AND AND ALL
THIS OTHER NASTY STUFF IS IS
GOING TO BE MADE IN OUR
COMMUNITIES BUT YOU KNOW.
WELL I I JUST WANT TO UNDERSCORE
THAT -- THAT
THEY DID THAT THE COMMUNITY IS
IS IT YOU KNOW ESPECIALLY WHEN
WE SEE THESE DRAMATIC FLARES --
IT -- IT
JUST HEIGHTENS THE THE THE THE
THE CONCERN --
IS SO WHAT WITH THIS VAPOR
REDUCTION IS THAT PART OF THE
BARK TECHNOLOGY THAT'S BEING.
CONSIDERED [inaudible]
IT'S IT'S NOT QUITE PARK IT IS
NOT NECESSARILY CONTROL
TECHNOLOGY IN THAT SENSE BUT WE
DO WANT TO COME BACK WITH OUR
FLARE REDUCTION RULE.
AND SEE WHAT WE CAN DO AND ONE
OF THE POTENTIAL TECHNOLOGIES
THAT CAN DO THAT IS.
THEY DO HAVE PAPER RECOVERY
SYSTEMS --
BUT THE MAYBE THEY CAN BE
ENHANCED IT'LL --
LARGER CAN HANDLE MORE VOLUME SO
THOSE ARE THE THINGS WE'RE
LOOKING AT WE WANT TO WORK WITH
THE WITH THE STEERING COMMITTEE
IN A. B. SIX SEVENTEEN CONTEXT
TO HELP DEVELOP THAT --
IT WOULD APPLY TO ALL REFINERIES
BUT YOU KNOW OUR MAJOR
REFINERIES ARE MOSTLY IN THAT --
ONE COMMUNITY.
AM I CORRECT IN UNDERSTANDING
THAT THE THE TORRANCE REFINERY
WAS ONE OF THE MOST HIGHLY FIND --
REFINERIES AN INJURED
JURISDICTION.
I DON'T KNOW ABOUT FINDS OVERALL
I KNOW THEY HAVE PAID --
THE LARGEST AMOUNT OF MITIGATION
FEES FOR EXCESS FLARING IN THE
LAST SEVERAL YEARS BY FAR.
I DON'T KNOW ABOUT THE THE
SPECIFIC I DON'T HAVE THE
ENFORCEMENT NUMBERS ARE
COMMITTED AND LARGER.
SO THOSE MEDICATION FEES ARE
SEPARATE FROM THE THE ENHANCED
PENALTIES THAT --
WERE WERE SUPPOSED TO BE AN
ACTOR PURSUANT AB.
SIX SEVENTY YES YEAH THAT'S
RIGHT IN PLACE AT THE TIME.
SO ARE.
OUR OUR THEIR ENHANCED PENALTIES
FROM A NINETEEN THAT.
THAT ARE SUPPOSED TO ADDRESS --
THE EXCESSIVE WEARING AT THE
TORRANCE REFINERY.
LET'S SAY THAT IF THERE'S A
VIOLATION TO BE FOUND THEN WE
HAVE THE ABILITY TO USE THE
ADDITIONAL PENALTIES THAT WERE
BROUGHT OUT BY.
SIX SEVENTEEN BUT THE MEDICATION
ASPECT THAT TO TALK TO FIND WAS
REFERRING TO IS KILEY WITHIN I
WILL STRUCTURE.
SO WHERE WE HAVE THE AUTHORITY.
TO INVOKE THE HIGHER PENALTIES
WE WILL.
AIMING JUST A COUPLE YEARS AGO
WE DIDN'T INCREASES MITIGATION
FEES.
OR LIFTED A CAP ON THE
APPLICATION FEES.
SO IN IN IN IN TERMS OF THE HAVE
ANY OF THE ENHANCED PENALTIES
UNDER AB SIX SEVENTEEN BEEN
APPLIED TO THE TORRANCE REFINERY
SINCE THE PASSAGE OF THE THE OR
THE THE THE SIGNING OF THE BILL
INTO THE INTO LAW.
I CANNOT RECALL A VIOLATION AT
THE TORRANCE REFINERY SINCE THAT
TIME.
THERE HAVE BEEN POWER FAILURES
AND OTHER ISSUES.
OF WHETHER OR NOT THEY'RE A
VIOLATION THAT RESULTS FROM THE
INVESTIGATIONS THAT ARE ONGOING
OKAY.
SO SO -- IT
TO DATE THE THE THE PRIMARY HE
ON THE TORRANCE REFINERY FOR ITS
EXCESSIVE FLARING HAS BEEN FROM
THESE MEDICATION FEES.
THEY REALLY SEPARATE.
THE MITIGATION FEES VERSES THE
PENALTIES AND PENALTIES WOULD
COME AFTER THE VIOLATIONS HAVE
BEEN DETERMINED.
AND THEN WE WOULD ENTER AND
NEGOTIATIONS WITH THE ACTUAL
REFINERY ON THOSE.
HI I GUESS I'M LOOKING FOR YOU
KNOW SOME KIND OF INCENTIVE OR A
CARROT OR A STICK --
FOR THE TORTURE FINERY TO CUT
DOWN ON ALL OF THE EXCESSIVE --
FLARING.
AND I I I DON'T HEAR YOU KNOW --
MUCH OF A A CARROT OR A STICK
HERE YOU CAN CAN YET AND CAN
HELP THESE.
SORRY THE STATE WILL BE OUR
RETURN TO RULE ELEVEN EIGHTEEN
OKAY THAT WOULD BE THE STATE NOW
THAT WILL ALSO HAS.
I GUESS REVERSE CARE IT BECAUSE
IF THEY GO ABOVE SOME LIMITS --
THEN THEY HAVE TO PAY THESE
MITIGATION FEES --
WHETHER THAT CONTINUES IN THE
ROLE GOING FORWARD AND WE JUST
HAVE A STAKE IN SOMETHING THAT
WILL LOOK AT WHEN WE OPEN THAT
RULE AGAIN.
AND SO YOU EXPECT THE THE
ADOPTION OF THE REVISED RULE
ELEVEN EIGHTEEN BY THE END OF
THIS YEAR --
PROBABLY NEXT YEAR AGAIN WE WE
WANT TO HEAR FROM THE COMMUNITY
MEMBERS LIKE JESSE WHO HAS THE
EXPERIENCE.
AND HAS LOOKED INTO THESE
TECHNOLOGIES WE WANT TO WORK
WITH THE COMMUNITY GROUPS WITHIN
AB -- SIX
SEVENTEEN TO HELP DEVELOP IDEAS
FOR THAT WILL PUT THAT IN THE
COMMUNITY EMISSION REDUCTION
PLAN MAKE A COMMITMENT TO COME
BACK IN.
AND THEN.
JUST LIKE WE DO IN OUR CALL ON
THAT RULE AS PART IMPLEMENTATION
OF THE PLAN [inaudible]
OKAY.
MAY I I JUST LIKE TO SUM UP I
MEAN I YOU KNOW MAYBE I DON'T
UNDERSTAND THE TELL THE
CHALLENGES THAT YOU'RE FACING
BUT IT BUT I I I'M I'M SEEING
THINGS FROM THE COMMUNITIES
PERSPECTIVE THAT DATE.
THAT YOU'RE YOU YOU'VE BEEN
CONDUCTING A A LT OF THESE
COMMUNITY OUTREACH ACTIVITIES
AND YOU KNOW I KNOW I I GET ALL
OF YOUR YOUR EMAILS.
BUT I DON'T SEE THINGS CHANGING.
AND AND I THINK THAT'S THE
BOTTOM LINE FOR PEOPLE IN THE
COMMUNITY --
AND SO I JUST WANT TO EXPRESS MY
FRUSTRATION THANK YOU.
CAN I CAN IS A QUESTION OF CARD.
EARLIER I SAID ACT AND I HAVE A
QUESTION FOR YOU LATER WHEN THE
PRESENTATIONS ARE.
ARE GOING ON IF WE'RE FINISHED
WITH THIS PANEL WHY DON'T WE DO
HAVE ANOTHER QUESTION FOR ITS
RELATED TO THIS PANEL I KNOW
WHAT YOU WANT THEM TO STAY.
NOW THIS OR MAYBE THEY MAYBE
SOME FOM CARP COME UP TO THE
MIKE THAT MICROPHONE TO BRIEFLY
ANSWER QUESTIONS.
I MEAN IT'S IT'S THIS IS
SUPPOSED TO BE A COMMUNITY
DRIVEN PROCESS IN PARTNERSHIP
WITH OUR DISTRICTS AND I WANT TO
EMPHASIZE THAT WORD PARTNERSHIP
WITH THIRD DISTRICTS.
AND IN SOME PLACES ARE FOR YOUR
IN THAT OUT BETTER THAN OTHERS
IS THERE A ROLE FOR CARBON NOW
AND NOT LATER NOT WITH THE
SECOND ROUND OF COMMUNITIES TO
BE A BRIDGE. TO HELP CREATE A
BETTER PROCESS IN SOME OF THESE
CASES ROOM I HAVE A BREAK DOWN.
IS THERE A ROLE FOR YOU CARVE
WHATEVER'S ARCHIVE TO BE THE
BRIDGE.
TO WHOEVER YOU KNOW WHATEVER IT
IS SO THAT WE COULD HAVE A
BETTER PARTNERSHIP SAY HEY I'M
I'M SEEN.
THREE COMMUNITIES HERE THAT HAVE
A LOT OF POTENTIAL BUT ALSO A
LOT OF FRUSTRATION FROM THE TWO
SIDES IS THERE A WAY FOR CARP TO
BE A BRIDGE. TO CREATE A BETTER
PROCESS NOW AND NOT LATER AND
NOT TO SAY I'M GONNA LEARN FROM
THIS SO THAT THE NEXT THING
COMMUNITIES HAVE A BETTER.
HOW DO WE MAKE THESE COMMUNITIES
BETTER NOW AS YOU'VE ALREADY
HAVE RECOGNIZED?
FROM EACH COMMUNITY ISSUES ARE
DIFFERENT RIGHT THE DIFFERENCE
IN TERMS OF THE SOURCES THE
COMMUNITY CONCERNS.
AND WHAT YOU HEARD FROM ME
EARLIER IS TO EFFECTIVELY MOVE
FORWARD AND GET REAL REDUCTIONS
UNDER THIS PROGRAM.
IT REALLY IS COLLABORATION WITH
THE DISTRICT AND WITH THE
COMMUNITY SO TO YOUR DIRECT
QUESTION THERE'S RECEPTIVITY TO
SIT DOWN AND LESS WORK THROUGH
WHAT OUR OPTIONS ARE THESE ARE
TOUGH ISSUES SEVERAL THAT WHICH
ARE.
DISCUSSED BECAUSE A NUMBER OF
POINTS WERE RAISED I HEARD THE
LAND USE COMMENT WHICH IS
EXTRAORDINARILY DIFFICULT ISSUE.
WE NEED TO HAVE AN HONEST%
CONVERSATION ON AN ACT BALLS NOT
JUST THE DISTRICT IN THE
COMMUNITY REPRESENTATIVES.
THAT INVOLVES THE CITY THAT
INVOLVES LOCAL PLANNING
DECISIONS BECAUSE YOU KNOW IT'S
KIND OF THE ISSUE THAT I THINK
HAS BEEN SET ASIDE FOR A LONG
TIME AND THAT IS IS THAT.
AS WE'RE FOCUSING ON REDUCING
EMISSIONS AND SIX SEVENTEEN
COMMUNITIES.
THE OBVIOUS QUESTION THAT COMES
THE REST BRINGS THE FOR IS.
HOW DID THAT COMMUNITY GET
CREATED IN THE FIRST PLACE WHY
IS THAT WAREHOUSE LOCATED IN A
RESIDENTIAL COMMUNITY WISE THAT
CHROME PLATER?
NEAR THE HOME THE ABSOLUTE
ANSWER THAT QUESTION THE LAND
USE DECISION.
AND WE CAN CRAFT I'M CONVINCED
OF THIS IN TERMS OF GETTING REAL
REDUCTIONS AT THE COMMUNITY
LEVEL.
BUT WE SHOULD BE ASKING
OURSELVES HOW DO WE AVOID
CREATING NEW SEVENTY SIX
SEVENTEEN COMMUNITIES.
WE'VE GOT HELP LOCAL CITY AND
LOCAL SAYS THAT'S PART OF THIS
TO ENTERS WHAT YOU JUST
DESCRIBED.
AND IF WE'RE GOING TO ASK CARP
TO COME IN AND BE A BRIDGE IN
ALL FAIRNESS ALL PARTIES
INCLUDING MY COMMUNITY MEMBERS
ARE VERY FASCINATING TO BE OPEN
TO THAT TO THAT BRIDGE --
AND IN THAT INCLUDES THE
RESPONSES HERE BUT ALSO WITH
THOSE AGENCIES SO THAT WE ARE
DISCUSSING THE LINE USE ISSUE
WHICH KEEPS POPPING UP IN ALL OF
THESE I MEAN I THINK.
THAT THAT'S THE POSITIVE ABOUT
WHAT'S GOING ON YOU KNOW WHAT
I'M TALKING ABOUT THE WORK WE'VE
BEEN DOING FOR ALL THESE YEARS
BUT WE'RE ALSO KNOCKS.
SAYING YOU KNOW WHAT THIS LINE
IS AN IMPORTANT PART OF THIS
DISCUSSION ON THAT WE NEED TO BE
ELEVATING HERE.
SOME IF I COULD.
THE CARD HAS BEEN A GREAT
PARTNER WITH US AT THESE
COMMUNITY MEETINGS AND WE
GENERALLY HAVE ANYWHERE FROM.
I'LL SAY TWO TO FOUR CAR BOARD
MEMBERS. TO PARTICIPATE AT THESE
BOARD MEETINGS.
IN FACT IN ONE OF THE MOST
RECENT BOARD MEETINGS A CARB
STAFF MY UNDERSTANDING HAS
AGREED TO COME BACK.
AND PROVIDE SOME ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION AND TO ACT MORE AS
THAT COLLABORATIVE ASPECT.
BUT IT TRULY IS THAT PARTNERSHIP
IN AND I JUST WANT TO POINT OUT
THAT.
YOU KNOW YOU'RE HEARING FROM ONE
OF EACH OF US YOU KNOW WE HAVE
OVER THIRTY MEMBERS IN THE
COMMUNITY.
AND WE HAVE DIFFERENT VIEWS ON
MANY DIFFERENT THINGS. SIX
SEVENTEEN IS NOT BEING DONE IN --
MANY OTHER PROGRAMS HAVE BEEN
IMPLEMENTED THAT A PART OF THAT.
AND SO I JUST SORT OF ASK THAT
YOU CONSIDER THAT AS WITH ME FOR
BUT WE REMAIN COMMITTED. TO
WORKING IN PARTNERSHIP. TO DOING
ALL THESE THINGS AND RECOGNIZING
THE CHALLENGE THAT WE HAVE AND
AND I ESPECIALLY WANT TO TAKE TO
HEART WHAT YOU SAID ABOUT THE
TIMING.
BECAUSE I TAKE THOSE DEADLINES
VERY SERIOUSLY AND I TAKE THE
ASPECT OF TRYING TO GET THOSE
REDUCTIONS AS SOON AS POSSIBLE.
AND IF IT'S ON THE HEAVY DUTY
SECTOR WE KNOW WHAT'S THERE.
IF IT'S A QUESTION OF WHAT ARE
THE TECHNOLOGY THAT'S AVAILABLE
LET'S HAVE THAT DISCUSSION.
BECAUSE WHILE ELECTRIC VEHICLES
ARE AVAILABLE AND YOU CAN ORDER
IT YOU MAY NOT HAVE THE
INFRASTRUCTURE IN PLACE.
LET'S LET'S HAVE THAT DISCUSSION
IN TERMS OF GETTING THE
INFRASTRUCTURE IN PLACE GETTING
THE TECHNOLOGY IN PLACE AND
REALLY UNDERSTANDING.
WHAT ARE THE TIME HORIZONS
BEFORE WE START ACTUALLY
REALIZING THOSE BENEFITS IN
LIGHT OF OTHER TECHNOLOGIES THAT
MIGHT GIVE US?
MORE REDUCE EMISSIONS SOONER
RATHER THAN LATER BUT NOT
NECESSARILY GET IS TO ZERO AND
WE ALL AGREE.
FROM A CLIMATE AND QUITE TO
RIPPLING PERSPECTIVE ZERO WAS
WHERE WE NEED TO BE.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ALL VERY MUCH.
OKAY MOVING ON TO PORT SIDE
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
NEIGHBORHOODS IN SAN DIEGO.
WE HAVE BOB CARD OF SAN DIEGO
COUNTY AIR POLLUTION CONTROL
DISTRICT AND DIANE TALK FLORIAN
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH COALITION.
YOU WILL EACH HAVE EIGHT MINUTES
THANK YOU [inaudible]
SO
.
GOOD EVENING CHAIR FRIEDMAN MY
NAME IS BOB CARD OF THE DIRECTOR
OF THE SAN DIEGO COUNTY --
POLLUTION CONTROL DISTRICT I
BROUGHT WITH ME ALSO ANNOUNCES
JOHN ADAMS THE ASSISTANT
DIRECTOR --
HE'S VERY KNOWLEDGEABLE HE'S
BEEN THE LEAD PERSON.
IN THIS PROGRAM THE SIX ONE
SEVEN PROGRAM.
AND SO HERE TO DO A BRIEF
PRESENTATION AND OF COURSE
ENTERTAIN QUESTIONS AND DIANNE
TECH FOREIGN WILL HAVE.
THANKS TO SAY AS WELL SO THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE
HERE IT'S MUCH APPRECIATED.
SO THE COMMUNITY OF PORT SIDE
ENVIRONMENTAL IN BURLEY
DISADVANTAGED NEIGHBORHOODS
THAT'S A MOUTHFUL --
AS YOU SEE UP.
ON THE MAP ACTUALLY WHAT YOU
HAVE IS ON THE RIGHT THIRTY
SEVEN CENSUS TRACKS AS
DETERMINED BY COLIN VIRUS SCREEN.
FAR UPPER RIGHT ON THAT ONE IS
THE BLUE --
ELCA HONE AREA AND THEN MOVING
DOWN YOU'LL SEE THE CHULA VISTA
AREA AND YELLOW AT THE BOTTOM
AND THERE'S A DARK BLUE AREA --
WHICH IS THE PORT SIDE COMMITTEE
IS AS WE'VE IDENTIFIED IT
WORKING WITH THE STEERING
COMMITTEE AND ACTUALLY WHAT
HAPPENED IS LEADING UP THE
STREET COMMITTEE WE HAD ABOUT.
SIX COMMUNITY MEETINGS.
WITH --
DIANE TECH FOR IN AND MANY OTHER
PEOPLE TO DISCUSS WHAT THEY FELT
THEIR NEEDS WERE HOW WE NEED TO
APPROACH THIS AND IT NEVER
REALLY VALUABLE BECAUSE WE ALSO
LEARNED.
THAT PEOPLE DON'T EVEN KNOW WHO
TO CALL IF THERE'S A COMPLAINT
AND THAT'S BEEN A BIG
IMPROVEMENT FOR US TO BE ABLE TO
HELP OUT IN THAT REGARD.
SO ON THE LEFT OR THE TWELVE
CENSUS TRACTS OF THE THIRTY
SEVEN THAT ARE PART OF OF THE
SIX ONE SEVEN COMMUNITY THE
PORTS LIKE ME THAT CARP HAS
CHOSEN.
AND WE THINK IT'S A GREAT PLACE
TO START WE HAVE A LOT MORE
WE'RE GONNA DO AS I MENTIONED IN
A MINUTE.
BUT WHAT WE HAVE FOR THE PORT
SIDE COMMITTEE IS LOGAN HEIGHTS
BAR LOGAN AND WEST NATIONAL CITY
AND AGAIN THAT'S THE DARK BLUE
AREA BOTH IN SMALL ON THE RIGHT
AND AND LARGER FORMAT ON THE
LEFT.
OTHER AREAS WE'RE CERTAINLY
INTERESTED IN OUR SANTA SEE
THROUGH TO LIVE IS TO THE
REMAINDER OF NATIONAL CITY --
AT EL CAJON WE WE ANTICIPATE
LOOKING AT THESE AREAS EVEN MORE
AND I'LL TALK A MINUTE ABOUT
MOLD WONDERING WHERE WE ARE
ACTUALLY OUT AND ABOUT ALREADY
STARTING ON MARCH ONE DOING SOME
MONITORING.
SO WE GET UP THE NEXT SLIDE --
THAT'S ME HOW.
SO WITH THE STEERING COMMITTEE
THAT FORMED --
WE HAVE IT A TWENTY FOUR MEMBER
JOHN TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FOUR
MEMBERS TWELVE OF WHOM ARE
RESIDENTS IN THE COMMUNITY AND
THEN THERE ARE A VARIETY OF
OTHER PEOPLE WERE LOOKING TO ADD
SOME MEMBERS.
SO IT IS NOT JUST AN EVEN SPLIT
BUT MORE THE RESIDENTS WILL BE
IN THE MAJORITY THERE --
INCLUDING A MEDICAL DOCTOR
PORTER SAN DIEGO'S THERE THE
INFORMAL HEALTH COALITION.
EVEN THE INDUSTRIAL
ENVIRONMENTAL SO SHE'S IN MANY
OTHERS AND IT'S BEEN A REALLY
COLLABORATIVE EFFORT FRANKLY
WHEN YOU SEE THESE MEETINGS AND
JOHN IS THE ONE WHO LEADS THESE --
IT'S COLLABORATIVE THERE'S A LOT
OF INTERACTION AND I THINK
REALLY THE OUTCOMES ARE VERY
GOOD IN TERMS OF WHAT WE LEARNED
ABOUT WHAT WE SHOULD BE DOING TO
NOT ONLY MONITOR BUT EVENTUALLY
PROTECT FOLKS ARE EMISSION
REDUCTION.
ACTIVITIES --
AND WE WERE CHOSEN BY THE STATE
TO INITIALLY JUST TO THE
ASSESSMENT NOT TO DO EMISSION
REDUCTIONS RIGHT AWAY BUT I WILL
TALK IN A MINUTE ABOUT HOW WE'RE
ACTUALLY ALREADY DOING SOME
EMISSION REDUCTIONS THAT ARE
SIGNIFICANT IN THE AREA --
SO WITH THE MONITORING PLANS
WE'RE GONNA BE DOING A VARIETY
OF THINGS WE WE'RE GONNA MONITOR --
WE HOPE BETWEEN TWELVE AND
FIFTEEN LOCATIONS WITH
STATIONARY EQUIPMENT AND THIS IS
A REFERENCE METHOD OF MEASURES
NOT PORTABLE MONGERS PER SE BUT
TRANSPORTABLE.
SO FIRST ALL ON THE RIGHT AS I
MENTIONED A MOMENT AGO WE HAVE A
COMPANY ALL RIGHT NOW AS OF
MARCH.
ONE DRIVING JOHN YOU SAID ALL
THE ALL THIRTY SEVEN CENSUS
TRACKS YES OKAY ALL THIRTY SEVEN
CENSUS TRACKS WITH A PORTABLE
MONITOR.
AND THEY'RE GONNA BE LOOKING AT
PARTICULATE MATTER OZONE
NITROGEN OXIDES CARBON MONOXIDE
AND CO.
TWO OF JUST TO SEE WHAT'S OUT
THERE TO GIVE US A SNAPSHOT IF
YOU WILL IN THEIR DRIVING EACH
ROAD TWENTY TIMES IN THE THIRTY
SEVEN CENSUS TRACKS. TO SEE
WHAT'S OUT THERE TO SEE WHERE WE
NEED TO BE LOOKING EVEN IF WE'RE
NOT CURRENTLY IN THAT AREA WORSE
FOR IN THE PORTS LIKE COMMUNITY
RIGHT NOW --
SO THE COMMITTEE HAS APPROVED SO
FAR TO MONITORING LOCATIONS AND
ONE IS -- IN
THE PORT UP WIND DOWN ONE OF SAN
DIEGO BAY BUT UP WIND OF THE
PORT ACTIVITIES THEMSELVES.
AND THAT'S THE TENTH AVENUE
MARINE TERMINAL JONES THAT
CORRECT THAT'S CORRECT OKAY AND
SO WITH THAT WE'RE GOING TO DO
THAT AND ALSO WE HAVE SHERMAN
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL WHICH IS IN
THE MORE THE SOUTHERN PORTION OF
THAT AREA CENTRAL SOUTHERN.
AND WE'RE GONNA HELP WE HAVE A
FULL BLOWN MONITORING STATION
THERE --
THAT WE'RE PUTTING AND WE HAD TO
MOVE FROM PERKINS ELEMENTARY AND
IN THE MIDDLE OF OUR LOGIN AREA
BUT THAT'S A FULL BLOWN
MONITORING STATION WHICH IS
GOING TO COUNT TOWARD THIS
BECAUSE IT IS VERY LOCALIZED.
AND AGAIN --
WHAT WE'RE GONNA MEASURE AT THE
TWO SITES --
PARTICULATE MATTER BLACK CARBON
MEANING DIESEL EXHAUST JOHN YOU
WANT TO ADD A LITTLE BIT ON THAT
SO GRADING TOXIC BILL SEES TOXIC
ORGANIC COMPOUNDS OF BLACK
CARBON OR DIESEL PARTICULATES
AND TOXIC METALS.
IT WAS A TOXIC METALS AND THE
BLACK CARBON OR DIESEL
PARTICULATE THAT THE COMMITTEE
OF THE RESIDENTS WANTED TO SEE
SO WE INCORPORATED. FOR THAT
INTO OUR PROGRAM.
SO WE'RE OFF THE BAT WE'RE NOT
USING OF INEXPENSIVE OTHERS WERE
GOING WITH FULL BLOWN REFERENCE
METHODS THAT WE THINK WILL GIVE
US.
REAL DATA THAT'LL HELP US
DETERMINE ASCERTAIN WHAT THE
SOURCES ARE OF THOSE POLLUTANTS
IN THE COMMUNITY --
WE DO HAVE PURPLE --
MONITORS HAVE HEARD PEOPLE
MENTION THAT WE HAVE A FEW THOSE
WERE TESTING BUT WE REALLY DID
WANT TO GET A REFERENCE METHOD
INVOLVES WERE DOING THIS OR
SPENDING THE MONEY ON THAT AND
AGAIN.
JUST TO EMPHASIZE THAT FOR SOME
OF THE FUNDING IS OBVIOUSLY THE
TO BECAUSE IT'S EXPENSIVE TO DO
THAT.
WE ALSO HAVE ANOTHER MONITORING
SITE OUT IN EL CAJON AT LIKE SIX
IN ELEMENTARY SCHOOL THAT'S OUR
NATIONAL COURSE A WHICH IS A
COMPREHENSIVE.
ON EMISSIONS MONITORING
INCLUDING FOR THE METAL LEAD
SINCE WE HAVE GILLESPIE FIELD
AND AIRCRAFT NEARBY.
AND OF BLACK CARBON AS WELL.
SO ON A MISSION REDUCTIONS ON
ALL THE TALK ABOUT THAT A LITTLE
BIT BECAUSE ALTHOUGH WE'RE NOT
DOING MORE THAN WE WERE DOING
WE'RE DOING A LOT AND SORE
CURRENT CURRENT COMMUNITY WAS
SELECTED FOR MONITORING AS I
MENTIONED.
WE HAVE INCREASED STATIONARY
SOURCE INSPECTIONS WE'VE BEEN
DOING THAT FOR SO FOR YEARS IN
THIS AREA BECAUSE WE SEE IN NEED
BECAUSE OF THE SENSITIVITY OF
THE COMMUNITY TO BE OTHER MORE
FREQUENTLY TO ENSURE THE
STATIONARY SOURCES.
ARE IN FACT FULLY COMPLYING WITH
THE REGULATIONS AND WE RUN A
VERY AGGRESSIVE ENFORCEMENT
PROGRAM.
BUT WE DON'T AS AN ASIDE WE ALSO
RUN A GRAHAM SO THAT WE CAN
REALLY DO POLLUTION PREVENTION
BY HELPING PEOPLE BE EDUCATED
AND NOT CAUSE A PROBLEM IN THE
FIRST PLACE --
FOR INCREASED MOBILE SOURCE
INSPECTIONS WE HAVE AN MO YOU
WITH CARB AND WITH THE CHP
ALLOWING US TO A TRUCK STOPS AND
INSPECT HEAVY DUTY TRUCKS AND
AND FOR DIESEL EMISSIONS AND THE
TRANSPORT REFRIGERATION UNITS
WHICH OF THE NCC UP ON THE BACK
OF THE TRAILERS.
AND WE'VE DONE OVER FIVE
THOUSAND OF THOSE KIND OF
INSPECTIONS LONG WITH OFF ROAD
DIESEL POWERED EQUIPMENT IT'S
BEEN A VERY SUCCESSFUL PROGRAM
JONES ONE AT ANYTHING ON THAT --
SO WHAT THE THE HEAVY DUTY
INSPECTIONS OF BOB MENTIONED
WOULDN'T WITH CITIES PRETTY
THOSE ARE AT THE BORDER OF THE
CENTRAL FREE AND PARADISE AND I
FIFTEEN FOR ALSO DOING TRUCK
INSPECTIONS WITHIN THE COMMUNITY.
WE'RE ALSO DOING IDLE
INSPECTIONS WITHIN THE COMMITTEE
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT --
DIANE MIGHT MENTION IS THAT
THERE'S BEEN A REAL PROBLEM A
TRUCK TRUCK DRIVING DOWN LOCAL
ROADS.
OF AMERICA HEALTH COALITION LONG
SEE SAN DIEGO CAME UP WITH A
RULE THAT NO LONGER ALLOWS
TRUCKS ON CERTAIN ROADS TO ROUTE
THROUGH A VERIFYING THAT THEY'RE
NOT DRIVING DOWN THOSE ROADS AND
PARKING AND IDOLING AND SO.
WE DO A NUMBER INSPECTIONS THERE
WE ALSO DO OF OFFROAD EQUIP
INSPECTIONS WITHIN THE COMEDIAN
OUTSIDE THE THE VEHICLES COMING
INTO THE INTO THE COMMUNITY AND
IMPACT RESIDENTS.
AND THEN THE LAST --
DOT POINT ON THAT SLIDE OF THE
FOURTEEN MOBILE SOURCE EMISSIONS
REDUCTION PROJECTS --
JUST APPROVED FOR INCENTIVE
FUNDING OF OVER THREE MILLION
DOLLARS AND OUR ESTIMATE IS THAT
DURING THE LIFE OF THESE
PROJECTS AND AND AND THE PROJECT
LIFE VARIES. FIFTY TONS OF SMOG
FORMING POLLUTION WILL BE
ELIMINATED AND THREE POINT SEVEN
TONS OF PARK FINE PARTICULATE.
MATTER THAT'S IMPORTANT AND YOU
KNOW I HEARD OTHERS SAY ZERO
EMISSIONS WE AGREE.
MOBILE SOURCES ARE ARE.
ABOUT 70% OF OUR PROBLEM IN THAT
AREA AND YOU KNOW WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING THESE
PROJECTS JOHN WAS A POOR SAN
DIEGO MEETING JUST LAST WEEK.
AND THAT THEY'RE FINALLY
STEPPING UP WE HOPE TO THE PLATE
TO LOOK FOR GRANT MONEY THAT WE
HAVE TO OFFER AND DO SOME
PROJECTS THAT WILL REALLY HELP
OUT THIS COMMUNITY. TEN KEY
POINT HERE IS CONTINUED FUNDING
IT'S EXPENSIVE WE CANNOT BILL OR
STATIONARY SOURCES AND LESS FOR
DOING SO.
IT WOULD BE CONSIDERED A TAXES I
HEARD ASSEMBLY WOMAN GARCIA SAY.
UNLESS IT'S DIRECTLY RELATED TO
THEM AND SO THE FUNDING FROM THE
STATE IS KEY.
YOU KNOW IT WE LIKE DOING THIS
PROGRAM WE'VE LONG SCENE IN NEED
FOR IT AND I'M GLAD SIX ONE
SEVEN IS PASSED --
I THINK WERE ENTHUSIASTIC --
IT'S BEEN GREAT WORKING WITH THE
VIRAL HOLD COALITION AND LIKE I
SAID WE WANT TO BE CUTTING EDGE
ON THIS AND WE WANT TO BE
AGGRESSIVE ABOUT IT.
AND WE ARE DOING THAT BUT I JUST
I SEE IT IS NOTHING BUT POSITIVE
THE FUTURE GOES ON AND I GOTTA
TELL JOHN.
RIGHT HERE FOR YOU GUYS HE'S
DONE THESE COMMUNITY --
STEERING COMMITTEE MEETINGS AND
HE'S GOT PEOPLE TALKING THAT I
NEVER THOUGHT MUCH OF TALK
TOGETHER BEFORE.
AND IT'S BEEN VERY GOOD WE GET A
LOT OF FEEDBACK AS I TOLD THOSE
FOLKS AND JOHN HAS UNTIL THE
LEGISLATURE.
IF YOU SEE THAT WE NEED TO BE
DOING SOMETHING.
TELL ME WE'LL DO IT.
WON'T MAKE EXCUSES WILL GET IT
DONE AND THAT'S HOW WE WERE.
SO WE'RE HERE FOR QUESTIONS AND
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
[inaudible]
THANK YOU --
PANTECH FOR IN --
I AM THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH COALITION
AND WE'RE A MEMBER OF THE SAN
DIEGO PORT SIDE --
COMMUNITIES PROJECT COORDINATED
BY THE SAN DIEGO AIR POLLUTION
CONTROL DISTRICT --
I ALSO SERVE AS A MEMBER OF THE
CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES BOARD
AS YOU MAY KNOW --
AND ITS UNIQUE PERSPECTIVE THAT
I'M REALLY GRATEFUL TO HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SERVE IN BOTH
CAPACITIES BUT TODAY I'M
REPRESENTING ENVIRONMENTAL
HEALTH COALITION --
BUT NO MATTER WHAT ROLE AYE MAN --
I THINK THAT MY JOB IS TO
IMPROVE COMMUNITIES JUST LIKE
THE OTHER ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
ORGANIZATIONS THAT HAVE BEEN
BEFORE YOU TODAY.
I THINK AB SIX SEVENTEEN
REPRESENTS A UNIQUE OPPORTUNITY
AND AN INTEGRATED OPPORTUNITY TO
LOOK AT HEALTH AND CUT AND THE
QUALITY OF LIFE IN COMMUNITIES --
BECAUSE IT'S INTEGRATED.
AND HOLISTIC --
I JUST WANT TO SAY FROM THE
BEGINNING AND I'LL SAY IT
PROBABLY MULTIPLE TIMES IS
COMMUNITY RESIDENTS ARE NOT
INTERESTED IN --
ENGAGING IN CONTINUED ARGUMENTS
ABOUT WHAT SOURCES OF POLLUTION
ARE THE WORST AND WHICH ONES
WERE GOING TO CHOOSE FROM --
THEY WANTCLEAN AIR NOW --
AND THEY WANT ACTION TO BE TAKEN
SO PART OF MY GOAL TODAY IS TO
SHOW YOU --
WHAT WE'RE LOOKING AT IN TERMS
OF THE WORK THAT'S ALREADY BEEN
DONE IN THE COMMUNITY AND WHAT
WE'D LIKE TO SEE GOING FORWARD
SO AS A BOB ILLUSTRATED THESE
ARE THE COMMUNITIES THAT WE'RE
FOCUSING ON IN THE PORT SIDE
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
COMMUNITIES?
THESE ARE NEIGHBORHOODS AT RISK
AND THIS GIVES YOU AN OVERLAY OF
THE COUNT ON VIRUS SCREEN --
WITH THE PORT SIDE COMMUNITY SO
WANT YOU TO SEE --
THAT THESE ARE SOME OF THE
CENSUS TRACKS HERE ARE IN THE
TOP 5% IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA FOR IMPACTS SO THIS
IS PART OF THE REASON THAT THEY
WERE SELECTED.
AND THESE ARE THE CHALLENGES
THAT THESE --
COMMUNITIES EXPERIENCE ONE OF
THE DIESEL EMISSIONS THAT ARE
OCCURRING IN THESE COMMUNITIES
THAT ARE DRIVING --
DRIVING THE AIR POLLUTION AND
DRIVING THE UNACCEPTABLE
UNACCEPTABLE IMPACT IN OUR
COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE RESULTED
IN CHILDREN'S ASTHMA E. R. RATES
AT THREE TIMES THE RATE OF THE
COUNTY WIDE AVERAGE.
AND OF THE FREEWAYS IS WHAT THE
FREEWAYS IN ADDITION TO THE
STATIONARY SOURCES INDUSTRIAL
SOURCES ARE ARE SOME OF THE
CAUSES FOR THIS --
THIS MOST RECENT DATA IS FROM
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND ITS
AND THESE E. R. ASTHMA RATES ARE
HIGHER THAN 92% OF THE CENSUS
TRACKS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SO WE HAVE A SERIOUS
PROBLEM.
WITH CHILDREN'S HEALTH WE ALSO
HAVE A PROBLEM WITH LIFE
EXPECTANCY AS YOU CAN SEE FROM
THIS -- WE
HAVE SOME --
LIFE EXPECTANCY THAT'S QUITE
REDUCED FROM THE COUNTY AVERAGE
IN THE SAME COMMUNITIES --
THESE PORT SIDE COMMUNITIES AND
BURIAL LOGAN AND NATIONAL CITY
IT SIX TIMES LESS THAN IT IS FOR
THE COUNTY AVERAGE WARS Là
HORIA --
WHICH IS A WHITE AND MORE
AFFLUENT COMMUNITY AND NOT
IMPACTED BY THIS POLLUTION THEY
GET -- FOUR
TIMES MORE --
YEARS OF FOUR TIMES MORE YEARS
TWO MEN OF MY MAN OUR THE PEOPLE
OF COLOR FAMILIES IN POVERTY AND
LARGELY RANCHERS AND YOUNG
POPULATIONS AND I THINK THESE
PROFILES MATCH A LOT OF THE
OTHER COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
INCLUDED IN THE PROGRAM.
OUR COMMUNITIES MEMBERS HAVE
CLEARLY BEEN CONCERNED ABOUT A
VARIETY OF AIRBORNE SOURCES OF
POLLUTION --
FROM TRUCKS AND SHIPS FROM
INCOMPATIBLE LAND USES --
TO TO AND ACCIDENTS THAT ARE
OCCURRING IN OUR COMMUNITIES.
YOU'VE TALKED.
A LOT TODAY ABOUT INCOMPATIBLE
LAND USE AND THIS IS AN EXAMPLE
IN MARIO LOGAN WHERE WE HAVE A
PRAXAIR FACILITY --
THAT HAD HAS HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF GALLONS OF OF OF
MATERIAL AS WELL AS COMPRESSED
GAS --
THAT'S LOCATED RIGHT ACROSS THE
STREET FROM A HOME OF FACILITY
LIKE THIS --
HAD AN EXTREME FIRE IN THE
MIDWEST THEY WERE SURROUNDED BY
NO HOMES THEY WERE SURROUNDED BY
MILES OF EMPTY LAND --
AND WORKERS WERE INJURED BUT NO
RESIDENTS WERE INJURED SO YOU
CAN IMAGINE WHAT WOULD HAPPEN
HERE IF THAT SAME KIND OF
ACCIDENT WERE TO OCCUR WE ALSO
HAVE BUSINESSES IN THE COMMUNITY
AS JOHN MENTIONED THAT ARE
ATTRACTING.
HEAVY DUTY DIESEL TRUCKS THIS
PHOTO WAS TAKEN FROM US
APARTMENT IN A SENIOR COMMUNITY
COMPLEX WHERE WE HAVE AN AIR
MONITORING.
DEVICE --
THIS IS WHAT GOES ON THESE
TRUCKS ARE COMING IN AND OUT.
WE'RE ALSO HAVE A LOT OF
RECYCLING FACILITIES --
THAT ARE LOCATED IN A COMMUNITY
LIKE THIS ONE AND THIS IS WHAT
HAPPENED IN TWENTY FIFTEEN IT
BLEW UP IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
NIGHT -- AND
OF THE FIRE WENT ON FOR FOR
QUITE SOME TIME.
THE PORT OF SAN DIEGO IS
CRITICAL --
TO ALLOWING US TO REALLY HAVE
EMISSION REDUCTIONS TO OTHER IT
THE CARGO TERMINALS ARE RUN BY
THE PORT OF SAN DIEGO AS WELL AS
THE PORT BEING A LANDLORD --
TO SOME FOUR HUNDRED BUSINESSES
INCLUDING LARGE FACILITIES LIKE
THIS SHIP YARD --
WHICH AS YOU CAN SEE IS LOCATED
RIGHT ADJACENT --
TO THE OF THE RESIDENTIAL
COMMUNITIES --
WE ALSO HAVE THE TENTH AVENUE
TERMINAL WHICH IS A SIGNIFICANT
SOURCE OF EMISSIONS --
DOLE IS THE LARGEST TENANT THERE
THE IMPORT ABOUT TWO BILLION
BANANAS A YEAR CLOSE TO A
THOUSAND TRUCK TRIPS EVERY WEEK --
AND IN NATIONAL CITY --
WE HAVE ABOUT ONE OUT OF CARS
THAT THROUGH THIS TERMINAL --
RESULTING IN ABOUT A HALF A
MILLION CARS A YEAR AND
THOUSANDS OF TRUCK TRIPS --
EACH MONTH.
SO THE ONLY PUBLIC PARK ON THE
NATIONAL CITY WATERFRONT IS
RIGHT HERE --
WHERE THAT COMMUNITY MEMBERS GET
TO SHARE THE PARK WITH THE
INCOMING SHIPS WITH ALL THE?
ALL THE TRUCKS NIGHT EXCUSE ME
HOW THE CARS --
AND THEN THERE'S ALSO A REAL
REAL YARD --
WHICH CREATES CANCER RISKS OF
ABOUT FIFTY TO A HUNDRED PER
MILLION AT THE LOCAL ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL.
SO WE KNOW A LOT AND I THINK
THAT'S MY MAIN MESSAGE HERE --
IS THAT WHILE WE APPRECIATE THAT
MONITORING PROGRAMS AND WE
SUPPORT THOSE AND WE'RE
CONDUCTING SOME OURSELVES WE
KNOW A LOT AND WE CAN BEGIN TO
TAKE ACTION AND THE COMMUNITY
HAS ALREADY STARTED TO DO THAT.
SO OF COMMUNITY MEMBERS HAVE
BEEN ON THE FRONT LINES AS THESE
TO OUR COMMUNITY MEMBERS ARE
SAYING.
AND WHILE COMMUNITY.
ABOUT AIR POLLUTION HAS NOT
SIGNIFICANTLY --
IMPROVED IN OUR COMMUNITIES
COMMUNITY RESIDENTS KEEP COMING
UP WITH IDEAS FOR HOW THESE
THINGS CAN CHANGE --
LIKE SEPARATING INDUSTRIES FROM
RESIDENTIAL AND SCHOOL AREAS
WHICH DOESN'T ACTUALLY REDUCE --
POLLUTION BUT IT DOES REDUCE
THEIR EXPOSURE OBVIOUSLY --
WE HAVE HAD --
TO HAVE A OF SUCCESSFULLY
ADOPTED --
GOTTEN ADOPTION OF THE WEST SIDE
SPECIFIC PLAN IN NATIONAL CITY
WHICH ACTUALLY CHANGES THE
ZONING.
SO WHILE WE HAVEN'T HAD.
MUCH SUPPORT FROM --
THE LOCAL AIR DISTRICT IN THIS
REGARD BOOK THIS IS THE PURVIEW
OF THE LOCAL --
CITY THEY HAVE GONE FORWARD TO
TAKE THESE ACTIONS SO I GUESS
GIVEN YOUR CONVERSATION I WANT
YOU TO KNOW THAT CITIES ARE
STEPPING UP --
TO TAKE THESE ACTIONS BUT THEY
NEED THE HELP OF THE LOCAL AIR
DISTRICTS AND THEY NEED HELP --
FROM CARP IN ORDER TO MAKE THIS
THIS HAPPEN --
WE ACTUALLY DID UTILIZED THE
LAND USE GUIDANCE THE CAR HAD --
DEVELOPED IN ORDER TO GIVE
JUSTIFICATION FOR THIS KIND OF
LAND USE CHANGE --
SO.
I THINK THE OTHER THING IS IS
THAT NATIONAL CITY HAS ADOPTED
AN AMORTIZATION ORDINANCE WHICH
RANKED ALL OF THE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY UP POLLUTION SOURCES NEAR
THE ELEMENTARY SCHOOL AND BEGAN
A PHASE OUT PROCESS --
SO THAT THESE FACILITIES WOULD
BE PHASED OUT AS NONCONFORMING
USES.
SO --
COMMUNITIES DOING A LOT THEY
WANTED A SIGN IN MORRELL AND SO
THAT IT WOULD SERVICE TRUCK
MEDICATION --
BOOKS ARE CREATIVE AND WE DID
RECENTLY GET A TRUCK ROUTE
ADOPTED --
IN THE CITY OF SAN DIEGO SO THAT --
THEY WOULDN'T BE GOING THROUGH
THE RESIDENTIAL COMMUNITY WE DID
CHANGE -- A
HAZARDOUS WASTE YARD RIGHT NEXT
TO THIS CREEK IN TO TWO HUNDRED
AND ONE AFFORDABLE HOUSING --
UNITS WITH THE HELP OF THE G. G.
R. F. FUNDS.
BUT THE COMMUNITY MEMBERS WANT
CLEAN AIR AND THAT'S NOT
HAPPENING AND THEY HAVE ASKED
OVER AND OVER AGAIN FOR IT TO
HAPPEN I THINK SIX SEVENTEEN IS
A REAL OPPORTUNITY.
AND IT'S AN OPPORTUNITY THAT I
THINK THE AIR POLLUTION CONTROL
DISTRICT IN SAN DIEGO IS HELPING
TO CREATE.
OF A SYSTEM IN A FRAMEWORK FOR
IT TO HAPPEN BUT FRANKLY OUR
CONCERNS ARE THAT THE STAFF OF
THE AIR POLLUTION CONTROL
DISTRICT IN SAN DIEGO IS QUITE
DIFFERENT IN THE BOARD.
OF THE AIR POLLUTION CONTROL
DISTRICT AND IN ORDER TO GET THE
EMISSION REDUCTIONS THAT FOLKS
REALLY WANT LIKE THESE --
THAT WE'VE ASKED FOR REPEATEDLY
WE'RE GONNA NEED NEW RULES WE'RE
GONNA NEED --
STRONG AUTHORITY FROM I NEED
HELP SOURCES BOARD IN ORDER FOR
THESE SOURCES TO BE REDUCED AND
EMISSION REDUCTIONS IS REALLY
WHERE IT'S AT AND THEY'VE REALLY
APPRECIATED THE EMPHASIS ON THAT --
IN BOTH OUR LOCAL COMMITTEE AS
WELL AS HERE AT THE STATE LEVEL
WE WE REALLY FEEL STRONGLY THAT
THAT THE PORT SOURCES AND THE
SHIPS AND SHIPYARDS AND THE NAVY
ARE THE AS WELL AS THE ROADWAYS
OBVIOUSLY --
ARE THE PLACES WHERE WE REALLY
NEED THE EMISSION REDUCTIONS TO
OCCUR.
WE ARE --
APPRECIATIVE THAT THE PORT OF
SAN DIEGO HAS SIGNALED TO THEIR
STAFF THAT CLEAN AIR PLAN SHOULD
BE DEVELOPED IN THAT JUST
HAPPENED LAST WEEK I DON'T THINK
THAT WOULD HAVE HAPPENED WITHOUT.
THE SIX SEVENTEEN PUSH I THINK
THAT'S A DIRECT RESULT AND WE
APPRECIATE THE AIR POLLUTION
CONTROL DISTRICT BEING THERE TO
SUPPORT THAT BUT I HAVE TO SAY
THAT THAT SOMETHING THAT'S BEEN
REQUESTED.
A ZERO MISSION PLANNED FOR THE
PORT OF SAN DIEGO --
FOR MANY YEARS SO SO IT'S NOT
SOMETHING THAT'S NEW AND I'M.
I'LL WRAP UP AS I CAN SEE IT
HERE THE US ME TOO SO ANY
QUESTIONS THAT YOU MIGHT HAVE
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER.
THANK YOU YOU'RE WELCOME --
ANY MISS CHRISTINA DO YOU HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS COMMENTS
[inaudible]
OKAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
WE ARE MOVING NOW TO SOUTH
CENTRAL FRESNO IN SCHAEFER WE
HAVE SOME HERE SHE CHIC FROM
SENATE FROM THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY AIR POLLUTION CONTROL
DISTRICT.
KEVIN HAMILTON CENTRAL
CALIFORNIA AS MORE COLLABORATIVE
AND CAESAR AGUILAR FROM THE
CENTRAL CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE NETWORK.
AND AS YOU CAN TELL WE'RE
RUNNING RUNNING QUITE LATE I
APOLOGIZE TO THOSE OF YOU WHO
HAVE BEEN HANGING IN WITH US.
IF YOU CAN PLEASE MAKE YOUR
PRESENTATION AS CONCISE AS
POSSIBLE.
WE WOULD APPRECIATE IT.
GOOD EVENING --
MADAM CHAIR AND ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
JUST WANTED --
TO INTRODUCE MYSELF AGAINST AMIR
SHAIKH ON THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
WITH THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY AIR
POLLUTION CONTROL DISTRICT
THANKS AGAIN FOR NIGHT --
I WILL TRY TO COME UP WITH A
RELATIVELY CONDENSED VERSION OF
THE PRESENTATION RESPECT OF
WHERE WE ARE --
THIS EVENING --
FIRST I JUST WANTED TO TO
MENTION --
AS YOU ALL KNOW THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY --
LIGHT LIKE SOUTH COAST FACES.
PERHAPS THE MOST DIFFICULT AIR
QUALITY FAMILY DOES NOT ONLY THE
STATE BUT IN THE COUNTRY.
WE'RE WE'RE DEALING WITH --
THOSE OZONE AND PM TWO POINT
FIVE ISSUES FOR MANY YEARS WE
PUT TOGETHER.
A NUMBER OF PLANS AND
GENERATIONS OF RULES AND OTHER
STRATEGIES TO TRY TO REDUCE.
THAT ARE POLLUTION THERE'S BEEN
A LOT OF PROGRESS OVER THE YEARS.
THERE'S NO DOUBT THAT THERE'S
STILL A LOT OF WORK TO BE DONE
AND SO AS THE ANTIWAR IN MISSION
EARLIER SHE THE TERM EUNUCH
UPPER SB SIX SEVENTEEN IS
PROVIDING A UNIQUE OPPORTUNITY
IN ADDITION TO ALL OF THE THE
REGIONAL WORK THAT WE'VE BEEN
DOING.
PROVIDING THE COMMUNITY FOCUSED
APPROACH AND NOT ONLY USING YOUR
RESOURCES THAT COME OUT OF OUT
OF THIS PROGRAM BUT ALSO NEW.
TACTICS AND YOU STRATEGIES
ACTUALLY THROUGH AB SIX
SEVENTEEN AND TRY TO DO A BETTER
JOB IN IN DEALING WITH THE
CONCERNS THAT ARE FACING OUR
VALLEY COMMUNITIES.
WE'RE NO STRANGER IN TERMS OF
WORKING IN OUR COMMUNITY IS AS
AS WAYNE AT TA TALKED ABOUT
EARLIER.
AND WE'VE BEEN WORKING IN VALLEY
COMMUNITIES FOR A LONG TIME WE
ARE THE FIRST THIS FOR TO DO
THAT BY MENTAL JUST ADVISORY
GROUP THAT'S AN OFFICIAL BODY.
OF OUR AGENCY A LOT OF THE THE
FOLKS THAT ARE THAT ARE HERE
TODAY ARE ACTUALLY.
GIVE A KEVIN ACTUALLY CREDIT --
FOR AT THE BEHEST OF OF HIM AND
AND AND A FEW OTHERS --
ACTUALLY CREATED THAT GROUP A
NUMBER OF YEARS BACK THEY'VE
BEEN ADVISING US ON A NUMBER OF
AREAS INCLUDING HOW WE CAN BEST.
INVEST IN OUR IN OUR VALLEY
COMMUNITIES IN A LOT OF
IMPROVEMENTS OF COME.
IN OUR PURCHASE THROUGH THAT
THROUGH THAT WORKS I REALLY
WANTED TO TO THANK THEM. FOR
THOSE YEARS OF WORK AND AND NOW
HOPEFULLY LEVEL LEVERAGING THOSE
RELATIONSHIPS TO DO AN EVEN
BETTER JOB THROUGH AB.
SIX SEVENTEEN I'M NOT GONNA
FOCUS HERE ON THE REQUIREMENTS
IN BRIEF YOU HEARD A LOT ABOUT
THIS -- SO
FAR TODAY'S INDEFINITE.
JUMP REALLY QUICK INTO BEST
AVAILABLE RETROFIT CONTROL
TECHNOLOGY AREA THAT --
IN OUR IN OUR REGION BECAUSE OF
OUR NON ATTAINMENT STATUS AND
NEED TO CONTINUALLY ADOPTS.
NEW PLANS FROZEN FOR PM TWO
POINT FIVE AND WE'VE ALL WE'VE
ALWAYS REALLY WORKED --
REALLY HARD AND KIND OF RE
EVALUATING THE LATEST
TECHNOLOGIES AND MAKING SURE
THAT OUR RULES.
ALWAYS MEET NOT ONLY BARKS BUT
ALSO STANDARDS LIKE MISTER
ENGINE MEASURES FOR PM TWO POINT.
FIVE WE DID --
TAKE A VERY CLOSE LOOK AT THIS
IN THE CONTEXT OF AB SIX
SEVENTEEN TO ADOPT.
THE THE STATUTORY --
A SCHEDULE THAT WAS REQUIRED AND
UNDER.
EIGHTY SIX SEVENTEEN LEVERAGED
ACTUALLY THE NEW QUICK NEW PM
TWO POINT FIVE PLAN ON THAT OUR
OUR BOARD ADOPTED I'M LATE LAST
YEAR THAT CARD WITHOUT THAT IN
JANUARY JUST A COUPLE OF MONTHS
AGO.
A LOT OF WORK WHEN TO THAT PLAN
ON THESE VERY SAME CATEGORIES.
OF THAT WERE SUBJECT TO THE BARK
REVIEW WE LEVERAGE THAT WORK AND
IF YOU CAME UP WITH A REALLY
AGGRESSIVE SCHEDULE --
OF RULE IMPLEMENTATION --
THROUGH THAT'S GOOD WE'RE
WORKING AT LEAST FIVE TO SIX
RULES PER YEAR THAT'S IN
ADDITION TO A LOT OF OTHER RULE
MAKING IS ACTUALLY GOING ON
RIGHT NOW IN THE CONTEXT OF OUR
NEW.
AT PM TWO POINT FIVE PLAN AND IN
A RECENT OZONE PLAN THAT WAS
ALSO ADOPTED.
IN FLARES AS THIS ONE ONE
EXAMPLE OF A OF A REGULATORY
EFFORT THAT IS BEING WORK AND
ACTUALLY AS WE SPEAK --
SUCH WANTED TO HIGHLIGHT --
THAT ONGOING WORK.
AND YOU KNOW.
THROUGH THE COMMUNITIES A
SELECTION PROCESS AS YOU HEARD
THERE WERE TEN THAT WERE PICKED
THERE WERE TWO THAT WERE
IDENTIFIED.
A TWO CARDS SELECTION PROCESS IN
THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY.
AND THE CITY OF SHAFTER WHICH
WAS PICKED REALLY IS A RURAL
COMMUNITY IN IN THE VALLEY AND
WE WE HAVE A LOT OF
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES IN IN
THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY A LOT OF
THEM ARE RURAL AND SO.
THAT WAS ONE THAT OUR BOARD
RECOMMENDED TO CARBON THAT WAS
PICKED BY CARBON THAT COMMUNITY
SELECTION PROCESS.
AND ALSO THE COMMUNITY OF SOUTH
CENTRAL FRESNO.
AND AGAIN I SWEAR TO HIGHLIGHT
THE POINT THAT THERE ARE A LOT
OF DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES IN
THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY.
A LOT OF THEM.
NOT ONLY THROUGH THE SO SCREEN
BUT ALSO WITH THE ENVIRONMENTAL
BURDENS THAT ARE A MAJOR PART OF
THAT EVALUATION.
AND THE REALLY IS NO SHORTAGE OF
WORK TO BE DONE IN IN OUR REGION --
IT ONE OF THE BIG ISSUES THAT WE
FACE IN KIND OF GOING THROUGH
THIS PROCESS IN THAT FIRST YEAR
WAS A NUMBER COMMUNITIES OF
REALLY WANTED. TO BE CONSIDERED
IN THAT PROCESS I WANTED TO BE
PRIORITIZE AND AND THAT'S ONE OF
THE BIG AREAS OF FOCUS IN THE
COMING YEARS HOW DO WE ACTUALLY
GO BACK IN.
AND NOT ONLY THROUGH THE AB SIX
SEVENTEEN SORT OF OFFICIAL
PROCESS BUT ALSO EVERYTHING ELSE
WE CAN DO SUPPLEMENTAL SB SIX
SIX SEVENTEEN TO REALLY TRY TO
ADDRESS.
THE CONCERNS THAT WE'RE HEARING
ABOUT IN THESE COMMUNITIES AND
LEVERAGE SIX SEVENTEEN TO DO
EVEN MORE WELL BEYOND WHAT WE
CAN DO.
IN THESE --
SEVERAL COMMUNITIES THAT WERE
PICKED THROUGH THIS PROCESS.
MEXICAN TO KICK THE PRESENTATION
OVER -- TO
JANIE HOLD SHE'S OUR DIRECTOR
ABOUT RINGS THAT HAVE WRITTEN
COMMUNICATIONS ISN'T WORKING
VERY CLOSELY WITH OUR
COMMUNITIES IN LAUNCHING.
ON THE PROCESS WITH THE STEERING
COMMITTEES AND ALL THE PUBLIC
ENGAGEMENT THAT WE'VE BEEN
WORKING ON HIS IN A WALK YOU
THROUGH THOSE ACTIVITIES AND
I'LL COME BACK IN.
AND CLOSE THE PRESENTATION WITH
SOME OF THE UPCOMING AREAS OF
FOCUS AND WHERE WE GO FROM HERE.
THANK YOU I TOO AM GOING TO BE A
LITTLE QUICK IN THE INTEREST OF
TIME.
WE HAVE LEARNED A LOT IN THIS
PROCESS ALREADY AND I HAVE TO
THANK OUR ADVOCATES BUT THE ONES
HERE THAT ARE AT THE TABLE AND
SOME OF THE OTHERS. FOR REALLY
AT GENTLY PUSHING US IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION THROUGH THIS
PROCESS --
OUR MEETINGS ARE MANAGED BY
FACILITATOR AND THAT THAT'S
DESIGNED TO PROVIDE OPEN AND NOT
A COMPLETE COMMUNICATION WE
LEARNED THAT TO HAVE THE
MATERIALS IN BOTH SPANISH AND
ENGLISH WE NEAR WE LEARNED THAT
EVERYONE NEEDED A HAD SAT.
IN WHEN SOMEONE WAS SPEAKING
SPANISH THEY NEEDED TO HAVE THAT
TRANSLATION GOING ON IN REAL
TIME IN ENGLISH WE'RE HOLDING IN
THE MEETINGS IN THE EVENING WE
TOO ARE HAVING FOOD PROVIDED BY
LOCAL BUSINESSES.
WE HAVE CHILD CARE WITH THE
ACTIVITIES WE STARTED TO HAVE
OUR BIGGER --
SOUTH CENTRAL ACT COMMITTEE
MEETING AT A BOYS AND GIRLS
CLUBS OF THE KIDS ACTUALLY HAVE
SOME REALLY FUN THINGS TO DO
WITH HELD FIVE PUBLIC MEETINGS
IN EACH COMMUNITY THAT INCLUDED
ONE KICK OFF MEETING.
IN EACH COMMUNITY AND THEN FOR
ACTUAL STEERING COMMITTEE
MEETINGS.
THE COMMUNITY OF CHAPTER SHOPPER
WAS AS THE MAYOR SAID SELECTED
TO REPRESENT A RURAL LAST DANCE
CITY -- IT'S
A RESIDENTIAL AREA NORTH OF
BAKERSFIELD IT'S ABOUT TWENTY
THOUSAND PEOPLE ABOUT FIFTEEN
SQUARE MILES.
IT CAPTURES TO IT DISADVANTAGED
CENSUS RACT AND I WILL TELL YOU
IT IS A MUCH DIFFERENT COMMUNITY
THAN SOUTH CENTRAL FRESNO THEY
DO HAVE SOME OF THE SAME
CONCERNS BUT THEN THEY ALSO HAVE
SOME CONCERNS.
BUT THEY POUR IT PRIORITIZE MUCH
DIFFERENTLY.
THIS CHAPTER COMMUNITY STEERING
COMMITTEE IS MADE UP OF TWENTY
SIX PEOPLE THAT INCLUDES FOUR EX
OFFICIO GOVERNMENT AGENCIES.
AND WE STARTED GATHERING --
INFORMATION SIMILAR TO OTHER
STEERING COMMITTEES ON
PRIORITIZING THE MAIN ISSUES
THAT THE COMMUNITY THOUGHT.
THAT WERE THE KEY ONES THAT
NEEDED TO BE DISCUSSED NUMBER
ONE IN CHAPTERS PESTICIDES AND
WE'VE ALREADY INVITED AND AT OUR
LAST MEETING WE HAD THE
DEPARTMENT OF PESTICIDE
REGULATION COME OUT.
AND TALK ABOUT SOME OF THE
THINGS THAT THEY WERE ALL WE
FEEL THAT THERE'S LOTS OF
OPPORTUNITIES THERE TO BRING THE
AGENCIES TOGETHER TO REALLY
SUPPORT THE COMMUNITY.
AND BETTER UNDERSTAND THEIR
CONCERNS AND MAKE PLANS TO
PROGRESS TO ADDRESSING THOSE
CONCERNS.
TRUCK TRAFFIC OIL AND GAS
PRODUCTION KERRY'S UNPAID ROSE
YOU CAN SEE THERE ARE MANY --
THE THAT COMMUNITY DID APPROVE A
COMMUNITY CHARTER AND A
COMMUNITY BOUNDARY.
AND IN THE MEETINGS HAVE GONE.
RELATIVELY WELL --
I WOULD SAY THAT WE ALL ARE
LEARNING A LOT THROUGH THIS
PROCESS THAT INCLUDES US IN THE
COMMUNITY MEMBERS --
BUT WITH THE SUPPORT OF THE
ENTIRE TEAM AND EVERYONE COMING
TOGETHER CHAPTER I THINK IT'S
BEEN INCREDIBLY POSITIVE ONE OF
THE OTHER THINGS BASED ON A
RECOMMENDATION OF ONE OF THE
STEERING COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
OF WHO SAID WE NEED A MONITOR UP
NOW WE REALLY HADN'T GOTTEN
FULLY INTO THE DETAILS ABOUT
WHERE THE MONITOR SHOULD GO BUT
WE AGREED WE NEEDED A PARTICULAR
MATTER MONITOR AND IT NEEDED TO
BE UP AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE
BECAUSE WE'RE IN PARTICULAR
MATTER SEASON.
IN THE VALLEY IT ENDS IN THE
SPRING SO WE'VE ACTUALLY HAD A
MONITOR UP IN CHAPTER. FOR A
LITTLE OVER A MONTH NOW.
SOUTH CENTRAL FRESNO IT'S A MUCH
DIFFERENT AREA --
IT'S MORE INDUSTRIAL MORE
DENSELY POPULATED IS THAT IT IS
ABOUT FOURTEEN SQUARE MILES BUT
A HUNDRED THOUSAND PEOPLE THE
BLUE LINE.
IS THE BOUNDARY THAT CARP
APPROVED THE YELLOW LINE IS THE
BOUNDARY THAT HAS BEEN SUGGESTED
TO US AND WE'RE WORKING WITH THE
APPLICANTS TO COME UP WITH WITH
THE BOUNDARY THAT MAKES THE MOST
SENSE GIVEN THE LIMITED
RESOURCES IN REALLY.
CAN DO SERVICE TO THE ENTIRE
COMMUNITY WHATEVER THAT
COMMUNITY AND THAT BEING.
HAS SEVERAL OF THE MOST
DISADVANTAGED CENSUS TRACTS IN
CALIFORNIA.
THE SOUTH CENTRAL FRESNO AT
SOUTH CENTRAL FRESNO COMMITTEE
HAS THIRTY SIX MEMBERS PLUS SIX
EXCEPT THIS YEAR --
GOVERNMENT AT MEMBERS.
NEED THEIR SOME OF THE SAME
THINGS BUT TRUCK EMISSIONS
HIGHWAY INTERCHANGES AND LARGE
INDUSTRIES TOP THE LOCK Là TOP
THEIR LAST --
WE'VE HAD A CHARTER THAT HAS
BEEN APPROVED --
IN FEBRUARY WE DID HAVE SOME
BACK AND FORTH ON THE CHARTER
AND WE REALLY AB AT THE END WENT
WITH THE COMMITTEE SUGGESTION ON
HOW THEY WANTED TO HANDLE VOTING
WITH THAT.
I'M IN THE COMMITTEE AND WITH
THE CHARTER --
WE ARE IN THE MIDST OF THAT
BOUNDARY DISCUSSION WHICH I
MENTIONED AND WE'RE LOOKING AT
WHERE WE GO NEXT AS FAR AS AIR
MONITORING WE ALSO FELT THAT THE
SAME ISSUE WAS HAPPENING IN
FRESNO SO WE HAVE AN AIR MONITOR
THAT JUST OUR LAST MEETING WE
ANNOUNCED.
THAT ROOSEVELT HIGH SCHOOL WHICH
IS A HIGH SCHOOL THAT'S ACTUALLY
IN THE AREA AND THAT'S UP AND
RUNNING SO WE CAN GET SOME OF
THAT PM DATA BEFORE THE SEASON
ENDS.
THIS IS JUST A SNAPSHOT OF A WEB
TOOL THAT WE HAVE UP THIS IS FOR
CHAPTER WE HAVE THEM BOTH FOR
FRESNO AND FOR SHAKHTER BUT
ALLOWS FOLKS TO GO IN YOU CAN
CLICK ON ONE THE COLORED --
LITTLE BUBBLES IN YOU CAN GET
INFORMATION WE ARE ADDING
INFORMATION TO THIS RIGHT THERE
YOU ONLY SEE VIOS THESE BUT OUR
GOAL IS TO HAVE A VARIETY.
OF OF POLLUTION INFORMATION SO
FOLKS CAN ACTUALLY GO IN THEY
CAN SEE WHAT'S GOING ON THEY CAN
SEE WHAT THE FACILITY YES AND
THEN WE CAN MOVE FROM THERE TO
MAKE SOME OF THESE DECISIONS
ABOUT AIR MONITORING PLANS.
EMISSION REDUCTION PROGRAMS.
THIS IS JUST A SNAPSHOT AND I
DID WANT TO POINT THIS OUT WE'VE
GOT A VARIETY OF DIFFERENT TOOLS
THIS IS R. SHAFTER WEBSITE IT
AIR MONITORING THEIR THE FOURTH
KIND OF NAVIGATION TITLE OVER IF
YOU'RE LOOKING AT IT
HORIZONTALLY.
THAT WILL TAKE YOU TO THE REAL
TIME AIR MONITORING DATA FROM
THE NEW CHAPTER PM MONITOR THAT
WE PUT IN ABOUT A MONTH AGO THAT
I MENTIONED.
AND I'M GONNA TURN BACK OVER TO
SMEAR SORRY I DID TRY TO BE VERY
FAST LIKE THAT.
WE'LL GET DOWN HERE --
SO YOU'VE HEARD THE STEAM WITHIN
A COUPLE TIME TODAY YOU KNOW
WE'RE WE'RE NOT WAITING TO TO
INVEST IN CLEAN AIR.
I PROJECTS IN THESE COMMUNITIES
IN AND AROUND THESE COMMUNITIES --
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE'VE
BEEN DOING --
IS REALLY SPEED ON THE
INVESTMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN MADE
IN THOSE COMMUNITIES I THINK
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT. FOR THEM
TO SEE THAT IF YOU CAN COME UP
WITH CREATIVE STRATEGIES IF YOU
HAVE A MODEL FOR HOW YOU CAN
ACTUALLY DO SOME OF THESE THINGS
WITH.
WITH BUSINESSES WITH AGENCIES
WITH RESIDENTS DEPENDING ON THE
SCALE OF OF PROJECTS YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT THERE.
IT REALLY HELPS THAT SOURCE AT
THIS STAGE FOR GETTING MORE
INPUT AS TO HOW MUCH MORE WE
COULD DO WITH ALL THE NEW
FUNDING AND RESOURCES THAT ARE
COMING TO BEAR THROUGH THIS
PROCESS.
THIS COULD BE A KIND OF A
SNAPSHOT IN THE CHAPTER AREA
JUST A STORE WITH THEIR
INCENTIVE PROGRAMS ALONE WE'VE
BEEN ABLE INVEST ABOUT TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS. FOURTEEN
HUNDRED PROJECTS AND THIRTY
SEVEN HUNDRED TONS OF EMISSIONS
REDUCTIONS ACHIEVED.
IN THAT AREA SO FAR JUST IN THE
SOUTH CENTRAL FRESNO AREA ABOUT
A HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS NINETY
TWO HUNDRED PROJECTS AND NINE
THOUSAND TONS OF REDUCTIONS WE
HAVE A REALLY.
GOOD TRACK RECORD OF GOING INTO
COMMUNITIES AND LOOKING FOR
THESE PROJECTS WHETHER IT'S BUS
FLEETS ARE HEAVY DUTY TRUCKS OR
WORKING WITH RESIDENTS ON ON
TAKING GROSS POLLUTERS OFF THE
ROAD.
REDUCING FUEL COSTS WHAT THE
SAME TIME YOU KNOW CLEANING UP
THOSE VEHICLES THERE'S A LOT OF
GOOD EXAMPLES THAT WE CAN BUILD
OFF OF IT SO THE QUESTION HERE
IS WE GET THE SIX SEVENTEEN
PROCESS HOW DO WE REALLY.
UNDERSTAND THE CONCERNS THAT
COMMUNITY AND THEN TRY TO LEAD
IDEAS FOR DOING DOING EVEN
THINGS YOU KNOW WITH WITH THE
NEW FUNDING THAT'S COMING.
THROUGH THE BUDGET PROCESS IS
GONNA BE SOME REALLY
OPPORTUNITIES THAT WE SEE WAS
STATIONARY SOURCES AS WELL WHICH
ADDITIONALLY Là FUNDING IS
GOING INTO MOBILE SOURCES.
THERE REALLY EAGER TO TO
UNDERSTAND THOSE CONCERNS AND
SEE WHAT WE COULD DO WITH A
COMMITTEE INPUT --
SOME OF THAT NEW FUNDING THAT
HAS COME THESE LAST A BUDGET
CYCLES AND THE EARLY WERE CALLED
EARLY REDUCTION OR THE ACTION
FUNDS.
HAVE BEEN PUT TO GOOD USE AND IS
VALLEY DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
IN OVER 50% OF THEIR INITIAL
EIGHTY MILLION DOLLARS IS
ALREADY.
OBLIGATED TO PROJECTS AND A 100%
OF THOSE PROJECTS ACTUALLY AND
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
THROUGHOUT THE VALLEY A LOT OF
THEM IN THESE VERY COMMUNITIES
THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT TODAY
SO THERE'S ALREADY A LOT OF
EFFORT IN IN BRINGING ABOUT
THESE REDUCTIONS THAT WERE
LOOKING FOR MORE INPUT AS TO HOW.
WE WOULD GO ABOUT AND WHEN
WISELY SPEND THAT MONEY IN THE
IN THESE COMMUNITIES.
SOME ISN'T IT --
WRAP IT UP HERE WITH SOME
CLOSING THOUGHTS IN SOME OF THE
THINGS YOU'VE HEARD SOME OF THEM
ARE ARE KIND OF UNIQUE TO WHAT
WE'RE DEALING WITH THE IN THE
SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY --
YOU KNOW FIRST OF ALL --
PROVIDING ASSISTANCE --
TAKES A LOT OF RESOURCES TO
SUPPORT YOU KNOW A LOT OF
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS THAT ARE
COMING UP.
NOW I I DO AGREE WITH A LOT OF
THE COMMENTS THAT WERE RAISED
EARLIER THAT THERE IS A LOT THAT
WE KNOW.
AND WE'RE BRINGING THOSE
RESOURCES TO BEAR WE OUR EXPERTS
ARE OTHER EXPERTS YOU KNOW FROM
OTHER AGENCIES DEPENDING ON THE
QUESTIONS INTO THE PROCESS.
THERE A LOT AND YOU QUESTIONS
ARE ALSO BEING RAISED THAT ARE
THAT ARE THAT ARE GENERATING
WHAT I THINK ARE GOING TO BE
SOME VERY FRUITFUL PROJECTS THAT
WE WE TRY TO PRIORITIZE AND
EIGHTY SIX SEVENTEEN PROCESS
WHETHER IT'S ON THE MONITORING
SIDE.
OR JUST GOING IN INVESTIGATING
THROUGH OTHER EXERCISES WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN THE COMMUNITY TO
TRY TO ADDRESS THE CONCERNS THAT
ARE COMING UP --
I THINK THAT --
WORKING WITH LOCAL STAKEHOLDERS --
MORE MOST EFFECTIVELY MORE
EFFECTIVELY IT IS REALLY KEY. TO
THIS PROCESS YOU KNOW ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT WE'VE BEEN.
CONTINUALLY IMPROVING --
WITH A. B. SIX SEVENTEEN IS THAT
THERE REALLY IS A DIFFERENT.
APPROACH WITH A. B. SIX
SEVENTEEN YOU KNOW WE WE IN IN
THIS PROCESS YOU DON'T GO
THROUGH WHAT MIGHT BE A TYPICAL
IN A REGULATORY RULEMAKING
PROCESS RESCHEDULE WORKSHOP GIVE
A PRESENTATION.
YOU KNOW HAVE A FORMAL PUBLIC
COMMENTING PROCESS AT THE END.
THESE ARE A LOT MORE --
INTERACTIVE MEETINGS UNDER A LOT
MORE DYNAMIC AND WE REALLY NEED
TO HAVE IT BE DRIVEN BY THE
COMMUNITIES IN TERMS OF YOU KNOW
IT SETTING THE AGENDA.
ARTICULATED HAVING THESE
MEETINGS OF THE COMMUNITY LET
AND THAT'S SOMETHING THAT IS A
PARADIGM SHIFT I THINK IN IN THE
WAY THAT SB SIX SEVENTEEN WORK
SINCE A WORK CONTINUALLY TRYING.
TO IMPROVE THAT PROCESS I THINK
EVERY MEETING.
IN SOME WAY HAS HAS ALLOWED FOR
FOR EVEN BETTER INTERACTION I
THINK WE YOU KNOW WE SEE THOSE
IMPROVEMENTS OVER TIME.
REALLY PAYING OFF YOU KNOW AND
BY THE WAY.
WOULD NOTHING THAT I'M SAYING
HERE IS TO IS TO MINIMIZE THE
FACT THAT THERE ARE GROWING
PAINS.
IN THIS PROCESS WE'VE LEARNED A
LOT YOU KNOW WE THINK THAT THE
COMMUNITY STEERING COMMITTEES.
THAT IN FACT I THINK THE THE
FRESNO STEERING COMMITTEE MAY BE
THE LARGEST ONE IN THE STATE.
JUST TALKING TO MY COLLEAGUES IN
TALKING TO TO AIR BE.
IT'S ABOUT FORTY PEOPLE YOU KNOW
THAT ARE THE ALL HAVE YOU KNOW
UNIQUE PERSPECTIVES THAT.
ALL REALLY WANTED WANT WANT
THEIR VOICE TO BE HEARD SO IT
REALLY IS A BIG LEARNING PROCESS
FOR US AND SO NOTHING THAT I
THAT I FIGURES REALLY MEANT TO
MINIMIZE.
JUST HOW IMPORTANT IT IS FOR US
TO KIND OF GET THROUGH.
THOSE GROWING PAINS AND REALLY
END UP SOMEWHERE WE CAN ACTUALLY
WORK TOGETHER TO PUT THESE PLANS
TOGETHER AND BRING ABOUT THOSE
REDUCTIONS.
NOW ONE THING WE'VE LEARNED
QUICKLY IS THAT A LOT OF THE
CONCERNS THAT ARE COMING UP.
ARE THINGS THAT DON'T
NECESSARILY EVEN FALL UNDER
OTHER WE HOPE TO BE VERY BOLD IN
A VERY EFFECTIVE EMISSION
REDUCTION PROGRAMS.
THERE ARE A LOT OF CONCERNS THAT
ARE COMING UP WHETHER IT SAID
YOU KNOW STATE PESTICIDE.
AUTHORITY ISSUE OR MOBILE SOURCE
ISSUES --
YOU KNOW WE DO IN OUR IN OUR
REGION HAVE AN INTER INDIRECT
SOURCE REVIEW PROGRAM.
THAT I THINK IS PART OF A OF A
LARGER.
SET OF ISSUES THAT DEAL WITH
MOBILE SOURCES THAT WE'RE TRYING
TO FIGURE OUT YOU KNOW HOW WE
ACTUALLY GO ABOUT IN ADDRESSING
THOSE IN A PLAN THAT WE
ULTIMATELY ADOPT AND THEN --
WORK WITH CARB YOU SEE TO TAKE
TO THEIR PROCESS SO THERE YOU
KNOW ONE OF THE BIGGEST THINGS
THAT I'VE BEEN DOING THAT OUR
STAFF HAVE BEEN DOING IS TRYING
TO MAKE SURE.
THAT WE BRING THE CITIES THE
COUNTIES INTO THE PROCESS THAT
WE BRING THE P. R..
OTHER AGENCIES INTO THE PROCESS
SO THAT THEY'RE ACTUALLY AT THE
TABLE THEY'RE HEARING THE
CONCERNS IN THEIR THINKING ABOUT
WAYS.
OF CONTRIBUTING TO OUR TO OUR
OLD ULTIMATELY TO THE PROGRAMS
THAT WE PUT TOGETHER IN A WAY
THAT RESPONSE TO THE CONCERNS
THAT ARE COMING UP.
YOU KNOW I MEAN THAT'S THAT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT THAT THEY HEAR
THOSE DIRECTLY SO THEY CAN
ACTUALLY RESPOND TO THEM.
AND I'M GONNA A C. WRAP UP HERE
WITH A COUPLE OF KEY POINTS HERE --
I THINK --
TALK ABOUT COMMUNICATION BEING
IMPORTANT.
JAMIE MENTIONED FACILITATED
MEETINGS TO ME WE LEARNED VERY
EARLY ON THAT WE NEED TO HAVE.
GOOD FACILITATION WE THINK THAT
THAT CONNECTS THESE FOR MAKING
THE PROCESS BETTER SO WE'RE
WORKING ON A SOLUTIONS FOR THAT.
I THINK WE NEED TO STAINED.
RESOURCES IN THE PROGRAM I THINK
IT'S REALLY REALLY HARD YOU KNOW
YOU TALK WITH YOU HEARD A LOT
ABOUT MONITORING FOR EXAMPLE.
AND THE FACT THAT YOU KNOW IN IN
FOR EXAMPLE IN THE FRESNO
COMMUNITY.
THERE ARE ACTUALLY SEVERAL
DISTINCT COMMUNITIES WITHIN OUR
FRESNO COMMUNITY OF CAL --
YET MALAGA YOU HAVE THE
INDUSTRIAL TRIANGLE WITH
DALEVILLE.
POTENTIALLY SOUTHWEST FRESNO --
THERE'S ACTUALLY THIS THE ALL
THE COMMUNITIES NORTH OF CAL --
EVERYONE OF THOSE COMMUNITIES
THE SORT OF WITHIN THIS LARGER
COMMUNITY AS PART OF THE PROCESS.
NEED SOME KIND OF EXTENSIVE
MONITORING AND SO AS WE INVEST
IN DIFFERENT TECHNOLOGIES FOR
TOXICS FOR FOR FEDERAL REFERENCE
MET THE CRITERIA MONITORING.
YOU KNOW EVERYONE OF THOSE GONNA
NEED SOME FORM OF A OF A TRAILER
YOU KNOW COUPLED WITH THE NEED
TO WRAP UP --
BUT NOT MAKE MY LEFT HERE AT LOW
COST SENSORS AND THAT TAKES A
LOT OF RESOURCES SO.
YOU KNOW WE'RE LEARNING A LOT
THROUGH THE PROCESS WE THINK
THAT WE WORK TO BE DONE AND
WORKING WITH A TO RECOGNIZE THEM
LET MY TESTIMONY AT BE
INCOMPLETE WITHOUT RECOGNITION
OF THEIR SUPPORT.
AND THEN OF COURSE THE THE
ADVOCATES THAT ARE HERE TODAY
WHO I KNOW.
YOU KNOW HAVE HAVE --
I I THINK SOME POSITIVE STORIES
THAT HELP PROBABLY HAVE SOME
AREAS WHERE THEY WANT TO SEE
CONTINUED IMPROVEMENT OVER READY
TO HEAR THAT AND AND WORK WITH
THEM AND OTHERS. TO TO MAKE THIS
IS VALUABLE PROCESS AS POSSIBLE.
IT'S ONE OF THOSE WITH THAT AND
WE'RE HERE AS LONG AS WE NEED TO
BE TO ANSWER YOUR QUESTIONS
[inaudible]
WE GET [inaudible]
YEAH.
THAT'S FINE LONG AS IT MOVES
[inaudible]
YEAH YEAH.
GOOD AFTERNOON KEVIN HAMILTON
WAS CENTRAL CALIFORNIA ASTHMA
COLLABORATIVE AND AS A MEMBER
ALSO OF THE STATE CONSULTATION
COMMITTEE --
FOR AB SIX ONE SEVEN AND I WANT
TO THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA
ONCE AGAIN. FOR THIS AMAZING
BILL AND THE AMAZING OPPORTUNITY
IS PROVIDED FOR OUR COMMUNITIES.
I WERE JUST BEGINNING TO REALIZE
THAT.
SO -- AND I
TALKED BRIEFLY I SORT OF AN
OVERVIEW HERE AND THEN DIVE INTO
FRESNO AND GET YOU KNOW THAT
CITY A LITTLE BIT.
MORE AND MY COLLEAGUE SAYS ARE
WHO IS FROM THE SOUTH VALLEY
WILL THEN --
FINISH WITH CHAPTER AND IN AND
THE PRESENTATION --
A SORT OF AN OVERVIEW AS FAR AS
OUR COMMUNITIES ARE COMMUNITIES
REALLY UNDERSTAND WHAT'S
HAPPENING HERE.
YOU KNOW VERY CLEARLY THAT THIS
IS AN OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE A LOT
OF VISION.
IT DIDN'T TAKE THEM EVEN ONE
MEETING TO REALIZE THAT THE
EXISTING BOUNDARIES WERE NOT
ADEQUATE --
TO ENCOMPASS ALL OF THE
POLLUTION THREATS THAT THEY HAD
SEEN THROUGH THE COURSE OF THEIR
LIVES.
AND AS WE LEARN MORE ABOUT THE
INVENTORIES PRESENTED BY THE AIR
DISTRICT.
THEY WERE VERY CONFIDENT THAT
THESE RICH INVENTORY DID NOT
REFLECT THEIR EXPERIENCES.
ANOTHER WORDS COULDN'T SURVIVE
GROUND TO WE CONTINUE TO MOVE
THAT BALL FORWARD.
AND IN THE FRESNO AREA YOU FIND
ABOUT -- TWO
THIRDS OF THAT AREA IS IN THE
TOP 1% OF CALAMARI SCREENS MOST
IMPACTED COMMUNITIES SO THESE
ARE SERIOUSLY UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES.
SERIOUSLY --
DISENFRANCHISED COMMUNITIES WHO
EXPERIENCED YEARS AND YEARS AND
YEARS OF ENVIRONMENTAL RACISM
[inaudible]
SO -- THIS
IS NOT GOING TO END SOON AND
WE'RE NOT GOING TO FIX THIS IN
IN ONE YEAR HERE BUT WE'RE GOING
TO MAKE A GOOD.
RUN AT IT AND WE'RE GONNA REALLY
USES PROCESS TO ADDRESS THE
SOURCES.
AND BEGIN TO SOLVE SOME OF THESE
PROBLEMS AS THEY RELATE TO AIR
POLLUTION WE ALL UNDERSTAND THAT
THE ENTIRE SOLUTION DOES NOT
COME FROM AIR POLLUTION AND AIR
TOXICS.
BUT IT'S A SIGNIFICANT
CONTRIBUTOR --
IN THIS CHAPTER AREA THEY CAME
TO THAT SAME CONSENSUS EARLY ON
AND IN THAT AREA AS WELL AND
WITH THE AIR DISTRICTS --
ALMOST IMMEDIATE --
AGREEMENT EXPANDED THEIR
BOUNDARY LEVEL FROM THE EXISTING
SQUARE TO A ROUGHLY SEVEN MILE
DIAMETER CIRCLE THAT REALLY DOES
BRING IN.
ALL THE SOURCES THAT THEY'RE
CONCERNED ABOUT --
BOTH SHAFTER AND FRESNO HAVE
DEMANDED THE INCLUSION OF
PESTICIDES.
AND DOWNING SHAFTER THEY
ADDITIONALLY ARE DEALING WITH A
LARGE NUMBER OF CONCENTRATED
ANIMAL FEEDING OPERATIONS.
MAINLY DAIRIES AND WHEN I SAY
CONCENTRATED ANIMAL I'M TALKING
ABOUT FIVE TO TWENTY THOUSAND
ANIMALS.
PEOPLE MAKE A LOT OF JOKES ABOUT
CAL FARTS YOU KNOW AND CAL BURBS.
YOU KNOW IT'S REALLY FUNNY
UNLESS YOU'VE GOT TWENTY
THOUSAND I'M SITTING NEXT YEAR
HOUSE.
IT'S NOT NEARLY AS HUMOR'S AT
THAT POINT.
SO THE INDUSTRY DONE A GOOD JOB
WITH THAT BUT YOU KNOW IT IT IT
IS WHAT IT IS SO --
WE HAD FOUR MEETINGS NOW FIVE TO
DATE -- IN
THE BEGINNING MEETING WAS AN
OVERVIEW OF THE PROCESS I JUST
WANT TO COMMENT ON THAT.
THERE'S THIS TENDENCY OF THE
DISTRICT TO RUN OUT HOW MUCH
MONEY THEY'VE SPENT OVER A
CERTAIN PERIOD OF TIME. TWENTY
YEARS THIRTY YEARS FORTY YEARS
OF BILLION DOLLARS WHATEVER IT
IS RIDICULOUS NUMBERS THAT MAKE
NO SENSE.
BECAUSE IF THEY DID MAKE SENSE
WE HAVE CLEAN AIR.
HOW CAN YOU SPEND THAT MUCH
MONEY IN A PLACE TO CLEAN THE
AIR NOT GET CLEAN AIR?
THAT MAKES NO SENSE TO ME AT ALL.
SO YOU HAVE TO REALLY WONDER IF
WE'VE INVESTED HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS ALREADY INTO
THE INDUSTRIES IN THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY TO HELP THEM
CLEAN UP.
WHY HASN'T IT HAPPENED WHY ISN'T
THAT MEASURED IN ACTUAL CLEAN
AIR DAYS WE SEEN?
SOMEONE OF A REDUCTION IN THE
NUMBER OF DAYS WITH DIRTY AIR --
YOU COULD ARGUE THAT A LARGE
AMOUNT OF THAT REDUCTION IS A
READ IS A RESULT OF MOBILE
SOURCE REDUCTIONS.
AUTOMOBILE CLEAN UPS HAVE BEEN
MASSIVE BY TWO THOUSAND THAT OUR
MOBILE TECHNOLOGY TO CLEAN THE
TAIL PIPE.
HAD GOTTEN TO THE POINT WHERE
YOU COULD ALMOST SAY.
AND TRUCKS AFTER THE TWO
THOUSAND TEN TRUCK RULE WE
REALLY DID START TO SEE SOME
REDUCTIONS IN EMISSIONS THERE.
BUT WE STILL HAVE A TREMENDOUS
AMOUNT OF INDUSTRY IN THE SOUTH
VALLEY WE'VE GOT A TON OF
BOILING GAS.
RESERVES THAT ARE BEING PUMPED
OUT OF THE GROUND AND STORED IN
COMMUNITIES NEXT TO HOMES.
AND UP IN THE NORTH VALLEY WE'VE
GOT BUSINESSES WHERE JUST LIKE
IN SOME OF THE CITIES IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA WE'RE SEEING
REALLY --
YOU KNOW.
POLLUTION.
RATING BUSINESSES BEING PLACED
RIGHT NEXT TO HOMES BUT MAINLY
IN THE SOUTH PART FRESNO.
IN THIS CONTINUES [inaudible]
SO -- EARLY
ON THE E. J. GROUPS REACH OUT TO
THE DISTRICT I WILL SAY NOW I
WANT TO SAY SOMETHING POSITIVE
HERE.
WE CAN REACH OUT TO THE DISTRICT
EARLY ON AND THEY AGREED TO MEET
WITH US AND PLAN THE FIRST
MEETINGS.
AND IN SUBSEQUENT MEETINGS WE
ADDED RESIDENTS TO THAT MEETING
GROUP AND WE CONTINUE TO MEET
WITH THE DISTRICT.
PRIOR TO MEETINGS AND AFTER
MEETINGS ON A REGULAR BASIS AND
THERE HAVE BEEN.
SIGNIFICANT IMPROVEMENTS IN THE
OVERALL MEETING STRUCTURE AND
HOW IT ROLLS OUT.
FROM THAT PROCESS --
THINGS HAVE SORT OF COME UP IS
QUITE HONESTLY WHAT WE SEE A
GENERAL CONCERN THAT ARE
RESIDENTS OF EXPRESSED ABOUT THE
CULTURAL COMPETENCY
INSENSITIVITY.
OF THE FACILITATOR AND SOME OF
THE AIR DISTRICT STAFF --
WE GET THAT THEY MEAN WELL IN
THAT NOBODY IS INTENTIONALLY
INSULTING PEOPLE BUT
UNINTENTIONALLY A LOT OF INSULTS
OF HAPPEN PEOPLE OF FELT.
IN THE DEGRADED HAVE FELT --
LIKE SOMEBODY IS IS TALKING DOWN
TO THEM AND AND TALKING FROM A
WHITE TOWER SAYING YOU KNOW THE
IVORY TOWER COMPLEX AND AND WE
KNOW THAT'S NOT INTENDED THOSE
OF US WHO WORK WITH THE DISTRICT
FOR MANY YEARS AND KNOW THESE
PEOPLE PERSONALLY.
BUT IN THIS SITUATION SITUATION
IT'S JUST NOT WORKING OUT WELL
SO.
WE HAVE PROPOSED IN THE DISTRICT
HAS EXCEPT SOME OF OUR E. J.
GROUPS MIGHT LEADS AND CULTURAL
SENSITIVITY TRAINING THERE HELP
THEM BETTER UNDERSTAND HOW TO
WORK IN.
AND COMMUNICATE WITH OUR
COMMUNITIES AND SO WE'RE HOPING
TO SEE THAT HAPPEN VERY SOON.
AND THAT SOMETHING GOOD WILL
HAPPEN FROM THAT SO I WANT TO
PUT FRESNO IN PERSPECTIVE THIS
IS THE CITY OF FRESNO --
YOU CAN SEE --
FROM THE LEGEND HERE THAT THE
MAJORITY OF THE COMMUNITIES IN
THE AREA THAT THE COMMUNITY
WANTS TO SEE PART OF THIS ARE IN
THE NINETY NINTH PERCENTILE.
THESE COMMUNITIES ARE
CONCENTRATED IN THIS AREA IT IS
ONE OF THE MOST IMPACTED IF NOT
THE MOST IMPACTED SAID OF
COMMUNITIES.
THAT ARE ADJACENT TO EACH OTHER
IN THIS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
SO -- THE
OTHER COMMUNITIES SURROUNDING IT --
IN THE 97%.
TO SO --
DRILLING DOWN INTO THE AREA OF
INTEREST FRESNO BY THE WAY AS A
METROPOLIS AREA WITH A
POPULATION OF ABOUT ONE POINT
ONE MILLION PEOPLE I ALWAYS
WONDER IF THE REST OF CALIFORNIA
UNDERSTANDS THAT.
IT'S NOT SOME LITTLE BURKE
SITTING IN THE MIDDLE OF A BUNCH
OF COUNTLESS.
K. THERE'S A MILLION PEOPLE
LIVING HERE ALL RIGHT.
AND SO THEY HAVE ALL THE
PROBLEMS THAT A MILLION PEOPLE
HAVE ANYWHERE ELSE YOU KNOW IT'S
IT'S THE ONLY INLAND CITY IN
CALIFORNIA WITH OUT DIRECT
ACCESS TO THE OCEAN.
EVEN SACRAMENTO HAS A RIVER UP
AND DOWN TO THE BAY.
FRESNO IS THE ONLY CITY OF IT'S
SIZE THAT DOES NOT HAVE THAT.
SO THAT MEANS WHAT.
TRUCKS RIGHT.
WE PRODUCE A LOT OF STOP.
SO -- WE NOT
ONLY PRODUCE A LOT AG PRODUCTS
BUT WE PRODUCE A LOT OF
INDUSTRIAL PRODUCTS WHICH MAY
NOT BE QUITE SO WELL KNOWN.
WE HAVE SOME OF THE LARGEST
GLASS PLANTS IN THE WESTERN
UNITED STATES.
RIGHT NEXT TO ONE OF THE
COMMUNITIES HERE.
SO THIS IS THE ORIGINAL TRIANGLE
THAT WAS CHOSEN.
THE PURPLE AREA REFLECTS WHAT
THE COMMUNITY WOULD LIKE TO SEE.
THE BIG GREG AND HERE'S WHY YOU
SEE THAT BIG RED DOT RIGHT THERE
AT THE BOTTOM EDGE ON THE RIGHT
HAND SIDE.
THAT'S A BIOMASS INCINERATOR
LITTLE RED DOT BELOW IT IT'S A
GIANT GLASS FACTORY.
UP HERE AT THE TOP THAT'S A BIG
TRUCK CENTER AND ROOFING CENTER
UP THERE AT THE TOP.
SO.
WE WANT TO KNOW.
WHO WROTE THIS BOUNDARY RIGHT
THIS ISN'T A BOUNDARY THAT WE
SUGGESTED IN FACT?
THERE'S EVEN A CREAMERY RIGHT
THERE IN THAT LITTLE TRIANGLE AT
THE TOP THAT LITTLE INDENTATION
IS LIKE HOW DID THAT GET LEFT
OUT.
WHO MADE THAT DECISION?
WE DON'T KNOW BUT THAT'S OKAY
BECAUSE WE'RE AT THE POINT NOW
WHERE WE'RE SAYING WE CAN FIX
THIS AND HERE'S HOW.
SO BY THE WAY WE WENT THROUGH A
VERY DELIBERATIVE PROCESS ON
THIS I KNOW THIS IS KIND OF
CONFUSING BUT I JUST WANT PEOPLE
TO UNDERSTAND.
WITH THESE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
THESE RESIDENTS HAVE BEEN
LOOKING AT THE SOURCES.
THOSE STARS ON THEIR THEY
REPRESENT TOXIC EMISSIONS FROM
AIR TOXICS SOURCES THE ROUND DOT
TREATMENTS DO.
NOT REPRESENT STATIONARY SOURCE
EMISSIONS SO YOU CAN SEE RIGHT
AWAY HOW MANY OF THESE EMISSIONS
LIE NOT JUST ALONG THE HIGHWAY
BUT OFF THE HIGHWAY IN THESE
COMMUNITIES.
ALONG THESE COMMUNITIES AND THE
RESIDENTS RIGHTLY SO WANT TO SEE
THESE SOURCES INCLUDED IN ANY
WORK THAT GETS DONE.
AND IN FACT EVEN THOUGH IT'S
QUITE SOME.
YOU SEE A LITTLE NOTATION OF
DARLING INDUSTRIES WHICH IS
BECOME NATIONALLY FAMOUS. FOR
ITS A RENDERING PLANT.
AND WRITE DOWN WIND OF IT IS A
HIGH SCHOOL.
AND THAT HIGH SCHOOL ON ANY
GIVEN DAY IT'S GOT ABOUT. FIVE
THOUSAND KIDS.
AN AND THEY'LL TELL YOU IN MAY
YOU CAN HARDLY STAND IT THERE.
THE SMELL OF THIS PLACE AS
ROTTING ANIMAL FLESH IS JUST.
WAITING INTO THE AIR AND COMING
DOWN ON THEIR SCHOOL WHEN THEY
COME OUTSIDE FOR A BREAK.
THEY HAVE TO DEAL WITH THAT THIS
IS RIDICULOUS SO IN THE NEXT TO
IT IS FOSTER FARMS AND I ALWAYS
SAY NINE O'CLOCK IN THE EVENING.
GO OUT TO ANY OF THE
NEIGHBORHOODS HERE DOWN WHEN TO
FOSTER FARMS AND ALL YOU CAN
SMELL FOR FOUR HOURS IS BAKING
CHECK.
SO I MEAN YOU KNOW THESE ARE
SOURCES THAT ARE DIRECT THREAT
TO THESE COMMUNITIES THAT THEY
EXPERIENCE EVERY DAY AND HAVE
BEEN. FOR THE LAST FIFTY YEARS
OR MORE AND THEY HAVE COMPLAINED
AND TRIED TO GET REDRESS FROM
LOCAL GOVERNMENT AGENCIES FROM
PLANNING COMMISSIONS.
AND FOR THE BAD LUCK OF OUR
AGENCY HERE NOW COMING HERE AND
SAYING LOOK.
YOU KNOW WE WANT THIS CHECKED
OUT WE WANT MONITORS AROUND THE
SOURCES WE WANT TO KNOW WHAT'S
IN THIS AIR.
AND IF IT'S WHAT WE THINK IT IS
YOU NEED TO FIX THIS.
AND THAT DOESN'T SEEM
UNREASONABLE SO THE COMMUNITY
HAS PROPOSED ACTUALLY THIS
BOUNDARY.
I I DON'T KNOW WHERE THEY GOT
THE MAP THAT THEY'RE USING BUT
THAT'S COOL I THINK IT'S MORE
THAT 1% RIGHT THAT YOU'RE
SHOWING ON YOUR MAP BUT THIS IS
ACTUALLY WHAT THE COMMUNITY HAS
pALL OF THESE CORNERS OUR GEO
TAGGED OUR SHOP AT CCAC HAS THE
TECHNICAL EXPERTS WHO CAN
PRODUCE THIS DATA.
AND ALL OF THE SOURCES ARE FROM
THE AIR THE BASE AND OUR MOST
CURRENT CELL.
SO THE LAST THING I DO WANT TO
MENTION IS YOU HEARD ABOUT OUR
IN THE INDUSTRIAL TRIANGLE
THAT'S NOT ACTUALLY A PLACE.
IT'S A PLAN THE CITY OF FRESNO
MADE TO SITE ALL THIS INDUSTRIAL
STUFF.
RIGHT IN THIS SPOT IN SOUTH
FRESNO THERE'S BEEN
DISENFRANCHISED FOR THE PAST
HUNDRED YEARS.
LOTS OF PEOPLE LIVING DOWN THERE
THIS IS NOT ACTUALLY A TRIANGLE
THIS IS ACTUALLY THE INDUSTRIAL
COMPATIBILITY PLAN THAT THEY'RE
STARTING THE PROCESS ON TO SEE
CAN WE PUT ALL THAT INDUSTRY.
RIGHT HERE AND NO WHERE ELSE IN
OUR CITY.
THERE'S NINETY SEVEN THOUSAND
PEOPLE LIVING HERE.
I MEAN SERIOUSLY.
SO WE SEE FROM A LAND USE
DECISION MAKING PERSPECTIVE THIS
IS WHY WE SAY WE NEED MORE TEETH
IN THE AIR REGULATIONS.
I SEE YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT THE
GREEN THE PURPLE OR BOTH ALL OF
IT THE GREEN THE PURPLE AND THE
YELLOW AT THE BOTTOM IS OUTSIDE
THE SPHERE OF INFLUENCE BUT THEY
STILL.
WOULD LIKE TO EITHER IN EXETER
GET COOPERATION FROM THE COUNTY
IT'S NOT THE GREAT.
RIGHT NOW IT IS THE GREEN IS THE
EXISTING INDUSTRIAL AREA.
THE PURPLE IS WHAT THEY INTEND
TO EXPAND.
TO SO ANYWAY --
I WANT TO PASS THIS ON NOW --
TO MY COLLEAGUES I JUST WANT TO
TOUCH BRIEFLY ON THE FRESNO
POSITION HERE.
CARB APPROVED BOND SO ARGUMENTS
WE'VE HEARD BACK FROM THE AIR
DISTRICT SO WE JUST WANNA.
RAISE THOSE TO MAKE SURE WE GET
HIM UP ON THE TABLE AND TALK
ABOUT HIM.
THE CARD APPROVED BOUNDARY
CANNOT BE MODIFIED TO THIS LEVEL
AND I UNDERSTAND THAT YOU'RE
ABOUT RESOURCES AND EXPAND YOU
KNOW AND STRETCHING THOSE THEN --
I UNDERSTAND THEY'RE
RECONSIDERING THE THE COMMUNITY
BOUNDARIES WE SAID AS HOME TO
THE MOST DISPROPORTIONATELY
BURDEN NEIGHBORHOODS IN THE
ENTIRE STATE.
THE AREA'S TWO BIG.
WELL COMPARED TO SOME OF THE
OTHER SELECTED COMMITTEES IT'S
IT'S NOT THE LARGEST EVEN WITH
THE NEW GROUP.
WITH THE NEW EXPANSION --
THERE'S A TYPE TIELINE WE NEED
TO KEEP GOING.
WE AGREE YOU KNOW WE WANT TO
KEEP THIS THING GOING.
WERE WILLING TO HELP BRING MORE
PEOPLE UP TO SPEED AND MEET MORE
OFTEN TO MEET THESE DEADLINES.
AND THERE'S BEEN THIS SORT OF
MET THAT SOUTHWEST IS ITS OWN
COMMUNITY.
WELL IN THE TCC IT WAS BUT YOU
KNOW THAT COMMUNITY IS ADJACENT
ALL THESE OTHER COMMUNITIES
EXPERIENCING THESE EMISSIONS --
IT'S YOU CAN'T FIND A DIVIDING
LINE WHERE YOU COULD SAY I KNOW
I'M HERE AND I KNOW I'M NOW HERE
TWENTY SAY THEY'RE NOW IT YOU
YOU ARE NOW A THIRTEEN MINUTE I
AM SO SORRY HAVE DOGS AND
BETWEEN THE TWO OF YOU --
SO AND FRESNO WILL NOT LIKELY BE
SELECTED IN THE SECOND ROUND SO
WE NEED TO GET IT IN NOW
[inaudible]
SIR.
I APOLOGIZE FOR ANY.
TAKEN UP --
MY NAME SAID HANNAH HERE TODAY I
A WORKING KERN WITH US INTO
CALIFORNIA BY MENTAL JUSTICE
NETWORK.
AND I WOULD LIKE TO START OFF
WITH A QUOTE FROM AN OF A
MARKETS WHICH IS ONE OF THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THAT LIVES IN
CHAPTER AFTER THE FIRST MEETING
THAT WE HAD --
THIS IS NOT WHERE YOU WENT TO
CHECK IN A CAR TO COME AND WAIT.
FOR PEOPLE TO TELL ME WHAT
THEY'RE DOING OR WHAT THEY HAVE
DONE INSTEAD OF WHAT THEY'RE
GOING TO DO IN MY COMMUNITY.
AND THIS IS A SENTIMENT THAT HAS.
BECOME BETTER WITH TIME I KNOW
BETTER NOW FEELS MORE HOPE WITH
THIS PROCESS AND THIS HAS BECOME
THIS IS BECAUSE OF THE PARADIGM
SHIFT.
THAT SAMIR WAS TALKING ABOUT.
OF COURSE NOT NOTHING IS PERFECT
BUT THERE IS WORK ON BOTH SIDES
AS FAR AS ON THE COMMUNITY AS
WELL AS THE DISTRICTS WHICH I'D
LIKE TO EXTEND A THANK YOU TO
FOR YOU KNOW RESPECTING AND
LISTENING TO THESE RESIDENTS.
AND NOT SAYING YOU KNOW WHAT WE
KNOW THEY'RE BETTER THAN YOU DO
SO THAT IS THE WORD JOB THEY'RE
LISTENING TO THE TO THE
RESIDENTS AND THEIR TAKING THEIR
INTERESTS INTO ACCOUNT AND
PRODUCING.
THINGS THAT WE CAN SEE. TO SHOW
US THAT THEY ARE LISTENING TO
THE RESIDENTS SO THIS IS CHAPTER
RIGHT.
THE PROPOSED BOUNDARY IS WITHIN
THE GREEN LINE.
THIS MAP WAS MADE LARGE AND
GIVEN TO THE COMMUNITY DURING
ONE OF THE COMMITTEE STEERING
MEETINGS.
THE COMMITTEE WAS ASKED TO PLACE
MARKERS WHERE THE POLLUTION
SOURCES WERE AND OF COURSE
WITHIN THE WINDOW OF THE GREEN
AREA.
THEY SAID WALL.
THE ROOFING PLAN IS HERE AND ALL
OF THE OIL IS DOWN HERE AND THAT
THERE IS ARE THIS WAY WE CAN PUT
HIM ON THE MAP.
WE NEED TO EXTEND THE BOUNDARIES
AND WHAT CAME OF A CONSENSUS IN
VOTING PROCESS OF THE COMMITTEE
WITH THIS EXTENDED SEVEN MILE
BOUNDARY WHICH AS YOU SEE THE
GREAT TABS ON THE OUTSIDE
REPRESENT EMISSIONS THAT WERE
NOT PREVIOUSLY.
WITHIN THE EMISSIONS INVENTORY
IN CHAPTER.
THIS IS A IS A GALLON VIRAL
SCREEN MAP THAT SHOWS THE HIGH
LEVEL OF PESTICIDE USE FALLS
WITHIN THE NINETIETH PERCENTILE.
WITHIN THE CITY OF SHAFTER THE
PROPOSED.
TONNAGE OF THE PESTICIDE IS
AROUND TWO THOUSAND IN THE
CENSUS TRACKS. TO THE WEST AND
TO THE EAST WHEN SHOWS TWO
THOUSAND SEVEN HUNDRED NINETY
SIX OTHER ONE THOUSAND NINE
HUNDRED NINETY THREE POUNDS PER
SQUARE MILE OF PESTICIDES
APPLIED.
WHICH IS ANOTHER REASON WHY THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS WERE VERY
INTERESTED IN EXTENDING THIS
BOUNDARY.
THIS IS THE MAP GIVEN TO US BY
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH THAT SHOWS A
LEGEND AS WELL --
THAT SHOWS THAT THERE IS NEAR
CHAPTER AND AS WELL THEY FALL
OUTSIDE OF THE JURISDICTIONAL
AREA -- BUT
WITH THIS INCREASE THE SEVEN
MILE RADIUS. SEVEN OF THESE TEN
DAIRIES WILL FALL IN THE NEW
JURISDICTIONAL INVENTORY AND
ONLY THREE OF THEM FALL OUTSIDE
WITH THE FOR THIS ONE BEING ON
THE EIGHT AND A HALF MILES FROM
CHAPTER ALL TEN OF THEM BEING
WITHIN FIVE MILES OF ME BEFORE
WHICH IS --
THIS ONE OF THE ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL THAT HAVE HOLDS THE
HIGHEST POPULATION OF KIDS IN
THE DISTRICT.
SO THIS MAP NOT CORRUPTED BUT
THIS IS KIND OF MY ROUTINE
INDICATOR MAP OF JENNER
GENERATORS OF HAZARDOUS WASTE I
WILL GO THIS WAY REAL QUICK.
SO IF YOU SEE RIGHT HERE THESE
ARE ALL OF THE HAZARDOUS WASTE
AREAS.
AND THESE ARE HERE AS WELL THAT
WERE NOT INCLUDED IN THE
ORIGINAL BOUNDARIES BUT BECAUSE
OF THE EXTENDED SEVEN MILE
BOUNDARIES NOW THESE HAZARDOUS
AREAS WILL FALL AND TO THE AREA.
THIS IS A TOXIC RELEASE FACILITY
GREEN INDICATOR MAP AS WELL IT
SHOWS THAT THE AB AGROCHEMICAL.
PLANT IS OUTSIDE AND THE GAP
ROOFING COMPANY IS OUTSIDE.
WHICH THEY ARE VERY GRATEFUL.
FOR THE THIS INDICATOR MAP IS OF
THE PM TWO POINT FIVE WHICH
SHOWS THAT.
CHAPTER FALLS WITHIN THE HUNDRED
PERCENTILE OF PM TWO POINT FIVE
ADDITIONALLY THERE IN EIGHTY
FIVE EIGHTY FIFTH PERCENTILE FOR
CARDIOVASCULAR PROBLEMS --
I THINK THE EIGHTY SIX
PERCENTILE FOR THE OVERALL
POLLUTION BURDENS NINETY ONE
PERCENTILE FOR OZONE AND THE
SEVENTY SIXTH PERCENTILE FOR
ASTHMA HAVING 6% ABOVE THE USUAL
AMOUNT OF KIDS PER CAPITA.
MEANING THEY HAVE A HIGHER
POPULATION OF KIDS THAN THE
USUAL CENSUS TRACT.
WHICH WE KNOW KIDS A DEVELOPING
KIDS ARE HIGHLY AFFECTED BY
THESE PM TWO POINT FIVE AND
OTHER ISSUES.
AS A RESULT OF THIS THIS WITH
THE PREVIOUS INVENTORY AND THIS
IS THE NEW SEVEN MILE INVENTORY
WHICH OBVIOUSLY SHOWS A MORE
COMPREHENSIVE.
INVENTORY AND THE ISSUES THAT
AFFECT THE RESIDENTS AS
EXPRESSED BY RESIDENTS IS MORE
EFFECTIVELY DEMONSTRATED WITH
THIS AREA OBVIOUSLY THIS THE HAS
IT THIS IS A MUST HAVE YOU SEEN
MY SHAKY HANDS RIGHT HERE.
THESE ARE THEIR YOUTH THERE IS
NO INFORMATION ON KNOCKS VOCS
YOUR TEAM TO POINT FIVE ON
DAIRIES. FOR TENANTS PER YEAR
WHICH WE WOULD LIKE AND THE ONLY
REASON WE HAVEN'T REACHED THIS
IS BECAUSE YOU KNOW WE HAVEN'T
TALKED ABOUT IT IN MEETINGS.
AND I FEEL CONFIDENT THAT WHEN
WE DO BRING THIS UP IN MEETINGS
IT WIL GET ADDRESS.
AS PER THE PARADIGM SHIFT THAT
SOME YOUR TALK ABOUT.
SELECT ALL THE SAME.
THESE ARE SOME POSITIONS THAT.
CAUSED I WOULD SAY TENSION BUT
NOT FRICTION WITHIN THE STEERING
COMMITTEE.
THE FIRST BEING WHY THE BOUNDARY
SHOULD BE EXPOUNDED WHICH I
THOROUGHLY EXPLAINED WITH THE
WITH THE PREVIOUS SLIDES THE
SECOND BEING VOTING AND
CONSENSUS NEEDED REFORM.
IN THE EARLY MEETINGS --
COMMITTEE MEMBERS WERE --
THE FACILITATOR TO THE COMMITTEE
IN CHAPTER WAS A MEMBER OF THE
AIR DISTRICT AND THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS ABOUT THAT --
THEIR VOTE WAS BEING WASHED OUT
BY OTHER PEOPLE THAT WERE
PREVIOUS OR CURRENT --
POLITICAL ADMINISTRATORS WITHIN
THE CITY OF SHAFTER AND OTHER
PEOPLE THAT HAVE THAT COULD
POTENTIALLY HAVE SPECIAL
INTERESTS WITHIN THE COMMITTEE --
THERE WAS NO CLEAR WAY TO REACH
CONSENSUS OR OF VOTING --
SYSTEM WHICH WAS ESTABLISHED
AFTER A CONCERN WAS MADE.
AND AS A TESTIMONY TO THE
PREVIOUS.
MEETING --
WIN CONSENSUS WITH ASKED FOR
EVERY SINGLE PERSON WAS TOUCHED
ON AND WHEN AN OPINION WITHOUT
FOR EVERY SINGLE PERSON IN THE
COMMITTEE MEETING --
WILL -- WAS
GIVEN AN OPPORTUNITY TO GET
THEIR OPPORTUNITY WHICH
PREVIOUSLY --
THEY DID NOT FEEL WAS THE WAS
THE CASE THE THIRTEEN THAT SOME
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MAY
HAVE A CONFLICT OF INTEREST --
THIS IS --
PERTAINING TO WERE ON THAT
COMMITTEE NAMED AT THAT BALLOT
GONZALEZ SHE IS A MEMBER OF A
ASTRO TURF A NONPROFIT CALLED.
LATINO LEADERS WHICH IS A CHILD
OF A ENERGY CONGLOMERATE CALLED
THE KERN CITIZENS FOR ENERGY
WHICH HAS I BELIEVE NINE
PETROLEUM ENERGY COMPANIES AS
PART OF THEIR BOARD ONE BEING
THAT C. R. C. WHICH IS
CALIFORNIA RESOURCE CORPORATION
AND I HAVE TO ASK YOU. TO TO
START WRAPPING IT UP AND THERE'S
NO INVENTORY FOR THEIRS AND
WE'RE SURE THAT IF SOMEONE'S ON
THE COMMITTEE THAT THEY WILL BE
MAKING SURE THAT THEIR EMISSIONS
ARE NOT --
TAKEN INTO CONSIDERATION.
AND THE FOURTH ONE WHICH HAS
IMPROVED IS DISTURBING MEETING
MATERIALS IN A TIMELY MANNER.
WHICH IS WHICH THE MERE TOUCHED
ON I'D LIKE TO AND BY --
AS YOU KNOW US PUTTING TWO
THINGS ONE WAS VERONICA ET SAID
SHE SAID --
COURSE ADJUSTMENTS TO HELP THE
SUBCOMMITTEE'S DO THEIR JOB
BETTER SO THAT'S WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN SHAFTER RIGHT NOW
AS I SAID IT'S NOT PERFECT IT'S
GETTING BETTER AND WE WE WILL
EVER FIND THIS PROCESS SO THAT
BY YEAR TO THIS WILL BE A MUCH
SMOOTHER PROCESS THEY GET THINGS
DONE.
MORE EFFICIENTLY.
AND AS TO YOUR POINT YOU SAID WE
NEED CREATIVITY THE RESIDENTS
ARE BRING IN THIS TYPE OF
CREATIVITY TO THE TABLE AYE AYES
WITH MENTIONED BY THE CENTRAL
VALLEY REPRESENTATIVE HE SAID
THAT HE WANTS INCENTIVES TO BE
MADE -- AND
RESIDENTS DON'T WANT TO SEE MORE
TRACTORS ONE THING THAT WAS
BROUGHT UP WITH MAYBE INSTEAD OF
OPEN BURNS WEEK THAT SHIP THEM.
INCENTIVIZE THEM FOR CHIPPING
AND THE CENTER BY THEM FOR
BURNING INSTEAD OF JUST GIVING
THEM SOMETHING WITHOUT AN
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR DOING A
BETTER A FOR EXAMPLE HERE'S THE
TRACTOR FOR LESS --
EMISSIONS BUT YOU DON'T HAVE TO
DO ANYTHING IT AND YOU KNOW THE
CREATIVITY THAT THEY'RE THAT
THEY'RE PRESENTING IS IS GONNA
HELP.
MAKE THINGS YOU KNOW HAVE BEEN
IN A IN A WAY THAT WE NEVER
EXPECTED BEFORE THEY DON'T HAVE
THE BLINDERS OF BUREAUCRACY TO
STOP THEM RIGHT THEY JUST SAYING
WELL WHY DON'T WE DO THIS THIS
SEEMS LIKE COMMON SENSE.
AND OBVIOUSLY BY WORKING WITH
THE DISTRICT IT WOULD HELP THEIR
IDEAS COMING TO FRUITION THANK
YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THIS GARCIA ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS.
THIS BILL.
I HAD A QUESTION OF ARE COMMON
ABOUT THE BOUNDARIES THAT RESET
AND EIGHTEEN THE INTENTIONAL IS
THAT WE DO LEARN AND WE GROW
WITH THIS PROCESS SO IS IS.
THERE A DISTRICT LOOKING TO
ADOPT.
THE SEVEN MILE OVER A FIVE MILE
AND I FORGET THE NUMBER I'M
SORRY IT'S LATE BUT THEN YOU
EIGHTY IF I RESPOND TO THAT WHAT
I UNDERSTAND TO BE THE QUESTION
THERE AT THE SEVEN MILES ARE IN
PLACE FOR SHAFTER IN FRESNO --
THE THERE IS A VERY OPEN MIND.
TO CHANGING THE BOUNDARY I I
THINK THE THE MAIN ISSUE THERE
IS REALLY GOING TO COME DOWN TO
UNDER AS YOU KNOW UNDER THE
STATUTE THE COMMUNITY SELECTION
PROCESS.
IS WITH CARD SO THEY THEY
SELECTED THE COMMUNITY SO.
RIGHT NOW THIS VERY ACTIVE
CONVERSATION GOING ON WITH
RICHARD CORY WE HAD A STEERING
COMMITTEE MEETING --
JUST WITHIN THE LAST WEEK OR SO
WHERE.
WE GOT SOME STRONG SORT OF FROM
THE COMMITTEE ON SORT OF WHAT
THEY WANT TO SEE.
THE ONLY THING THAT WE NEED TO
FIGURE OUT IS BETWEEN CARBS
SELECTION PROCESS LAST YEAR AND
THE RESOURCES THAT ARE IN PLACE.
HOW DRASTIC OF A OF A CHANGE YOU
TOO CAN YOU MAKE THAT BOUNDARY
WHEN YOU GO BACK TO THE
BLUEPRINTS IN THE PROCESS
ENVISIONED OR?
TO SEVENTEEN ADJUSTMENTS I THINK
AND YOU KNOW TO TO MAKE SURE WE
CAPTURE ALL THE RIGHT SORT I
THINK THERE'S DEFINITELY PROCESS
FOR DOING THAT.
IF YOU GOAL FOR WHOLE SCALE
CHANGE ANY KIND OF SHIFT OFF
INTO HUGE LIKE RIGHT NOW.
AB LIKE TO SEE THIS THIS MAP
THAT KEVIN MENTIONED TO LOOK A
LITTLE DIFFERENT THAN WHAT YOU
KNOW I THINK WE'VE SEEN IT'S
BEEN INVOLVING I THINK OVER TIME.
IT WAS OF A THREE FOLD INCREASE
ACTUALLY IN THE IN THE
GEOGRAPHIC AREA --
BASED ON THAT THE FIRST SET OF
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT WE SAW I
THINK IT AS WERE ABLE TO KIND OF
WORK TO WORDS OKAY WHAT ARE
THOSE CONCERNS THAT WE'RE TRYING
TO GET.
TO AND HOW DO WE MAKE SURE WE'RE
STILL CONSISTENT WITH YOU KNOW
WITH THE THE THE STATE ROLE
ACTUALLY GONNA SELECTING THE
COMMUNITY TO THAT PROCESS.
I THINK WE CAN GET THERE SO.
WE'RE WE'RE WORKING ON THAT VERY
ACTIVELY IT SHOULD BE YOU KNOW
WITHIN WITHIN A WEEK AND THE
DEADLINE THAT WE'VE ESTABLISHED.
TO HAVE A FINAL BOUNDARY SET UP
THAT I'M HOPING WE CAN REPORT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
YOU KNOW SORT OF SUPPORTS ALL OF
THEIR CONCERNS THAT CAME UP IN
THE IN THAT DISCUSSION.
SO WHAT THE NO WE BECAUSE
THEY'RE HAVING THE CONVERSATIONS
WITH AIR THE AND ALSO IT YOU
KNOW IT WITH WITH DIFFERENT
INDIVIDUALS HAVE BEEN.
CONTINUALLY GIVEN SUGGESTIONS ON
HOW TO TAKE THAT DIRECTION
ACTUALLY DO SOMETHING WITH A
THAT MEETS THOSE CONSERVATIVE
COME UP SO.
A AND I APPRECIATE THAT THERE BE
STILL HERE ON AND TAKING NOTE OF
OF THAT AND HOW.
EVEN FROM THE COMMUNITY OR TO
SEE THOSE BOUNDARIES LEARNING
FROM THIS PROCESS.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ALL VERY MUCH.
AND THEN OUR LAST PANEL --
IS -- MARK
LYTTON HEISER FROM SACRAMENTO
METROPOLITAN AIR QUALITY
MANAGEMENT DISTRICT.
AND BILL KNOWLTON MACRO
PARTNERSHIP WITH PATRICIA SHALL
BE NORTH OF GOING TO A CREEK
NEIGHBORHOOD ASSOCIATION.
I JUST TO CLARIFY THAT THAT --
MISTER KNOWLTON AND MICHELLE BE
WILL HAVE EIGHT MINUTES COMBINED
NOT A GOOD THING YEAH.
WE DOWN AT THE LAST WE HAVE A
GOAL.
THE BEST FOR LAST THANK YOU AND
WE WILL HAVE PUBLIC.
YEAH I MEAN WE WILL HAVE PUBLIC
COMMENTS AND COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AS WELL AT THE
END [inaudible]
SHARE
.
OKAY WELL I GUESS AT THIS POINT
IT IS GOOD EVENING.
MY NAME IS MARK ROUTES AND HIGHS
ARE REPRESENTS SECULAR QUITE
MANAGEMENT DISTRICT HERE THIS
EVENING.
ON OUR EXECUTIVE OFFICER NEVERS
PROSSER DR ALBERT TIE ALL OF
POLITICS WOULD NOT BE ABLE TO BE
HERE IN PERSON HE SURE IT'S GOT
AROUND HIS AVAILABILITY.
IN THE INTEREST OF TIME I'M
GONNA SORT OF SKIP SOME PARTS OF
THIS AND SO I'M GONNA.
APOLOGIZE TO ANY OF THE ELECTED
SOONER THAN THAT WE WERE GOING
TO THANK REPRESENTS CHECK OUR
REGION COULD OUR LOCAL ELECTED
SOME JUST GIVE A BROUGHT SHOUT
OUT TO ALL OF THEIR SUPPORT IN
THIS PROCESS --
TO THAT EXTENT I MAKE SO.
I MISTER JUMP RIGHT AHEAD THEN
IN TO SHARE WITH YOU VERY
QUICKLY WILL THAT WHAT WE DID IN
TERMS OF OUR ORIGINAL
NOMINATIONS OF MULTIPLE
COMMUNITIES AND FOCUS IN ON THE
COMMITTEE THAT WAS SELECTED IN
YOUR ONE SO.
WE'RE GONNA TALK VERY QUICKLY
ABOUT OUR ANALYSIS IN THE
IDENTIFICATION OF OUR ORIGINAL
TEND COMMUNITIES --
THAT WE HAD THOUGHT WERE THE
HIGHEST PRIORITY IN THE
SACRAMENTO AREA.
WE'LL DISCUSS IN THE UNIQUE
ASPECTS ARE COMMUNITIES AND HOW
THESE ASPECTS TRANSCEND BOTH
CHALLENGES AND OPPORTUNITIES.
AND BY THEN WE'LL TALK ABOUT
WHAT WE SEE MOVING FORWARD SIX
SEVENTEEN IN THE OPTION IS GOING
INTO THE FUTURE YEARS.
SO JUST FAIRLY QUICKLY HERE ONE
OF THINGS WE DID IN TERMS OF
JUST IDENTIFY COMMUNITIES AS A
WHOLE IN SACRAMENTO'S WE TRIED
TO GO WITH SOMETHING FAIRLY
QUANTITATIVE MEANING WE LOOKED
AT EVERYTHING FROM.
THE CALLIN BUYERS SCREEN --
WE TOOK A LOOK AT JUST THOSE
DIFFERENT ELEMENTS WE LOOKED AT
THE HEALTH RISK NEEDS ASSESSMENT
WHICH IS A HOSPITAL BASED
INFORMATION THAT THE LOCAL
HOSPITAL REQUIRED PUT TOGETHER
INVOLVED EVERYTHING FROM ASTHMA.
EMERGENCY ROOM VISITS WE TOOK A
LOOK AT ECONOMICS WE TOOK A LOOK
AT POVERTY ISSUES WE ALSO TOOK A
LOOK AT WHERE ARE THEIR PARKS
WHERE THEIR SCHOOLS WHERE IS THE
LOCATION OF OUR NEARBY
BUSINESSES INCLUDING OUR TOXIC
HOT SPOTS FOR THE TWENTY FIVE
IDIOT SOURCES.
DOING ALL THOSE THINGS WE
BASICALLY SIGNED JUST A
SCREENING NUMBER TO THEM AND
FROM THAT THEN WE RANKED OUT TEN
BROAD COMMUNITIES.
THE REASON I KNOW THIS RECAP
EARLIER IN SOME THE OTHER
PRESENTATIONS THAT YOU SEE SIR
SOME ODD BOUNDARIES AS A WHOLE
IS A LOT INFORMATION CENSUS
TRACT BASED.
AND CENSUS TRACTS THEMSELVES
HAVE VERY ODD ANGLES.
BANDS NOOKS CRANNIES XTERRA.
SO THEN WE TOOK HIM WE ADDED A
HALF MILE BUFFER --
TO THE CENSUS TRACKS THAT'S WHY
YOU SEE SOME OF THESE.
CURVING AREAS.
SO. TO THE EXTENT THAT WE DO
BELIEVE THAT --
THIS ROBUST APPROACH MORE
QUICKLY CAPTURES EXPOSURE TO
POLLUTION AND THE IMPACT ON OUR
COMMUNITIES.
AND SO WITH THAT THOUGH THEN
WILL FOCUS IN ON THE SOUTH
SECOND FLOOR AND COMMUNITY WHICH
WAS ACTUALLY SELECTED IN YEAR.
ONE AND YOU'LL SEE THAT ONCE OF
A NICE LITTLE CLEAN BOUNDARIES
ARE CLEANER BOUNDARIES AT THE
MOMENT ON THIS MAP AND WHERE
THAT COMES FROM.
IS THIS SENSE OF IT HARD TO SEE
ON THIS.
YOU WILL SEE A DASHED LINE
INSIDE OF THE OVERALL BOX.
THAT WAS THE ORIGINAL COMMITTEE
BOUNDARIES TO THE CALIFORNIA
RESOURCES BOARD BACK IN THE FALL.
AND THE FINAL BOUNDARIES ARE
WHAT CAME OUT OF THE COMMUNITY
PROCESS OF THEM TAKING A LOOK AT
THAT THEM LOOKING AT SAYING --
WHERE DID YOU COME UP WHY YOU
HAVE THIS NICK HERE WHAT IS TO
COME UP WITH AND SO THERE
FEEDBACK ON BOTH?
BUSINESSES THAT THEY KNEW ABOUT
JUST WHERE THEY WANTED TO TRY IT
SO KEEP THE COMMUNITY SOMEWHAT
DEFINED.
IN TERMS OF JUST MAKING SURE
THAT THIS IS A COMMUNITY FOCUS.
HAS ALWAYS WE GO BACK TO
PREVIOUS MAP WE HAVE A NUMBER OF
AREAS TROUT SECTOR THEY'RE ALL
VERY IMPACT IN CONCERN.
OF RHETORIC INTO A COMMUNITY
SCALE MONITORING.
THE THOUGHT PROCESS FROM THE
DISTRICT BUT I AND SUPPORTED BY
THE STEERING COMMITTEE WAS.
LET'S TRY TO KEEP IT DOWN HERE
INTO THIS COMMUNITY WE CAN FIND
OUT ATTY COMMUNITY.
NEIGHBORHOOD LEVEL BASIS.
ANSWER THE SOUTH SECOND FORM WAS
ONE OF OUR TOP RATE COMMUNITIES
DUE TO SEVERAL FACTORS.
NOW WE DO HAVE THE CENSUS TRACTS
ARE DESIGNATED AS DISSIDENTS
COMMUNITIES THEY ARE THAT TOP
TWO PERCENTILE OF THE COUNT
BUYERS SCREEN.
IT IS RIGHT NEXT TO IN
SURROUNDING THE HIGHWAY.
NINETY NINE A LOT OF TRAFFIC
COMING IN AND JUST A BIT FURTHER
WEST THE FIVE OZ THEY ARE AN
AREA THAT IS CRISSCROSSED BY
MAJOR THOROUGHFARES INCLUDING
TRUCKING ROUTES THAT ARE GOING
THROUGH THEIR COMMUNITY AREA.
AND SO THOSE ARE JUST SOME OF
THE DIFFERENT ELEMENTS THAT
CAUSES -- TO
RISE TO THE TOP AREAS.
I ALREADY MENTIONED THE STRENGTH
IS ACTUALLY ONE IN SELECTING THE
FINAL BOUNDARIES ON THE
COMMUNITY.
AND JUST TOUCH REAL QUICKLY UPON --
STRUCK ME ITSELF IT IS COMPRISED
OF MOSTLY RESIDENTS ALTHOUGH WE
DO HAVE REPRESENTATION FROM THE
BUSINESS BOTH --
BROAD REPRESENTATION AND SMALL
WE HAVE SOME COMMITTEE GROUPS
ARE REPRESENTED ON AS WELL ALONG
WITH A HEALTH OFFICIAL AND ONE
MEMBER REPRESENTING OUR LOCAL
ELECTED FOR THE AREA --
THE SELECTION PROCESS JUST THAT --
HAS READ THE TYPE OF PERSON THAT
OCCURRED TO HOW WE SELECTED OUR
STEERING COMMITTEE WAS WE SORTED
IT WERE WE DID IT IN A TWO STEP
PROCESS.
THE DISTRICTS SCREENED ONLY TO
ENSURE THAT INTEREST THE CANNONS
LIVED OR WORKED IN OR
IMMEDIATELY ADJACENT TO THE
SELECTED COMMUNITY THE REASON I
SAY CHASTENED TO IT IS WE KNEW
THAT THE BOUNDARY LIKELY WOULD
BE CHANGING A LITTLE BIT.
AND ULTIMATELY THE ALL THE
BRIDGE.
THAT MEMBERS ARE WITHIN THE
FINAL BOUNDARY.
THE SECOND STEP OF THE PROCESS
WAS THEN THE DISTRICTS SIMPLY
RECOMMENDED INCLUSION OF ALL
MEMBERS ARE ALL APPLICANTS WHO
MET THOSE CRITERIA OF LIVING OR
WORKING IN THE COMMUNITY. TO A
SELECTION BODY IF YOU WILL IN
THAT BODY INCLUDED BOTH OUR
LOCAL ACT IT'S INCLUDED THE E.
J. OFFICE OF CARP.
AND INCLUDED OTHER NGO GROUPS
THROUGHOUT SACRAMENTO INCLUDING
AREAS SUCH AS BREEDS.
AN ORGANIZED SACRAMENTO JUST TO
NAME A COUPLE OF THE L.
ORGANIZATIONS ARE INVOLVED.
OUR COMMUNICATION PROCESSES
COMMANDER WAY AND STERN
COMMITTEE HAS COME IN SEVERAL
TIMES SINCE DECEMBER AS MEETING
AGAIN BOTH TOMORROW AND NEXT
WEEK.
WE REALIZE HOW WAIT WE'RE GOING
TONIGHT WITH MY POSTPONED THAT
ONE FOR TOMORROW --
JUST SOME KEY CONCERNS THAT PIPE
IN HIGH BY THE COMMITTEE INCLUDE
EMISSIONS FROM THE FREEWAYS AND
ROADWAYS.
IMPACTS FROM THESE MISSIONS ON
SENSE RECEPTORS SUCH AS CHILDREN
WALKING TO SCHOOL AND LIVING
NEAR THE ROADWAYS.
SO REAL QUICKLY JUST WALL.
WE HAVE BEEN UNDER VERY
AGGRESSIVE TIME LINES WITH GUYS
MISTER COMMITTEE WE ARE ON TRACK
TO MEET THE STATE'S DEADLINE TO
INITIATE CARE MONITORING BY JULY.
ONE I QUIT WILL LIKELY INCLUDE A
COMBINATION OF MOBILE LAB
EQUIPPED WITH A COLLECTION OF
VARIOUS WITH THE FOR THE
COLLECTION OF VARIOUS GASES AND
CAN'T POLLUTION SAMPLES OF THIS
WOULD BE REGULATORY GREAT
MONITORING.
IN COMBINATION WITH.
A NETWORK WANDERING IN THE
COMMUNITY.
WHILE LOW COST SENSORS COME WITH
LIMITATIONS WE BELIEVE THEY ARE
GOOD SCREENING TOOL AND CAN LEAD
TO A BETTER UNDERSTANDING OF
LOCALIZED ENTRANCE IN IMPACTS
THAT EXISTING AIR MODERN
NETWORKS CANNOT CAPTURE.
HENCE THE BENEFIT OF SIX
SEVENTEEN IN PARALLEL WE'RE ALSO
WORKING VERY EFFECTIVELY WE
THINK THERE STERN COMMITTEE AT
SUGGEST BY CARD DURING THIS TIME
A BOARD MEETING WHEN THE TEN
COMMUNITY STATE WIDE WERE
SELECTED.
WHETHER COMMUNITIES FORMALLY
IDENTIFIED FOR AIR MONITORING
ONLY SHOULD NOT DETRACT FROM THE
IMPORTANCE EMISSION REDUCTION
PLANS FOR TAKING PROMPT ACTION
TO IDENTIFY SOURCE OF POLLUTION
IMPACTS.
ANY OPTIONS TO MITIGATE THEM.
IN THIS REGARD WE APPEAL TO THIS
COMMITTEE AND YOUR FELLOW
LEGISLATORS TO MAKE A BILL CAP
AND TRADE FINE PRINCESS
REMISSION REDUCTIONS IN OUR
COMMUNITIES. FOR EXPECT MUCH OF
THE FOCUS WILL RIGHT PLEASE.
BE ON AND SENSIBLE SOURCE
REDUCTIONS WE APPLAUD THE
LEGISLATORS LET'S SESSIONS WITH
HIM TO LEAVE THE DOOR OPEN
POTENTIAL NEW OPPORTUNITY
REDUCTIONS THAT STATIONARY
SOURCES.
AB SIX SEVENTEEN TO BEGIN A NEW
CHAPTER IN THE HISTORY OF BACK
TO PUSH CONTROLS OR INCENTIVES --
BY LAUNCHING THE RIGHT SOLUTIONS
FOR SENSOR RECEPTORS LIKE
SCHOOLS AND EDUCTION BEYOND
THOSE REQUIRED FROM LOCAL
SOURCES.
ON OUR SIDE THE DISTRICT IS
REVIEWING A RULES AND UPDATING
FESTIVAL RETROFIT CONTROL
TECHNOLOGY REQUIREMENTS WE ALSO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH CARP ON
NEW AN EXPECTED REGULAR
REQUIREMENTS FOR MISSIONS
REPORTING AND REMAIN HOPEFUL
THAT THE LEGISLATURE WILL
IDENTIFY THE NESTOR RESOURCES WE
NEED TO EMPLOY.
IMPLEMENT THIS NEW STATE MANDATE.
THE LAST POINT I WOULD LIKE TO
COVER WROTE BEFORE I TURN ORDER
STERN COMMITTEE REPRESENTATIVES
IS WHERE WE GO FROM HERE.
THE DISTRICT APPRECIATES
RESOURCES ALLOCATE IN THE FIRST
YEAR THE PROGRAM FOR
IMPLEMENTATION AND INCENTIVES
ONE KEY TAKE WAY FOR EXPERIENCES
THAT EVEN GREATER THAN
ANTICIPATED RESOURCES.
SOURCE NEEDS OF AN ASSOCIATE
WITH HIS FIRST COMMUNITIES.
INVOLVED WITH OUR COMMUNITY
STERN COMMITTEE HAS BEEN VERY
POSITIVE IT ALSO BEEN FAR MORE --
RESOURCE INTENSIVE THAN WE
ORIGINALLY ANTICIPATED.
BOTH IN TIME COMMITMENTS FOR THE
STRENGTHENING THEMSELVES IN
AGAIN APPRECIATE THE TIME THAT
ARE STERN COMMITTEE HAS SPENT
HER TODAY CAN TOMORROW NEXT WEEK.
BUT ALSO THEN THE NECESSARY
RESOURCES THAT WE HAVE AS A
DISTRICT TO PROVIDE INFORMATION
TO THEM AND TO ANSWER QUESTIONS
THEY HAVE SAID THEY CAN MAKE
WELL INFORMED DECISIONS AND
RECOMMENDATIONS.
MOVING FORWARD WILL CONTINUE
WORK WITH CARBON INTEND TO
RECOMMEND THE INCLUSION A SECOND
COMMUNITY IN THE SECOND REGION
FOR YOUR TO THE PROGRAM.
BUT AS WE EXPANDED TO ADDITIONAL
IMPACTED COMMUNITIES.
SUFFICIENT RESOURCES FROM THE
STATE WILL BE ESSENTIAL TO THE
SUCCESS OF COMMITTEE MONITORING
AND REDUCTIONS OF LOCAL MISSIONS.
THESE NEIGHBORHOODS ALL HAVE
ACCESS POLLUTION IMPACTS ARE
EXPECTING ACTION.
RIGHTFULLY THE PROMISE OF AB SIX
SEVENTEEN HAS RAISED
EXPECTATIONS IN OUR
NEIGHBORHOODS THAT HELP IS
COMING.
OUR AGENCY LOOKS FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH.
YOU TO ADVOCATE FOR ADEQUATE AN
UNINTERRUPTED FUNDING THAT NOT
ONLY CAN WE IMPLEMENT THIS
PROGRAM THE MAINTAIN PROGRESS
REDUCTION POLLUTION BURDENS AND
IMPROVE HEALTH OUTCOMES.
WEEKEND WANTED THANK THIS STAFF
HERE AND ALL OF OUR ELECTED
SPOKE STATE AND LOCAL IN TERMS
THIS.
WE APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY
SHARE OUR PERSPECTIVE AB SIX
SEVENTEEN IMPLEMENTATION WE HAVE
TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS NOW OR
AFTER MISTER DALTON AND THE
SHALL BE ADDRESSED THE COMMITTEE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING EVERYONE.
MY NAME IS BILL WALTON AND I AM
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
MACRO PARTNERSHIP --
WE ARE A BUSINESS.
AND PROPERTY IMPROVEMENT
DISTRICT AND IN SOUTH SACRAMENTO
ALONG BACK ROADS.
SORRY.
I WILL BE EXTREMELY BRIEF I
PROMISE -- I
REPRESENT ABOUT THREE HUNDRED
BUSINESSES IN THAT AREA.
AND AND THE CHAIR OF THE
STEERING COMMITTEE I FOUND THE
INTERACTION BETWEEN THE STEERING
COMMITTEE AND THE AND THE STAFF --
EXEMPLARY --
WE HAVE LEARNED SO MUCH ABOUT
OUR OUR OUR REGION AND SO MUCH
ABOUT REALLY THE LOCAL IMPACTS
OF OF DIFFERENT KINDS OF
POLLUTION.
SO I CAN'T SAY ENOUGH ABOUT THE
STAFF IN IN THEIR LEADERSHIP --
WE HAVE --
WE HAVE A DIVERSE GROUP OF
PEOPLE FROM FROM BUSINESS PEOPLE --
TO TO RESIDENTS TO COMMUNITY
ACTIVIST ACT --
REALLY PEOPLE ADVOCATING FOR
THEIR NAME I WILL SAY THAT THAT
THE THE NEIGHBORHOOD THAT WE
HAVE IS IS IS IT'S A REALLY --
A COMMERCIAL DISTRICT WITH WITH
A LOT OF WHAT THAT BRINGS WITH
IT -- BY
OFFICE SITS ON RIGHT ON STOCKTON
BOULEVARD IN.
NINETY NINE AND ON SUCH A
BOULEVARD THERE'S THERE'S RIGHT
UNDER --
EIGHT NINETY THOUSAND CARS THAT
SIT THERE AN IDLE EVERYDAY.
AND WHEN WE HAD ONE OF OUR
MEETINGS THE THE THE DOCTOR SAID.
I WANT TO TELL YOU WHERE THE
EGGS THE WORST [inaudible]
BUILDING.
IN THE ENTIRE DISTRICT AS AN OF
LISTENING AND HE SAID YOU'RE
SITTING AT BILL IT'S OUR OFFICE.
ED AND AND THAT'S POWERFUL.
WOULD YOU SAY THIS IS THIS IS
REALLY.
THE THE MOST OF MOST AFFECTED
YOU KNOW PART OF OUR OUR
COMMUNITY AND IT'S RIGHT THERE
RIGHT IN THE HEART.
SO I AYE AYE BOGLE YOU KNOW INTO
TO A LOT OF DETAIL AND KNOW YOU
GUYS ARE TIRED AND AND I'VE
HEARD A LOT.
I JUST WANT TO SAY THAT THIS
THIS MISTER COMMITTEE HAS BEEN
VERY VERY INTERACTIVE.
VERY -- VERY
PRO NOT A LOT OF BRAIN DAMAGE --
REALLY IT'S BEEN HOW DO WE GET
FROM HERE TO HERE AND IT'S
REALLY ABOUT BUILDING HEALTHY
COMMUNITIES IN OUR OUR COMMUNITY
IS UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES.
AT AT OUR COMMUNITY DESERVES
EVERYTHING THAT EVERY OTHER
COMMUNITY HOUSE.
THE SAME OPPORTUNITIES YOU KNOW
LIFE LIFE EXPECTANCY SHOULD NOT
BE A ZIP CODE AND AND AND WE WE
HEAR THAT A LOT IT'S KIND OF A
BUZZ WORD BUT IT'S A FACT.
YOU KNOW WHO PEOPLE A GRANITE
BAY LIVE LONGER THE PEOPLE IN
AND SALSA THAT'S A THAT'S A FACT.
AND SO FOR US THIS IS REALLY
REALLY IMPORTANT AND AGAIN THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP
WERE WERE HAPPY TO BE HERE AND
WERE -- WERE
BOTH HAPPY THAT WE WE'VE WAITED
ALL DAY.
OF OUR CLASSES.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS PATRICIA SHELBY I AM
A A LONG TERM RESIDENT OF CELL
SACRAMENTO.
MOTHER OF FIVE GRANDMOTHER TO AT
THE NINTH ONE ON THE WAY --
I HAVE REAL CONCERNS I AM A AND
ASTHMA SUFFER I HAD TO STOP MY
JOB EARLY BECAUSE OF MY LUNG
PROBLEMS AND MY SPECIALIST HAS
RECOMMENDED THAT I MOVED.
AWAY SOME PLACE THAT I DON'T
KNOW WHERE AND TO TRY TO
PRESERVE I NATURAL LIFE TIME FOR
MYSELF.
I BURIED MY MOTHER IN SEPTEMBER.
I A NON SMOKER NEVER LIVED IN A
HOUSEHOLD OF SMOKERS WHO DIED OF
LUNG CANCER AFTER MOVING TO
SACRAMENTO TO SUPPORT ME AND MY
CHILDREN AND MY FAMILY FOR
THIRTY YEARS.
SO THIS IS IMPORTANT TO ME IT IS
IMPORTANT TO MY FAMILY IT'S
IMPORTANT TO MY CHILDREN.
ALL OF MY GRANDCHILDREN ARE
ASTHMA SUFFERERS --
THAT'S AMAZING TO ME I DID NOT
HAVE ASTHMA UNTIL I MOVED TO
SACRAMENTO THIRTY YEARS AGO.
AND STARTED TO FIVE YEARS AND
STARTING TO HAVE PROBLEMS.
SO -- THIS
OPPORTUNITY WAS IMPORTANT TO ME
I DE I A STATED AT THE VERY
FIRST MEETING I'M NOT HERE TO BE
WALL PAPER.
I'M NOT HERE TO JUST BE A CHECK
ON THE BOX ARE WE REALLY TRYING
TO DO SOMETHING.
AND THAT'S WHAT WE WANT TO PUSH
AND THAT'S WHAT WE WANTED TO WE
HAVE.
A LOT OF CHILDREN IN THE AREA WE
HAVE A LOT OF YOUNG FAMILIES.
AND THEY ARE IN THE SAID DID --
ERR ERR QUALITY AND WE WANT TO
BE ABLE TO ADDRESS IT AND MAKE A
CHANGE FOR THE FUTURE FOR
OURSELVES AND FOR OUR CHILDREN.
I WANT TO LIVE A LONG TIME I
WENT TO BE ABLE TO ENJOY MY
CHILDREN AND MY GRANDCHILDREN
AND MY GREAT GRAND CHILDREN.
BUT I KNOW THAT THE AIR THAT I
BREATHE AND THAT THE AIR THAT IS
THERE FOR THEM.
CAN IMPACT THAT.
AND SO -- WE
HAVE --
WORKED TOGETHER SUCCESSFULLY WE
HAVETRIED OUR VERY BEST. TO
LAND ON A MOVING PLANE.
AND GET --
GET INFORMATION AND THE WE'VE
ASKED WE DEMANDED A LOT THEY
HAVE GIVEN US A LOT OF
INFORMATION A LOT OF RESOURCES.
SO WE COULD BRING OURSELVES UP
TO SPEED.
THE TIME FRAMES ARE VERY VERY
STRICT AND VERY VERY DIFFICULT
TO MEET.
BUT WE ARE ENDEAVORING TO DO IT
BECAUSE THIS IS IMPORTANT.
AND WE KNOW HOW MANY IS IT CAN
BE FLEETING WE KNOW HOW --
HOW TENDER ARE YOUNG CHILDREN'S
LUNGS ARE IN THE WE NEED TO
START THIS WORK NOW TO ADDRESS
IT AS SOON AS POSSIBLE?
SO I THINK YOU I THINK --
AND PARTNERS AND COLLEAGUES AND
WORKING ON THIS --
THEY DON'T TALK DOWN --
THEY BREAK IT DOWN WHEN WE NEED
TO BREAK IT DOWN.
AND BILL AND I ARE ARE CHAIR AND
CO CHAIR AND WE READ THE MEETING.
AND WE MAKE SURE THAT THE PUBLIC
HAS THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK CAN
BE UNDERSTOOD.
AND HOW TO HELP BORROWED CELLS
MANAGE BY TABLING SOME THINGS
AND STAFF WILL STAY AND LINGER
IN CANCER THAT PERSONAL ONE ON
ONE QUESTION INSTEAD OF TAKING
UP.
THAT THE TABLE TIME BUT I THINK
YOU SO VERY MUCH I SEE MY CLOCK
IS RUNNING OUT AND I WANT TO
BEAT THAT TIME SO THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY.
THANK YOU ARE YOU ARE YOU ARE
GOLD STAR GROUP --
BEFORE YOU BRING UP THE LAST
GROUP WHICH IS PUBLIC COMMENTS I
WANT TO SEE OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GARCIA'S ANY QUESTIONS FOR YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR JOINING
US.
AND THEN LASTLY WE HAVE A THREE
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WE'RE
GOING TO SPEAK IF THEY WANT TO
MAKE THEIR WAY UP.
GEN WILLIAMS --
EIGHT AND SMITH AND PROBABLY TRY
KNOWN IF THERE'S ANYBODY ELSE
WHO WANTED TO SPEAK PLEASE COME
UP.
I'LL GIVE MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
NO MORE I WILL CUT YOU OFF FOR
SURE -- AT
THAT POINT.
AND IF YOU CAN SPEAK FOR LESS
TIME THAT WOULD YOU'LL GET IT
DOUBLE GOLD STAR [inaudible]
VERNE.
SO WE WILL HAVE COMMENTS
AFTERWARDS FROM --
DISCUSSION MYSELF OKAY.
OKAY I'M CHEN WILLIAMS I'M THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITIES AGAINST TOXICS --
HOWEVER I HAVE AN ALTER EGO AND
THAT IS THAT YOU'RE THIS YOU'RE
CLOSE NATIONAL CLEAN AIR TEAM.
AND IN THE ROLE AS THE CHAIR OF
THE SIR CLOSE NATIONAL CLEANER
TEAM I DO A LOT OF WORK ON THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE FEDERAL
CLEAN AIR ACT.
AND I JUST WANTED TO JUST
BRIEFLY PUT THE ACT IN
PERSPECTIVE AND THAT IS THAT.
IT HAS A LIMITED NUMBER OF TOOLS
TO REDUCE AIR POLLUTION.
IT HAS ENFORCEMENT IT HAS
STANDARD SETTING AND IT HAS
CHANGES IN --
BASICALLY ATTAINMENT STATUS
EATING OF THIS PROGRAM WE WERE
VERY CLEAR IN ASKING.
THE CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES
BOARD.
WHATEVER MONITORING YOU'RE GONNA
DO CAN YOU PLEASE DO IT WITH
FEDERAL REFERENCE METHOD SO THAT
WE CAN GET THE BENEFITS OF THE
ACT --
BECAUSE WITHOUT THOSE BENEFITS
IS VERY DIFFICULT CARVE AND THE
DISTRICTS DO HAVE LIMITED TOOLS.
FROM AND WE'RE VERY FRUSTRATED
THEY DO NOT FOLLOW THAT ADVICE
BECAUSE NOW YEARS GONE BY AND WE
HAVE NOTHING THAT WE CAN USE TO
USE ANY OF THE TOOLS AND THE
FEDERAL ACT ACTUALLY GET
EMISSIONS REDUCTIONS.
AND MANY OF US --
ON THE ADVOCACY COMMUNITY OF
SAID THAT THIS WAS NOT EIGHT AIR
POLLUTION MONITORING BILL IT IS
A REDUCTION BILL.
AND NOW WE SEE THE CONSTANT NEED
FOR PEOPLE.
BOND MOST OF THE DISTRICTS CAME
UP HERE AND SAID IT'S GREAT TO
HAVE THE FUNDING WE NEED MORE
PEOPLE.
SO I WAS GOING TO HAVE A QUICK
POWER POINT IT HAD A PERSON WITH
A CLIPBOARD SAYS THIS IS NOT ANY
MISSION REDUCTION.
YOU KNOW A ELECTRIC CAR --
A HYBRID VEHICLE A YOU KNOW ONE
OF ONE OF THE LIST OF MY
COLLEAGUES JESSE HAS ALL THESE
ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES.
SO A NUMBER OF US SORT OF WORKED
ON EFFORTS TO REDUCE AIR
POLLUTION IN THE STATE FOR THE
LAST QUARTER OF A CENTURY.
ARE FRUSTRATED WITH THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF AB SIX ONE
SEVEN WE WANT TO EMBRACE THE
PROMISE TO THESE HIGHLY IMPACTED
COMMUNITIES OF ACTUALLY GETTING
CLEANER AIR.
AND WE'RE NOT SURE THAT WE'RE
SEEING THAT --
THERE IS JUST A STUDY THAT CAME
OUT --
ACTUALLY YESTERDAY.
FROM THE WORLD HEALTH
ORGANIZATION PARTICULAR MATTER.
IS KILLING MORE PEOPLE GLOBALLY
THEN SMOKING IS.
BUT YOU CAN CHOOSE TO SMOKE YOU
CAN'T CHOOSE NOT TO BREED.
SO -- THOSE
ARE MY COMMENTS AND AGAIN WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING.
COOPERATIVELY WITH THE COMMITTEE
WITH THE LEGISLATURE AND WITH
AGENCIES TO TRY TO MAKE THE
PROMISE OF AB SIX ONE SEVEN REAL.
AND APPLAUD THE ASSEMBLY AND
SIMPLY MEMBER GARCIA FOR PUSHING
THIS BILL FORWARD AND HOPE THAT
WE CAN AGAIN WORK TO ACTUALLY
GET EMISSIONS REDUCTIONS THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU I'M ASK YOU ONE
QUESTION DO YOU THINK THAT THE
REASON THAT YOU'RE NOT SEEING
THE REDUCTIONS THAT YOU WOULD
LIKE TO SEE IS A QUESTION JUST
OF THE LIMITED AMOUNT OF TIME.
THAT THERE'S BEEN SINCE THE BILL
WAS IMPLEMENTED OR DO YOU THINK
THAT THERE'S SOMETHING.
OUR SYSTEM AYE KLAY --
THAT CAN BE DONE IN OTHER WORDS
DO YOU THINK IF YOU WERE HERE A
YEAR FROM NOW YOU WOULD HAVE A
SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVE.
I WOULD LOVE TO HAVE A DIFFERENT
PERSPECTIVE.
AND I GUESS.
WE WILL SEE IF WE HAVE A
DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVE BUT THE
ONE THING TO KEEP IN MIND
ESPECIALLY ON STATIONARY SOURCES.
IS THAT THE MAJORITY OF THE
REDUCTIONS.
FROM STATIONARY SOURCES IN
CALIFORNIA HAD ACTUALLY OCCURRED
THROUGH THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
THE FEDERAL ACT.
NOT THROUGH STATE LEVEL ACTIONS
pLINE MONITORING IT REFINERIES
THAT ACTUALLY THIS BODY PASSED
TO BILL IMPLEMENTING.
IS ACTUALLY REQUIRED ALREADY BY
THE FEDERAL ACT AND THE
DEADLINES ARE IN THE FEDERAL ACT
AND WE EXPECT GREAT REDUCTIONS
FROM THAT FENCE LINE MONITORING.
THAT WAS A HUGE --
NUMBER --
JUST HE WAS WAS PART OF OUR COLD
THE COUNTRY WORKED ON THAT
DURING THE LAST ADMINISTRATION.
WITH SO.
THE THE REDUCTIONS THAT WE SEE
UNFORTUNATELY ARE NOT MANY OF
THEM ARE NOT COMING FROM ACTIONS
THAT ARE FROM OUR STATE AGENCIES
ARE COMING FROM THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE ACT JUST
TO SAY.
IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY OPEN
BURNING OF ADDRESSES INCREASE
4100%.
IN THE LAST TWENTY FIVE YEARS I
MEAN THERE THERE'S NO WAY THAT
YOU CAN CONTROL STATIONARY
SOURCES WE CAN'T GET THOSE KINDS
OF REDUCTIONS IF WE'RE JUST
GONNA OPEN BURN AG WASTE.
SO.
THANK YOU.
OKAY NEXT SPEAKER --
PHOEBE SETON --
WITH LEADERSHIP COUNCIL FOR
JUSTICE AND ACCOUNTABILITY I I
WILL BE QUICK AND I WILL LOOK
FORWARD TO THE GOLD STARS AND I
WOULD LIKE. TO I MEAN I I WOULD
LIKE TO KNOW HOW MANY GOLD STARS
STARS I NEED TO TURN.
IN GOLD STARS FOR A SNACK BUT
CAN OF THIS NEGOTIATE THAT LATER.
I AM IT MANY OF THE THE FOLKS
WHO WHO PROVIDED TESTIMONY HIT.
SO MANY OF THE KEY POINTS WE
NEED TO SEE STRONGER CAN
LEADERSHIP FROM CARVE CHARTER
LEADERSHIP FROM THE LEGISLATURE
TO MAKE SURE THAT CARP IS
INSTITUTING STANDARDS TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE'RE READING WE'RE
MEETING.
OUR OUR EMISSIONS GOALS ACTUALLY
ACHIEVING MEANINGFUL EMISSIONS
REDUCTIONS IN THE SELECTED
COMMUNITIES AND THROUGHOUT THE
STATE --
ALSO IT WAS VERY VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE HOW MUCH TIME THAT
YOU ALL DEDICATED TODAY --
TO THESE --
TO THIS HEARING AND THE THING
FEEL THAT FIVE MINUTES IS A VERY
VERY VERY GENEROUS AFTER SO MUCH
TESTIMONY AND I THINK IT SPEAKS
TO KIND OF THE THE VALUE THAT
YOU ALL PLAYS ON THE LEADERSHIP
FROM THE COMMUNITIES AND FROM
THE REGION'S.
AND AND WE'RE REALLY HERE TO ASK
PLACE THAT MUCH CAN CONFIDENCE
AND FAITH AND RESPECT IN THE
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE PART OF THE
COMMUNITY STEERING COMMITTEES --
AT CARVE IN IDENTIFYING THE
AREAS IN THE COMMUNITY SELECTED
AS THE THE INITIAL --
AREAS COMMUNITIES AND
NEIGHBORHOODS FOR MISSION
REDUCTION PLANS.
IT WAS A DATE SPECIFICALLY SAID
THAT THOSE WORK IN GENERAL AREAS
AND DELEGATED TO THE COMMUNITY
STEERING COMMITTEES
IDENTIFICATION OF THE SPECIFIC
AREAS BASED ON COMMUNITY BASED
KNOWLEDGE SO WE WOULD I THINK
LAKE CONTINUED CAN LEADERSHIP
FROM CARVE.
AND THE LEGISLATURE TO REALLY TO
TO REINFORCE THAT THE COMMUNITY
STEERING COMMITTEE IS FOR OUR
PROVIDING LEADERSHIP AND
DECISION MAKING AROUND
BOUNDARIES.
ARE AROUND THE EMISSION
REDUCTION PLANS IT CETERA A
COUPLE FOLKS OF ALL TO DISCUSS
THE AREA WIDE THAT WE WE NEED TO
REALLY LOOK AT STATIONARY.
MOBILE SOURCES AND AREA WIDE
LOOKING AT AT BURNING DUST AND
PESTICIDES IN PARTICULAR YOU
WANT TO MAKE SURE IT SOUNDED
LIKE FROM SHAFTER LAST MEETING
THAT PESTICIDES ARE GOING TO BE
CONSIDERED.
AND PART OF THE MEASURE ACTION
PLANS DOESN'T WANT TO REINFORCE
THAT WE REALLY WANT TO SEE AND
FORCE OF ALL KIND OF METRICS
TIED TO PESTICIDES IN THOSE
AREAS IMPACTED BY PESTICIDES.
SEVERAL PEOPLE HAVE SPOKEN TO
THE IMPORTANCE OF A LAND USE SO
AGAIN JUST REINFORCING THAT WE
WILL NOT GET ANYWHERE ARE KIND
OF IN THE AREAS OF EITHER
MISSION REDUCTIONS OR
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE SCHOOLS.
IF WE DON'T INCORPORATE ON THE
LAND USE INTO --
SIX ONE SEVEN AND AND FINALLY.
CAN YOU CAN I'M CLEAR THE
LEGISLATURE'S ROLE HERE BUT
PROVIDING STRONG DIRECTION TO TO
CARP TO MAKE SURE THAT YOU'RE TO
SELECTION OF COMMUNITIES IS
TRANSPARENT AND EQUITABLE AND
MAKING SURE ESPECIALLY THAT
RURAL COMMUNITIES.
HAVE A FAIR CHANCE OF BEING
SELECTED AS URBAN COMMUNITIES
THANKS SO MUCH THANK YOU.
SPEAKER.
GOOD EVENING --
MY NAME IS KELLY TREVINO AND I'M
IN ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
SPECIALIST FOR THE CITY OF
FRESNO.
I WOULD LIKE TO FEET READ THE
FOLLOWING STATEMENT ON BEHALF OF
OUR MAYOR LEE BRANDS --
GIVEN THE IMPORTANCE OF THE
SUBJECT MAYOR BROWN WANTED TO BE
HERE HIMSELF BUT DUE TO A
PREVIOUS COMMITMENT HE WAS
UNABLE SO YOU GOT ME --
DEAR CHAIR FRIEDMAN AND
COMMITMENT COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
AS PRESIDENT MAHER I WANT TO
THANK THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY AIR
POLLUTION CONTROL DISTRICT STAFF
FOR CONDUCTING ASSEMBLY BILL SIX
ONE AT SEVEN'S LOCAL STEERING
COMMITTEE MEETINGS.
THE STAFF HAS WORKED HARD TO
FIND A CONSENSUS AMONG THE
VARIOUS STEERING COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
THE CITY OF FRESNO HAS BEEN
INVOLVED IN THE STEERING
COMMITTEE AND PRESIDENT AT
PRESENT AT EVERY MEETING BECAUSE
WE DESIRE CLEAN AIR AND WANT TO
WORK FOR REASONABLE AND SENSIBLE
AIR QUALITY SOLUTIONS AND FRESNO
AND THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY.
THAT BEING SAID I HAVE DEEP
CONCERNS ABOUT THE STEERING
COMMITTEE'S CURRENT DIRECTION.
THE MAIN FOCUS OF THE
DELIBERATIONS SO FAR HAS BEEN
THE OVE TO DOUBLE THE SIZE OF
THE BOUNDARY FOR OUR AB SIX ONE
SEVEN STEERING COMMITTEE TO
INCLUDE MOST OF FRESNO'S
INDUSTRIALLY ZONED AREAS.
WITH FRESNO COUNTY'S
UNEMPLOYMENT RATE AT EIGHT POINT
9% NEARLY DOUBLE THE STATE
AVERAGE.
THE CITY NEEDS TO HAVE
INDUSTRIALLY ZONED LAND READY
FOR INDUSTRY TO BRING A BADLY
NEEDED JOBS TO THE REGION.
THE AREAS THAT WOULD BE INCLUDED
IN THE EXPANDED AB SIX SEVENTEEN
AREA IS A RURAL PROPERTY WITH
ONLY A VERY SMALL NUMBER OF
HOMES THIS LAND HAS BEEN ZONED
AND PLANS FOR INDUSTRIAL GROWTH
FOR NEARLY FIFTY YEARS.
WELL WE AT THE CITY OF FRESNO
CERTAINLY SUPPORT REASONABLE AND
SENSIBLE AIR POLICIES WE SIMPLY
MUST HAVE PROPERTY AVAILABLE FOR
INDUSTRIAL EXPANSION.
WITH NEARLY FORTY ONE THOUSAND
OF OUR RESIDENTS LOOKING FOR
WORK ON ANY GIVEN DAY WE MUST
HAVE LAND AVAILABLE FOR BUSINESS
ATTRACTION EXPANSION AND
RETENTION.
NOT TO MENTION THOUSANDS UPON
THOUSANDS OF PART TIME WORKERS
LOOKING FOR FULL TIME WORK.
PEOPLE LOOKING FOR BETTER JOBS
AND THOSE INVOLVED IN THE NEO
AND WELFARE TO WORK PROGRAMS.
FRESNO'S NEED FOR QUALITY JOB IS
BEYOND TANGIBLE.
WE CANNOT SUPPORT THE EXPANSION
OF OUR AB SIX SEVENTEEN
BOUNDARIES AND ASKED THAT THE
LINES REMAIN AS ORIGINALLY
RECOMMENDED BY THE CALIFORNIA
AIR RESOURCES BOARD.
THANK YOU FOR HEARING MY COMMENT
CONCERNS ABOUT THIS PROCESS IF
THERE ARE ANY QUESTIONS I WOULD
BE HAPPY TO GET BACK TO YOU WITH
RESPONSES AS SOON AS POSSIBLE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SIR ANYONE
ELSE WANT TO SPEAK [inaudible]
YES.
GOOD EVENING THANK YOU FOR THE
TIME --
MADAM CHAIR AND TO THE OTHER
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS ERIC PAIN AND I AM THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CENTRAL VALLEY URBAN INSTITUTE.
TIME IN FRESNO --
AND ONE OF THEM BUT ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT I ALWAYS SAY --
MUCH OF THIS CONVERSATION --
SPECIFICALLY FROM THE CENTRAL
VALLEY HAS BEEN CENTERED AROUND.
THE INDUSTRIAL DEVELOPMENT --
BOUNDARY LINES --
AND THAT'S ACTUALLY MY
NEIGHBORHOOD --
I ALWAYS SAY THAT I'M JUST THE
GUY -- FOR
AND AND WITH THAT.
YOU KNOW WHY WE WHY WE ADMIRE
THE MAYOR'S --
EFFORTS TO INCREASE EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITIES --
BUT IT SHOULD NOT BE BURDENED BY
A COMMUNITY --
OF COLOR --
AND MUCH OF THOSE THAT ARE
DISENFRANCHISED IN MY
NEIGHBORHOOD --
SUFFER FROM --
DISCRIMINATORY PRACTICES OF THE
NINETEEN SEVENTY TWO GENERAL
PLAN -- WERE
AFRICAN AMERICANS ARMENIANS AND
OTHER PEOPLE OF COLOR WERE NOT
ALLOWED TO BUY PURCHASE HOMES --
ON THE OTHER SIDE OF THE TWO
HERE WE ARE AND RAVELING DECADES
OF POOR POLICIES THAT HAVE BEEN
DRAFTED BY --
PUBLIC OFFICIALS WITHIN OUR CITY
GOVERNMENT I'M AND WE ARE
CHALLENGED WITH --
HOW DO WE TAKE CORRECTIVE
MEASURE TO ENSURE THAT?
MY CHILDREN AND MY CHILDREN'S
CHILDREN --
DON'T HAVE TO BEAR THE BURDEN OF
POOR AIR QUALITY IN OUR
NEIGHBORHOOD --
BUT ALSO WE WANT TO BE SENSITIVE
TO THE NEEDS OF BEING A
COLLECTIVE SPIRIT OF
COLLABORATION --
TO ENSURE THAT --
AS WE WORK WITH OUR LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS TO MOVE THIS
POLICY FORWARD AND THAT --
WE ARE NOT --
OSTRACIZED THROUGHOUT THIS
PROCESS AND SO FOR ME --
I COME TO SHARE MY THOUGHTS --
AS A RESIDENT.
THAT LIVES IN THIS NEIGHBORHOOD --
AN **** AND THAT THIS COMMITTEE
TO RACE AND OF THE STEERING
COMMITTEE AND TAKE --
TAKE HEED IN AND LISTEN TO THE
VOICES --
FROM THOSE THAT HAVE TRAVELED
OVER TWO AND A HALF HOURS TO BE
HERE TODAY I'M AND I THANK YOU
AND I APPRECIATE YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU I THINK --
THE LAST SPEAKER.
YES.
I'M STEVE BIRD NOW --
RESIDENT OF FRESNO AND MEMBER OF
THE STEERING COMMITTEE THERE.
I'M HERE TO FORMALLY COMPLAIN
ABOUT THE CENTRAL AREA OF VALLEY
AIR DISTRICT SUPERVISION OF THE
SIX SEVENTEEN MEETINGS.
AT FEBRUARY MEETING OUR
COMMITTEE DECIDED TO EXPAND THE
BOUNDARIES OF THE PROGRAM.
AND WE CAME TO A CLEAR AND
DOCUMENTED CONSENSUS ON THIS
ISSUE.
WE HEARD NO CONCERNS RAISED BY
THE DISTRICT AT THAT TIME --
OUR COMMUNITY ADVOCACY GROUP --
AFTERWARD REACHED OUT TO THE
DISTRICTS TO ASSIST WITH THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS EXPANSION.
AT OUR MARCH MEETING WITH
MINIMAL PREPARATION TIME GIVEN
TO THE COMMITTEE.
THE DISTRICT SAID THAT THEY
COULD NOT FOLLOW THE COMMUNITIES
CONSENSUS.
THEY CITED THE PRINCIPLE THAT
THEY SHOULD KEEP TO A ARBY'S
ORIGINAL BOUNDARIES AS CLOSE AS
POSSIBLE.
THE MARCH MEETING WAS TOTALLY
CONSUMED BY AGAIN REVISITING THE
EXPANSION OF BOUNDARIES ISSUE.
BUT AS THE DISTRICT WAS UNABLE
TO DEFINITIVELY CITE ANY
SPECIFIC TECHNICAL ISSUES WITH
THE CONSENSUS BOUNDARIES. FOR
WITH ANY NEW PROPOSALS.
WE COULD HAVE VERY LITTLE
MEANINGFUL DISCUSSION.
IN THE END THE DISTRICT PROMISED
ONLY TO TAKE OUR SUGGESTIONS
INTO ACCOUNT.
WHEN DECIDING THE BOUNDARIES ON
THEIR OWN BEHIND CLOSED DOORS?
THE PARTICIPATION AGREEMENT IN
THE SIX SEVENTEEN CHARTER SAYS
THAT MEMBERS SHALL RESOLVE
CONFLICTS IN A SWIFT POSITIVE
AND CONSTRUCTIVE MANNER.
BY ACTIVELY PARTICIPATING IN THE
MEETINGS.
THE CLEAR VIEW OF THE COMMUNITY
IS THAT THIS DISTRICT FAILED TO
RAISE CONCERNS IN ANY TIMELY
MANNER [inaudible]
FAILED -- TO
FACILITATE A WAY TO RESOLVE THIS
CONFLICT.
WE CANNOT PROCEED IF THE
DISTRICT DOESN'T PLAY BY THE
RULES FOR EFFECTIVE DISCUSSION
THAT THEY THEMSELVES LAID DOWN.
WE CANNOT ACHIEVE THE GOAL OF A
PLAN INFORMED BY THE COMMUNITY.
IF THE DISTRICT DISREGARDS THE
WILL OF THE COMMUNITY.
THE MEMBERS OF THE FRESNO
STEERING COMMUNITY OF LIKE MANY
OTHER --
COMMITTEES ARE PEOPLE WHO ARE
SUFFERING FROM CHRONIC LUNG
DISEASE TODAY.
SO WE NEED SIX SEVENTEEN TO
SUCCEED.
WE ARE DESPERATE TO MOVE PAST
THE BOUNDARY ISSUE AND HAS START
HAVING THE REAL CONVERSATIONS
THAT WE NEED TO HAVE. TO REACH
THE BALANCE BETWEEN A HEALTHY
JOB MARKET AND BEING ABLE TO
BREATHE.
AT SIX MONTHS INTO THE PROGRAM.
AS FAR AS A COMMUNITY INPUT GOES
THE FEELING IS THAT WE ARE STILL
AT SQUARE.
ONE OUR STEERING COMMITTEE HAS
DISCUSSED NONE OF THE PROPOSED
AND EVALUATED RULES THAT.
MISTER SHEIKH DESCRIBED IN HIS
PRESENTATION ALL OF THAT HAS
ALSO BEEN DONE BEHIND CLOSED
DOORS [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SEEING NO OTHER PUBLIC
COMMENTARY I WILL NOW TURN TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA FOR
CLOSING COMMENTS AT ONE A SURVEY
THINKING THE CHAIR FOR HOSTING
THIS --
HEARING TODAY AND GIVING THIS
OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO CHECK IN
OF WHERE WE'RE AT ON ON THIS
BILL AND THE WORK THEY'RE DOING
AND WHAT I THINK EVERYONE NOT.
THAT JUST.
IF YOU STICK AROUND OR NOT THEY
MADE THE TRIP OUT HERE BUT I
THINK THE WORK THAT'S BEING THAT
IN THE COMMUNITY.
I WAS REFLECTING ON YOUR
COMMENTS ABOUT LIVING IN THE
COMMUNITY AND LIKE YOU I LIVE IN
THIS AND A COMMUNITIES JUST LIKE
YOURS A COMMUNITY THAT --
FOR GENERATIONS HAS BEEN TREATED
LIKE A WEST LINE AND OUR
CONSTITUENTS TREAT ELECTRIC
DISPOSABLE.
AND YOU KNOW I GO HOME I GO HOME
TO IT EVERY WEEKEND AND I WANT
TO SEE AB SIX SEVENTEEN BE
SUCCESSFUL I WANT TO SEE THESE.
TEN A COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE BEEN
SELECTED BE SUCCESSFUL BECAUSE
THEY WILL BE THE BLUEPRINT FOR
THE ADDITIONAL COMMUNITIES THAT
NEED TO COME ALONG THE WAY AND I
THINK.
THAT THERE ARE DEFINITELY A LOT
OF LESSONS TO BE. TO BE HAD I
THINK THAT THIS QUESTION AROUND
BOUNDARIES IS IMPORTANT I THINK
THE DISCUSSION AROUND.
LAND USE IS IMPORTANT --
THE DISCUSSION OF IS IMPORTANT
AND SO I HOPE THAT.
THE AT THE STATE LEVEL THAT THEY
ARE BE AT THE LOCAL OR DISTRICTS
WE ALK ABOUT.
YOU KNOW CHANGES THAT WE NEED TO
DO NOW TO THE PROCESS AND THAT
WE TALK ABOUT THE FACT THAT IF
THERE IS A CONSENSUS AND IS THE
PHONE THAT WHERE WE WERE WITH
THAT WERE YOU WE WERE AT TO
BEGIN WITH.
HOW DID WE ADOPT SOME OF THAT
CONSENSUS?
ALONG THE WAY SO THAT IT IS
COMMUNITY DRIVEN THIS IS ONLY
GOING TO BE SUCCESSFUL OF THE
COMMUNITY IS IS AT THE TABLE AND
THEY HAVE BODY AND I HAVE HEARD.
OF A WIDE RANGE OF THAT AND SO I
AM HOPEFUL ACTUALLY YOU KNOW AND
AND NOT EVERYONE IS HAPPY IN
THIS PROCESS AND I'VE BEEN
WORRIED ABOUT IT CONSTANTLY.
BUT I'M HOPEFUL THAT THAT WE
HAVE SOME.
STEPS THAT WE COULD TAKE TO BE
IN A IN A BETTER PLACE ACROSS
THE STATE LATE.
WITH THESE COMMUNITIES --
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO THE TWO
CARBS LEADERSHIP TO HELP US FIND
SOME SOLUTIONS --
AND I LOOK FORWARD. TO TO THE
CONTINUE TO WORK FOR THE
COMMUNITY MEMBERS FOR THOSE OF
YOU THAT ARE FRUSTRATED PLEASE
DON'T LEAVE WE ARE LISTENING AND
I DON'T KNOW HOW QUICKLY WE'RE
GOING TO GET TO THE SAME PLACE
BUT WE NEED YOUR INPUT TO TRY TO
CREATE A PLAN THAT.
THAT IS SUCCESSFUL AND I KNOW
THAT'S ASKING A LOT FOR
COMMUNITY MET THAT'S BEEN OUT
THERE WAITING.
BUT THIS IS A TO WE HAVE AND
I'VE ALWAYS IT IS NOT THE ONLY
TO WE NEED BUT THIS LITTLE WE
HAVE RIGHT NOW.
AND I THINK BEFORE I COULD FIGHT
FOR ADDITIONAL TOOLS I NEEDED --
TO MOVE FORWARD.
SO THANK YOU ALL.
THANKS I ALSO WANT TO THANK
EVERYBODY WHO CAME AND TESTIFIED
PARTICULARLY THE ACTIVISTS AND
PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN WORKING FOR
SO LONG --
ON THESE ISSUES IN THEIR
COMMUNITY AND I ALSO WANT TO
THANK --
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CRISTINA GARCIA
FOR SPEARHEADING THIS EFFORT AND
FROM WATCHING IT FROM MY SIDE OF
THE ROOM.
AS A COLLEAGUE I KNOW THAT IT
WAS A REALLY HUGE TASK FOR HER --
TO TAKE ON AND SHE WORKED VERY
VERY HARD ON TRYING.
TO I'M A CREATE THIS TOOL AND
ALSO TO GET IT YOU KNOW OVER THE
FINISH LINE AND NOW SHE'S YOU
KNOW OBVIOUSLY VERY CONCERNED
WITH THE OLD IMPLEMENTATION IS
REALLY THERE TO TO SEE IT
THROUGH SO I COMMEND YOU.
FOR ALL OF THAT WORK --
YOU KNOW LISTENING TO THIS TO ME
REALLY IT LISTENING TO THE
AMOUNT OF TESTIMONY THAT WE HAD
IN THE PASSION THAT WE HEARD
FROM SO MANY PEOPLE.
SHOWS WHAT IMPORTANT TOOL THIS
REALLY ISA MORE POWERFUL TOOL
AND IT SEEMS TO ME AS A YOU KNOW
AS AS YOU BROUGHT UP THAT THERE
ARE YOU KNOW THERE ARE
REGULATIONS THAT ARE ON THE
BOOKS WHAT WHAT'S BEEN MISSING
OVER THE YEARS.
WAS A FORMALIZED APPROACH TO
REALLY BRINGING THE COMMUNITY TO
THE TABLE --
IN A MEANINGFUL WAY SO THE
COMMUNITY THAT ARE YOU KNOW IT --
EXTREMELY IMPACTED BY PUT BY
POLLUTION --
BUT THEY'RE ALSO COMMUNITIES
THAT HAVE BEEN MARGINALIZED AND
NEVER NEVER REALLY LISTEN TO
NEVER BROUGHT TO THE TABLE FOR A
VARIETY OF REASONS SO HAVING A
TOOL LIKE THIS THAT REALLY
FORCES.
THEM TO BE LISTENED TO AND AND
GIVE SOME THAT SEAT AT THE TABLE
IS VERY VERY IMPORTANT AND YOU
KNOW IT WAS INTERESTING TO HEAR
THE RANGE OF EXPERIENCES.
IT SEEMS CLEAR THAT THERE'S
CERTAINLY --
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF LESSEN
LEARNING OVER THE PAST YEAR AND
NOT A LOT OF PEOPLE TALKING
ABOUT THE PROCESS THAT STARTED
OUT BEING MAYBE.
I'M -- NOT
REALLY FORMED AND REALLY
STARTING TO HONE IN ON FOR WHAT
THAT INDIVIDUAL COMMUNITY IN
THAT INDIVIDUAL DISTRICT.
IS WORKING AND THAT'S GREAT NEWS --
LESSONS THAT I KNOW WE'RE GOING
TO BE BROUGHT FORWARD --
YOU KNOW INTO THE NEXT ROUND OF
COMMUNITIES AND AND YOU KNOW IS
THIS MOVES INTO THE FUTURE.
I'M ALSO A CERTAIN AMOUNT OF YOU
KNOW FRUSTRATION AT YOU KNOW
SLOWNESS IN SOME AREAS OF
PERCEPTION THAT THINGS AREN'T
MOVING AS QUICKLY AS THEY WOULD
LIKE AND SO.
YOU KNOW THERE'S A LOT OF WORK
TO BE DONE BUT I THINK IT'S
REALLY ENCOURAGING TO SEE.
THE AMOUNT OF PASSIONATE PEOPLE
WEREN'T PASSIONATE THEN.
YOU KNOW WE WOULDN'T HAVE A TOOL
THAT WAS REALLY USED AND THEY
STAYED HOME IT'S BECAUSE THEY
DIDN'T SEE VALUE IN THIS SO I
THINK THAT BECAUSE SO MANY
PEOPLE.
ARE DEDICATED TO MAKING THE MOST
OF IT AND MAKING IT WORK BECAUSE
WE KNOW AT THIS POINT.
HOW IMPORTANT THIS IS FOR THE
COMMUNITIES WE'VE HEARD IT OVER
AND OVER AGAIN --
I THINK I THINK YOU KNOW I'M
REALLY ENCOURAGED BY THAT AND
CLEARLY WILL HAVE TO DO THIS
AGAIN IN CERTAIN AMOUNT OF TIME.
TO SEE WHETHER SEIZE THESE KINGS
ARE KIND OF WORKING OUT --
I MADE A WHOLE BUNCH OF NOTES
BUT I'M NOT EVEN GOING TO AYE
AYE.
I CAN'T POSSIBLY GO GO DOWN
THESE AND READ THIS AT THIS
POINT BUT I WANT TO AGAIN THANK
EVERYBODY AND I KNOW WE'VE BEEN
TAKING A LOT OF NOTES APPEAR SO
WILL BE A LOT OF MORE
CONVERSATIONS.
FROM OUR SIDE AND WITHIN THIS
BUILDING --
ABOUT -- THE
BILL SO THANKS AGAIN AND THANKS
TO STAFF --
AND EVERYBODY ELSE.
OKAY WITH THAT WILL CONCLUDE OUR
MEETING